THIS ORDER CALL TO ORDER THIS
HEARING OF THE BUT SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE NO. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WELCOME
EVERYONE. NAY OB I HEARING
ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION AND ITEMS
REGARDING HEALTH HEALTH IN
HUMAN. HE THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
IS A THIRD PARTY THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLAN DEVELOPED.
DEPARTMENTS HEALTH IN THE PARK
HEALTH WAS ONCE A PRESENT ON
THE STATE OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
HEARING AID WHICH IS EXTREMELY
TIME OF NINE IN THE- THAT.
BACKROOM BUYERS I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR DID OUT
YOU I THINK IS A LEE ESTIMATOR
IN THE MORNING RE. NOW BRINGS
WE ARE STILL OF COURSE CAN HERE
DO THE PEOPLE ARE BUT OUR
MENTION THAT US WHY CURRY BUT
ALSO DISTANCE. DEFYING IN- ARE
IS NOT IMMEDIATE AND YOU WANT
TO GO UPSTAIRS OR JUST SPREAD
OUT THAT'S THAT GOOD. WITH
SMALL PEOPLE THE BASE ABOUT
HAVING PEOPLE WASH THEIR HANDS
AND WE TO THEIR FACES ANYONE
FEELING ALL THAT WE WOULD ASK
THAT YOU DID NOT. PHYSICALLY
PRESENT. WELL EVERYONE ODDS
KEEP EVERYONE THIS WE ARE
PLAYED SO. THE TESTIFIED DO YOU
HAVE HAN SET. HE ADDED. SO I'M
IN IT SHE IS ARE LIKE THAT THEY
CAN'T SIZER CLEAN YOUR- BEFORE
YOU TOUCH YOUR- SO. BE SURE
IT'S REALLY VERY YES HAVE TO
ISSUES OF AT THE- AT RIGHT AT
THE TABLE BUT ALSO ENOUGH ASK
HER. SO WE'RE TRYING TO. I'M IN
A STATE HERE I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THOSE SO THAT THAT ALSO THIS
CONDITION IS IT IS AT THE MOST
SOME PEOPLE SEE THEIR SET KLAY.
ABOVE DATE I'VE ARE WHOEVER
PLEASE CONDITION BOB PARTY
LINES ARE YOU IN AS A THE RISK
TO FOLKS RELATIVE LOW IT'S MORE
TRYING THIS. HOUSE AND OF. DO I
REACH PEOPLE THE TO. THE
INTERNET. SECTION IT'S ARE IF
YOU'RE NOT HIGH RISK AT IT'S
MORE ABOUT TO SLOW SPREAD TO
AND ACTUAL HARM TO. DO WELL
SELF. SO I THAT'S THE- SO IT'S
WANNA LAY THAT OUT FOR A NOW
AND WE WILL BE AGAIN LATER FROM
THE PART PUBLIC AS WELL IN
TERMS ARE I. AS OF THE TWO ARE
NOT SET. THIS SUBCOMMITTEE BAY
SCHOOL HERE IN ITEM AND THEN.
FOR HIGHER FROM THE LA- AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- AFTER WE
FINISH ALL THE ISSUES IN EACH
CATEGORY FOR EACH AGENCY WILL
THEN TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT I AM
THAT IN TERMS OF A PUBLIC
COMMENT TO TRY TO KEEP YOUR
CAR. A MINUTE I HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN. THEY WILL GIVE IT TO
OUR COMMITTEE ARE RECOGNIZING
THAT MINUTES NOT BUT YOU CAN
HIT THE LIGHTS AND THEN-
PROVIDE YOUR DOCUMENTS- TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THOSE BEEF- FULLY
CONSIDERED. SO THE DESERVED THE
ITEMS WE ARE NOT TAKING ANY
VOTES TODAY SO WE HAVE NO ITEMS
RECORD AND FOR ACTION IN THIS
HEARING WE ARE BE. FULL WHICH
ITEM. BUT HEARING TODAY AND-
AND OF COURSE TAKING IT BACK UP
REVIEWING IT- AT PRICE AFTER
MAYBE REPRISES THE MOST LIKELY
TIME SO WITH THAT I WOULD FIRST
LIKE AT THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO STOP. EVEN THOUGH NOT
VOTE. THESE CALL. THERE OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD FIRST ITEM IS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND SO AT THAT-
AGE PLEASE COME UP THE TRAIL IN
FINANCE TWENTY YEARS WE ARE
SPREAD OUT. RIGHT WELCOME AND
FOR THE RECORD WHICH SAYS GIVEN
FIRST IT JUST INTRODUCE
YOURSELF YOUR NAME YOUR TITLE
SO START WITH AGENCY. ANASTASIA
DOZEN DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IF. CYNTHIA TUCKER
OFFICES IN A GREAT. MARRIAGE IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF SERVICES
THANK YOU AND ALEJO. THE KALLIO
FINANCE. CARLOS SECULAR OF
FINANCE TYLER WOULD FINANCE
OKAY THANK YOU WELCOME ALL
RIGHT SO THE FIRST ITEM IS ARE
ELECTRONIC VISIT PHASE TO PLAY
WITH HER FACE ONE PRIOR HEARING
THE WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY.
THE RIGHT UP HIS A IS WELL
FOUNDED IT SUMMARIZES VERY WELL
WE'VE BEEN TO. AND SO THEY WERE
QUESTIONS SO FOR AS A HIGH LOW
LET CATION. THE FACE TO. IS THE
TO ME BOB PROGRAMMATIC FOR THE
FIRST CURES ACT FOR MORE FOR
MULTI OF PRO ARE FIVE PROGRAM
DEPARTMENTS. A HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS SINGLE RIGHT THOSE SO
PROVIDED A BRIEF OF THIS
PROPOSED. WAS WERE TWO POINT
NINE DOLLARS TO HER NINETY
THREE OF IT IS FOR GENERAL FUND
AND IMPROPER AS NINE POSITIONS
ACROSS MULTI DEPARTMENTS AS
WELL AS- PROJECT. I CONSULT TAX
THESE. WITH THEIR DON'T VERSION
QUESTIONS REGARDS TO THE DOLLAR.
I WANT MY YOU JUST GO AND
ANSWER ALL THREE CREDIT. THEN
WILL TAKE COMMENTS FROM THE ON
FINE AND THEN IS THIS NUMBER
SEC. WHAT IS THE CURRENT EXPECT
TIMELINE SO AS A PART OF A TWO
WE BOTH PER CARES. ARE AS WELL
AS HELP HER HHC. THE PERSONAL
SERVICE THAT ASSOCIATED WITH
FACE TO IS CURRENTLY. FOR AND-
UP. AND THEN FOR ITEMS I'M
GONNA. UP MY PROGRAM COLLEAGUES.
GOOD MORNING SO FOR OF THE
PLANNING FOR PHASE WE HAVE ALL
IN CORE THE FEDERAL. OVER A LOT
FAIR FOR OF STAR AND TIME AND
LOCATION SO THERE'S NO CHANGES
NEEDED TO FACE TO AS FAR AS THE
OFFICE IS FROM C. OKAY THANK
YOU COMES MILLION. SENATE
PARTICULARLY- WE WHICH IS NOT
THAT SOME OF THE REQUESTED
RESOURCE IS WOULD POTENTIALLY
BE USED TO FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROJECT STAGE FOR PROJECT
PRIVILEGED ALL PROCESS IS SOME
TO LAST YEAR TO DO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A COMPLETE
PROJECT PLAN BEFORE. THE
SCHEDULE. WE READ PROVISIONAL
BUDGET LANGUAGE THAT WOULD MAKE
ANY APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
FOR DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION CONTINGENT ON
THE PROJECT- BE THROUGH STAGE
FOR. I'LL PROCESS AND WRITTEN
NOTICE AND- WHAT. IT'S ARE
UNDER FROM THE STREET THAT IT
NOW USING KHAN SO WITH THE TYPE
LANGUAGE FOR PER. IT PRESS X. A
AN WERE CONCEPT TO BE APPROVED
BY LEGISLATURE WERE WE'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE ADMIN.
ON THE FINAL DATE THE LANGUAGE.
OUR OF OUR OVERSIGHT THANK YOU
FINANCE. OKAY NOTHING TO ADD
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SO
JUST AB SO TERMS OF THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE SO YOU INDICATED THAT
SAYS THE- FEDERAL GOOD IT'S
ACTUALLY FINAL- ARE STILL
WAITING FOR ANYTHING. IN TERMS.
ENTER THE REQUIREMENTS TO
COMPLETE A PROJECT THAT I
THOUGHT THERE WAS SOME. THERE
ARE STILL SOME THINGS THAT THEY
HAVEN'T CLARIFIED YET OR IS IT
ARE WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WANT NOW BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE I
KNOW THAT THE STATE ANDERS STEP
BACK AND FORTH WITH. WITH
CHEATING THE WITH. CERTIFIED
CERTAIN IN. THAT WOULD THE
SYSTEM THAT WE Vì USE BECAUSE
IT WOULD DEPEND ON LIKE WHAT
SORT OF THINGS PEOPLE AFTER
WHAT DATA ENTRY DO WOULD HAVE
TO DO AND SO FORTH SO CAN YOU
CLARIFY THAT I WASN'T. YEAH YES
IS FOR FIFTY WE HAVE. ALL ALONG
BEEN PLANNING TO- TAKEN
APPROACH THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE. SO
THAT WOULD BE AN ELECTRONIC
METHOD TO VERIFY. IN PERSON.
THAT THE PROVIDE PERSON AT.
HOME AT THE START AND STOP TIME
USING A LET LET ME WHETHER
THAT'S A LAND LINE OF. OR A APP
UNDER TAP. THAT HAS BEEN- PART
OF OUR PLANNING ALONG FOR EVEY
PHASE ONE- I'D WOULD WOULD
RATHER DEFER TO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT THEY WERE
FOR- FOR THE- THAT THERE IS. A
CMS. DURING SO I ACTUALLY AND
WE DID HEAR THEM LAST YEAR SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO BE AS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE- IS STILL
SOME NEGOTIATE GOING ON BRING
PAIN IS ONCE THIS MOVE THEY
ALSO OFFER. ED THEN FACED. YEAH
BUT THERE IS. SHE SHE DOES THE
GOVERNMENT ROLE THAT EARLY
VISUAL SAID OUR IN QUITE
COMPILED A THE THINGS WANTED
AND OTHERS ABOUT AND FORTH
BURKE CLEARLY WHAT THAT IS
RIGHT SO THIS FACT THERE IS SO
I UNDERSTAND GOING TO GO SHE
XIN RIGHT NOW THAT IF FATE. BUT
ANYWAY. PLEASE WHAT NOT AFFECT.
YOU SO FOR AND FOR PHASE ONE- I
WOULD SAY WE HAVE GOTTEN
GUIDANCE FROM CMS AND WERE THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
AGENCY ARE CONSIDERING NEXT
STEPS ON THAT BIDEN'S SO WEAK
BUT FOR FACE TO WE HAVE ALL
ALONG AND ARE PUT IN PROCESS
PRETTY THAT WE WOULD YOU SOME
KIND OF ELECTRIC PROCESS FIVE.
AT THE PROVIDE. HOME USING THIS
MEANS. OKAY SO I MEAN I'D AIDS
AT. I JUST WANNA ALSO BILLS I
RECOGNIZE THE ISSUES TWO OTHER
ON DIFFERENT TRACKS AND- END OF
PHASE TWO IS THUS FAR. YOU HAVE
MORE TIME TO MAKE IT JUST.
POURS NO THAT. YOUR TO ASSIST.
THAT YOU KNOW BASICALLY YOU
HAVE YOU HAVE ALL THE GUIDANCE
YOU NEED FROM CMS IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP THERE'S KNOWS LIKE WISH
IS. THAT REGARD OKAY AND THE
OTHER PART I DO I MAKE NO PART
OF THE REASON WE DID HAVE
THERE WE PROTECT IT PRIVATE THE
CLIENTS AND THE PRICE OF. SO I
AM WHY THEY WANTED CERTAIN
THINGS BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING
THAT YOU A OF A FOB THAT
BASICALLY TELLS TWITTER THAT
FIGHTER. JET IN OKAY INS AND SO
FORTH. GRADE PRIVACY ISSUE THE
CARD FROM OR THE CLIENT. SURE
SIR. WELL HOW ARE SO I SAW AS
THE LEADER SIMPLY SAY SAM S.
OKAY WILL DO WHATEVER YOU EVEN
THOUGH IT SOME MAY COST ISSUES
I ON WITH OUR OWN. BOB GRAHAM.
PROGRAM THAT ON WITHOUT SO I
JUST WANTED TO SEE CHECK IN TO
BE SURE WERE WHERE WE ARE NOT
SPACE YES WE WELL AS FAR AS
FACE TO REWRITE. SO WHAT IT IS
WHAT OTHER STATES DOING DOES
THE AUDITOR GUIDANCE SAY YES WE
DO NOT SEE VERY. BESIDES
COMPLYING WITH THEIR GUIDANCE
WOULD MEAN- WE UNDERSTAND THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS TAKE THEM VERY
SERIOUSLY AND SO AS FAR AS
TRYING TO VERIFICATION IT'S NOT
CONSTANT IT'S JUST ONLY START
TIME. RIVES AT THE CONSUMER.
AND IT WHEN THE PROVIDER
LEAVES- WE IN IN DESIGNING THE
SYSTEM WE DO WANT TO TRY TO
PROTECT PRIVACY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. UT WE TO BE MY OF
WHAT IS. AND AVOIDING THE
VACANT PENALTIES. ABOUT A YEAR
WE WANT FEDERAL MONEY TO
FEDERAL GUIDANCE BUT SOMETIMES
THERE'S ALSO SOME BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT. YEAH EVEN ADDS
ABOUT WHAT DID A REAL BY WHAT
SO OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I JUST-
JUST WANT TO SEE WHERE WE WERE
WITH THAT AND- I HAD HEARD THAT
NAVY DIVERS SO YOU. STILL HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S OUTSTANDING
AND- SO OKAY PLEASE SAY NO
WE'RE WE'RE ALL SET THAT ON ON
FACE TO FACE TO THAT EXACTLY
FACE TO IDEA WE ARE HEARING A
PLACE TO I'M JUST TAKING YOU
KNOW ABOUT PHASE ONE SAYING HEY
SAME PROP. TO THEY KNOW. AND
FEES WE A COLD OR WET ARE MARCH
THIRD I WAIT TALKED WITH STATE
OF WHAT WE WILL NEED TO DO AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE FOR THEIR
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT ON THAT
OKAY. AGAIN OKAY QUESTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BURGER MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO TWO
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON. WELCOME.
SO I THINK WE ARE WE DO HAVE-
SINCE WE HAVE NEW PEOPLE AROUND
THE TABLE TO SOME INTRODUCTIONS
HERE WE DO HAVE THE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THE QUESTION SO WE JUST
GET YOU PRESENT TO ALL THE
STATE WILL GET AND THEN WILL
QUESTION. RIGHT REMEMBER MY
NAME IS MATT CHILLER HIME THE
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR THE OFFICE
OF THE CALIFORNIA SURGEON
GENERAL. THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I'M AN EIGHTEEN
FOR CHARIZARD IN GENERAL FOR
THE STATE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
SENATE FAILS FINANCE GOOD
MORNING NINA HENNINGER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TIGER
WOODS FINANCE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WELCOME. THESE BEGIN
THANK YOU- A. AS AS A AS YOU
KNOW- ADVERSE AND ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND TOXIC
STRESS PRESENT A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS HIT IN PLANES SIGHT. WE
FROM THE C. HAD AND THERE
DOCUMENTED STRIKING FINDINGS
ONE. ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ARE INCREDIBLY
COMMON 62% OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
AT LEAST ONE SEVENTEEN POINT 6%
OF CALIFORNIA. BY CITY LEADERS
IT HOW FOUR OR MORE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE. AND OUR SECOND
STRIKING FINDING IS THAT THERE
IS A DO RESPONSE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND THE LEADING-
CAUSES OF DISEASE- AS WELL AS
MENTAL ILL HEALTH AND NEGATIVE
SOCIAL OUTCOMES INCLUDING HEART
DISEASE STROKE. LONG IS. THE
PART SUICIDALITY SUBSTANCE
DEPENDENCE AND HOME. TO DATE
THERE HAS BEEN NO COORDINATED
EVIDENCE BASED PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO ADDRESS ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND TOXIC
STRESS AS A MAJOR DRIVER OF
CHRONIC DISEASE AS YOU KNOW
WITH. THE GOVERNOR CREATED THE
ROLE OF THE- CALIFORNIA SURGEON
GENERAL- AS SPECIFICALLY TO
ADDRESS THE- SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH ARE THE
DRIVERS SOME OF OUR MOST
SERIOUS AND CHALLENGING- PUBLIC
HEALTH CHILD AS- THE PAST YEAR
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING TO.
TO PULL IT TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY.
FIRST IN THE NATION EFFORT TO
TRAIN OUR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS ON HOW TO SCREEN FOR
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
HOW DO EIGHT FIVE EIGHT SO
SEATED POSITION. HOW TO RESPOND
WITH TRAUMA INFORMED CARE. AND
WHILE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE RECOGNIZED
BONTA EIGHT IS WE KNOW THAT THE
NAME AND- HEALTH CARE IS DOES
NOT OFF A TRUE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE INCLUDE PREVENT. AND
FRENCH BUYERS OKAY ASIAN CROSS
TRAIN. BE TO A FIVE IF. THE WHO
ARE IN IRAQ. WITH THE RE SAYS
AND TOOLS BE ABLE TO PREVENT
RECOGNIZE AND RESPOND TO
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AND TOXIC STREP AND THAT IS THE
WORK OUT WE- IN THE CURRENT ASK
WITH. IN DOLLAR. IT OVER TO YOU
ON PUBLIC AT ACROSS. RIGHTS TO
THE PROPOSED LOVE AND MILLION
ENCOMPASSES EIGHT MILLION FOR
THAT PUBLIC A TOOK AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN. TO RAISE AWARENESS
ENDING ABOUT ACES AND TOXIC
STREP ND THEN TWO BILLION
DOLLARS PER ACRE TRAINING
EFFORT WHICH WILL CONSIST OF.
IN FOR ONE PERSON FOR CATEGORY
THIS EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
ONE SPENT AND THEN GENERALLY
GOVERNMENT WORKERS. IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I CAN
COVER THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA ABOUT THE PROPOSAL SO
THE FIRST QUESTION ABOUT HOW
WOULD WE IMPLEMENT PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN AND WITH THE
PLEASE BE AND- IT IS EXPECT. WE
WOULD UTILIZE- OUTSIDE OF
SERVICES IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO- IMPLEMENT AND DELIVER THE
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN- THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL FOR OF A VARIETY
OF ENTITIES TO INVOLVE. NOT
PROFIT PROFIT. TENCHI BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SO- BUT WE
DO INTEND ON USING- INTO IT
HAVE EXPERTISE I IN THAT IT AND
THEN WILL BE MANAGED BY THE
PACIFIC IN GENERAL SO. A MAN.
TAKES A TRACK OF THOSE TYPE.
MANAGE BY THE OFFICE. ANYTHING
OKAY AND THEN THE NEXT QUESTION
WITH THE EFFORT BILL UPON
EXISTING MEDIA CAMPAIGN
RESOURCES SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. I WE HAVE
BEEN IN. NATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
IT'S REALLY MORE ABOUT
UTILIZING THE BEST PRACTICES
AND LESSONS LEARNED FROM PUBLIC
IN THIS CAMPAIGN SUCH AS BACK-
IN. THOSE ANTI CAMP IN AND WE
ALSO WANT TO LOOK TO OTHER
TYPES OF WHAT AWARENESS ANZOR.
BY THIS TO JUST COVER CAL IS.
PEOPLE AWARE CAMPAIGN SO THE
IDEA IS TO USE THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS TO INFORM OUR CAMPAIGN.
AND THE ONE WITH RESPECT TO WHO
WERE TO CROSS SECTOR TRAINING
MATERIALS AND HOW THOSE
TRAININGS BE CONDUCTED. I WE
ALREADY HAVE HAD A VARIETY OF
THE DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS A
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS. THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I
REACH OUT TO IT ALREADY- WITH
INTEREST IN A TEAM. I THE
MATERIAL PAN BOTTOM ASSIST WHAT
DOES DEPARTMENTSWOULD BE BUT
THEN ALSO- IN TERMS OF THE
DELIVERY OF THOSE TRAININGS THE
IDEA IS TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
TO BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE TRIP IT
IS ALREADY OCCURRING WITHIN
THOSE ENTITIES AND REALLY TAKE
A TRAIN THE TRAINER. WHICH WITH
THE- FACT. GETTING MATERIAL
AROUND ACES AND TOXIC STRESS.
HELLO SONYA PETTITTE KALLIO WE
HAVE A HOPEFULLY MINOR ISSUE
RELATED TO QUESTION ONE- OR
OTHER QUESTION TWO IN THE
AGENDA AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE ALREADY DISCUSSED WITH C.
ADMINISTRATION IN THAT. THE
VISUAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD EXEMPTS- THE OFFICE
CONTRACTS RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL FROM THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE- SOME OF THIS
MIGHT BE JUSTIFIED IN THE SENSE
THAT SOME OF THE PARTNERSHIPS
ARE HOPING TO LEVERAGE- NOT
SORT OF THE TRADITIONAL TYPE
OF- CONSULTING CONTRACTS THAT
MIGHT BE PUT OUT FOR BID BUT
SOME OF THE CALL. MAY BE. OR
BRAVE LIKE CAMPAIGN SO GIVE.
BILL SO FAR ON THESE CONTRACTS
IN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE WHICH IS TO
ENSURE PROPER USE OF PUBLIC
FUNDS WE SUGGEST A SLIGHT
REVISIONS ABOUT LANGUAGE TO
SORT OF DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
THE TWO TYPES OF CONTRACTS
EXIST REQUIRE THEM TO FOLLOW
THE TRACK CODE FOR THE MORE
TRADITIONAL ONES. OKAY WHICH IS
NOT I WAS GONNA SAY I WOULD
JUST A THAT WE- THAT SENTIMENT
AND WE ARE WORKING ON A REVISED
LANGUAGE. FINANCE TED AT THE
THAT OKAY NOW QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TURTLE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION OUT
JUST WONDERING IN TERMS OF THE
CAMPAIGN DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
THAT YOU'LL BE USING TO JUST
KIND OF HELP IF. WHAT THE ****
TO IMPLEMENT THIS PAIN. I AM A
WIN YOU MEAN I MEAN- BASELINE
AND FOLLOW UP DATA AROUND- THE
EFFICACY OF THE CAMPAIGN. ENTER
NEED. IN IN YOU KNOW ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE PETITIONS JUST
ALL IS IT JUST- A CROSS FOR
EXAMPLE WILL BE WILL WE BE
TARGETING- SO WE KNOW- CITY AND
PARTNER WITH A YOU SEE. THE
ANALYSIS I AT COUNTY LEVEL AND
I BELIEVE NOW CITY THE AROUND
THE PREVALENCE OF ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE
WE GOING TO USE I'M- THE-
AROUND. WANTS TO TARGET WHERE
WE'RE WE TALK ACT YES
ABSOLUTELY. Q. THAT FEW
QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE THE LA
IS COMMENT ABOUT- THE- CONTRACT
CODE YOU KNOW WE- DEFINITELY
WANT TO TRY TO PAID
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE GOING AROUND. THE
REGULAR COMES TO BACK
CONTRACTING AND OF. SO IN TERMS
OF THE- WELL FIRST OF ALL THE A
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN- SAYS
EIGHT MILLION I CAN. BUT CAN
YOU TO. ARE YOU TO PARTNER WITH
OTHER ENTITIES LIKE FIRST FIVE
COMMISSIONS OR OTHER AND TRY TO
EXPAND THE I MEAN EIGHT MILLION
FOR THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S NOT
A LOW DOWN IT'S A WHOLE LOT
WELL I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE RIGHT
WE GOT BY THE WAY THE SENSE
THAT FORMS. SPEAK TO HOW HOW IS
THE EIGHT MILLION GOING TO
REACH. HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU
EXPECT REALLY REACH WITH YOUR
EIGHT MILLION AND HOW DO YOU
PLAN TO THE ARE YOU LOOKING TO
LEVERAGE SOME OF THAT. WHAT
WILL WE THIRD CERTAINLY.
LOOKING TO LEVERAGE CAPACITY
WHETHER IT'S- IN EXISTING-
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN FOR.
YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY. ENTITIES
THAT HAVE PASSED CITY TO
DISTRIBUTE. A YOU KNOW THE
MASS. AROUND ASUS. SO THE IDEA
IS THAT WE WOULD DO THAT TO THE
LARGEST EXTENT POSSIBLE. BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE MAY NOT
BE. PAINS IN. FRANCE ONE THING
IT BE IN OUR IS YOU KNOW THE
RESOURCE. CAPACITY SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE REESE ARE THE
WOULD HAVE TO BE A NEW EFFORT
BUT AGAIN WOULD BE. ALL THE OF
A- TIED UP AT IN TWO MORE OF
DELIVER OUR CAMPAIGN. AND PART
OF THAT PLAN THAT STILL NEEDS
TO DONE AROUND THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS IS REALLY- WHAT
DOCTOR BURKE AMEND. IS THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK TO SEE YOU KNOW
WHAT TYPES OF GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
MIGHT BE YOU KNOW MOST SUITABLE
TO ADD IN THE PAIN. RELEASED TO
LEARN A HOW WE- EIGHT EIGHT
WHAT IT CAMPAIGN MORE. I WOULD
JUST I'M- THAT. THE WHY WE DO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE ABOUT ABOUT
THE THAT CON IT'S BEST BE WE DO
HAVE PHILANTHROPIC IN OTHER WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN PARTNERING ON.
AND SO WHAT WE INTO TO. OUR
GOAL TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER
ADVANCE X. THE REACH HEY END OF
WHO IS THAT TARGET AUDIENCE FOR
YOUR PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
IT'S IS PUBLIC BUT IS IT. FOR
THERE IS IT SAM. WHO IT GIVEN
THE LIMITED. I MEAN IT IS IT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET RID
AWARENESS MONTH YEAH TYPICALLY
SO. WE'VE BEEN A I SAID TO THE
X. THAT WE DIRECT OUR- SOME OF
THE EIGHT. EIGHT AT OF THE
PUBLIC AT CAMPAIGN TO MEDICAID
RISK. TO AND THE TO TALK TO
THEIR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
BOB PULLED OFF OF THE- AT THE
EXISTING EFFORT THAT WE TURN TO
AN OUT PROVIDERS THAT BAD. AT
ON THE DOLLARS TO WE DEPLOY THE
AND THEN BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
A DON'T JUST MEDIC COME. SO
WHAT WE AND TO. IS A BALANCE.
BETWEEN BETWEEN A DIRECTED AT
THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- YOUNG PEOPLE. I
THE WORD THE SIXTY TWO OKAY
WHO'VE X. IN THE ONE A AND THE
P. WHO LOVE THEM SO A 100% OF
CAL. SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND
EIGHT EIGHT ONE THINGS THAT THE
HELP. THE END JUST RECOGNIZING
WHAT RESOURCES YOU'RE ASKED FOR
YOU'RE USING ABOUT LIKE OKAY BY
AT THE BY THE SOCIAL AND WHAT
PRINT OUT DID JUST BY ITS NOT
GONNA SEE IT. YES BUT FIT SO. I
THINK OF THE HELP TO YOU KNOW
WHEN ONE. THING COME BACK.
NUMBER SPACE. ABOUT THE- IT'S
STAR GO YEAH I ALL OF US USE UP
HERE TO RUN TO WE HAVE A
FEELING YOU OKAY YOU KNOW WHO
WE A SIX RESOURCE TO COME
ACTUALLY TALK TO THAT GOING TO.
TERMS OF THE CROSS SECTOR THAT
COMMON FORM TRAINING NOW IS
THIS. SO WHAT DEGREE WE- TEST
OF LAMBS AND WAIT WE RAISED OR
NOW RAISING AWARENESS OF EXES.
AND WE'RE- YOU KNOW WE FEEL USE
THE STATISTICS AND THEN I MEAN
YOUR FUTURE SHOULD OF PETER'S
LIKE WHAT WE DO NOW RIGHT SO
ARE WE ARE WE TEACHING PEOPLE
MEDI XIN ARE WHAT THAT SO THE
SECTOR BEING TRANSFERRED. IT'S
ONLY TO ME **** WITH THAT AND
WHAT IS THAT WE CAN BE TO TIE
TEACHING PEOPLE ABOUT THINGS
THEY CAN DO TO MITIGATE. ALSO
BUT IN TERMS OF PEOPLE HAVE A
ASUS SCORES. WHAT WHAT HAVE
HARRY DRESSING THAT YES SO MUCH
OF THE ORIGIN FOR THAT CROSS
SECTOR TRAINING INITIATIVE IS
ACTUALLY- NOT ONLY FROM WITHIN
THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL BUT FROM OUR IT
DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN REACHING
OUT OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL. OUR HELP SHAPE AT
THREE. ON THEIR TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE- CDC ARE-
AT IT'S REACHED OUT- GTD P. HAS
REACHED OUT- THE SUPER IN A
PUBLIC EDUCATION HAS SAID HEY
YOU KNOW WE WILL BE OUR- AT.
BEING AT COMMUNITIES WHERE
LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES TO I JUST SUPPORT
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS BUT WE
WOULD. AND FOR THAT WE'RE USING
THE OTHER BASED. AS WE ARE TO
PUT. IN THE THAT WE'RE DOING TO
THE BUDGET THAT'S- AT THAT WE
ASKED FOR IS REALLY THE
RESOURCE THAT TO ALLOW THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
TO A MAP THE TEAM AND THE
RESOURCES BE ABLE TO ENGAGE AND
PROVIDE THAT EXPERTISE- AND
MATERIALS TO FOLKS WHO ARE
LOOKING TO INCORPORATE IN THEIR
EXISTING TRAINING. OKAY SO. WE
HAVE A SENSE GIVEN THE IN HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE HOW HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO BE ABLE TO. CONNECT
HOW MANY DEPARTMENTS THIS
INCORPORATES FOR THIS FOR THESE
RESOURCES BAIL WE CAN WE CAN
DEVELOP A MORE- PRECISE-
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY
DEPARTMENTS THAT WE'RE-
PLANNING TO REACH WITH THIS AT.
ALL PATIENTS OKAY THAT DEL
HELPFUL SO I DON'T TO HAVE MORE
SPECIFICITY GIVEN IF YOU GIVE
US TWO MILLION THIS IS WHAT. DO
IT RIGHT. BUDGET PROCESS SELF.
TO A- MULTIPLE. I COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT- WORKERS AND- SPECIALS
AND- SO THEY WERE VERY
INTERESTED- SO I DON'T KNOW TO
WHAT DEGREE ALSO YOU'RE HAVING
STATIONS WITH I MEAN THAT HE
SAID TOWN AND FEW WORK. CHILD
SUPPORT CAL SO WE WERE. THIRD
LINES ACTUALLY THE ONES WHO ARE
GATEWAY TO THE RESOURCES THAT
MAY OF THAT STATE PROVIDES.
INCLUDING YOU KNOW. AB CALL FOR
ACTION ARE THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT MAY ACTUALLY BE
INVOLVED AND- HELPING- ADDRESS
SOME OF THE YOU KNOW THE
MITIGATION ISSUES SO I'M HOPING
THAT THERE'S SOME BUT ABOUT HOW
HE- WITH. THOSE I'M SURE YOU
TALK RATE TO THE PHARMACY THE
SERVICE AND THE SERVE SO FOR
BUT HOW YOU REACH AN WHERE THE
FRONTLINE WORKER ARE AND IT
BECAUSE I CENTER THANK THEIR
INTEREST. AND SO THAT THAT MAY
ALSO BOB RESOURCES WELLS SO
THAT MIGHT HELPFUL KNOWS WHAT
IS THE SCOPE OF WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR THE TWO MILLION AND
WEBER DEATH RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER. ELSE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OKAY WELL
THANK VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENT THANK YOU FOR
DEATH GETTING MORE INFORMATION
FOR ME REVISED THANK YOU. OKAY
NEXT UP WE HAVE- WEALTHY
PROPOSED. CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION.
WELCOME. SINCE LIKE. PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES LOOKS LIKE
LA ON FINANCES THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT WE CAN OF THE AGENCY FOLKS
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES. WELCOME
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S ELAINE
SPARTACUS I'M THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR WITH THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH INFORMATION INTEGRITY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JENNIFER SCHWARTZ ON THE
CHIEF COUNSEL OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH INFORMATION INTEGRITY.
YOU HI I'M- SO- I'LL PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE TO GO THROUGH YOUR
QUESTIONS- AND THEN OF COURSE
ANSWER ANY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
THE WHAT YOU TO WANT TO GO
AHEAD PRESENTED THEN GO THROUGH
A QUESTION AND THEN WILL HELP.
THEM WHAT. SO THE- PROPOSES.
BILL LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH THE
CENTER FOR DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION. WITHIN THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY- THE
PROPOSAL LANGUAGE WOULD MERGE
THE CURRENT OFFICE OF HEALTH
INFORMATION INTEGRITY THE
OFFICE OF THE PAY. ADVOCATE AND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE FOR
THE PROTECTION OF HUMAN
SUBJECTS. A AND INTO THE NEW
CENTER- IT WILL COMBINE THE
FONG. THESE ENTITIES. ARE DOING
WHAT INCLUDE ANY REPORTING ON
QUALITY CARE. AND PATIENT
EXPERIENCE A PUBLIC HEALTH
COVERAGE PROGRAMS. WILL
CONTINUE GUIDANCE ON. DATA
SHARING. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
HEALTH INFORMATION. THE LOS
CLOTHES HAMPER. AND REVIEW
RESEARCH PROPOSALS THE- DATA
ASKS. THIS THE CENTER ISLE OF
MAN A RESEARCH DATA HOW BEEN
BEEN DATA PORTAL. ENGAGE AND
COORDINATE WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO ADDRESS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH EXPAND
HEALTH DATA SHARING HEALTH
INFORMATION PRIVACY CLIENTS GUY
AMONG STATE ENTITIES IMPROVE
DATA PROCESS AND NOT MANAGEMENT.
PARCHMENTS AND FINALLY DEVELOP
ENERGY FUTURE DATED SHOULD HAVE
THEN THE AGENCY UNLESS PROPOSAL
IS A COST NEUTRAL PROPOSAL.
I'VE OUR ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WAS WHY DOES THE PROPOSAL WOMEN
AT THE OFFICE OF THE PATIENT
ADVOCATE COMPLAINT DATA REPORT
AND HOW DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION- AND TEND TO
TRACK THE PERFORMANCE OF CALL
CENTERS OF THE FOUR REPORTING
TO PART OF THOSE REPORTS
PERMITTED APARTMENTS HEALTH
CARE SERVICES COVER CALIFORNIA
REVENGE. WHAT DO I. THE GOAL OF
POOR WHICH IS TO COLLECT AND
ANALYZE THIS COMPLAINT CALL
DATA- AND THE RELATED CONSUMER
ASSISTANCE INFORMATION TO
IDENTIFY TRENDS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS- TO IMPROVE.
IMMERSES ARTICLES WITHIN THESE
FOUR ENTITIES- THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE STILL ALLOWS THE
CENTERS TO COLLECT THE STATE SO
THAT'S NOT STOPPING- WHAT WITH
TO SEE THOSE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO EVALUATE
THE- PLAYING. FORTY AN
ABUNDANCE OF INFORMATION AND
THAT INFORMATION- BUT WE DO IT
DOES POSE A FEW QUESTIONS LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE- IN THE MOST
CURRENT REPORT IT STATES IN ONE
PART THAT THE DATA PRESENTED
MAY PROVIDE IN PERFECT
COMPARISONS- BETWEEN YEARS AND
REPORTING ENTITIES COVERAGE
TYPES AND SOMEWHAT CATEGORY SO
WE THINK THAT'S WITH A PAUSE
AND TAKE A LOOK AND SEE. WHAT
WE CAN DO IT BETTER. I'M NOT I
WOULD LIKE TO POP. BETTER WOULD
LIKE TAKE A CLOSER LOOK ALSO
THE REPORT BASED ON SOME
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK AND FIND
OUT WHAT'S FEASIBLE FOR THE
WHAT'S MORE USABLE WHAT'S OF
MORE VALUE ARE WE PUTTING THE
RIGHT INFORMATION OUT TERE SO
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
DO THAT AS WELL- AND THAT'LL
BENEFIT OBVIOUSLY THE
DEPARTMENTS AND ULTIMATELY THE
CONSUMER SHOULD THE PATIENT
THINK. ONLY ON THE DATA THAT WE
WERE GOING TO CAN TO. ANALYSIS
FROM THAT WOULD LIKE TO EMPLOY
THE AGENCY'S OFFICE OF
INNOVATION TO HELP GO THE NEXT
STEP. AND HELP THESE ENTITIES.
CMOS WERE NEEDED TO DO BETTER
AND REDUCE THE COMPLAINTS. SO
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION WOULD
YOU GO THROUGH ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT AND NOW WE WILL
THEN THEN WILL COMMENT SO. THE
REGARDING THE THIRD QUESTION
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY. HOW HELLO
HI THE MANDATE FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH HIP BUT PROTECTION OF
PATIENT INFORMATION WILL BE
CONTINUED THERE IS NO
DISTINCTION OR DIFFERENCE IN
THE AUTHORITY IN CALLOW HIGHEST
TUBES AND THIS NEW LANGUAGE
INSTEAD SOME. TION OF THAT LINK.
BECAUSE YOU ARE YOU CAN'T DO
YOU SORT OF HAVE A COMPLIANCE
WITHOUT ALSO CONSIDERING OTHER
FEDERAL AND STATE HELP PRIVACY
LAWS AND SORT OF BRIDGING THE
GAP PERFORMS THE MORE COVERAGE
OF WHAT THOSE REQUIREMENTS ARE.
WE'VE ALL BE DONE NOT AND SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE IN PATIENT
POLICY MANUAL FOR STATE
DEPARTMENT AND WHAT LANGUAGE
DOES TO SIMPLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT'S REALLY HEALTH PRIVACY LAWS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUDGET.
THE AUTHORITY. THE IN
COMPLAINTS ARE TO BE IN LARGE
PART WILL NOT CHANGE SO COME
LET ME KIND OF BREAK DOWN WHAT
THAT MEANS A LITTLE BIT MORE-
SO THE CENTER WILL STILL BE
RESPONSIBLE TO DO YOU OVERSIGHT
OVER STATE DEPARTMENT'S
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE HEALTH
INFORMATION IT WAS THE LAWS
THROUGHOUT TIRES SO THAT PEACE
SAME WILL STILL CONTINUE TO
PUBLISH MEDI POLICIES WILL
CONTINUE TO DO TO. VIEWS AFTER
THE BREACH UP THEM THAT HAVE
THAT WOULD A REVIEW- BUT WE'RE
MERGING THE TASKS THIRD OPPOSE
BAND REQUIRED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THREE SO THERE'S BEEN
A LITTLE BIT OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
HERE THAT WE'VE HAD A LONG TIME
TO COMPLETE I REALLY DOES MORE
ABOUT FULL COMPLY OTHER THAN
IMPLEMENTATION. SO WHAT WE DO
IS WE THE FLEXIBILITY OF MOVING
THOSE PROGRAMS IN CONSISTENT
FORM WITH TYPE OF LEVEL OF
COMPLIANCE THE STATE AND HIS
HOUSE SO. YOUR PHONE ON. THE
MANAGEMENT SORT OF STANDARD XIN
OF THAT PIECE OF LOOKING AT
TOOLS AND METHODOLOGIES THAT
ARE HELPFUL FOR STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO CONTINUE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE IN COMPLIANCE-
FOCUSING ON WHAT VALUE WE CAN
OUT THERE PROVIDING EDUCATION
SO. THINGS IS MORE FRIENDS OF A
RECOGNITION OF THE LEVEL OF
COMPLAINTS AND MOVEMENT TOWARDS
UP TRANSITION OF THAT. SO WITH
RESPECT TO NUMBER FOUR-
DESCRIBED WHAT BARRIERS OF
SHARING OF THAT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS IDENTIFIED
THAT THE CENTER WOULD HELP
MITIGATE SO- THERE'S BEEN A
COUPLE OF STUDIES BY MEN THAT
AS WELL AS THE NATIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY THE
FEDERAL SIDE NOT STUDY WAS ON
CALIFORNIA THAT- REALLY ABOUT
WHY ARE PEOPLE DOING
INFORMATION BLOCKING IS THAT
WHAT THE BARRIERS TODAY TO
SHARE. AND TO PIECES FROM LOS
DOWN FIVE AT ONE THERE'S CAN UP
LAWS WHEN THEY UP WITH THE MEAN
AND TO THERE IS A RISK CATION
HAPPENING BECAUSE THERE'S A
FEAR OF POTENTIAL LIGHT. WE DID
A LOT OF THE ENGAGE. AT HELLO
HI WHEN WE PUBLISH SOMETHING
CALLED THE STATE HEALTH
INFORMATION MANUAL FOR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND COUNTIES.
AND SO E HEARD A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT CLARIFICATION
OF HOW CALIFORNIA LAW AND HOW
FEDERAL LAW WORK TOGETHER. AND
WHEN THEY APPLIED AND LOOKS
LIKE TO ALSO BRING THOSE SORT
OF STATE TO RECITE ENTITIES SO
WE CAN STANDARDIZE LOOKS LIKE
INTO. FIRST WE A TEST IN DOING
HARPER CONCURRENT IN CARE. LET
ME KIND OF GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT I MEAN BY THE- ONE.
THAT DOES PRESENTATION OF MORE
OF PART. CHALLENGE WOULD BE
SOMEONE WHO WOULD HAVE YOU KNOW
NO HEALTHCARE COVER. COVERED BY
THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION OCT FOR CALIFORNIA.
IF THEY HAVE A MENTAL ILLNESS
THEY'VE. ACT IF THEY HAVE SOME
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES HISTORY THEN THEY'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE COVERED BY THE
LACK TO MEND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES ACT. IF
THEY HAVE- SOME SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER HISTORY THAT THEY'RE
ALSO VERY LIKELY GOING TO BE
COVERED BY THE FEDERAL FORTY
TWO CFR TWO PM THE STATE'S
HEALTH AND SAFETY. SO THAT
GIVES YOU A SUGGESTION OF LIKE
HOW COMPLICATED THIS MIGHT BE.
THE PERPETRATORS. PLANS AND A
LOT INDUSTRY SERVICE PROVIDERS
HAVE ASKED HEY COULD YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE SOME CLARIFICATION OF
HOW THESE AND TO RELATE HOW CAN
I DO THIS WITHOUT VIOLATING THE
LAW. IN THE PRO AND A YOU KNOW
VALUABLE WAY FOR THE PATIENT.
SO WE SEE THAT OUR VALUE TO
BRING ON THIS WOULD BE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS WHERE. OUR
CONFUSION AND- NEEDING
CLARIFICATION ON WHEN YOU CAN
SHARE APPROPRIATELY UNLAWFULLY
AND THE TO HELP PROVIDE THAT
EDUCATION. TO CONTINUE
PUBLISHING AND EXPANDING OUR
GUIDANCE ON THAT FROM THE
STATE'S PERSPECTIVE. AS WELL AS
GO OUT AND PERFORM MORE
ENGAGEMENT AND MORE EDUCATION
WITH COUNTIES WITH LOCAL
ENTITIES. AND WITH A PRIVATE
SECTOR. AND NONPROFITS. OKAY
THANK YOU HELLO COMMENTS. HELLO
SONYA PETTITTE KALLIO- I WOULD
NOTE THAT OUR OFFICE- TOOK A
LOOK AT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS ACROSS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WOULD
EITHER REORGANIZED DEPARTMENTS
ARE CONSOLIDATE PERMANENCE AND-
THAT ANALYSIS- PROPOSED THAT
THE QUESTIONS. THAT YOU WANT TO
ASK WHEN THESE TYPE OF THINGS
ARE PREPOSTEROUS YEAH THE
PATIENTS BENEFIT IT'S DOES THIS
AND A POLICY GOAL. REFLECT JUST
LATER. AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT
RELATIVE TO SOME OF THE OTHER
PROPOSALS AND WINNERS BUDGET-
THIS ONE. THE IN A FIT THANK
PROBABLY OUTWEIGH THE I MEAN
FOR OF ALL IT'S JUST IN DOLLAR
IT'S COST NEUTRAL- THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL ISSUE WITH THE
REPORTING ON COMPLETE DATA BUT
OTHERWISE I'M SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS- WE ALSO
THINK- REFLECTS LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF BETTER
COLLABORATE ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENTS- AND OFFICES WITHIN
HEALTH AND HUMAN. AGENCIES
AGENCY. AND HOPING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF JUST HOW SOME
OF THOSE- PROGRAMS NEED YOU
KNOW WORK TOGETHER AND GETTING
A BETTER SO. ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE THE DATA ACROSS THOSE
DEPARTMENTS. THANK YOU FINANCE
THING TO AT THE END OKAY ALL
RIGHT- I'VE READ SO- APPRECIATE
THE LOOKING AT THIS IN YOUR
OPINION ACTUALLY QUESTION
ANOTHER QUESTION SO GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S THOSE READING THIS
IS A MERGER THE STREET THAT'S
APARTMENT. I THE TITLE. CENTER
FOR DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION. YOU WANT BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO FIT. ANY OF THE
TASKS OF THE THREE AGENCIES
THAT ARE BEING COMBINED TO FORM
THIS IN FACT THE MAIN THRUST OF
EACH OF THE AGENCIES IS NOT
INSIDE INNOVATION I MEAN WITH
LIKE INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION-
BUT IT REALLY ISN'T OUT.
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION AND
ASSURING THAT PEOPLE YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THAT'S NO PATIENT
PROTECTION I MEAN THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS YET THAT AND I DON'T
AYE ENTITLES DO YOU KNOW IF
YOUR WORK AND AGENCIES IN THE
TITLE OF YOUR AGENCIES ACCESS
THAT. THE FIGHT HELP CERTAINLY
ONE ELEMENT TO HELP TO FIND THE
CULTURE AND SEE. SO I MEAN I
SEE CERTAIN BODY BEING A CENTER
FOR DATE INSIGHTS INNOVATION IF
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO CRUNCH THESE
AND FIND OUT CERTAIN PATTERNS
AND SO FORTH. BUT I WOULD THINK
THIS. ENTER KEY GIVEN THE
AGENCIES THAT WE COMBINE TO
FORM THIS SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT. INTEGRITY AND PRIVACY
AND SECURITY NOT INNOVATION AND
INSIGHTS I MEAN NOT SEEN THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T DO THAT BUT BUT
THAT THAT SHOULD BE THERE IN
THAT SHOULD. RIGHT THAT SHOULD
BE THEIR MAIN THE PEOPLE GO TO
WORK THERE'S- A STICKY PEOPLE
PROTECTOR DATA RIGHT BE SURE
THAT THEIR PRIVACY IS PROTECTED
BECAUSE WE HAVE DIFFERENT ALL
THE MULTIPLE LAWS RAIDS YOU
MENTIONED RIGHT. THAT FOR OUR
JOB IS TO BE FOR PATIENTS WHAT
THEY HAVE COMPLIANCE- LEVERED
AT- WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE PATTERNS O BE SURE THAT
THE AND THAT THAT WERE DRESSING
THE ISSUES THAT PATIENTS ARE
RAPING WITH. PLAN ARE TYPES OF
THINGS RIGHT. STATION THAT. FOR
WELL IT OLD OFFICE HELD IN.
INTEGRITY RIGHT. SO AGAIN I
SORT OF FEEL LIKE WE'VE LOST
THE PURPOSES OF THE THREE
AGENCIES THAT WE PUT TOGETHER
EVEN IN THE TITLE SO CAN YOU.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT ONE
ABSOLUTELY. SO BE THERE'S SORT
OF A SHORT TERM. NEED FOR
EVOLUTION AND- SOME BUILDING
AND THEN A LONG TERM VISION FOR
WHERE WE WANT TO GO AND THE
TITLE REALLY REFLECTS MORE OF A
LONG TERM VISION OF WHERE WE
WANT TO GO. BEFORE YOU CAN
REALLY START DOING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU MENTIONED AS
WHAT YOU WOULD EXPECT WITH THAT
TITLE. RELEASE START WITH THE
MEN AND WOMEN'S AND SORT OF
STANDARDIZED THAT THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. THEN ONCE WE
SET. RULES AROUND WHAT
COLLECTION LOOKS LIKE DATA
DICTIONARY- ALL THOSE PIECES.
ONCE WE UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER'S
DATA WHAT IT MEANS WILL HAVE A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY OF. TAKING
USE CASES AND COMPARING APPLES
TO APPLES INSTEAD OF APPLES TO
ORANGES. AND THEY'D BE ABLE TO
LOOK THROUGH THAT. AND DO THAT
KIND OF ANALYTICAL WORK. SO
THERE. WE ARE LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH RESPECT TO
YOU. HOW WE CAN BETTER USE OUR
DATA AND BETTER INFORMED THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE USING
THEIR DATA ON HOW TO MAKE THEIR
PROGRAMS MORE EFFECTIVE AND
IMPROVE SERVICES. SO ONE OF THE
VISION THAT WE HAVE ISSUE. TO
MOVE THIS TOWARDS. PULLING THAT
INFORMATION FROM AN AGENCY
PERSPECTIVE SO FOR EXAMPLE.
DEPARTMENTS ARE AWARE OF WHO AT
WHO'S AT HIGHER RISK WITHIN
THEIR OWN DEPARTMENT. BUT AS AN
AGENCY WE'RE NOT ENTIRELY SURE
WHO'S AT HIGHER RISK WITHIN. AS
IN. E. PERSPECTIVE OVER THE
SCOPE OF ALL OF OUR PROGRAM.
AND SO. A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
AND WILL PROBABLY HAVE IT BASED
ON SOME USE CASES. WHO IS AT
RISK THROUGHOUT ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS IN A MORE HOLISTIC
RISK RESPONSE. SO THAT WE CAN
REPORT BACK TO THOSE
DEPARTMENTS AND PROVIDE BETTER
SERVICES LOOK TO SEE WHICH
POPULATIONS ARE UNDERSERVED
WHICH RESOURCES NEED TO BE
ADDED TO CERTAIN. PROGRAMS TO
HELP SERVE THOSE FOLKS ADD TO
BETTER YOU KNOW PROVIDE
EFFICACY AND EFFICIENCY
THROUGHOUT. AND ALSO AS
JENNIFER MENTIONED HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES DATED THAT'S
DATA RICH WHEN WE HAVE A LOT OF
DATA ACROSS ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS. AND ONE OF THE
VISION THAT IN THE FUTURE AN
ANALYST IN ONE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS CAN TAP INTO OUR
DATA AND SOME TYPE OF THE
PORTAL OR SEARCH DATA. AND MAKE
IT INTO ASSISTANCE IT THAT'S
ONE TERM. WELL WE TAKE OUR
HOUSE AND TAKE CARE OF THE
POLICY ISSUES OF THE WORK. WE
DO. DOING WELL BUT EXT AND- SO
IT'S A LOT TERM VISION WHICH
WOULD LEAD TO THE NEED. THE NEW
NAME A NEW BRANDING OKAY SO.
BUT I'M GONNA BECAUSE THIS COST.
OKAY SO OF THE GUY. RIGHT
NINETEEN NINETY HEALTH SERVICES.
FOR FACT CD. I ALSO EVEN IN
LEGISLATURE I AUTHOR BUILD OPEN
DATA RIGHT SO I AM A BIG
BELIEVER IN THE POWER OF DATA I
ALSO- THE QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT- LEAST CERTAINLY. NEED AND
CAN USE FOR BASED ON YOUR
EXPLANATION I AGREE THAT WE
COULD USE AND A CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION DATE
THAT I POINTED OUT THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT IN QUESTION THAT WE
SHOULD NOT WE HAVE A LOT OF
DATA. WE SHOULD MAKE IT
AVAILABLE WE ARE ANALYTICAL
CAPACITY TO ANALYZE THE DATA
WITHIN THE STATE IS PROBABLY IT
DOWN GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF DATA
WE HAVE IS. IT YOU KNOW COULD
BE EXPANDED I THINK THERE'S
ALSO- AND WHAT IS THAT AGAIN
PROTECT PRIVACY FOR THEM SURE
ALSO THEIR SECTORS. OKAY ALSO
THE- BENEFIT. MARKS IN A WAY
THAT IS SO THAT IT'S NOT ONLY
THE STATE BUT OTHERS CAN CAN
CAN- IT CAN YOU APPLY IT TO
HELP BENEFIT YOU KNOW- THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA AND
INDIVIDUALS AND SO FORTH. MY
QUESTION IS THAT THE AGENCIES
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER AND
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
HALF TO THEY HAVE SOME-
INSIGHTS IN THIS BUT THEY THESE
FUNCTIONS. HE IS ALMOST THE
COUNTER BALANCE OKAY SO YES WE
HAVE ONE AGENCY THAT'S FIGURE
HOW HE PUSHED IT OUT BUT I ALSO
WANT AN AGENCY THAT'S AS- YOU
KNOW IT BECAUSE- BUT TIMES LIKE
A BIG DATA WE CAN LOOK AT ALL
THE WONDERFUL THINGS WE CAN
USE. BUT WE NEED TO ASSIST. YOU
HAVE GREAT YOU WANT TO DO THIS
BUT FIRST STEP IS THAT. IN
ORDER TO RETAIN THE PUBLIC
TRUST. INCOMPETENCE WE ALSO
NEED PEOPLE WHOSE PRIMARY JOB
IS SAY YOU KNOW WHAT BUT WE
CAN'T DO IN A WAY THAT. THAT
BASICALLY PEOPLE FEEL LIKE TO
PRIVACY IS BEEN EXPOSED ANOTHER
THING SO YOU TALK ABOUT SOMEONE
WHO HAS MULTIPLE THE RATE AND
THEIR INTERFACING ETCETERA AND
YES THEY NEED HELP AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BETTER
DELIVER CARE TO LIMóN PART IS
TRYING TO PUT ALL THESE PIECES
TOGETHER BUT WE NEED SOMEONE
SAYS. BUT IT'S- GREAT WE'RE DO
THIS AND EVEN LIKE HERE'S HOW
THE LAWS SAY BUT THE REASON WE
SAY HERE'S WHILE THE LHASA IT.
THEY'LL LET YOU DO THIS OR WHAT
X. Y. OR Z. IS ALSO THERE PART
OF THEIR JOB TO SAY. YOU REALLY
OUGHT TO THINK TWICE ABOUT
WHETHER YOU REALLY WANT EVEN DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE- THAT IF IT.
THAT MAY LEAD TO A DATA BREACH
ARE WRITTEN REVELATION OF
CERTAIN THINGS RIGHT SO EVEN.
IN WHAT WE CALL. THE INDEMNIFY
DATA. IF YOU HAVE ENOUGH
ELEMENTS YOU CAN GO BACK AND
RECONSTRUCT. STRAIGHT AND SO IN
THE A THROUGH Z. AS IN TO TRY
TO YOU KNOW AND IT AND IT AND
TRY TO PUT THE DATA TOGETHER TO
DO THE INSIGHTS TO HELP PEOPLE.
SOMETIMES THOUGH OLD MAY ALSO
NOT BE IS SENSITIVE TO. BE WELL
IT IS TO DO SOMETHING GOOD BUT
ALSO PUT CERTAIN THINGS AT RISK
IN TERMS OF PRIVACY AND OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS. AND AS- ABOUT
PUTTING EVERYBODY IN THE SAME
HOUSE. EIGHT BECAUSE IT HAPPENS
IS THAT IF YOUR MAIN MISSION OF
THIS AGENCY IS TO DO INSIGHTS
AND INNOVATION. AND YOU PUT THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO SAY WE WORRY
ABOUT THE STUFF. UNDER NEED
THEM AND THE ONLY PEOPLE THEY
CAN TELL IS THE PERSON THE
PERSON SAYS I NOR YOUR VICE
BECAUSE I'M MORE ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT ACTS. AND THEY DON'T HAVE
A SEPARATE YOU KNOW THAT THE
EIGHTY EIGHT IFS ARE PROTECTED
OR SEPARATE ROLE THAN WE COULD
PROBLEMS CAN AND THEN OF COURSE
ONCE. ONCE UP LIKE THAT HAPPENS
AND YOU LOSE THE PUBLIC TRUST.
DELETED THIS GO AWAY RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE TALKING
ABOUT LOSS TO TELL YOU THE NO
NO NO STOP STOP STOP EIGHT AND
PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS BECAUSE READ
STORIES ABOUT- YOU KNOW. THESE
TECH COMPANY THEY WANT TO GET
ACCESS TO MEDICAL RECORDS OF
HOSPITAL A MASK THESE LARGE.
RECORD IS THE WORK MISSING BUT
TO MOUNT RECORDS IS THAT ARE IN
AS. WELL AND YOU KNOW THERE. SO
THERE'S TYSON HAD THE- MONEY TO
BE THERE TO. AND SO. YES THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS THE AGE WITH
THE I DO WONDER WHETHER THEY
SHOULD HAVE SOME SEPARATION
FROM THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING
THE INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION AND
OFF OF THAT THEY CAN PLAY THEIR
OVERSIGHT ROLE IN ADVISING ON
THE NEED TO ADVISE DANY IN BUT
THEY ALSO NEED TO KNOW THAT.
THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO. I IS
DIRECTOR OF THIS AGENCY IS
GONNA SAY WELL YOU KNOW WHAT MY
JOB IS INNOVATION AND INSIGHTS.
AND SO YOU GUYS ARE CAN YOU
STOP INTERFERING YOU KNOW
TELLING US DON'T DO STUFF.
EIGHTY GET WITH ANY DENTIST I
ITEM NO THAT'S NOT YOUR
INTENTION. I JUST ALSO WANT TO
BE CAUTIOUS BECAUSE THESE THAT
WE CREATE THAT WAS AROUND WE
TREAT. THE PATIENT ADVOCATE
RATE IN THE IT WAS CENTER. ME
THAT RIGHT AND HAD TO DEAL WITH
THE SOME OF THE S. AND IN SOME
OF THESE PRIZE ISSUE AND I WILL
BE SURE THOSE FUNCTIONS ARE
DONE. WAY AT. THANKS FOR IT
ALSO THE PEOPLE WHO DO THAT
HAVE A VERY CLEAR IDEA THEIR
JOB IS NOT TO IN A THAT THEIR
JOB IS TO BE SURE YOUR FIRST
PRIORITY IS TO BE SURE TO GIVE
GOOD ADVICE TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S
PRIVACY BECAUSE ONCE WE STORY
AGAIN. I'VE CI INTENT BECAUSE
WE SOME BIG THEY'RE SAYING.
WHICH OBVIOUSLY WAS THE FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS AND RATING. AND
ASSUME THAT. BUT YET BECAUSE
THE PROBLEM. THEN WE HAVE A
THEN WE HAVE A BIGGER PROBLEM
OUR HANDS RATE AND SO I WOULD
BE CAUTIOUS WE STRUCTURE OUR-
THE BUREAUCRACY BAR
ORGANIZATIONS IN A WAY THAT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT BALANCE. THERE
SO THAT TO THE RIGHT DECISIONS
ARE MADE BY THE PEOPLE WHO
FINALLY MAKE POLICY DECISIONS.
SO TO KIND OF SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT AND I'M HOPING THAT
THIS WILL HELP. PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE- RETURNS- OF
SOME OF THE FIRST. SET MAYBE
TACKLING ARE EXACTLY THAT
GOVERNMENT PEACE. OF SO. CENTER
OF IS. NOT JUST SORT OF DOING
THE MANAGED PORTION BUT ALSO
SETTING THE RULES AROUND IT.
AND TO BE VERY VERY CLEAR THERE
IS NO INTENTION HERE OF
VIOLATING ANY. GREAT YEAH I
YEAH. BUT EVERY DAY THERE'S NO
IMPLICATION THAT THAT DESIRE
BACK YOU TRY THE IN THIS
ACCIDENT. SO IT'S SORT OF OPEN
THE FLOODGATES IN A LOT OF
PROGRAMS UP HAVE A LOT OF
SPECIAL RULES AROUND WHEN YOU
CAN COMBINE THAT INFORMATION
WITH OTHERS SO THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN A PROGRAM WILL HELP. DO
YOU ACTUAL ANALYSIS BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT RELEASE THAT
INFORMATION TO ANY OTHER
ORGANIZATION BUT SENT ME CAN'T
PROVIDE I'M WAS DAY. THEY DO
THE EN EL SEND THAT AND- WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE THAT WE LOOK TO
FOR EFFICIENT. AND YOU KNOW AND
PROVIDE BETTER SERVICES AND
IMPROVE THAT- BUT I WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT WERE. MORE
NOT DOING THIS WITHOUT RULES
AROUND HOW THAT LOOKS. AROUND
SHARING PORTION OF IT THEY HAVE
TO BE VERY CAREFUL A WELL
THOUGHT OUT UP. WITH THEY CALL
ME THROW OVER TO PART NOT SURE
THE CENTER ON ITS OWN BECAUSE
THOSE. THOSE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
A- SPECIFIC LAW. APPLIED TO
VARIOUS PROGRAMS ALONG WITH
REGULATIONS AND WE NEED TO BE
PRESENT THOSE TO RECEIVE. THOSE
SO THAT IT CALLED. IS TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THEY WERE DOING THIS
IN AN APPROPRIATE FASHION AND
WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO DO THIS
IN AN APPROPRIATE FASHION WE DO
NOT WANT TO LOSE THE PUBLIC
TRUST EITHER YEAH AND I KNOW
THAT AND SO I GUESS. THE ONE OF
THE MY COST IS THAT SIR OFF TO
COME THE TITLE IS IT STRIPS SO
IS WHAT. THE CULTURE WILL.
RIGHT AT THAT I KNOW ALL YOUR-
ARE RIGHT. IN THE STATE BUT
THIS THAT THE FIRST STAB AT
CULTURE IS THE TO RIGHT OF THE
GIVING THE STATE IN YOUR
PUTTING. IN SO FORTH AND SO I
SAYS CAUTION RIGHT AND HOPEFUL
WE SHOULD THINK THIS THROUGH
BIT ABOUT DOCTOR STATE'S JUST
DOWN TO. IN HELPING KASHA BUT
CANCER OF THE REAL ISSUE BE.
NOW THESE EIGHT THREE AGENCIES
THAT WERE MERGING INTO THISHOW
HOW THEY WILL THEN SIT IN THE
OFFICE WHICH WILL BE MORE TO
THOSE THREE AS- IT. A POOR ONE
THAT IS AT THE- TERM GEN. SO WE
KIND OF. SURE WERE SET THEIR
OBVIOUS THAT CULTURE. AND BY
THE FEW DIRECTOR AND PEOPLE WHO
SERVE IN THAT SAID BUT YEAH
WE'RE SORT OF TOOK THE FOR STAB
BY A THIRTEEN THE TITLE I WANT.
OF ABOUT TITLE BY REALLY IS
LIKE AND THEN THE ROLE OF THE
P. WHO DO. BECAUSE ARE THE
FIRST PEOPLE ARE THEIR YEAH ON
TUESDAY HAS BEEN AN WILL NEED
TO BE BUT OF THAT THEY'RE VERY
CLOSE THEY STAND THEIR JOB IS
NOT THE NO BUT IS MUCH IS THIS
TO BE THE PEOPLE WHO NOT ONLY
AT LAWS AND- IS WHAT LETTER LOS.
BUT ALSO. YOUR IT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE PEOPLE YOU KNOW
IN THE END THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW IS THAT WE'RE
BEING WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE THAT ARE PROTECTING US
GREATER THINGS. IT SAYS THAT-
AND SO WITH THAT WHAT IS TODAY
INTEGRITY AND THEN THERE IS THE
PEACE I MEAN I JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
SAID THAT WELL WE TAKE A PAUSE
AND LOOKING AT. ABOUT IT SINCE
FORCED AND IT AB YES MAYBE WE
HAVEN'T GOT THAT DATA ENTIRELY
RIGHT BUT I UP CONCERNED THAT
WE TAKE OUT THE LANGUAGE THAT
SAYS THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO THAT WILL
EVENTUALLY GET LOST SO WE WILL
NOT. THE CLEANUP A BETTER BUT
ALSO. TO THAT IS BEING WHAT THE
FUNCTION. BASICALLY MEANS NEED
TO. BECAUSE NOW THERE'S NO
LEGAL REQUIREMENT TO DO THAT-
AND SO I THINK I WILL BE A
LITTLE CAUTIOUS ABOUT THAT AS
WELL. OKAY YEAH AND- YOU KNOW
ABOUT YOUR CAUTION WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE AND WE
RECOGNIZE GO. FORWARD THAT WE
NEED A VERY STRUCTURED
FRAMEWORK AROUND GOVERNANCE AND
GETTING THE INFORMATION OUT.
ONE HIP. STARTED PEOPLE YOU
SAID AS A REASON TO NOT SHARE
PERMISSION. SO THAT. QUESTION
WAS. WHAT SO. MOVING FORWARD
WITH THIS OFF AS EXPLAINING HOW
TO GET YES TO APPROPRIATELY
SHARING THAT INFORMATION WITH
THIS- FOUNDATION AND FRAMEWORK
OF GOVERNANCE AROUND IT SO WE
ABSOLUTELY KNOWLEDGE QUESTION
ON THAT. SORT OF CULTURE IT'S
WE SEE IT AS HAVING A DUAL
CULTURE ON ONE HAND IT'S THE
OVERSIGHT. OVER PRIVATE THE
HEALTH AND THAT AND THE OTHER
PIECE AND ESSENTIALLY THE
OVERSIGHT OVER DATA MANAGEMENT
AND GOVERNMENT'S PEACE BUT ALSO
THAN THIS PIECE WHERE HOW DO WE
USE IN A WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO
DO SOMETHING BETTER. WITH IN
THAT FRAMEWORK. YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT'S SOAK UP THAT UP
WILL BE AN INTERESTING WAY OF
DOING IT- BUT BUT YES WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE THERE
MIGHT BE THE SUGGESTION OF A
IT'S FREE FOR ALL BUT THAT'S
NOT ALL OUR- YEAH THE CULTURE
WILL. CULTURE OVERSIGHT AS WELL
AS SORT OF A FIFTEEN PROVIDING
SERVICES THAT WILL HELP IMPROVE
SERVICES OKAY. SHE DEBT- BUT
WHEN YOU DO YOU'LL MULTIPLE
CULTURES IN THE QUESTIONS WHEN
THEY'RE IN CONFLICT WHICH
WHAT'S FOR ALL THAT. AND THAT.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT SO
ANYWAY LET'S THINK ABOUT THAT
I'M SURE WILL I'M SURE YOU HAVE
SOME THOUGHT ADDITIONAL
THOUGHTS AND REFLECTIONS AND
REVISIONS WHEN WE- IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS SO. SHE TO
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU THE-
OKAY RIGHT BURN NEXT CAN TAKE
UP ISSUE NUMBER FOR THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY- I
WOULD MAKE NOTE WHEN WE GIVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. YEAH WE
JUST GOT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE EARLIER THIS WEEK SO
WE'RE GOING TO DO AN INITIAL-
WE'RE GONNA INITIALLY HERE THIS
ISSUE BUT MY IT'S ALSO MY
INTENTION- THAT BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE PEOPLE. COME TO HEAR
ABOUT THAT- BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT WILL I ALSO HEAR IT AGAIN
BEFORE MAY REVISE- TO. DO A
MORE THOROUGH THE- THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S AND THERE MIGHT EVEN
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE SOME
REVISIONS ADDITION. BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN TOO I WON'T THE
RESTORATION CAN TELL ME WHAT A
PLAN TO DO WHETHER THERE'S ANY.
BUT THE PROBABILITY THAT IS BUT
I CERTAINLY THINK YOU CAN WITH
ALL. THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US.
THE SERVER DESERVE FIRST CUT
OVERVIEW AND GET AND- AND-
EXPECT WE WILL HAVE YOU COME
BACK AND- MORE DEEPLY INTO THE
PROPOSAL BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S A-
ALSO WITH. THE US THAT. OKAY SO
ACTIVISTS TWO INTRODUCTIONS
FIRST. THANK YOU AGENCY. I AM
DR ALICE CHEN I SERVICE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR POLICY AND
PLANNING AND DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL AFFAIRS AT THE AGENCY
I THANK YOU L. L. BEN JOHNSON
ALEJO YOU FINANCE RAMOS FINANCE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WHICH GO IN
FOR THAT YOU SO MUCH FOR GIVING
US A SEPARATE NEED AT. PRESENT
I. AND THEN BACKGROUND
MATERIALS TO AGENDA ITEM
THERE'S A CITATION OF A C. H.
C. F. AND KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION POLL FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT FOUND THAT- THINK
MORE THAN TWO OUT OF FIVE
CALIFORNIANS REPORTED DELAYING
OUR FOR GOING CARE BECAUSE OF
COST CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IS A FIVE OH UP
SURVEY JUST EARLIER THIS YEAR
LAST MONTH WHICH SHOWS THAT NOW
MORE THAN 50% OF CALIFORNIANS.
MONTHS FOR GOING. ARE TELLING
CARE SO- THIS IS A PRESSING
ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIANS THE
GROWING ISSUE ADDRESSING IT IS
ONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S TOP
PRIORITIES AND OFFICES ONE OF
IT HIT SIGNATURE OF PROPOSAL
SO- I'M WALK TO THE PROPOSAL
AND HOPEFULLY ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS AS I GO ALONG BUT IF
I DON'T BRING THEM UP. PLEASE
PROMISE. PROMISED FOR A GUIDING
IS- THAT WE HAVE TO SET A
TARGET- IF WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE'RE HEADED IT'LL BE HARD TO
GET THERE. SO SENDING A
STATEWIDE PER CAPITA COST
TARGET FOR YEAR OVER YEAR
CHANGIN IN HEALTHCARE COSTS THE
SECOND IS- THEY WERE ALL IN ALL
PARTS OF THE HEALTHCARE SECTOR.
I HAVE A ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO PLAY IN
MEANING THAT TARGET. THE THIRD
IS ACCOUNTABLE- WHEN YOU TALK
TO OTHER STATES THAT WERE- KIND
OF NICELY OUTLINED IN THE
BACKGROUND MATERIALS- THE HOPE-
AND EXPECTATION IS THAT AS YOU
SET A GOAL PEOPLE'S BEHAVIORS
WILL START ALIGNING TO THAT
GOAL- END. IF THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN WE HAVE A WHOLE SERIES
OF PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THAT I'LL GO THROUGH IN
MORE DETAIL AS I WALKED THROUGH
THE OFFICES RESPONSIBILITIES
AND LAST. I'M REAL IN PART WE
WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ENSURE THE SAVINGS ACCRUE BACK
TO CONSUMERS SO THOSE ARE THE
POOR GUY. FALLS I'LL GO AHEAD
AND REVIEW THE KEY COMPONENTS-
IN TERMS OF THE ORGANIST OF
OFFICE AND THEN REPORT THIS IS
AGAIN A HIGH PRIORITY. FOR NINE
IT WILL BE CALLS DOESN'T OFFICE
WITH THE AGENCY. WITH THE DRY
APPOINT. AN IN A LETTER NUMBER.
THE BILL. UP THAT IS INTENDED
TO HAVE BROUGHT EXPERTISE RIP
OF THE DIVERSE OF CALIFORNIA
THE BOARD ADVISES THE DIRECTOR
IN ALL KEY ASPECTS OF THE
OFFICES WORK- AND THERE IS A
ROBUST PUBLIC STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS EMBEDDED A AND ALL
PROCESSES- IN TERMS OF THE
HEALTH CARE COST TARGET. AT THE
ADVISORY BOARD WILL- CONFORT
LOOK IT- ESTABLISHED ECONOMIC
INDICATOR SO DIFFERENT STATES
OF LOOKED AT PERSPECTIVE STATE
JUDY PDD PEOPLE'S MINDS URBAN
CPI THEIR NUMBER OF ESTABLISHED
ECONOMIC INDICATORS THE POINT
IS NOT MADE UP THIS ACT BASED
ON- ON. THE ACCEPTED A MEASURE-
THEY'LL SET A STATEWIDE TARGET
ON THE FORTY TO SAYS SECTOR
SPECIFIC TARGETS AS WELL AS-
HERE. HELLO THIS IS A AND SO
THE STATE WIDE TARGET IS- THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS AND
DEPENDING ON THE DATA THAT
COMES IN AND ANALYSIS- THE
BOARD MAY THEN ADVISE GOING TO
DIFFERENT SECTORS HOSPITAL
PHYSICIAN'S PHARMA- OR STE
FOCUS ON SPECIFIC GEOGRAPHIC
REGION THERE IS A PUBLIC PROP.
OF THE ADVISORY BOARD
RECOMMENDS THE TARGET THE
DIRECTOR THAN HOLDS AND THIS IS
AGAIN BAGLEY KEENE MEETINGS-
DIRECTOR HOLDS PUBLIC. A PUBLIC
MEETING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
DISCUSSION AND THEN THE TARGET
IS ACTUALLY ADOPTED AT A
SUBSEQUENT MEETING SO THREE
FORMS FOR COMMENT. THERE WAS
ALSO C<c.cyan> THE COPS TURN IT</c>
INCLUDING GROUP THAN OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS. LOOKING AT
AFFORDABILITY IS A KEY FOCUS OF
THE OFFICE. AND IT'S
COMPLICATED SO THEY WILL
DEFINITELY BE TRACKING-
AFFORDABILITY IN TERMS OF TOTAL
OUT OF POCKET COSTS AGAIN THIS
IS NOT FOR INSURED FOLKS BUT
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HAVE
COVERAGE ALL OUT OF POCKET
COSTS PLUS EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTION TO PREMIUM. WILL
BE COLLATED AS A MEASURE OF
AFFORD ANY AND THAT POINT TO-
THE STEP SIZES TO REALLY
MEASURE TRACK ANALYZE DOT. IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO TARGET
BECAUSE YOU START A BENEFIT
DESIGNED. AROUND THEM PLEASE
SURE FREEMIUM. AND WE CAN TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT
IF- IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
TERMS OF DATA COLLECTION. THE
COST DATA STARTS WITH DATA
SUBMISSION FROM PAYERS
INCLUDING A RECIPIENTS- THIS AT
THE OFFICE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
FORTY. TO COLLECT DATA
PROVIDERS IS NEEDED AND I JUST
WANT TO CALL OUT THAT WE DIDN'T
WANT TO START OUT OF THE GATE-
WAS COLLECTING DATA FOR THIS
BEFORE REALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE GAPS WERE- AFTER ANALYZING
THE DATA FROM PAYING BECAUSE
THE SPEC. CATIONS WILL LIKELY
CHANGE YEAR TO YEAR. THESE
EXPECTS WILL BE ADOPTED BY
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS AND AGAIN
THERE WILL BE ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
PUBLIC MEETING- PRIOR TO
ADOPTING THE REGULATION. THE
OFFICE IS ALSO CHARGED WITH
ANALYZING AND REPORTING ON THE
DATA IT COLLECTS- BOTH THROUGH
PUBLISHING AN ANNUAL REPORT AND
HOLDING A PUBLIC MEETING- THE
CONTENT OF THE ANNUAL PORT IS
DELINEATED IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. STRANDS TO EVERS.
KING THERE ON TOWARD IMPACTS ON
IT SAYS EQUITY QUALITY- ANY
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS WHICH
WILL GET TO IN A SECOND BEST
PRACTICES IMPACT ON WORK FORCE.
AND AGAIN THERE'S A PUBLIC
PROCESS EMBEDDED IN THIS WHERE-
THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC MEETING
TO PRESENT THE ANNUAL PORT OF
THE ADDRESS FORDHAM BROADER
PUBLIC. BARBER FOR EMPLOYMENT
IN. BODIES AND THE REPORTING
NICE TO JUST MEETING. YOUR
QUESTION MILLION FORSMAN SO THE
PRINCIPLE OF ENFORCEMENT IS
THAT OF PROGRESSIVE-
ENFORCEMENT. THERE WILL BE A
FULL REGULATORY PROCESS HERE
AND TO DEVELOP AND FOR SOME
PROVISIONS. INCLUDING THE
METHODOLOGY TIMELINE WARRANTED
AND WARRANTED FACTORS TO
PROCESS AN APPEALS BUT IT
REALLY IT STARTS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OF THE YEARS- THE
DATA GETS COLLECTED IT GETS
ANALYZE IF SOMEONE IS EXITING
THE COST TARGET YOU SIT DOWN
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
REALLY TRADED. DOWN TO SEE WHAT
IT THE DRIVERS- IF. THAT
DOESN'T- MODIFYING THE
TRAJECTORY- THERE ARE PUBLIC
HEARINGS ON BY THE OPTION OF
REQUIRE CORRECTIVE ACTION AND-
IF THAT DOESN'T WORK THEN THERE.
A CIVIL AND CIVIL PENALTIES
TEST SO START WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PUBLIC HEARINGS
CORRECT. PLANS CIVIL PENALTIES
AND THEN ESCALATING CIVIL
PENALTIES. AGAIN THE IDEA
BEHIND THE PENALTIES IS THAT IT
IS MEANT TO BENEFIT CONSUMERS-
BY TRACKING FOR BUILDING A
TRACKING PREMIUMS- TALKED ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF USING. THE
MLR REBATE PROCESS- TO- MAKE
SURE THAT THE ANY SAVINGS
ACTUALLY TANGIBLY ACCRUE BACKED
CONSUMERS BUT WE ARE- HAS A TEN
ABOUT SENDING OUT A BUNCH OF
FIVE DOLLAR CHECKS DEPENDING ON
THE AMOUNT. OTHER PARTS OF THE
OFFICE- INCLUDE AGAIN FOCUSING
ON WHAT WE THINK OF AS BALANCED
SCORECARD MEASURES AS YOU FOCUS
ON COST YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE
AN INTENT CONSEQUENCES ON YOUR
WORK FOR STILL. SIAN IT'S-
LOOKING ACCESS QUALITY EQUITY
IMPORTANTLY THERE'S A GOLDEN
MINISTRY OF SIMPLIFICATION IT'S
NOT ABOUT CREATING A BUNCH OF
NEW MEASURES CREATING BUNCH OF
NEW MANDATES ARE REALLY TRYING
TO IDENTIFY PARDEE CORPSMAN IS
THAT CAN BE USED- THERE'S A
PROVISION ARE AT ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT FALLS REALLY ONE AND
WANTING TO OUR SYSTEM FROM
FIFTY BUSINESS. STATION TO THE
THEM AT IN THAT ROLE CAUGHT.
STANDARDS AND CRITERIA FOR A
PM- AND IN PARTICULAR FOCUSING
ON PRIMARY CARE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INVESTMENT- SHIRTS
SAVINGS MODELS POPULATION BASE
PAYMENTS. THE OTHER UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES- TRACKING IS
AROUND HIGH QUALITY JOBS AND
HEALTH CARE WORK FOR STABILITY
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
AREN'T UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
IN TERMS OF LOWERING STANDARDS
ARE ENCOURAGING LAYOFFS. AND
WITH THE GOAL OF ENCOURAGING
HIGH QUALITY JOBS AND AGAIN WE
KNOW THAT AS WE LOOK AT BEST
AND EFFICIENCY THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WILL. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S A GLIDE PATH
PEOPLE ENTER TRAINING AT THE
TRAINING AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE WORK FORCE AS A QUICK FOR
THAT NEW AYE LANDSCAPE. AND
THEN FOR ME OFFICE HAS CHART OF
IN COSTA MARKET VIEWS. IT
THERE'S A LOT OF CAN. ACROSS
MULTIPLE SECTORS IN THE
INDUSTRY THE INTENT IS TO HAVE
A MORE PROACTIVE VIEW RATHER
THAN CHASING THINGS AFTER THE
HORSES LEFT. THE BARN AND IT
HAS A VERY BROAD SCOPE LOOKING
AT HORIZONTAL OR VERTICAL CROSS
INDUSTRY MERGERS AND MEAN AND-
AND JUST A FILL IN THE GAPS SO
IF THERE IS A REGULATORY AGENCY
ARE READY THAT HAS THAT PER
VIEW- THE OFFICE WILL NOT
DUPLICATE THAT. WORK BUT WILL
COORDINATE WITH THE- AGENT AND
IF THERE IS A FINDING ONLY OR
FOR. AG IN TERMS OF FINDING
THERE'S A B. C. P. FORTHCOMING.
THANK YOU AVAIL. GIVEN THE
TIMING OF THE RELEASE WE DON'T
HAVE AN ANALYSIS OF THIS
TRAILER BILL AT THIS TIME WE
WILL BE ANALYZING THE ISSUE
OVER THE NEXT MONTH OR SO AND
WE'LL BE SURE TO COMMUNICATE
THAT ANALYSIS- TO THE
LEGISLATURE JUST A NOTE- AS
WELL THERE IS A POLICY BILL
THAT IS MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS. THE TWO EIGHT TWENTY
THAT WOULD STEP OFF THE AND
CONCEPTUALLY IS QUITE SIMILAR
TO TRAILER BILL BUT WITH THE A
COUPLE KEY DIFFERENCES SOME BUT
ULTIMATELY WE WILL PROVIDE AN
ANALYST AT A LATER TIME I THANK
YOU AND I SAID I THINK WE WILL.
HAVE A JOB. AND SO WE-
CERTAINLY- WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
THE BUDGET ARE THROUGH THE BILL
I GUESS I WILL BE HEARING IT
SOMEWHERE WHEN FORMER ANOTHER
OKAY- A FINANCE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE OKAY
THANK YOU- HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
AGAIN I THINK WE GOT DELVE MORE
DEEPLY INTO THIS. AT A FUTURE
HEARING SO WE CAN GET ALL THE
DETAILS BUT- SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT DIRECTION PLANS IN. CIVIL
PENALTIES AND SO FORTH WHICH
ENTITIES AS THE SUPPLY TO BE
SORT OF. REFER TO IMPLIED
HEALTH PLANS BUT I MEAN I READ
IT- SO YOU SET THE COST TARGET
SO WHO WHO WHICH ENTITIES ARE
SUBJECT TO. THESE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS CIVIL PENALTIES
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT FOR I GUESS I
ASSUME FOR NOT MEETING OR
EXCEEDING ACOSTA IT'S-A LOT OF
THE DETAIL WILL BE WORKED OUT
BY THE ADVISORY BOARD IN THE
OFFICE- THE- CAN CONCEPT. IS
THAT AS YOU LOOK AT THE PAIR
LEVEL DAY AND IF THERE IS IF X.
YOU. DRILL DOWN TO STATE IS IT
DRIVEN BY. HOSPITAL COSTS BY
FORMER BECAUSE BY. A WARRANTED
COSTS CORONAVIRUS COSTS- AND
FIGURE OUT- WHAT THE WARRANTED
IN AN WARRANTED FACTORS ARE YOU
BRING THOSE PEOPLE TO THE TABLE
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT-
ADJUSTMENTS THAT CAN OCCUR IN
ORDER TO. BEND THAT COST
TARGET- AND THEN HAVE THE
ENTITY THAT ACTUALLY IS
IDENTIFIED AS A DRIVER TO
ACTUALLY COME UP WITH A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN. THAT'S
THE GENERAL CONCEPT- WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF DETAILS BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE WORK IN
THE OFFICE OKAY. I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE BETTER DEFINED
SIMPLY BE KEY TO THIS BECAUSE
WE'RE- ABOUT IT THEY CAN GO
AROUND THEY GET ANYBODY IN THE-
GOING AND PUT. YOUR FALL. EIGHT
SO I THINK IT AT YOU FROM. FIND
A BRING PEOPLE IN IN THE PEOPLE
A START FINING PEOPLE I MEAN
THAT TIME IS SOMEWHAT JAILING
ANYONE DURING A FINE PEOPLE WE
DEALT THE NEEDS AND- EXACTLY
YOU KNOW WHAT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY A TRADE AND SO-
I THINK IT. I THINK THAT WOULD
BE FINE AND SIMPLE TO DO YOU
SIT THERE ARE AND HUNTER AND
SAVE BY THE WAY WE NOW THIS YOU
NOW OPPOSE ON YOU PAIN RIGHT OF.
QUESTION OTHER WAYS BUT IF THEY
WERE NOT DOING YOU KNOW
PROVIDING HONEST LABOR ON THE
SERVICES- TO THEN TURN AROUND
AND FIND THEM. BECAUSE NOW
THEY'RE THE ONES ARE BEING
BLAMED FOR SO I MEAN THAT SO I
THINK WE NEED TO FLESH THAT OUT
A LOT MORE THAN SIMPLY A- YELL
WILL HAVE AN END TO FIGURE IT
OUT RIGHT. THAT A AND THEN I'M
I'M A LAWYER BUT I DON'T WHEN
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THINGS
LIKE CIVIL FINES. THE PROBABLY
NEEDS TO BE YEAH I'M I'M NOT
SURE IN TERMS OF WHAT. YOU KNOW
IN THE- THIRD PERSON THE FIGHT.
IS RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS TO
RIGHT. RIGHT I WOULD SAY THREE
THINGS WERE ON A SERVICES RIGHT
YEAH YEAH I THINK THREE THINGS
ONE IS THAT THAT'S WHY THERE IS
A FULL REGULATORY PROCESSES
COULD. BE IN PLACE. TO FILL UP
ANY OF THESE BILLS- WHICH WILL
TAKE UP ONLY AT LEAST A YEAR
WITH. CLEARLY AMPLE OPPORTUNITY
FOR INPUT AND- COMMENTS. AND GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE LEGAL PROCESS
INCLUDING THE APPEAL. AND IN
THOSE PROVISIONS THAT PROTECT
THE- PERSON UNDERSCORE. ARE THE
AT INDUSTRY.TO IS. I MAY HAVE
FIT THE END- EMPHASIZING THE
PROGRESSIVE NATURE OF THIS. THE
INTENT IS I MEAN. I KNOW
RELIGION TENDS NOT TO SAY OH
YOU DID THIS WE GO STRAIGHT.
FIVE BUT IN. THE HOPE WE- THEN
TEND TO. FIFTY CREDIT AND PLAN
NOT EVEN TALK ABOUT FOR THAT RE
HAVING THE DAY BY TRAINS MY
HAVING CA. THE PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO LINE TO THAT GOAL AND THE
REASON WE HAVE THAT HOPE
ALTHOUGH MANY PEOPLE REMIND ME
THAT CALIFORNIA RADICALLY
DIFFERENT FROM MASSACHUSETTS IS
THERE THE GROUP THIS HAD THE
MOST EXPERIENCE AND FRANKLY
THEY'VE NEVER EVEN GOTTEN TO A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN SO AGAIN
DON'T WATER EXPERT IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE. LARGER MORE
DIVERSE IN COMP. EIGHT AND
THERE SOME HELP FROM OTHER
PLACES IN THE COUNTRY THAT BY
HAVING THIS TARGET BY HAVING
THE DATA BY HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS. YOU'RE NOT
RUSHING TO PENALTIES OKAY WELL
I THINK IF WE IF WE ARE GIVING
SOMEONE THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
PENALTIES. FENDER SPEAK CLEARLY
WAS ON HOW AND TO WHOM THOSE
PENALTIES GET APPLIED AND UNDER
WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES SO PEOPLE
ARE VERY CLEAR AS TO WHEN. THEY
ARE IN PENALTY YOU KNOW THAT.
THEY MAY BE SUBJECT TO A
PENALTY- SO AS I UNDERSTAND THE
PROGRESSIVE NATURE BUT AT SOME
POINT ONCE YOU KNOW VI<c.cyan></c>
YOU'RE SAYING ONE OF THE THINGS
WE COULD DO IS NOW BANNED- THE
AND THIRD THEIR NEED. PEOPLE
NEED TO KNOW THEY CAN'T JUST
LIKE FALL INTO IT GREAT SO
THAT'S I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT- THE OTHER. THE YOU
DID MENTION THAT THIS ALSO
INCLUDES PRINCIPALLY ENDS THREE
OF THE THIRTY TO INCLUDE RISA
PLANS AGAIN THIS IS WHERE WE'RE
AT SEEING AROUND IT SO IT
REDUCES HIGH LEVEL PAYER DATA
AND IN TALKING TO. THE STATES
THAT ARE DOING THIS WHICH
ACTUALLY INCLUDE- MASSACHUSETTS
RHODE ISLAND DELAWARE AND-
ORGAN ARE THE ONES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE THIS TYPE OF
STATEWIDE COST TARGET- THERE
HAS NOT YET BEEN ANY ISSUE.
WITH REQUIRING AGAIN HIGH LEVEL
DO WHEN WE'RE NOT TALKING AN H.
P. THAT IS A TOLD THAT'S
CLEARLY DELINEATED. PLANS ARE
EXEMPT FROM A P. CITIES- THIS
IS HIGH LIVER LEVEL DATA THAT
AND HAS BEEN SUBMITTED AND
WE'RE HOPING WILL BE SUBMITTED
FOR US AS WELL. OKAY AND-
ACTUALLY INTERESTING DETAIL
TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE- BECAUSE-
SO. WHEN THE DRIVERS OF HEALTH
CARE COSTS AND THEY THINK
MEDICARE'S IDENTIFIED THIS IS
THAT THE MORNING DEPEND
PRACTITIONERS YOU HAVE THE MORE
UTILIZATION YOU HAVE. THE MORE
UTILIZATION YOU HAVE TO PRESS
YES THE MORE INDEPENDENT
ENTITIES YOU HAVE GOING AROUND
DOING THINGS THE MORE
UTILIZATION WE HAVE SO THAT.
NOW IF YOU'RE IN AN UNDERSERVED
AREA IT'S PROBABLY IS NEEDED
UTILIZATION RATE SO THAT THEIR
DUE TO AN ABSENCE ARE AT AN
UNMET MEDICAL NEEDS- WE ALSO
KNOW THAT CERTAIN AREAS BUT
ALSO IF THAT'S- IF YOU'RE- DAD-
IT IS. FIND PLAN I TWO OR FOUR
THREE INCH BUT THAT'S- A SO ARE
WE LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
THINGS RELATE TO WORKFORCE AS
WELL. I THINK THAT'S TO BE
DETERMINED BY THE OFFICE I WILL
NOTE QUE YOU LOOK IT AND COST
TRENDS THE MOST OF IT IS NOT
DRIVEN BY UTILIZATION. ACTUALLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE- FACT THAT
HEALTH CARE COSTS HAVE
INCREASED AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
JEAN PIERRE WAGES OR ANY OTHER
MEASURE MOST OF IT IS AROUND
THE PRICES RATHER THAN
UTILIZATION. OR DEMOGRAPHIC
MAPS OR NOT SO WE HAVE IT'S
WHAT'S THE MARGARET THE RIGHT
AND- AS WE TRIED TO TOSS TRACK
DID YOU MENTION THE GP BUT YOU
GUESTS FOR. AGING BUT I DON'T
KNOW THE LONG TERM PART OF.
WHAT THAT. IS TO BE DETERMINED.
AS AN ENTRY. SO IT'S- RATE IT'S-
IT ALSO DEMOGRAPHICS IT'S
STICKING. NO SIR BROADLY
DEFINED RATE SO WE GO FROM. X.
RAYS A CT MRI IS RIGHT FOR- OR
WE GO FROM YOU KNOW-
IMMUNOGLOBULIN TO CIVIL THE
IRATE. SO FORTHRIGHT SO YOU
HAVE YOU OF IT DANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY. AND YOU HAVE THE
ACTUAL INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIORS OF
THE PEOPLE ARE. OF THE SYSTEM
RIGHT TERMS OF OKAY. SO IT I
THINK IN THAT SO- THAT'S WHERE
I MEAN IN IN HEALTH ECONOMICS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY TALK ABOUT
HOW PROVIDERS CAN GENERATOR AND-
SO I AM IN THE MANNER. PRESS
FIGHTER CANCER THAT GOES BACK
TO THE NUMBER OF INDEPENDENT
ACTIVISION HERBS AND HOW MANY
WE HAVE AND WHAT ARE THEY DOING
TO DRIVE THEIR ON DEMAND WHAT
DEGREES THAT DEMAND. OF
INVERSES NEEDED RIGHT NOW IT'S
HARD TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE
TWO RIGHT SO TRY TO. THAT PIECE
AS WELL. THE TRYING FIGURE OUT
HOW WE PUT ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
PIECE. THERE IN TERMS OF FIGURE
OUT LIKE QUICKLY STRATEGICALLY
PUT OUR RESOURCES HOW DO WE
DIRECT THEM- AND YOU KNOW GOES.
TO HOW DID AN APPROPRIATE GETS
RIGHT YOU ARE YOU SEE ALSO THAT
pWE'RE TALKING UP FRONT VIRUS
DISTANTLY. BEFORE PANEL FOR THE
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE. FIVE OR
EIGHT. I DON'T KNOW WHAT DEGREE
DO WE TELL PEOPLE IT'S OUR A
TRUCK THAT HE- WHEN YOU. I WAS
READ AN ARTICLE ABOUT HOW LOCAL
HAAS HAD YEAR BECAUSE PEOPLE
GOT THEMSELVES IMMUNE OR FOOD
FLU CASES EXPECTED THAT YEAR.
RIGHT THAT'S ACTUALLY GOOD
OUTCOME BUT WASN'T GOOD FOR THE
HOSPITAL'S CELL BECAUSE THAT
YOUR ADMISSIONS RIGHT AND SO
HOW THOSE KIND OF DYNAMICS WORK
RIGHT IN TERMS OF. I'M FOR COP
THING THEY'LL- JACQUELINE. NEXT
THAT IS WHAT WE WANT BECAUSE IT
MEANS YOU PEOPLE BUILDING TWO
BARS. SO HOW'S THAT SO LOOK AT
WELL THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS TO
DELVE INTO HIM LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING AT THE- MORE DETAIL
A LOT. OF LIKE TO WORK OUT WE
GOT THE TRUCK THE ONE ON MY
CELL AND THEY'LL- NEED TO DO TO
NOT ASSIST. PROBLEM IN. TELLING
I DON'T KNOW IS TO SELL. THAT
YOU CAN'T AND I DON'T KNOW. SO
I. WANT TO DEL INTO. TO THAT
AND I YOU. RIGHT FOR OF THE OFF
ARE YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SEEN OUT
BUT A LOT OF THE MATH THAT
METHODOLOGIES FOR. I MEAN ARE
GOING TO RELY ON THE X.OF THE
PEOPLE STAFF THE OFFICE AND
ADVISORY BOARD AND I THINK
ANOTHER IS TO CALL OUT H. P.
IT'S GONNA BE A- RESOURCE. THE
THINGS YOU TO ABOUT IS IT OUR
DURING BY NATION OR BY ARE BY
SO BODY EUROPE YOU KNOW CURRENT
OF OURS I THINKALL OF THAT
WILL BE- OR A PARENT BY HAVE A
GRANULAR DATE IN THE H. B. D.
OKAY. SO I GUESS THE ONE OTHER
THOUGH CASH FOR IT IS- ME SO I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S- THERE WAS A
LOT OF COMPLICATED THINGS. SOME
OF IT YOU KNOW YOU MIGHT DO
PLACE AND BUT I THINK ALSO SO I
SECTION WE'RE STARTING TALKING
ABOUT LIKE SOME TOWN. AND BUT I
THINK THE LED TO SO WANTS TO BE
SURE WE ALL IN. NINE BUT THINGS.
ALL THE- TURNED OUT REGULAR IN
THAT WE ACTUALLY SLATE. IS TO.
THE KEEP QUESTIONS THAT WOULD
IN THE CODE. CLOSE SURE WE- TO
VIEW IS AND ALSO TO AT TWO TWO
ALSO GIVE TO WHAT WE YOU PLANE
TO DO AND TO GIVE ALSO THE
THAT'S WHAT THAT A CODE HAS
THAT THIS IS. YOU MIGHT HAVE IN
THE IN A REGULATIONS SO I THINK
CAN WE DON'T BUY DISABLED AND
FOR ALL THAT TO THE REGULATORY
PROCESS I THINK WE WANT TO THE
VET THAT. THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THROUGH OUR THE-
SEAT AT THREE BILL ARE ARE TO
THIS PROCESS THE WORKING AT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. SO MUCH OKAY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT IN FACT. WE HAVE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS HERE
AND THEN WE'LL- THE WHOLE CD
THINGS WE HEARD RELATED TO.
HELP HIM SERVICES. BUT SO START
OFF WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY FAMILY PHYSICIAN. NEVER
PROPOSAL HERE. ACTUALLY I'M NOT
SURE. USUALLY ASK LIKE ELIA
FINANCE WITHIN THE PINION ABOUT
NOT SURE WHO HE SAID SITTING UP
THERE RELATED TO THAT IN A
REALIZE YOU'VE OFTENTIMES YOU
SAY I DON'T HAVE IT IF YOU KNOW
WE HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT YET BUT
EASY DO YOU SELL EITHER WHO
COULD HAVE FROM FINANCE UP HERE.
IF YOU'RE- AFTER ALL YOU HAVE
AN OPINION WILL ON HERE IT SAYS
OKAY. HOPEFULLY GOOD I DO IT WE
DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO ANYTHING
IN ADDITION TO THAT IS NOT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I GOT THAT.
BUT THEIR OPINION. SO OKAY
LET'S GO AHEAD AND START MULTI
PAYER PESTS PATIENT CENTERED
MEDICAL HOME WORKING GROUP I
ASK OF YOU CAN TRY PLEASE KEEP
YOUR PRESENTATION TO THREE
MINUTES OR LESS. AND WE HAVE
MORE TIME FOR QUESTIONS OKAY
THANKS TO PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD- I'M
ADAM FRANCE IN THE- OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS ALL RIGHT. PLEASE
BEGIN. CAN YOU SEE TODAY ABOUT
OUR MODEST PROPOSAL. WILL HELP
BEEN COST CURVE. AND THEY
CLOSER TO VALUE BASED PAYMENT-
YOU'LL BE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THIS SINCE YOU AUTHORED
LEGISLATION SOME YEARS AGO AT.
THIS TIME LEGISLATION ON THIS
ISSUE- WE'RE LOOKING TO- TAP.
TO JUST FOR TERRY WITH
CONVENIENT WORKING GROUP
CONSISTING OF PAYERS PROVIDE.
AND INSTEAD OF. EMPLOYMENT MORE.
GRAMS AIMED AT CREATING A LINE
FOR DEFENSE PRIMARY CARE. AND
VALUE BASED PAYMENT. IS THIS
TYPE OF ADVANCE TO LIMA
REQUIRES VERY NARROW ANTITRUST
LIABILITY WAIVERS THE STATE
MUST BE INVOLVED. READING MULTI
PLAYER PILOTS HELPPRIMARY CARE
PRACTICES TRANSFORM TO ADVANCE
PRIMARY CARE PRACTICES ALSO
KNOWN AS PATIENTS AND OUR
MEDICAL HOMES HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO REDUCE COSTS AND IMPROVE
OUTCOMES. AS IN OTHER STATES
LIKE NORTH AND COLORADO HAVE
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL THIS. CAL
AYMAN UP ROSE OFFICE OF-
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY- WILL
GET US THERE IN SEVERAL YEARS
AND WE THINK THIS PROPOSAL CAN
HELP BUILD THE FOUNDATION FOR
THOSE FOR THE ACTIVITY AND HELP
DISSEMINATE BEST PRACTICES. CO
IS LIKELY TO PLACE A CODE
NINETY IS LIKELY TO PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT- BUDGET IMPACT ON
OUR STATE AND ON FRONTLINE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS THE WE
NEED A CRUCIAL SUPPORT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS FOR OVER. THE
WILL HELP SAVE MONEY ON TRAINED
PHYSICIANS THIS IS NECESSARY TO
MANAGE THING FROM CURRENT
DISEASES TO ADDRESSES. THIS
MULTI STATE. TASK FORCE HAS THE
POTENTIAL MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN OUR STATES EFFORT
TO SUPPORT PRIMARY CARE IMPROVE
OUTCOMES AND BEND THE COST
CURVE. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR HOPEFULLY FUTURES. AND
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
FROM ALEJO. IT'S NOT ALL RIGHT-
SO BASICALLY YOU'RE ASKING FOR
ESSENTIALLY A- WELL WORKFORCE A
CONVENER BECAUSE YOU KID
FRIENDLY TRUST REASONS WE CAN'T
THE ONLY STATE CAN PULL PEOPLE
THE FROM THIS CORRECT IS SO
FORTY. YOU SOME YEARS AGO DID
OUR PCMH PROGRAM FRESNO RIGHT
WHICH WAS WITH- ONE'S SELF
INSURED PAYER AND SO THAT
PRACTICE COULDN'T THEN GO TO
ALL THE OTHER PAIRS ARE PART OF
THAT MEDICAL PRACTICE AND SAY.
LET'S WITH SOMETHING RIGHT. YOU
NEED THE STATE TO OVERSEE THAT
OF THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY IT'S
VERY NARROW IN TERMS OF THE
ANTITRUST LIABILITY BUT YOU
STILL NEED THE STATE TO APPLY
AND CONVENER THOSE GROUPS.
AGAIN WE JUST HEARD FROM THE A
PROPOSAL FROM THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY I
THINK ONE OF THE ELEMENTS WAS
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
PAYMENT MODELS- YEAH I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TOWARD THE FRESNO-
PROGRAM. IT WAS ONE THAT- YOU
KNOW THEY WERE ON THE CURVE TO
BASICALLY BETTER MANAGE CHRONIC
DISEASE BUT ALSO SAVE MONEY- SO
IT'S ALSO A YOU KNOW IT'S BASED
APPROACH- TO CARE. CAPS SOME
THAT YOU'RE ASKING HERE IN THIS
PROPOSAL PERHAPS- BEING
INCORPORATED ARE INTO- WORK
WITH THE- THIS OFFICE SAYS THAT
AS A WAY TO HELP- CONVENE
PEOPLE TO TRY STEPS THE
STANDARDS ACROSS PAYERS. WITHIN
THE TO BEST AND AFFORDABILITY
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THERE'S- THIS THIS TASK FORCE
COULD HAVE A LOT OF- BENEFIT
ACROSS TO PROGRAMS-
PARTICULARLY THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
POSSIBLY CAL AIMED. I THINK
EIGHT WAY TO TAKE THE FIRST
STEP INTO THAT I THINK-
CERTAINLY IT'S A VERY BIG
PROJECT THAT THE STATE- IS
PROPOSING AN AND ONE THAT WE
SUPPORT CERTAINLY IN
CONTROLLING COST AND BELIEVE
THIS IS A SMALL STEP THAT CAN
HELP GET THEIR- IN FRESNO. SIDE
WE HAD MORE THAN TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES IMPROVE SIGNIFICANTLY
AND SO I'VE I THINK AS WE CAN
FILL THE EVIDENCE FOR THAT.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BEEN TO
DO ADDRESSING COSTS OKAY. SHEET
THAT I KNOW THAT- WAY BACK WHEN
I WAS- ASSEMBLY HEALTH CARE AND
I WAS BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE- WE
ACTUALLY HAD A HEARING AROUND-
PATIENT CENTERED MEDICAL HOME
AND THE BAD BETTER MAGIC
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. I NOTED
THAT WE PRESENTED A REPORT THAT
HAD SEVERAL PAGES OF PILOTS
EACH FILE FILE CARD THE ONLY
TWO LINES OF PRIDE LIKE. THE
THIRTY SOME LET'S SHOULD. YEAH
BURKE LOWER COST SO FOR THE
MIKE WAS WHY ARE TAKE TAKING
THESE SCALE WHY IT'S EVERY A
PILOT WITH DOING AFTER PILOTS A
PILOT THAT ALL SHOWS THE SAME
THING WE'RE GETTING REALLY GOOD
RESULTS YET IT DOESN'T GO TO
HELP PEOPLE TAKING IT SCALE.
FUNNY IT SCALES SO WE THINK
ABOUT CAN WE ACCOMPLISH THAT IF
YOU HAVE A CONVERSATION STILL
SHE STILL HERE THEY OP
AFFORDABILITY AT DIFFERENT
CLUBS BUT IT SET AT THAT VALUE
BASED PURCHASING WHICH THEIR
PER IS A IS A IS A IS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT- I MEAN I
THINK THE- WE DO. YEAH TO A-
TWO. THERE WERE NOT FILING A
TRY BUT ALSO BE ISSUE RECORD I
MEAN THINK THAT'S OF AT LEAST
AS HEARD OFFICE OF FOR LIKE
THIS IS LIKE HOW DO WE EVERY
TOGETHER TO THINK OF HOW WE NOW
HE SETS ARE BUT AND THE COST
CURVE. PEOPLE ARE YOU WILL HAVE
TO TELL BUT LIKE WHAT IS WE CAN
TRY TO DO PROVIDE TO DO THAT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN YOU CAN HAVE
SOME KIND OF A YEAH WE CAN
LEAVE THAT MAKE THIS SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENED AND YEAH OUR
HOPE IS THAT BY INCLUDE THE
STATE ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN ONE
WORKING GROUP YOU CAN REALY
BUILD THE TRUST AND MOVE TOWARD
SKATE INSTEAD OF JUST. ONE IN
OTHER OTHER PEOPLE IN THE IN IT
PATIENT SELF WE CAN FIGURE OUT
HOW THIS IS SO WE CAN MAKE THIS
PART OF AN INTEGRATED INTO A-
INTO- INTO SOME OF THE OTHER
ACT. I'M GOING OUT PRIORITIES
OF THE GOVERNOR CELL. RIGHT
OKAY MY EXTRA MUCH THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. OKAY NEXT UP WAS.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPICES
SITUATION- REQUESTS FOR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH ACCESS
NETWORK OKAY AND- SEE SOME OF
THE REGULATORY WELCOME. WE ARE
HONORED BY YOUR PRESENCE I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST APOLOGIZE
FOR MY DRESS TODAY I'M ON MY
WAY OUT. SO LITTLE CASUAL THAT
SOME WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'LL
GET TO THAT HERE I KNOW. A GOOD
MORNING SENATOR PAN AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY WITH MERA MORTON
FROM THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL SO
AS- TO PRESENT AN IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
MIDDLE CARE. ALL TO BRING IN
OUR DATA SHE CAN ARE YOU JUST
WANT TO EAT I JUST CAN WE
INTRODUCE EVERYONE IS TO GET
YOU. AND HE'S- HERE MORTON THAT.
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE CAL
TALK. TO SEIZE OKAY FOR THE
RECORD OKAY THANK YOU SORRY TO
INTERRUPT THAT'S FINE. GIVEN
THE CALIFORNIA IS SUFFERING
FROM A SEVERE LACK OF ACCESS TO
SPECIALIZED MENTAL HEALTH%
PROFESSIONAL. ESPECIALLY CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRIST.
CAN TAKE. THE TEACHER COOLEY
USING TELEHEALTH AND TELL
CONSULTS TO ADDRESS THE UNMET
NEEDS ARE UNMET NEED FOR
PEDIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
QUEST FOR A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION OVER
FIVE YEARS TO INSTITUTE A
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER NETWORK. OTHER STATES
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED
PROGRAMS USING THIS HUB AND
SPOKE MODEL. I COULD GO FURTHER
IN DETAIL BUT I KNOW YOU HAVE A
FULL AGENDA AND I APPRECIATE
YOU GIVING ME THE TIME TO
PRESENT TODAY I'M I WILL NOT
AND IT TO ME. AND I TO THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SEE. WHICH I.
IN HANDS. YES MEMBER. YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
DON'T MYSELF SO YOU KNOW THE
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
THE WHOLE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
BUT ESPECIALLY THE CHILDREN'S
BUT ALL SYSTEM AND IT REALLY
ISN'T NEEDED MEN UNDER. OFTEN
UNDER WHEN STATES IN. I WILL
HELP IMPROVE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- AND BETTER
ENFORCEMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
PARITY FOR COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS AND ALSO A HOST OF
WORKFORCE PROPOSALS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS. ARE PROPOSAL
SIX. AND THE GAP WHICH- THE-
YOU KNOW THE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
UNDERSTOOD IN TRAINING AT. HER
WORK FOR TO CHILDREN HOW NEEDS
WHEN THEY FIRST ENTER IN
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND HOLD THE
KIDS WHO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH SEC
ADDRESSED IN THE PRIMARY. AND
ARE YOU DO THIS YOU. IMAGINE
MANY OTHER STATES AS THE PATH
THAT WE ARE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY MENTIONED- BY
ESTABLISHING A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM TO ESTABLISH UP
TO TEN OF ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE
FOR ASIAN THEY WOULD. TAKE THE
BODY FOR ALL OF THE PROVIDE
CHILDREN UNLESS. AN TO PROVIDE
TELEPHONE SOLD TRAINING TEN
EWING EDUCATION- PROJECT ECHO
STYLE WEBINARS TO REALLY HELP
THEM BECOME FLUENT IN WHAT ARE
THE PROBLEMS THAT CHILDREN FACE
SOME MENTAL HEALTH EMERGENT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. AND THEN
WHEN THE THIRTY WHEN A CHILD
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE ACT TO A
SPECIALTY METAL. ANGELA CAN
ACTUALLY PROVIDE SERVICES USE
WELCOME SO ANSWERING BUT YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. I
THANK YOU INCOME MILLION.
FINANCE RIGHT WHAT YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I DID
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND EIGHT SO
WHEN I WAS TRAINING I WAS
FAMILIAR WITH THE MODEL WHERE
THEY DID- PROVIDE ESSENTIALLY
PUT DOES. TELL A MENTAL HEALTH
THE- ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS SO IF YOU AS A TEACHER
XIN YOU'RE SEEING A PATIENT TO
A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE AND SURE
WHAT TO DO WE COULD ACTUALLY.
MEET LEE CONTACT THE- THE CHILD
PSYCHIATRISTS AND THAT THEY
WOULD FOR APPS THE INITIAL
INTERVENTION AND- THE NATION'S
THIRD I NEED YOUR NOT BE SENT
FOLLOW AT CENTER. THE THAT SIR
KIND OF WHAT YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT YEAH THAT THE BASIC MODEL
IT BUT DOING A STATE Y. AND
MAKING IT MORE UNITS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND THE OTHER. IS UP.
THIS BECAUSE YOU'RE ASKING FOR
GRANT FOR YEARS HOW WOULD THIS
PROGRAM INTO WITH A MAY HEALTH
SYSTEM SO YOU KNOW HALF OF ALL
CHILDREN MEDI CAL. THIS CAN
WITH A HEALTH NET NETWORK ARE
ARE ARE MEDI CAL PROGRAM AND
THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE THE
VARIOUS MHSAA PROGRAMS
DIFFERENT COUNTIES HAVE SO-
SOME PEOPLE SAY WELL LOOK YOU
KNOW WE'VE IN ITS DAY MONEY UP
THERE WE HAVE. HAVE MEDI CAL
AND SHE BE ABLE. IN CENTER AND
SHE DATE PAYING FOR THIS WHY
ARE WE GIVING MY SEPARATE FROM
AND SO HOW HOW HOW THESE HOW
HOW THIS PROGRAM INTERFACE.
WITH THE THAT ACTUALLY REALLY
GOOD COMPLEMENT PLEASE SYSTEM
AND MEAN BASICALLY RIGHT NOW
YOU HAVE. YOU KNOW MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND COUNTY WHO ARE HOPING
THAT PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS ARE
SCREENING CHILDREN AS THEY
SHOULD BE AND PROVIDING BASIC.
EARLY INTERVENTIONS AND THEN IF
THEY PREFERRED INTO THE
SPECIALLY MENTAL SYSTEMS AND
HELP MANAGE CARE PLAN IF IT'S A
KID. FOR COVERAGE OF THE WAR
EVEN IN A MEDICAL ME. COURTNEY
CARE BUT MINISTER I PRIVATE
PSYCHIATRIST OR WHETHER IT'S BY
CAN PROVIDER SO THAT SYSTEM ALL
REMAINS IN PLACE WITH THIS IS A-
GETTING RAINING. AND RESOURCE
TO THE PRIME. THERE BEFORE
INTEREST. THE ROBOT AND THAT
FEWER KIDS ARE BEING IN A PROBE
REFER OUT WHO REALLY CLICK BE
MANAGE IN A PRIME CARE SO AND
THEN POTENTIALLY ALSO HELPING
TO CONNECT THE KID TO THAT
SYSTEM SO THE PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER AND HAVE TO USE A
VALUABLE TIME MAKE THAT
CONNECTION FOR THE CHILD SO
IT'S TAKING SOME OF THE
WORKLOAD OFF OF THAT THAT
THEY'RE ALSO FIGHTING AND- TO
BE ABLE TO. THANKS PEOPLE OR
THAT- SO WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT ANY AGE SO YOU HAVE THIS AS
A SEPARATE GRANT PROPOSALS TO
THINK ABOUT IS THERE A WAY WE
CAN LEVERAGE OUR EXISTING
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS THAT. THE
MAN. THAT AND SO NOW IT SO YOU
SAID NO WE'RE NOT TOUCHING THAT
BUT WE'RE BUILDING A SYSTEM ON
TOP OF THAT GREAT AND SO THE
QUESTION IS THAT- BILL WHAT WE
WILL MORE FRAGMENTATION- AND-
SO WE- THINK ABOUT HOW HOW THIS
INTERFACES AND THEN ALSO. THE
OF YOUR FOR YEAR WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THE END OF THE FIVE YEARS
RIGHT SO WE SHOULD BE STARTING
TO THINK ABOUT IT YOU KNOW IT
AS A SUSTAINABLE PLANTER IT'S
LIKE HOW DOES THIS EVENTUALLY
THEN GET. FULL ARE INTEGRATED
TWO WAY WE- OR SO GET THE
FEDERAL MATCHING TYPES OF
THINGS TO. THE MENTAL HEALTH IN
PROVIDING THIS SERVICE ONGOING
BASIS RIGHT WHAT A COUPLE
DIFFERENT POINTS COUPLE
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS THERE SO
FIRST I WOULD SAY WE'RE NOT
CLOSED OFF TO I THINK THAT
THERE MAY BE A PATCHWORK OF
FUNDING THE COULD BE PULLED
TOGETHER TO FUND AS WE DID
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE WE IS
ALREADY CONVERSATION GOING ON
AROUND THE HELL AND MAKE SHOULD
BE DISCOUNT. ARE THE- WE HAVE
JACKSON. WE DID BURKE COUNTY
MAY BE OCT TO A PRO AND HAVE
FIFTH EIGHT DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
THIS LIKE THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WANT HAVING HAPPENED
SO CREATING A STATEWIDE ON THIS
IS CALIFORNIA WE- WELL THE
LOCAL CONTROL RIGHT. OKAY
SOMETIMES WE WANT A LITTLE
LITTLE BIT OF GUIDANCE SO
PUTTING UNDER THE OFFICE OF AND
THE AGENCY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ALL OF THEM TO KIND OF
STANDARDIZED CREATE ONE
WEBSITE. IS TO THE UPS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER GUIDANCE
WHEN THE PRIMARY KERR WRITERS
IS UNIFORM RATHER THAN HAVING
IT HAPPEN FIFTY EIGHT WAY AND
WE FUND THAT. WE CAN OFTEN
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T TO PULL FROM
PEOPLE WHO WE THINK ALREADY
HAVE SCARCE RESOURCES BUT
OBVIOUSLY I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF WAYS TO PULL THE FUNDING
TOGETHER. THE REASON WE
PROPOSED YEARS IS TO GIVE THE-
ON. FOR STATUS. I AM SO TRUST.
OF PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS AND
GET THEM INTO THE PROGRAM THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT AND
THEY DON'T. JUST BECAUSE YOU
OFFER THEM A LINE OR YOU OFFER
THEM A PROJECT ECHO.
OPPORTUNITY AND SO. MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S TIME FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN WE ALSO KNOW UTILIZATION
IS HIGHER IN THE BEGINNING. THE
CALL A LOT I FOR. THE PROGRAM
AND AS THEIR KNOWLEDGE. THE
LAST. MAN THE CARD WILL GO. AND
I THINK OUR STATE HAVE A WAYS
SUSTAIN THE ON CON AND SO WE
HAVE A FOR THAT WOULD BE HAPPY
TO DISCUSS WITH YOU BUT IT
SHOULD BE LESS EXPENSIVE AFTER
THOSE FIRST FIVE YEARS. ALRIGHT
WELL THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU OKAY
TWENTY. ALL RIGHT- THEN WE HAVE
A PEDIATRIC TRAUMA FOR MEDICAL
HOME MODEL PILOT FROM LOMA
LINDA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
WELCOME SEE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD. FIRST. THANK YOU ASIDE
SHORT REPRESENTING LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY HEALTH ISSUE TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR A REALLY
GREAT CONVERSATION ABOUT OUR
PROPOSAL AND LOTS OF OTHER
THINGS- AND TO INTRODUCE A
DOCTOR IN YOUNGER CHILD ABUSE
PEDIATRIC AND FROM LEVEL CITY.
GOOD MORNING ALL. THIS FREE FOR
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ANY YOUNG
I'VE BEEN A CHILD ABUSE
PHYSICIAN AT LOCAL IN THE
UNIVERSITY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS. AND
I'VE TREATED MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND VICTIMS OF CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT IN THAT TIME. I'M
HERE TO PROPOSE A PILOT PROGRAM
TO FROM INFORMED MEDICAL HOME
MODEL FOR ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
CHILDREN IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
THIS PROPOSAL COMES GREAT PART
DUE TO MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
IN THE FIELD. NOT LONG AGO I
WAS CALLED TO THE BEDSIDE OF A
CRITICALLY INJURED CHILD THE
INFANT HAD NUMEROUS UNEXPLAINED
TRAUMATIC INJURIES THAT WERE
SUSPICIOUS FOR CHILD ABUSE. I
MET WITH THE FATHER TO TAKE
HISTORY I USUALLY DO DURING THE
HISTORY TAKING ALL TALKING
ABOUT HIS BABY INJURY IS BABIES
ENTRIES FATHER ENDED UP TELLING
ME THAT AS A CHILD HIMSELF. HAD
BEEN IN MORE FOSTER HOMES AND
HE MEMBER HE SAID TO BE IN
FOSTER CARE. AND THROUGHOUT
HELD THAT HE SAW. AND
CONSISTENTLY. AND HAD MANY- ON
MATT MATT NEEDS TWENTY TERMS.
THIRTY BEING AND STRUCK. SYSTEM
BECAME HOMELESS AND BECAME A
FATHER. WHEN I SIT. THERE WAS
VERY FOR. ABOUT I'M TO. VENTURE
ON ME ABOUT THAT BROKEN STANCES
THAT IN THE- AND THE FIRST
PLACE. MOMENT THAT REALLY
CHANGED MY LIFE MY CAREER HE-
CARS. AND FOR USE AND THAT'S
WHEN I RE. HIM HE WAS FAMILIAR
I WAS THE PHYSICIAN WHO HAD
MADE THE DIAGNOSIS OF ABUSE
WHEN HE WAS YOUNG. AND DESPITE
TAKING EVERY ACTION THAT I KNEW
TO HELP THEM TO BREAK THE
CYCLES OF ABUSE. I WAS NO NOW
THERE TO WATCH AS HE WAS
ARRESTED FOR FATAL INJURIES TO
HIS CHILD. THE STORY ABOUT ANY
TROUBLE OR RARE CHILD THIS IS A
PERVASIVE PREVALENT DISEASE
PROCESS. THAT IS AFFECTING OUR
CHILDREN. I'VE BEEN WORKING IN
THE TRENCHES FOR QUITE SOME
TIME WITH A VERY LARGE
POPULATION. CHILDREN IN THE
INLAND. WHO HAVE THE HIGHEST OF
A SCORES. DO AGREE THAT ACES
ARE. THE GREATEST UNADDRESSED
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT THERE'S
FACING OUR NATION TODAY AND I'M
THANKFUL THAT LEADERS OF THE
STATE NOW HAVE PHYSICIANS
TALKING ABOUT ACES MORE THAN
THEY HAVE IN THE PAST. AND
LEARNING HOW TO ACT FOR CALL
TENS NOT HISTORIC BEEN TAUGHT
THIS TRAINING. SYSTEMS IN PLACE
NOW OR NOT ENOUGH THEY DO NOT A
SUPPORT SUPPORT THE TIME AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING THAT'S
REQUIRED TO DELIVER TRAUMA
INFORMED MEDICAL CARE. OR
TREATMENT TEAMS NEEDED THE
VICTIM SPECIAL IS ALDERMAN
INTEREST THE WHOLE THIRTY MIN
LEE. MEDICAL CARE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM STILL WORK IN SILOS.
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO WE
PARTNERED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CHILD WELFARE FOR BY. HELP
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH BARBIE
HEALTH TO CREATE AN ADVOCACY
CENTER FOR CHILD ABUSE VICTIMS
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY THE
LARGEST GEOGRAPHIC COUNTY IN
THE NATION THIS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TREATMENT TEAM
PROVIDES COORDINATED FRIENDS OF
MEDICAL CARE FORENSIC
INTERVIEWINGA MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES HOWEVER THIS IS SHORT
TERM IS ONLY AVAILABLE TO CASES
WERE AN INVESTIGATIVE AGENCY.
BILL ON THE SUCCESS OF THE
CENTER AND ARE COUNTY BY COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS WE'RE PROPOSING AN
EXPANDED PROGRAM THAT WILL
PROVIDE RESILIENCY INFORMED
ONGOING MEDICAL CARE TARGETING
SECOND LARGEST POPULATION OF
FOSTER YOUTH AND STATE THE
CLERK GAUGE CARE GIVERS AND
PROVIDE HOLISTIC CARE
CONSISTING OF COLIN MENTAL
HEALTH DEVELOPMENTS READINESS
SCHOLARSHIPS- COULD TAKE THE
STORY AND DO ARE AND THAT'S
REALLY. TO BE. THANK YOU YOU
MAY VERY MUCH A MILLION. IN
MINISTER RIGHT THEY WILL
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENT OF THE
THAT WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
STATE FUNDS HOW WHAT'S THE
SCOPE OF THIS PROGRAM MEANS.
THAT'S WHY I RATED THIS IS FOR
THE INLAND EMPIRE YEAH YEAH
SORRY OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S A
HELPFUL NOW OKAY. ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION APPRECIATE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK THANK YOU
THAT SAID I KNOW IT'S A HOW.
CAN BE CALLED AREA TO PRACTICE
AND WE NEED TO LIKE IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- SO WE'LL
WE'RE GONNA TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS I REALIZE THAT THERE
ARE FIVE VERY DIFFERENT ISSUES-
AND ASK PEOPLE TO TRY TO KEEP
THEIR COMMENTS TO WITHIN ONE
MINUTE IF YOU'RE TRYING TO COME
FROM. ONCE YOU FEEL WILL ACT
FOR A LOT OF THE. THAT'S IT.
YOU SEE I JUST THEM IN YOUR-
SIGN UP CUT YOU OFF. AND IF YOU
MAY OVER. SOUTH OKAY SO I KNOW
WE HAVE FIVE DIFFERENT THINGS.
ONE SIXTY THREE DIFFERENT THING
SO WITH THE- A NEW. DURING THE
DAY. AND ME WHAT YOU THINK
THANK YOU WELCOME. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
I'M ITEM NUMBER THREE. SEE
MAYES PORTS GOVERNOR PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH THE CENTER FOR
DATA IN. NATION BUT WITH THE
CABBIE OUT. YOU MAY RECENTLY
RELEASED THEIR FIVE. FOR IN OUR-
BUT WE BELIEVE THE STATE IN
THIS NEW CENTER ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO FILL IN THE GAPS
AND STRENGTHEN THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE MANY OF THE FEDERAL
STILL LEAVE IT UP STATES TO
IMPLEMENT MOST OF THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE ONLY SPECIFIC
TO SEE REALLY. ARE A PAIR WILL
BE PUBLIC COMMITTEE WITH MORE
SPIN BUT GESTIONES ONCE WE
DIGEST THE HUNDREDS OF PAGES IN
THE NEW FEDERAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS VINYL
COMING HERE BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA WE ARE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY.
HELLO UNIONS ARE STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP WITH A HIGH. OF HEALTH
CARE WOULD CONTINUE TO OUTPACE
WAGE GROWTH INFLATION. PEOPLE
ARE GOING CARE OR- DEEPER INTO
AT SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
KEEP UP THIS PROPOSAL THIS WILL
TAKE THE- ALL. AND THE DEAL
WITH ISSUES LIKE ALL HEALTH
SECTORS WE ARE PLEASED THAT THE
PROPOSED OFFICES SPECIFICALLY
TASKED WITH TRACKING
AFFORDABILITY BUT ALSO THAT
BILLY IS DEFINED AS PREMIUMS
AND COST SHARING INCLUDING
COPAYS AND DEDUCTIBLES WE
SUPPORT MUCH OF WHAT'S IN THE
TRAILER BILL THAT WAS RELEASED
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND LOOK FOR
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE MINUTE ON. ISSUE NUMBER. WE
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT THE
PROPOSED ON THE DATA ONE- THE
CENTER FOR DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION. LIKE DOCTOR PAN WE
DO BELIEVE AND THAT THE STRONG
VALUE OF DATA WE DO NOT THINK
THAT THE OFFICE OF PATIENTS.
KßT REPORT. THAT IT SHOULD BE
A LITTLE DATED WE DO WANT TO
SURE THEY WERE ABLE TO GET THE
INFO. WE NEED TO HELP HEALTH
CARE OURS. HELP TAX. CLOSE BY.
BEING INTO TO MINING A- FOR
THOSE REASONS WE REALLY DO WANT
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND HOPE WE ARE CONSULTED AS
PART OF THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME I
GET AFTERNOON OR IS IT STILL
MOURNING IT IT'S ALMOST
AFTERNOON GET ALL THIS AND
MORE. THE OR ON BEHALF OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION AND WE'RE EXCITED TO.
THROW CONVERSATION ABOUT ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THIS IS ABOUT THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD FROM OUR MEMBERS I KNOW.
WE HEAR IT EVERY DAY THE PORTS
OF ENTRY TING. HEALTH CHECK.
IT'S IMPORTANT IN OUR
CONVERSATION. FOR THE BILL THE
AT LARGE THE WORK SITE. BROKE
MR ABOUT IT. DARK BUT THINGS
LIKE TO. YOUR CHEN MENTION ALL
IN APPROACH THAT IS A FULL COME
THAT'S A WE HOPE THAT THAT THE
CHIEF DONE REAL TARGET SETTING
ENFORCEMENT IS KEY RIGHT DOCTOR
BENEFIT FORSMAN DOESN'T HAPPEN
YOU'RE NOT GONNA CURVE THE BAD
BEHAVIOR THAT WE SEE WE ALL
MAKE SURE ANY GOES BACK TO
CONSUMERS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
FILLING THE BURDEN OF HEALTH
CARE COSTS. AND MADE IT TO
FIGURING THAT OUT MYSTERY AND-
THE ONE OF. LABOR PROTECTIONS.
SERVICE EMPLOYEES THAT WORKERS
STATE DEPARTMENT DESERVED TO
RUN THIS OFFICE AND WE DO A
GOOD JOB AND HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT PRACTICE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS. LAST AND FINAL THING
THAT I MENTION IS. TO SEE A
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION IS THE- FOR THE
POINTS THAT YOU MADE BEEN
DOCTOR PANDA. SURE THAT THERE
GAMING. THEM SURE WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THE- SAID.
WE HAVE. FOR THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS. THE INFORMATION WE'VE
SEEN. GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SO FAR.
OF THAT WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IN
THERE. THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TIP MEMBERS ENTER
KEEPER WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA- WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH ITEM NUMBER TWO
AS WELL AS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
NUMBER TWO JUST LIKE THE AND
DOCTOR IN OTHER NEWS
MINISTRATION ON- ON THE WORK
AROUND ADVERSE CHILDHOOD- INTO
THAT WE AS A COME WATCH THIS
PERNICIOUS I WOULD LOOK FOR TO
OPERATING. COMMITTEE IS TAKE A
TO OFFICE TO AFFECT PROPOSED
WITHIN THE GREAT I. ON EITHER%
NUMBER FOUR I I'LL SUBMIT THE
COMMENT TO IN RIGHT AS WELL TO
THE TO THE COMMITTEE BUT WE-
ARE HEARTENED BY THE EFFORT BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALLY TAKE ON
HEALTH CARE COST WE'VE HEARD.
FROM DOCTOR CHAN AND OTHERS-
THE REASONS TO DO SO ARE
PROFOUNDLY OBVIOUS- WE ARE
ERODING WAGE GROWTH. AND WE
ARE- EXACERBATING THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN THE
STATE BY NOT TAKING ON HEALTH
CARE HAD ARE THIS PROPOSAL DOES
THAT. I WORK TO WORK DO YOU AND
THE NEWS MINISTRATION TO WORK
OUT SOME FINAL SALES HI BUT WE
THINK THIS IS A AND A
PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT STEP AT
THE RIGHT. TIME TO HANDLE YOUR
CALL. YOU TIP ON THE- GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND HE CHURCH. JEFF
WE ARE TO HERE. I TO AND- I'M A
ITEM NUMBER TWO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT WE APPLAUD EFFORT TO
STRENGTHEN AND THE ONE OF CAL
FAMILIES SCREEN CHILDREN FOR
EARLY EXPOSURE TO EASE HIS
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS IDENTIFIED
WHO ARE AT RISK- ON THE OFFICE
OF HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY WE
ARE PART OF THE CONCEPT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING DISPATCHER
WITH ALL ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. COULD I. PLAY WITH
WEST. ALREADY REGARDING ISSUE
ONE OF IN REGARDS TO THE CENTER
FOR DATA INSIGHT WE DO SUPPORT
CENTRALIZED DATA AS ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS OF THE ENABLING
LANGUAGE FOR THE OFFICE OF
PATIENT ADVOCATES WE WOULD WANT
TO CONTINUE TO SEE THAT DATA
COLLECTED BY WEATHER THAT HE-
WITH THIS- OR SOMEONE ELSE
THAT. IS IMPORTANT AND SO WITH
WANT TO SEE IF I CAN FIND ISSUE
FOR RELATED TO THE OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY WE SUPPORT TO
HONOR AND CAN AWESOME THE BILL
EIGHTY REMAINS TO BE A BIG
ISSUE FOR OUR- WHERE'S AS WELL.
AS NO THAT RIGHT HEALTHCARE
COSTS. WORKER WAGES
PARTICULARLY IMPACTING LOW
INCOME WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME. A GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR BAND MEMBERS ATTEMPT
COMMITTEE A JET HAMPTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS I HEAR TO ADD TO
THIS WELCOME ITEMS OR- JUST TO
SHOW THE COVER HEALTH PLANS
ARE. A SUPPORTER OF THE
CONCEPTS TO ADD TO INCREASE
ACCESSIBILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS- WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS CONTINUING TO
PRIORITIZE AFFORDABILITY WE ARE
STILL REVIEWING THE TRAILING
TROUBLING WHICH CURRENT. WE DO
LOOK FOR TO BE A PART OF THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. WELCOME
THE CHAIR OF ASKING ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS HERE SUPPORT
OF THE CONCEPT OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY THE
GOVERNOR'S LANGUAGE AND THEN
POTENTIALLY LEGISLATING
LEGISLATING WHICH TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT AS YOU HEARD EARLIER
IN OUR PROPOSAL DAY REGARDING
CONSENT TO CALL HOME LEAVE THE
FAMILY AFTER IS AS THE CARE
PROVIDER CAN BE THE THREE AND
FOR THE CARE FOR THE- BUS STOP.
IN FOR ONE OR STAFF DECISION
BETWEEN FOOD RENT TREATMENT SO
FOR HAT. BE WOULD LIKE TO BE.
THE CON. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU WELCOME. HELLO
MY NAME IS JOYCE GEORGE AND
NINE. S. CI YOU HEALTH CARE
JUSTICE LEADER COMMUNITY LEADER
AND I AM. A SUPPORT AND- THE
WATER LEVEL CALIFORNIA- AND. I
LIKED IT THE SUPPORT THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HE SAID WELCOME
HI MY NAME IS SERRA PEARSON I'M
A BARTENDER A CASH BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS ARE AND A VERY PROUD
MEMBER OF YOU LOOK PRETTY NINE
AND I SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WITH STRICT COST
TARGETS. THANK YOU WELCOME HI
MY NAME IS MAY WILL AND THAT
MADE THEM WORK AT THE HILTON
HOTEL IN SAN FRANCISCO- I MY
MEMBER OF THE LOCAL TO AND I
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT. SO
POOR THAT ME NIXON. SO A
PROPOSAL ABOUT THE- HEALTHCARE-
AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. WELCOME WITH THE
SEVEN OWN MY NAVY I'M AT THE
NSA WHAT YOU'RE FOR THE FED MY
HOTEL. IN SAN FRANCISCO I
BELONG TO LOCAL TOOL. YEAH I
FOR MISS TAYLOR. AVENUE SOUL
HAVE REPORTS OF. OKAY BASIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I AM BILL
MOST OF MY YOUR- I WILL GET
THAT HE THOUGHT THEY LOSE I'M
LOCAL TO AYE SUPPORT TOOL
MISTER NEWS HOLE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY MIGHT AS WELL
THAT'LL BE CHáVEZ A I WORK IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO HILLS DAHLE
FOR THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AGING
ARE RIGHT NOW I AM HERE
BECAUSE- WE WANT TO- FOOTBALL.
THE STATE NEWS SO PROPOSAL
BECAUSE WE NEED WITHIN THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US WE POSSIBLY
TOO MANY STRUGGLES TO LIKE THEM
FOR- FOR WE HAVE A MISTRIAL
O'CONNELL IN THAT IT NOT USED
TO. SEE WHAT'S RAINY USED CAR.
IS WORKING WITH. IS BETTING FOR
A BI WE ON WE HAVE TO DO THE
BECAUSE YOU BETTY FOR OUR IT'S
WHEN WE HAVE A PERSON WITH A
PROFIT IN YOUR LAW AND THEY
NEED THEY NEED SOMEBODY STOP
THIS COMPANY BECAUSE THEY MAY
WE OPT TO BE BIG DIRTY AND THEN
A COUPLE AND THEN WE DID IT
MONEY COMING FOR UP FOR POCKET
BUT NOT BIG LEGAL TOOL. IS
EIGHT WHICH- IS. THE MONIES OR
BY WE NEED MONEY FOR OUR TO.
FOUR FIVE ME. AND THEY IS STOP
SOME TO. FOR THE BY THE
COMPANIES MAKE YOU MONEY PAYING
YEAH. I WE HAVE TO MOVE FROM
THE CITY WE GO WE CAN OPERATE.
A NOT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO BUY. ABA RENTS AND
THEY WE STILL GOT MORE. USEFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK ALL RIGHT WE. THE WHITE
HOUSE. WELCOME ONE OF HIS
ROBBER FAT ACTUALLY SORRY THE
RULES THE RULES HERE DO NOT DO
ANY AUDIBLE BUT YOU CAN DO THIS
YOU LIKE THAT WAVING HANDS ALL
RIGHT THERE WE GO ALL RIGHT
SOUNDS GOOD WELCOME. WELCOME IS
MORE OF A FLAT I MAY A MEMBER
OF UNITE HERE LOCAL FORTY NINE
WE HAVE FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS
ACROSS THE REGION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO- WERE THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY. OR IN
SUPPORT OF THE ALL OF HER FOR.
THANK YOU SIR. WHAT GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT ANY OF OUR DEBT
UNDER VALLEY FOR FIVE YEARS A
UNITE HERE- LOCAL FORTY NINE-
IN SUPPORT OF DOG GOVERNOR'S
ALMA THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME HELLO
MY NAME IS MARIA VASQUEZ I WORK
I GREATER SARCOSINE NOW I'M
ALSO WITH LOOK OR FORTY NINE
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE. THANK
YOU WELCOME HELLO MY NAME'S
MERRY WITH UNITE HERE LOCAL
FORTY NINE- WHIRL SO HERE TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
THANK YOU WELCOME- MY NAME IS
STRUCK SENATE THE BILL WOULD
DENY HERE LOCAL FORTY NINE I'VE
BEEN A MEMBER FOR TEN YEARS
NUMBER HERE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR IS KERR OF REALITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
HELLO I'M RHONDA VILNA WAIVER
OUR RETIRED SEIU MEMBER WORK
FOR THE PRIME CONSUMER AFFAIRS
NOW I'M A- RETIRED VOLUNTEER
FOR WORKING YOU H. W. I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THE FOR THE LADY
COUNT ABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
ACT. DUE TO MANY FACTORS I
THINK IT WAS A BIG STORY. I
BECAME HOMELESS AND THANK GOD
FOR STEINBERG AND- SMU IN KEVIN
MCCARTY I AM NOW HOUSED IN A
BEAUTIFUL ONE BEDROOM SENIOR
CITIZEN PAID. EIGHT I WAS MOVED
OUT FROM MIDTOWN HERE SQUEEZED
OUT BECAUSE MY- KIDS DON'T GET.
RICH AND NOT OR I CALLED QUOTE
MODERATE. I'M GOOD SQUISHED. SO
THEY CAME TO MY HELP AND I AM
NOW BLESSED TO HAVE A LITTLE
PART MEANT BUT- DUE TO I AM
CHRONICALLY ILL EXISTING.
CONDITION EIGHT COPAYS AS
ADVANTAGE CARE BECAUSE AGAIN I
DON'T MEET THE- QUOTE PORK
STATUS NOT RICH STATUS SO I GET
SQUEEZED OUT OF EVERYTHING AND
NOW I ACTUALLY HAD TO PICK
HEALTHCARE OR WHOLE HOUSING AND
THAT'S WHEN. MY TO A STEINBERG
ANISTON. KEVIN MCCARTY TO
ASSIST ME IN THIS AND THE SAD
JOURNEY I'VE BEEN THROUGH AND I
SUPPORTED PLEASE CAUSE BABY
BOOMERS ARE GONNA NEED JOHN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WELCOME
HELLO MY NAME IS SHARON BROOKS
BOYD RETIRED AND- A AND HOME
SUPPORT SERVICE WORKER AND S.
CI YOU YOU H. W. HEALTH COULD
JUST MEMBER AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE- GOVERNOR ON.
PORTABILITY OFFICE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. WELCOME MESSAGE
MEMBERS THEIR FLOCKS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WE'VE WORKED ON THE ISSUE
OF HEALTH CARE COST CONTAINMENT
AFFORDABILITY FOR MANY. YEARS
AT ALL WE- APPROACH OF WHAT MY
BOSS IS NIBBLING AROUND THE
EDGES TAKING ON PART VERY. I AM
AND- THAT THE GOVERNOR IS AN
OFFICE THAT TACKLES THE WHOLE
INDUSTRY- AND LOOKS AT GETTING
AFFORDABILITY AND MONEY BACK TO
CONSUMERS AND PUT BACK IN
WORKERS POCKETS SO WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT WE DO WANT
TO FLAG THE ISSUE WITH THAT
DATE IS PAUL HAVE A- OFFICE
HAVE ACCESS TO DATE. ALSO THAT
PUBLIC I CAN MAKE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE ABLE TO USE THIS DATA AND
HAVE REAL- ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE OFFICE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE WITH THE
SENATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SET. THANK YOU WELCOME. YOUR
CHAIR MAP BROUGHT HERE FOR THE
TEAMSTERS YOU HEAR MACHINISTS
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION AND-
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS THE
CALIFORNIA UTILITY WORKERS
UNION AMERICA I WOULD JUST TO
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH- MY
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE FROM
UNITE HERE- YOU SEE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY IS A HUGE. FOR
MEDI THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO MY NAME'S TIM
DURAN I'M A BARTENDER AT
THUNDER VALLEY CASINO RESORT
I'VE BEEN THERE FIFTEEN YEARS
VERY PROUD OF MY UNION AND
LOCAL FORTY NINE. AND I'M NOT
OBVIOUSLY HERE TO SUPPORT BY
NUMBER FOUR WE NEED TO KEEP AND
PUT AND CHECK THOSE HEALTH
CARE. PROVIDERS SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELCOME I THINK IT'S
GOOD AFTERNOON NOW KATHERINE'S
GOT WITH CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE FOR THE BILL IN THE
EFFORTS MADE BY. BOTH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE-
TO ADDRESS AND SET A BENCHMARK-
I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS FOR
US AS WE WORK THROUGH THIS IS
YOU KNOW BLANK PAGES FRESH BUT-
THINGS AS WE ARE. PART OF THE-
PRO TO APPRECIATE HEARING THOSE.
I'M US. ALL THERE AND HE'S- AN
EQUAL. IN MEET NOT BENCH. I'M
TO SLOW WE WANT TO ENSURE THE
DATA IS RIGHT. WE AGREE THAT
THE DATA- HAS TO BE
APPROPRIATE- AND HAS TO BE.
AVAILABLE BECAUSE WE ARE
WORKING ON SOME OF THESE DATA
SETS HAS TO BE AVAILABLE SO
THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
BENCHMARK. AND HOLDER PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT BENCHMARK
THAT. TO REFLECTS WHAT REALLY
GOING ON WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
THAT WERE KIND OF. IN THIS
PROCESS OF COLLECTING DATA. I'M
IN THAT AS WE- APPROACH THE
BENCH MARKS. BENCHMARKS IN
MANAGING A PENALTY PORTION- AND
WE APPRECIATE THE PROGRESSIVE
PENALTY PORTION THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE RIGHT THINGS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT WE
NEED TO BE LOOKING OUT SO FOR
US. I'M AS WE ESTABLISH
BENCHMARKING HELP LEVEL TO WHAT
THE DATE IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL. ABOUT RELIEF TO THE
TIMELINE. THIS IS WHAT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
THE ADMINISTRATION AS WE GO
FORWARD FOR ALSO SUPPORT OF
SORRY THANK YOU WE'RE ALSO
SUPPORT OF THE CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH ACCESS NETWORK.
IN THE PEDIATRIC TRAUMA
INFORMED LOCAL HEALTH PILOT I
APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU. WELCOME
THANK YOU MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL SEASON ASSIST. WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY- C. H.
A- R. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE BUT NOT
WITHOUT CONCERNS. NOT ALL
HOSTAGE THERE EQUAL AND
TERTIARY HOSPITAL. PRINCIPLES
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS WE
TREAT A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF KIDS WITH HIGH ACUITY CASES
AND UNPREDICTABLE COSTS AND WE
DON'T WANT TO CREATE A SYSTEM.
THAT MOVES THOSE THOSE FENCE
ALL TO CERTAIN FACILITIES WHO
THEN CANNOT CONTAINER COSTS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE TYPES OF
PATIENTS WHOSE COSTS ARE
PREDICTABLE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T CREATE A SYSTEM
WHERE WE- CERTAINLY. DISK COST.
FROM X. BEING CARE SERVICE
CENTER HAVE GROWING NEEDS LIKE
BEHAVIOR HOW SO WE JUST WANNA
BE MINDFUL OF THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TIME. THANK
YOU. WELCOME NUMBER ONE I LOOK
BACK AND SAY THE FLANNEL FOR
THE LOCAL FEW HER LEFT A LITTLE
YOU FOR YOUR POINT ON THE LOWER
LOWER BUT A GOOD THING I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'RE NOT IF YOU HAVE
A LESS A LITTLE. ROUGH YES.
CLASSES WELCOME. HI MY NAME IS
NICOLE ONE I'M A MEMBER OF
LOCAL TO I'M LOOKING AT THE
HOTEL QUESTION SERVICES AS A
MRS CALL FOR TWO YEARS TODAY
I'M HERE I SUPPOSE TO KNOW
SINCE. PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELCOME HI MY NAME IS THE
YOLANDA AND I'M LOCAL TO MEMBER
ALL WAFFLE HUGHTON UNION SQUARE
A FULL FOUR YEAR AND I SUPPORT
MR NEWSOME PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS BILL FOR MOVIE
MY- NEED AND IF THE VEHICLE MAY
HELP THEM WE CERTAIN THE TO
PHOTO I SUPPORT NIELSEN THE
NIELSEN PROPOSAL. THE TOUGHEST
BOTTOM NEESON A MY PROPOSAL
BUFFALO I THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH BRING
HERE THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS A
YEAR IN OUR LOCAL TO. OKAY
GOURMET CAN YES I SUPPORT FOR
NEW XIN PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY PICKING ON
JUNE FROM TYLER AND I HAD I HAD
BEEN THE AND CALIFORNIA- FULL
FIFTEEN YES. I'M THE MEMBER OF
THE UNION LOCAL TOOL ICE THE I.
BUT I BUT PART OF MY UNIT I
SUPPORT THE- YEAH. NUISANCE
WILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WELCOME. HI MY NAME IS ON PER
SIDE I'M A MEMBER OF UNIT HERE
LOCAL FOR YOU KNOW FOR SEVEN
YEARS I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER FOR. ME WELCOME ON
ME NUMBER IS MILLION A BY THE
YEAH II S YOU'RE ONLY THE
LOCALS DISASSOCIATE LIMB FRESNO
YES BUT YEAH KEEP UP FOR YET
AND WILL THAT ANOTHER. BUT I
CAN THINK OF ONE OFF WE SEE IN
THAT. ACCESS TO SEE RELATED THE
ON THE POINT OF WHAT ASKED
ABOUT HOW THE CLASSICS. CLASSES
WELCOME. BUT THAT IS THE SENATE
HAVE. THE SITE MEMBER THAT I
WHOSE THE CI. THIS THE FOR NOT.
IS THE IRAQI A BOY AND A-
TOMORROW. APPROACH WITH THAT
THE OFFICE NOW MY FOR. SEE
BLOOD. BUT MUSCLE TO. BEEN
DESCENDS BUT A. CRISIS WELCOME
WHEN IS THAT THE NUMBER A
HAIRLIKE. EVEN UP. UP IN THE
LIST LOVE BETTER THAN. BRING UP
WITH A LIST OF ON OF IS ENOUGH.
BUT OUR LITTLE BIT LEVEL BUT I
CAN ALSO YOU THEY'RE LIKE
HONESTLY CAN A BY MOST OF
THOSE- IMPACT. BELOW THE LEVEL
OF THE LAST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT. FORGET THE BUS ON THE
PORTAL A STILL THE CASE.
METHODICAL ON THE WILL GET THE
LEVELS THE LOSSES GROUND
SERVICE HE ALREADY TO THE OWNER
AND THEY WILL BE A PART. MISS
WE ARE MORE CHOI LESS ALSO ALSO
SEE IN A COUPLE MINUTES OF YOU
SEEN A PART TIME BUT I CAN.
TELL YOU THAT BILLS. THAT THIS.
WELCOME TO START WITH ME I WE
THOUGHT A LETTER SO HE THEIR
LEADER THE DIGITAL CL ETHIOPIAN
THE WITH A LITTLE AT THE NEW A
PEOPLE OF THAT I THINK CRISIS
WELCOME BUT AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH MARTINEZ I AM A
LEADER OF THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF THE OFFICIAL. OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE. OF THANK
YOU WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME JIM GOMEZ FROM SACRAMENTO
AND FROM OKAY JUSTICE AND I
STRONG SUPPORTER NEWS ON THE-
HEALTH CARE FOR THE OFFICE
THANK YOU. WELCOME COMMON
SERVICE I'M A NUMBER IS
AVAILABLE LIMóN BANG ON IN A
FEW OF THE OAKLAND IS FOR THE
UP WE ON THE LAPTOP WITHOUT AND
ALONE BUT I. BUT AT THE NEW.
THE SCENERY IS ALEXIS WHO LED
BY THE LEVELS YOU NEED A LOT OF
CLASSES IN IT. THIS BASIS. GOD
BLESS WELCOME. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN ON TO SELL
MARANDA FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE JOBS AS A VOLUNTEER.
I AM IN SUPPORT AND WE ARE ALL
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS GINNY
RETIREE I AM MY HEALTHCARE
JUSTICE FROM IS SEE- YOU I AM
RETIRED FROM P. MY GARDEN IN
NURSING BUT THIRTY YEARS I AM
SUPPORTING. GOVERNOR NUISANCE
ALL THIS. HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY THANK YOU AND GOD
BLESS YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME
HELLO MY NAME IS NORMA
ARMSTRONG I'M A VOLUNTEER FOR
YOU AND HEALTH CARE ALSO
RETIRED SOCIAL WORKER. AM IN
SUPPORT OF GOVERNOR KEVIN AND
SOME OF THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS SEVEN I WAS AT THE- I
AM WITH THE HEALTH CARE JUST IS
ONE OF THE LEADER I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS ME DIRECTLY
AND NOT EMOTIONALLY PHYSICALLY
BUT FINANCIALLY TO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION- I'M
SPEAKING TO ITEM NUMBER TWO-
RELATED TO TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING AND PUBLIC AWARENESS-
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAS
IN. A TREMENDOUS ON SCHOOL TO
THAT THROUGHOUT THE AND ARE ARE
GREATLY COURAGE BY THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS IN FIGHTING
FUNDING NOT ONLY IN THIS.
BUDGET BUT ALSO LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET TO ADDRESS ASUS FUNDING
AND SCREENINGS SO WE LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
ON THE LEGISLATURE AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BUDGET COMING
BACK AGAIN YES KELLY BEING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE TO BOOK AND ALL THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE'RE
DEFINITELY SUPPORTED. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
AFFORDABILITY FOR HELP
CONSUMERS AND WE APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH
COMMITTEE. AFTER ENTERING THANK
YOU GIVE ME A LECTURE TEN SAY
THAT ALL RIGHT. OKAY SO I'LL BE
FAIR YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THIS
WEEK- ALRIGHT BUT THAT- WANTED
THANK EVERYONE TO- PRESENTED-
IT IS TWELVE. TWENTY SO I THINK
WE'LL DO IS WE'LL TAKE A FIVE
TO TEN MINUTES STRETCHED BREAK.
AND THEN WILL RESUME WITH THE-
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES OR
THE CELL BUT- SUCH AS A WE CAN
STRETCH A LITTLE OKAY THANK YOU
I. THAT ARE YOU BACK TWELVE
THIRTY.
OKAY LET'S RECONVENE
HERE AND- WELCOME EVERYONE BACK
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO- THE MERCY MEDICAL
SERVICE STORY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE ALL RIGHT SO
WHAT WE FIRST DO INTRODUCTIONS
AROUND THE TABLE SO START WITH
THE AGENCY. THANK YOU ACTING
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
REGULATORY AN EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
I AM PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR DAVID DUNCAN AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AND
DIRECTOR OF THE EMS AUTHORITY.
MY NAME IS RICK ROSS ON THE
CHIEF OF THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
FORTY THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME SEAN TRASK I AM THE
CHIEF OF THE IMMENSE PERSONNEL
DIVISION IT IN MY STORY THANK
YOU HELLO SONYA PETA KALLIO
FINANCE IN THE ARRIVALS FINANCE
FROM OFTEN TELL. THANK YOU
WELCOME ALL RIGHT SO WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH THE-
REVIEW AND DISCOVER ALL THE
QUESTIONS IN THE BETTER- AND
THEN WE'LL GO AROUND TO OKAY
GREAT THANK SACRAMENTO- DOCTOR
DUNCAN WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
HIS POLOGIES FOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO BE HERE HE IS ELSEWHERE
ENGAGED WITH A CO IN NINETEEN
ACTIVITIES. ARMORS THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
BY HEALTH AND SAFETY. CODE TWO
POINT FIVE WITH THE INTENT OF
CREATING A STATEWIDE SYSTEM
WITH THEM SO RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION OF ALL STATE
ACTIVITIES. CONCERNING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES TO
ENSURE THE PROVISION OF A AND
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT-
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE. AND
THAT IS A VERY SMALL DEPARTMENT
BUT WITH SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT FALL INTO
THREE MAJOR CATEGORIES.
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE OVER SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND CERTIFIED EMTS
AND NEARLY TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
LICENSE PARAMEDICS THAT RESPOND
TO ABOUT. FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION NINE ONE ONE CALLS.
EMERGENCY SERVICES ANNUALLY AND
WITH FORTY TWO. HUNDRED GROUND
AMBULANCES AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN AIR AMBULANCES.
SPECIFICALLY MS IT WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LICENSING
OF PARAMEDICS AND DISCIPLINING
THOSE LICENSES WHEN NECESSARY
AND ENTERTAINING THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE TRAINING STANDARDS AND
REGULATIONS FOR ALL EMS LEVELS
INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
STATE. CALIFORNIA EMS IS A TWO
TIERED SYSTEM BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES AM SAID DEVELOPS
GUIDELINES AND APPROVES PLANS
FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL SYSTEMS
THAT ARE IMPLEMENTED AND
OPERATED BY THIRTY THREE LOCAL
EMS AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE.
I AM SO ALSO DEVELOPS
REGULATIONS FOR THE DESIGN AND
CALL QUALITY OF SPECIALTY CARE
SYSTEMS A TRAUMA SYSTEM
PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY CARE
CENTERS A STROKE SYSTEM CARDIAC
SYSTEMS AND A CITY WIDE POISON
CONTROL SYSTEM. THE THIRD MAJOR
AREA OF RESPONSIBILITY IS THE
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES. WE
PARTNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO BUILD A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MEDICAL RESPONSE
EMERGENCY FUNCTION WITH THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO PLAN FOR THE
MEDICAL IMPACT OF ANY TYPE OF
DISASTER OR HEALTH EMERGENCY.
RECALL GO AHEAD AND GO INTO THE
BUDGET AND BCP'S IF THAT'S OKAY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE RELEASED
IN JANUARY INCLUDES EXPENSE
REPORTING AMOUNT OF THIRTY FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION. IN SEVENTY
POINT A PERMANENTPOSITIONS OF
THIS AMOUNT SIXTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION OR FORTY SIX PERSONS
DELEGATED FOR STATE OPERATIONS
IN NINETEEN POINT THREE MILLION
OR 56% FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
BUT WE HAVE PROPOSALS ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER DURATION FOR.
HIS FOR A CUSTOMER HEALTH
RESPONSE LOCAL SO WE'RE GONNA-
SINCE IS PARTY OF REVIEW WHEN
WE GET TO THOSE TWO AREAS WILL
DELVE INTO THAT OFF. OKAY
ANYTHING. YOU AND I THINK WE
DID HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
SUSPECT. IN THE STATE SCORED A
RESPONSE WITH OF IN NINETEEN AS
YOU CAN DRESS THAT I KNOW THAT
THE DIRECTORS BUSY DOING THAT
RIGHT NOW IF I DO I JUST
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THAT. SIR I'M
STILL AS FAR AS AN FULLER SPOTS
ABILITIES. EIGHT INFECTIOUS
DISEASE PACKED MA WE ARE
CERTAINLYINTEGRATED WITH THE
EMERGENCY SUPPORT FUNCTION
EIGHT MEDICAL HEALTH A MEDICAL.
OR THE STATE EMERGENCY PLAN.
MORE WORK CAN CURRENTLY WITH
THE LOCAL RENT. AND STATE AND
FEDERAL PART OR STRIPPING THE-
PLAN MANY RISKS NUMBER. SO WE
HAVE A MAJOR AREAS FOR WORKING
ON PREPAREDNESS AND COMMUNITY
XIN SERVER ONCE AND DETECT.
ACTIVITIES INCLUDE STAFFING AND
ALL STATE OPERATIONAL CENTERS
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER THE
MEDICAL AND HEALTH COORDINATION
CENTER. OUR DEPARTMENT.
OPERATIONS CENTER AND ALSO THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
LOCATED IN SAN MATEO COUNTY. WE
ARE COORDINATING A TO POINT
AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS
ROSTERING AND COORDINATING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TEAM. MEMBERS FOR TO PLAY IN IN
ENSURING MEDICAL SHELTERS ARE
PRESSED TO BE DID FLOYD.
COOPERATING PATIENT TRANSFERS
TO QUARANTINE CENTERS OR
HOSPITALS AND WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS. TO UP EIGHT AND MANY
THE POLICY NECESSARY TO OFFER
SONOMA THE NURSERY. AND SEE THE
MISSION. M. SET HAS ALSO
DEPLOYED STAFF INCOME EQUIPMENT
TO OAKLAND TO SUPPORT THE GRAND
PRINCESS CRUISE SHIP MISSION
CURRENTLY MS IS INTEGRATED WITH
THAT HEALTH AND HUMAN SAFETY.
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM
OVERSEEING THIS MISSION
ADDITIONALLY ABSENT HAS
ESTABLISHED ONSITE EMS COMMAND
AT THE OAKLAND AIRPORT OUT
COMPORT SORRY TO COORDINATE THE
MOVEMENT OF PERSONS
DISEMBARKING FROM THE CRUISE
SHIP REQUIRING MEDICAL CARE TO
HOSPITALS AND IS ENTERED INTO A
CONTRACT WITH AMERICAN MEDICAL
RESPONSE. TO EXECUTE THOSE
TRANSPORTS USING MULTIPLE
AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS. AS YOU
KNOW THE AMPLE INSTRUCTING
PROGRAM IS A GROUP OF FIVE
AMBULANCES OF THE SAME TYPE
WITH EITHER ADVANCED LIFE
SUPPORT OR BASIC LIFE SUPPORT
WITH COMMON COMMUNICATION AND A
LEADER IN A SEPARATE CALL. THEM
SAYS ALSO DEPLOYED SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE CAL MATT TO
ATTEND TO GUESS AT DESIGNATED
QUARANTINE CENTERS. AND PHILLIP
AND SAYS IMPLEMENTING POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES ALLOWING LOCAL
EMS AGENCIES TO UTILIZE
PARAMEDICS TO TRANSPORT
PATIENTS TO MEDICAL FACILITIES
OTHER THAN GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS AND ALLOWING FOR THE
USE OF OUT OF STATE MEDICAL
BOARDS NOW. AS DEFINED IN THE
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION. THANK
YOU LU COMMENTS. SENATE
PARTICULARLY- JUST ONE ISSUE-
THAT WE WOULD RAISE IS THAT
THE- BACK BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'LL COME UP ANYWHERE ELSE.
AND SO HAS THE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS FOR USE IN TIMES LIKE
THIS AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS ALSO WANTED TO
DEPLOY A SOME OF THOSE SHELTERS
TO HANDLE HOMELESSNESS AND SOME
OF THE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
SOME OF THOSE SHELTERS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING USED IN OAKLAND
AND SO I GUESS THE QUESTION IN-
THAT WOULD COME UP IS WHETHER
OR NOT ENOUGH FOR THE SHELTERS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR USE IN
RESPONSE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN.
ALL RIGHT THANKS A FINANCE AND
GOVERNMENT ALL RIGHT WELL MAYBE
IF THEY CAN ARE YOU ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SO. AS A
HOMELESSNESS IS A CRISIS ALL
RIGHT AND- WE ALSO HAVE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE MY UNDERSTANDING
AT LEAST AT THIS POINT JUST
READING THE NEWS AND I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER THIS IS THAT OF
COURSE ARE FINDING ALTERNATIVE.
FACILITIES TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE EITHER CONTACTS ARE WHO
HAVE CORONAVIRUS AND DON'T
REQUIRE HOSPITALIZATION BUT- DO
YOU SEE A NEED FOR. THAT WERE
USING THE SHELTERS ARE READY
THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE SO THE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS. THAT SAYS A
RAINY CONVERSATION AND SAID
ABOUT THE THESE AMER SHELTER
THAT- THAT I GUESS ARE UNDER
YOUR SECTION. SURE IS. IN THE
MOBILE SHELTER. AS YOU KNOW WAS
BORN OUT OF THE MOBILE FIELD
HOSPITAL PROGRAM AND WE HAD
THREE SETS OF TWO HUNDRED AT
BED HOSPITALS COMPLETE EACH.
AND WE BROKE THOSE DOWN SOME OF
THOSE DOWN WEEK WE ARE
RETAINING ONE FULL TWO HUNDRED
BED AT OUR STATION AND THEN WE
HAVE ONE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR
USE. AND THEN WE'VE GOT THE
REMAINING HOLE. OF TWO HUNDRED
INTO SIX MODULE THAT WE'VE
PLACED STRATEGICALLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. FOR LOCALS TO USE-
CURRENTLY WITH THE- HOMELESS UP
PROGRAM WE ONLY A FEW THAT ARE
LOAN TO THAT ENDEAVOR AT THIS
MOMENT- AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
SET. AT THE- IS IT NEEDED
QUARANTINE SITE USING THEIR-
EIGHT PROPER CENTER SO I
BELIEVE IF WE- EIGHT. ALTER OUR
RED DID THE ONE AT THE READY IF
NEED TO WE HAVE USED THESE
SHELTER IN THE- FOR. PARKS PLAY.
WE DOES ISOLA TEN. STATE AREA
THE COURTNEY. USE JUST. SO WE
HAVE THOSE. RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
THE SINGLE AND AS DEPENDENCY ON
THOSE. I CAN SAY RIGHT NOW BUT
IT CHANGE AT THEM. EVERY YOU
KNOW OUR IS DIFFERENT SO- THERE
MAY BE AS- THE STRESS ON THOSE
RESOURCES BUT FOR RIGHT NOW I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ENOUGH TO COVER
WHAT WE'VE BEEN OBLIGATED TO SO
FAR. AND CERTAINLY LET ME ONE
THE ISSUES THAT PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT PROJECTED
FUTURE AS FAR AS I KNOW THE
ISSUE RIGHT NOW BUT SCENES
REJECTED IT'S HAPPENED IN.
OTHER COUNTRIES- SUES THE
SAMPLE THE MOBILE HOSPITAL- IT
IS EQUIPPED SO THE NECESSARY TO
BE USED TO AS SIR CASSIDY OF WE
HAVE AN AREA THAT'S HARD HIT BY
A CODE NINETEEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY A FEW UNPAYABLE.
YOU KNOW HOW IT OF SENIORS IN
THE HOSPITAL LOCAL HOSPITALS-
BASICALLY PASS THESE OVER OVER
RUN- IS THAT DESERVE. AS IS A
RENTS OF THOUGHT ABOUT A
WHETHER THAT'S AN ASSET THAT'S
GONNA BE USABLE FOR THAT
FUNCTION AT THE MOMENT THE- SH.
ARE WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO EAT THE
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND
FILTERS IT. WE WAS BUILT
AWESOME WE HAD A MET. I QUICK
IN A SERVICE IN MAINTENANCE
THAT. MADE IT TO. IT NEEDS.
STATIC SENSE SO IT'S JUST
DURABLE EQUIPMENT AND
THEMSELVES OKAY IS THIS IS ANY
AT THIS MOMENT WITH THIS PURELY
NEED AT THIS MOMENT WE DON'T
KNOW IN THE FUTURE IS THERE
SOME DISCUSSION I THOUGHT ABOUT.
I TEND TO USE. THE QUICK TO IF
WE NEED SEARCH TO PAY. I MEAN
IS THAT IT MAY NOT BE READY FOR
THAT RIGHT NOW BUT ANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT EVEN
THE EVEN NOTHING ELSE IT'S THE
PRESSURING THE HOSPITAL FEEL
WITH BABY LESS BILL CASES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT STILL
NEED HOSPITALIZATION SO I
WASN'T SURE WHETHER DOES. SOME
PREPARATION WORKERS AN
EXAMINATION OF THE ASSETS. AT
UMASS ASSETS THAT MIGHT BE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE- THE
OUT BREAK. OUT WE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN LOOKING AT WHAT WOULD IT
TAKE TO- REVITALIZED THAT
PROGRAM SO IT IS CERTAINLY HAS
BEEN ON. THE TOP OF OUR MINDS
OKAY SO THERE'S WORK BEING DONE
TO EXAMINE YOUR EXISTS CURRENT
ASSETS AND THINK ABOUT WHERE
THIS THING. ARE ACTIVELY
LOOKING AT WHAT RESOURCES WE
HAVE AVAILABLE OUT FOR
OURSELVES AS WELL AS A FEDERAL
INNER AND LOCAL PARTNERS OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL. I MEAN I THINK.
JUST TO. EIGHT RIGHT BEING
BEING AND HOPEFULLY THAT
DOESN'T COME TO THAT BUT- IT IS
THE PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED THAT-
IF THERE'S A SUDDEN INCREASE
AND- WE'LL WERE SOMEWHAT
CONSTRAINED BY A LACK OF
AVAILABLE TESTING- YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN DELAYS AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL WITH.
TESTING AND SO FORTH AND WE
HAVE COMMITTEESPREAD RIGHT NOW
WE'RE HOPING THAT IF EVERYONE
DOES THEIR JOB AND WE DO SOCIAL
THAT SINGS OF WHAT WE CAN SLOW
THE- SPREAD OF THE OUTBREAK
SUFFICIENT. WE DON'T OVER TAX
OUR- I SEE OF OUR HEALTHCARE
INSTITUTIONS HOSPITALS AND SO
FORTH BUT IT'S ALWAYS POSSIBLE
THAT- WE MAY USE THAT THAT THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN- AND THAT- SO
PEOPLE WILL BE LOOKING FOR WHAT
OTHER ASSETS WE HAVE TO TRY TO
TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE IN THAT IN
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES ALL. RIGHT
OKAY- AND THEN OKAY AND THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT- AGAIN I KNOW YOU'RE THE
OVERSIGHT BUT- IS- CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF IT. OF SO WE'VE HEARD
FROM HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
SOME OF THE INSTITUTIONS ABOUT
THE- LACQUER OF SUB PROTECT.
QUIT MEN'S- SO FIRST TECH TO
ACQUIT MEANT. IS THAT SOMETHING
WERE HEARING FROM- FOLKS IN THE
FIELD IT IS CONCERNS ABOUT
HAVING SUFFICIENT PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT FOR OUR EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS OUT IN THE FIELD
THAT THEY HAVE TO GO IN AN AREA
DEL THE FACILITY WHERE
SOMEONE'S BEEN TESTED POSITIVE
FOR. A FOR CODE- NINETEEN. IT
TO. TELL YOU HEARING FROM THE
FOLKS ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY OF
PROTECTIVE. THE OPPOSITION PUT
MEANT PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO
PROTECT THE- PEOPLE WONDER. OUT
IN THE FIELD IF YOU NEED TO
AGAIN PROVIDE. CARE TRANSPORT
SOMEONE WHO HAS- COVER NINETEEN
OR MAY POTENTIALLY HABIT. WE
KNOW THAT DOCTOR DUNCAN HAS-
BEEN IN REGULAR COMMUNICATION
WITH THEM LOCAL EMS
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ARE THEN-
HAVE CONNECTION AN OVERSIGHT
OVER HIM AND PROVIDE IN THEIR
AREAS. AND SO I KNOW THOSE.
THINGS ARE FLOWING BOTH WAYS- I
HAVE NOT HEARD OF A REQUEST AT
THIS POINT IN TIME- THAT THERE
IS A DECLINE. OF JOHN- JOHN
TRASK HERE- DO YOU WANT TO.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT-
YES- WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING
FROM THE LOCALS COMING UP TO
THE STATE AND THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF MANY PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT I. STONE
THERE IS. MMA ALL RIGHT. OKAY
WELL JUST- YET DIVS THINKING
ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE OUT THERE
AND- WE'VE HEARD KNOWS WE'VE WE
KNOW SOME. THAT THE LEAST- SOME
HOSPITAL STAFF- IT'S ZERO
FOURTH HAVE INDICATED THEY HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT WE KNOW
THAT UNFORTUNATELY FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE MASKS HAVE BEEN SHORT
SUPPLY BECAUSE OF AN BY THEM
UP. AND SO- WHEN OUR ABOUT THE
TOILET PAPER PART OF THINGS
FROM THE HEALTH CARE AND BUT-
BUT- WE DO SEE THE SHORTAGES OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF THINGS AND-
AND OBVIOUSLY. WITH THIS
PURPOSE DISEASE NOT ONLY OF
COURSE HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
IN THE US AND AROUND THE WORLD
DESTRUCTION SUPPLY CHAINS. YOU
KNOW I'D- WELL I KNOW THAT WORD.
THE NEED FOR THIS KIND OF COULD
END OF COURSE HAVING PERHAPS
HAVING TO TRIAGE SUPPLIES BUGS
THE MANY DIFFERENT. BILL
PROFESSIONALS WHO MIGHT
DEMANDED BUT CLEARLY WE WANT TO
PROTECT OUR FRONTLINE FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO MAY BE ASKED TO
GO AND- PROVIDE CARE TRANSPORT
FOR PATIENTS. WELL THE PLEASE
KEEP US SURPRISED IF THAT AS
THE DAY GOES ON AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF CONVERSATION
SO. RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
BULLETS. I JUST MOVE ON THEN
ISSUE TOO SO THAT WE GOT THE
REGIONAL DISASTER MEDICAL
HEALTH RESPONSE LOCAL SYSTEM
PROPOSALS. EMERGENCY MEDICAL AT.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITIES REQUESTING THREE
AND SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GENERAL FUND
TO IMPROVE REGIONAL SHASTA
MEDICAL AND HEALTH MITIGATION
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY. BY FUNDING THREE
ADDITIONAL RT MHS IS TO SERVICE
SHARED RESOURCES WITHIN THE SIX
CALLOW YES MUTUALLY REGIONS.
THE THREE RD MHS POSITIONS
WOULD BE LOCATED IN THE THREE
OH YES STREET REGION'S WHICH
CONSIST OF THE COASTAL REGION
THE INLAND REGION IN THE
SOUTHERN REGION. THIS INCREASE
IN STAFFING WOULD ALLOW FOR
AROUND THE CLOCK EMERGENCY
DISASTER SUPPORT ENHANCED
BACKUP DURING BEFORE AND AFTER
DISASTER RESPONSES IMPROVE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE REGIONAL
COUNTY MEDICAL AND HEALTH
DISASTER RESPONSE SYSTEM. AND
RT MHS IS ARE CRITICAL TO BOTH
THIS DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE. THE PURPOSE OF THE
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE ALL FORTY IS
PREPARED TO PROVIDE FOR MEDICAL
AND HEALTH NEEDS DURING
DISASTERS IN TO COORDINATE
THESE NEEDS DURING A DISASTER
RESPONSE. THIS PROGRAM WAS
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED ASSIST
THE STATE REGIONS AND COUNTIES
OPERATE AREAS IN THE DEVOID OF
MUTUAL ASSISTANCE PAYMENT.
CENTER THIS PLAN CAPTION
EFFORTS REACHED MEDICAL HEALTH
RESPONSE PLANS IN REGIONAL
RECOVERY PLANS. XIN ALREADY
MADE JUST PERSONAL ARE TASKED
WITH WORKING WITH LOCAL AND
REGIONAL TRAINING EXERCISING
APPROPRIATE FOR HIS SERVICE.
FOR THE RT THIS IS. BUT
REGIONAL NATION OF MEDICAL AND
HEALTH THREE. DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. I
THANK YOU LA COMES WE REVIEWED
THIS PROPOSAL AND- DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH AND WOULD
RECOMMEND APPROVAL THANK YOU
FINANCE ALL RIGHT OKAY- PROCEED
THE PRESENTATION WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THIS ONE OPEN BUT- LIKE
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING ELSE-
BUT- IT'S THE SYRUPY SHEET-
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING SO THANK
YOU THAT'S- NEXT POST EMERGENCY
MEDICAL DECEMBER TO MEDICAL
DISPATCH YES- THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE SUPPORT IS
REQUESTING ONE PERMANENT
POSITION AND THREE ON FOR JUST
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THREE FORTY TWO AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. THE
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
IMPLEMENT A MEET THE ONGOING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL FOUR
THREE EIGHT SP FOUR THREE
PROHIBITS A PUBLIC AGENCY FROM
DELEGATING ASSIGNING OR
ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT FOR
NINE ONE ONE CALL PROCESSING
SERVICES. REGARDING THE
DISPATCH OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
RESOURCES IN LESS THE
DELEGATION OR SIMON'S TO OR THE
CONTRACT IS WITH ANOTHER PUBLIC
AGENCY. WITH THE PASSAGE OF
REST BEFORE THREE ENDS A WILL
BE REQUIRED AMONG OTHER THINGS
TO PROVIDE UNANTICIPATED
WORKLOAD IN STAFF TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL REVIEW OF EMS PLANS
ESTABLISHED REGULATIONS FOR EMS
DISPATCHERS. AND NINE ONE ONE
CALL PROCESSING OPERATIONS AND
ALSO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES AND FIGHTERS ON SYSTEM
IMPACTS. OF SB FOUR THREE EIGHT.
IN THE WILL REQUIRE ONE- HEPA
POSITION TO SERVICE THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL DISPATCH
COMMUNICATIONS COORDINATOR WITH
THE ANSWER. TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND MAKE OPERATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS OF SP FOURTH.
TEMPORARY FUNDING IS ALSO BEING
REQUESTED DURING FISCAL YEARS
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
FACILITATE THE WORKING GROUP
WHICH WILL CREATE AND DRAFT THE
REGULATIONS COMPLETE THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS FOR TO EMERGENCY
RIGHT PACKAGES AND BEGIN THE
REGULAR RULE MAKING PROCESS
WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF ENACTMENT.
OF THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
THE PROMULGATION REGULATIONS
WILL STAB STANDARDIZE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LENSES
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF EM ELSE PROGRAM REVIEW
APPROVAL AND DENIAL
DETERMINATION AND APPEAL
CRITERION PROCESSES THAT SHOW
IN SIR CORD. PLEAD AND
EFFECTIVE VM CMS SYSTEM
PRACTICES THAT ADVANCE THE
QUALITY SAFETY AND SATISFACTION
HEALTH CARE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. Q. LU. FIND ALL
RIGHT. OKAY THAT THAT MAKES
SENSE WE AND THE LAWS THAT WE
PASSED ALL RIGHT OKAY WITH
THAT- THAT- THERE'S A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON- EMS. WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A CHRISTIE
VELMA ON THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
THINKS THE UP TO SPEAK I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THEIR WORK AND ALSO THANK
DOCTOR DUNCAN WHO'S BEEN FIXED
EXTREMELY ACCESSIBLE TO OUR
ORGANIZATION IS OUR FOR
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE FIELD AS
THE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED ARE
EXPERIENCING LOTS OF
INTERACTIONS WITH PATIENTS
VULNERABLE AND OTHERWISE AND-
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
A BILL HE AUTHORED AND HAD AN
ACTIVE. FORCE TO SOME YEARS AGO
TRY TO TIGHTEN THE TIME FRAME
UNDER ONE OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
NOTIFIED OF CLOSE TO A COUPLE
DISEASE AND I THINK WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO IN THAT AREA
WHAT A FIREFIGHTER EXPOSED
RECENTLY- KEPT WORKING FOR FIVE
DAYS FIVE DAYS WAS THE
IMMEDIATE NOTIFICATION THE FIRE
RECEIVE THAT. HE WAS EXPOSED TO
A CO IN NINETEEN POSITIVE
PATIENT AND RIGHT AROUND THAT
SAME TIME HE BECAME
SYMPTOMATIC- AND SO THAT YOU
KNOW AND HEADED EFFORT TO
CONTAIN A NOT SPUR I THINK THAT
WE ARE LOT TO DO WE APPRECIATE.
THE SUPPORT OF THE- THIRTY. TWO
THERE MEDICAL THIS PROGRAM
BUSTIN I THINK THE COME BETWEEN
THE EM THE WHICH STARTED ON
CONSIDER A GREAT JOB HIM FOR
AND LOOK PUBLIC IS STILL I
THINK THE ROOM FROM A BIT FOR
APPROVED MEANT FOR THE SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS I'M AND THEN ON
AS BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT- WE
RESPONSES THAT BILLS WE DO
APPRECIATE. AND SINCE FOCUS ON
GETTING THIS. HI THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTED WE APPRECIATE THE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT MAYBE SOME
MORE CLARITY ON HE M. D. RULES
AND ALSO LA A LESS AGREEMENTS
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENTS BY LOOK BMS
AGENCIES ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
OR DOESN'T MEAN SO SOME CLARITY
IN THAT AREA. TO THE- APARTMENT.
CAN IT THIS PROGRAM OKAY WITH
WHAT'S EXPECTED BY THE STATE AS
WELL AS HAVING ADEQUATE
FUNCTIONING EMD I'M SORRY AT
BUT CERTAINLY WE ARE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT NINE ONE ONE CALL
PROCESSING IS I'M NOT SURE HOW
MUCH ACTIVITY TO TAKE US PLACE
IN THAT AREA THANK YOU SO MUCH
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SEEN
NO OTHER MONEY- NO QUESTION SO
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU AND PLEASE KEEP US
RISE ON. HOW THE IT'S A FUNNY
THANK RIGHT. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT.
ACTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE. SO
WHAT THE THAT'S THE WAY. OKAY
WELCOME. ON ONE YEAR. OKAY
ALRIGHT SO- WILL FIRST HAVE
EVERYONE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
FOR THE RECORD FOR THIS GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR WILL
INTRODUCE OURSELVES I AMERICA'S
LIKE I AM THE ACTING CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
ELEMENT THE CLANCY JARED AND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION AT ASPEN
THANK YOU HI MICHAEL VALLEY
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
INFORMATIONS DODGE BUT THANK
YOU TYPE CHRISTIAN CINEMA AUDIT
MANAGER FOR THE INFAMOUS
SEARCHES THE DIVISION AT
OSBORNE. OKAY BEN JOHNSON ALEJO
WE ARE ALMOST FINANCE THANK YOU
I HEAR A LOT OF ACTING SO I
GUESS WE'RE STILL ON THAT. WHAT
AID. BEING YOUR JOHN SO FOR GO
AHEAD AND WITH THE- VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SIR SO HARSH.
ADVANCES CAL ACCESS TO SAFE
QUALITY HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENTS
BY FOCUSING ON THREE PRIMARY
AREAS. HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. HEALTHCARE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING. AND
HEALTH CARE CONSTRUCTION AND
FINANCING. SO I GOT A NOT TO
SORRY TO INTERRUPT- SO WE HAVE
A PRETTY GOOD RIGHT ABOUT THE
AGENCY HAVE. PRETTY GOOD
FAMILIARITY WITH THE AGENCY SO
I THINK WE CAN FOCUSED REMARKS
MORE ON LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENED
THE PAST YEAR ONE. LOOKING FOR
IN THE COMING YEAR THIS BUDGET
CELL. OKAY CURRENT YES I MEAN
IF WE OF THE WRITE UPS EXAMPLE
DO YOU WE COULD GO RIGHT TO OUR
BCP'S THAT THAT'S THE TOP OKAY
WELL I MAY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS-
OF THEY DID HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS JUST REGARDING A
REVIEW SO DID YOU WANT JUST A
THING THAT YOU SEE PLANNING TO.
IN TERMS OF THE YEARS. THAT YOU
CAN BE DOING THIS COMING YEAR
THAT'S DIFFERENT WELL YEAH WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING SOME NEW
PROGRAM SO I COULD JUST TOUCH
ON THE ALLEGED ATTACK THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA SURE SEPARATE FROM
THE VCP JUST ARE LIKE FOR ALL
LIKE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT. SO SAID A WHOLE BREAK
THIS WHERE DOES A USER TO THESE
THINGS WERE WORKING ON RIGHT
NOW DOES HE HOOKED UP TO GREAT
SIR AB. PERSON TO WORK FORCE
JUST BUT THE TURN KNOW THAT WE
ARE- TAKING KIND OF A BROAD
LOOK AT. THE CROSS. IN AND ARE
A C. ADD OR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
TERM THE ACTUAL IMPACT OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AND SPECIFICALLY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND OUR PROGRAMS
INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR SO WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF THINKING AND
LISTENING IN THAT AREA RIGHT
NOW- MOVING ON TO- DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING SO WE-
SINCE JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN- PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES HAVE PROVIDED SIXTY
DAY NOTIFICATIONS DIRECTLY TO
SPECIFIED REGISTER PURCHASERS
AS PART OF OUR SB SEVENTEEN
PROGRAM- DRUG UP. PRICES COSTS
TRANSPARENCY PROGRAM- IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ALL SHOULD
BEGIN PROVIDING QUARTERLY
REPORTS THE FRACTURES THAT
INCLUDED INFORMATION THANK IS
TO DISTINCT MODES THE SUBJECT
OF VACATION REQUIREMENT TO
PURCHASERS. AND ALSO IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BEGAN
PROVIDING QUARTERLY REPORTS OF
FROM MANY FROM IDENTIFYING NEW
DRUGS THAT WERE INTRODUCED A
MARK OF A CERTAIN COST HAVE ALL
BEEN POSTING THE- LARGER MORE
COMPLETE WHOLESALE ACQUISITION
COSTS REPORTS. WHICH CONTAIN
INFORMATION THAT GIVES THE
RATIONALE FOR THOSE INCREASES
AND I THINK WE JUST POSTED
CORNER THREE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TODAY. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ABLE MOVING TO OUR OTHER CLOSE
FRIENDS BURNS YOU PROGRAM THE
HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATA
PROGRAM PER STATUE THE DATABASE
WILL BE SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
THE SYSTEM WILL SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATION INITIATIVE AIMED
AT ADDRESSING COSTS AND
IMPROVING SYSTEM PERFORMANCE.
COULD IN THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY AS WAS
MARKED ON EARLIER THE CENTER
FOR THE INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION
AND INITIATIVES TO.
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS ARCHES
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMMUTING
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO ADVISE US
ON THE ESTABLISHMENT
IMPLEMENTATION ONGOING
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STATE
WIDE. HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS
DATABASE- OF THE REVIEW COULD
BE FIRST CONVENE IN MARCH. AND
THEY HAVE THEIR LAST MEETING IN
FEBRUARY FEBRUARY TWO ANY I AM
VERY PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
REVIEW COMMITTEE MADE THIRTY
SIX UNANIMOUS. TO WASH BED AND
SUNDAY. ARE REALLY REPORTER
FLETCHER. MAYES SHINS. DATABASE
OR WAS DO YOU. ONE WE WILL TO
HELP FROM SOME IN AND ABOUT
THESE DISK IN AND MISTER PROP
NEAR OF A FOUR TO AND QUALITY.
HEALTH CARE CONSTRUCTION
FINANCE SO- THE MAIN UPDATES
THERE THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT-
95% OF THE HOSPITALS OF THE Q.
KERR BUILDINGS CALIFORNIA NO ME
TO TWENTY TWENTY STANDARDS. ARE
FULLY. THE ACUTE CARE BUILDINGS
IN CALIFORNIA MEET THE TWENTY
THIRTY STANDARD- BUT STILL MUCH
WORK TO DO THERE. ABOUT THE
MAIN I THINK JUST OF THINGS
GOING ON AUSTIN I'M HAPPY TO.
ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU THE LA- ANYTHING ON THE
ROOF THE ONLY THING AND THAT IS
THE CHANGE IN GENERAL FUND
FUNDING IN PARTICULAR FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY ONE
IS REALLY DUE TO THE EXPRESSION
A ONE TIME FUND THAT REALLY
CARE IS OVER AS IT HAS MULTI
YEARS PARTY. OKAY THANK YOU
FINANCE NOW OKAY SO YEAH AFTER
I MADE NOTE THAT WE HAVE THIS
VERY LARGE INCREASE FOR ONE
YEAR BUT THIS IS REALLY MONEY.
PROMOTE YOUR- YES. DOES IS GIVE.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE- IN TERMS
OF. SO ACTUALLY IN TERMS OF THE.
PARTIALLY TO TALKING ABOUT THE-
THE WHAT PROGRAM CAN DISCUSS
AND GO THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. ARE WE GOING TO BE TRY SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
THEIR MENTAL WORK FORCE ONE
THINGS I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT
OFTEN TALK WERE WORKFORCE WE
TALK ABOUT THE PIPELINE AND HOW
WE CHANNEL PEOPLE AND BUT ALSO
WE LOOK AT THE LATEST ECONOMICS
WHICH IS. THAT NOW YOU TRIP ON
THE- IN THE CAR. JOHN AT NO
WORK. YEAH ARE THEY GOING TO.
BE ON THE- SECTOR THE PRICE
SECTOR DâN OF THE SOMETHING
ELSE. ARE WE ARE WE LOOKING AT
TRACKING LIKE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE GRADUATE SERVER WHAT
TRAINING. AND SO FORTH THAT ARE
THEY- THIS. PART OF IT IS TO.
BUILDER WORK FORCE THAT WE-
TYPICALLY IN OUR PUBLIC. ARE
NOT ALWAYS PUBLIC SECTOR BUT-
IN OUR- AREA SO. TRACKING THE
SERVER WAS AND ARE LEAVING RAM
IN TERMS WHERE HOW SUCCESSFULLY
PLACING AYE GETTING PEOPLE WHO
IN THE PLACE WE THEY- AS ALL
THE- EXTRA SO ONE OF THINGS WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEM ASIAN OF
THE NEW AT IS. RIGHT THE PUBLIC
MENTAL. I WAS JUST THE TOP.
EVEN WITH PUBLIC MENTAL HOUSE
SOME OF THE CITY THAT WE HAVE
IN THAT WE PUT PLAN TO DO MORE
LONGER FOLLOW UP ON- HAVE SHOWN
SUCCESS WITH OUR LOW PAYMENT
PROGRAM AT. RIGHT COURSE NOT.
OF THEIR- A SERVICE CLINTON BUT
THEN ALSO KNOWING NOTING THAT.
MORE THAN 70% OF THEM- HAVE
STAYED HAVE SINCE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO START DOING THE FOLLOW
UP AND WE'LL WE'LL KEEP DOING
THAT AND BEING ABLE TO. MORE
LAW TO REMOTE ON THAT. OKAY
YEAH I IS IMPORTANT SO BECAUSE
SO. THIS WAS WAY MEAN. TO COME
BACK TO A FOR MORE MONEY I
THINK YOU KNOW WHAT SUPPORT
THAT- BUT WHAT THE WHAT THE
OUTCOMES ARE REYES ON ANY IT'S
A LITTLE BIT ON FAITH AND THEN.
EXPLODED EXPERIENCE WILL O. L.-HOW IS- AND THEN I GUESS. THE
APPRECIATE WE AT THE WHOLE
TABLE OF- ALL THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS OR FUNDING WITH PRIME
CARE THAT NOW. ONLY A RESIDENCY
DOES TEND SO WE I HAVE AS FOR
INSTITUTION A HOBBY RESIDENCES
AXE. AND I GET SEIZE THE REST.
AND LIKE S
THESE OTHER PROGRAMS SO
RIGHT SO WE THE WAY THAT THAT
MOST SO THERE'S FOUR DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES OF FUNDING AND A
FOCUS THE COMMENT ACTUALLY TO
THE PRIMARY CARE AS PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE ALL ON FAMILY
PRACTICE AND SAY. FUNDS
DEDICATED TO FIND EXISTENCE
LOTS- AND THAT FUNDS- A PORTION
OF AN EXISTING SLOT SO WE WOULD
AWARD A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER THE
COURSE OF THREE YEARS. NO AT
IT'S ABOUT A COP. IN A RIP IN
IS THAT A RESIDENT. MUCH MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE.
THIRTY HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS A-
EIGHT YEARS AGO I WE FUND
PORTION OF A SLIGHT WHEN WE
TALK EXISTING FINE AND WE CAN
GET NUMBERS OF HOW MANY SLOTS
THAT SUPPORTS FOR THE- EXIST.
FOR THE- FUNDING THAT IS
ACTUALLY WHERE THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. THERE'S EXPAND AND YOU
PLAN AND SO THE SPEECH
EXPANSION AS FOR AN EXISTING
PROGRAM EXPANDS THEIR ACGME.
ACCREDITED NUMBER THIS IS WE
ARE ACTUALLY PAYING FOR MARGE.
CREASE UP BETWEEN WHAT AND
THREE DEPENDENT HOW COMPETITIVE
THE APPLICANT WHILE AT THE
COMMITTEE. IT FUNDS TO THAT
PROGRAM. RIGHT GOOD. I JUST
MADE I THINK WE HAD A HEARING
AND SEISMIC AND WHERE WE ARE
ALSO DAD AS WERE TO MOVE YOU
THAT AN EX PHASE. GOING HAVE A
HEARING ON THE OMMITTEE AROUND
THE DATA COLLECTION ON THE
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS SO AS WELL
SO I GUESS WE'LL DELVE INTO
THAT THE LORD IS VERY ON GOING
BACK TO WHAT WE WHERE YOU FOUND
THAT FROM FROM THOSE ACTIVITIES.
OKAY SO I'LL GO AHEAD MOVE.
ISSUE TO WHICH IS KIND SIR
PRONE THE PROGRAM LOW REPAYMENT
DISCUSSION. SO OFTEN- REQUEST
THREE YEAR REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY TO REFLECT A SERVICE
AGREEMENT EXTENSION WITH THE
COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES PROGRAM
GOVERNING BOARD TO ADMINISTER
THE PC. I AM PROGRAM THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THE EXPANSION INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL TO NINE DOLLARS AN AWARD.
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY. TWENTY
ONE. AND FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SUPPORT
COSTS FROM. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THREE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
OKAY BUT- WANT. YOU REVIEWED
THE T. P. AS WELL AS THE OTHERS
THAT ARE CHEN NICE TODAY AND
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH ANY OF
THEM. THANK YOU FINANCE THE
COMMISSION OKAY. ALL RIGHT-
OKAY SOUNDS. UP TO KEEP THE
LOAN PAYMENT GOV PROGRAM GOING
SO- RIGHT GREAT EXCELLENT SO I
MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE HEALTHCARE DATA
DISCLOSURE SB THREE FORTY
THREE. OF CARE DISCLOSURE SB
THREE FOUR THREE REQUIRES US.
NEW DINNER POURING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOSPITALS
LICENSE HOSPITALS ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT FINANCIALS
COACH STOSCH. PERFORMS AUDITS
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE MAKES
THOSE OF TO THE PUBLIC. FORTY
THREE REMOVE CERTAIN STATURE
ALTERNATIVE REPORT PHARMACIES
BY KAISER BLOUSE REPORT THEM
WELL THIS LOS WIDER REPORT.
LEVEL AND BETTER COMPATIBILITY
ACROSS POSH WAS REQUESTING
PERSONAL RESOURCE TO DOT AT THE
ADDITIONAL VOLUME OF REPORTS
THAT. HELLO CLEAR. THERE ARE A
LOT TURNS. I CAN IN THE- BCP'S
BY OUR BED NOT NECESSARILY
AFFECTED BY OKAY NO I FOR THAT
OKAY THANK YOU. YES THE ALSO
ASK YOU ARE YOU THINKING
ALRIGHT FINANCE NO ALL RIGHT
APPRECIATE YOU HAVE SOME BILL
AFTER. RIGHT ISSUE THEM FOUR
ASK COMMITTEE PLAY REPORTING
EIGHTY TWO OH FOR IF YOU TO FOR
QUITE US TO DO NEW COMMUNITY
BETTER PLAN FOR GARMENTS
HOSPITAL NOT HOSPITAL ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED COMMUNITY
BENEFIT PLAN STOCKS BID. BE TO
REQUIRES. A STANDARDIZED FORMAT
ALLOW FOR BETTER COMPATIBILITY
ACROSS HOSPITALS- AND WITH THE
FINANCIAL SCHOOLS REPORTS
ALREADY SUBMITTED TO DODGE BUT
IS AUTHORIZED ISSUE PENALTIES
FOR NON COMPLIANCE- AND IS
REQUESTING PERSONAL RESPONSES
COMPLIANCE THE PROGRAM AUDIT
REPORTS EMISSIONS AJ BUT IS
ALSO REQUESTING ONE TIME AYE
CONSULTING FORCES TO CAPACITY
OF BUT I. SELECT OKAY RIGHT
NOTHING FINANCE OKAY CAN JUST
SO THE SAID THE USES OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEARS LARGER
THAN THE FUZZ OF THAT'S FOR THE
CONSULTING AND SETS DIE T. SET
UP CORRECT ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT
OKAY RIGHT- ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
THIS HOSPITAL PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS REPORTING AB NINE IS
THAT IN SIXTY RECORD DR NEW A
NEW REPORTING PROSPERO'S FOR
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY INTEREST AS
FAR COMMISSION OF RESTORED BUYS
THE- POSSIBLE THROUGH THIS. BUT
EXPENSE OR REQUIRED SMITH
REPORTS DETAIL THE OUR
DIVERSITY SPEND TOP. OSPREY
THAT I WILL BE AUTHORIZED ISSUE
FAMILIES FOR NOT CLIENTS OSCARS
REQUESTING RESOURCES TO MANAGE
ITS EMISSIONS AND COMPLIANCE
AND TO STAFF THE- AFTER.
REQUEST MY TO CONSULT RESORT TO
BUILD A PASSED THE- NINETIES
EVEREST TO COLLECT AND TRACK
REPORTS MISSIONS. OKAY HELLO
FINANCE TWO OKAY THANK YOU SO
JUST TO CLARIFY BECAUSE THERE'S
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE IN
THE FIRST YEAR I ASSUME THE TWO
POSITIONS TWO HUNDRED NINE THE
RIGHT THOUSAND THAT FIVE YOU.
AND YOUR REMEMBER BEING
COMMISSION MEMBERS FIFTY
THOUSAND. SEVEN TO SERVE ON THE
COMMITTEE AND JUST TRYING TO
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY
BUT I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
NOT WORK SO I TRY TO CLARIFY
THAT FOR THE FIRST YEAR IS A
LITTLE ON THE SECOND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RIGHT UP WITH
THE GAP IS MORE THAN A LITTLE
BIGGER SIZES IDEA EXCEPT FIVE
HUNDRED. IS TO. TWO OF. ALRIGHT
SO FOR THE FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
COMMISSION MEMBER REIMBURSEMENT
BUT THE REST OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND IS OKAY.
IT'S I SAID THIS IS ALL ABOUT
TRYING TO UPGRADE YOUR DATA
COLLECTION THE FIRST YEAR AND
THAT THAT WOULD BE IT IS A SIN
YOU'RE GONNA BE CONTRACTING
DECKED OUT TO SOMEONE- THAT ARE
NOT TAXATION WEEK NOT BACKED
OUT. OF THEIR CONTRACT IT WE'RE
ASSUMING ITS CONTRACTORS WITH
OKAY ALL RIGHT FOR SYSTEM
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OKAY.
RIGHT BUT WITH THE BACKING
CAUCUS DONE THE ONE YEAR RATE.
YES CENTER OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY
TO START HIS. ACTIONS A SORRY
AT THAT'S MY JOB TO ASK
QUESTIONS I SEE THINGS. OKAY
VERY GOOD. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
AND THEN- WE HAVE- PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS SO. SEVERAL OF
THEM. OKAY SO WE HAVE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS SO I
GUESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
SHE'S JUST HAVE PEOPLE MOVE
AROUND THE SIDES HERE. THAT WAY
WE CAN. IF THE SAME COMMENT
FROM. THE AGENCY. NOT BUT-
OFTENTIMES YOU CAN BIDEN
INSIGHTS CELL ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SO
WE HAVE FIVE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT AND- AS HE TRACED
YOUR PRESENTATION TO THREE
MINUTES OR LES- AND SO OKAY WE
USED TO PLEASE INTRODUCE SO FOR
THE RECORD. BOB GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HAAS. CJ'S REQUEST
IS FOR TWENTY TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME FOR THE
OFFICE THE WHITE. PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN THIS IS TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL AN EXISTING
RESIDENCY SLOTS THIS IS A NEW
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WAS FUNDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AS PART
OF THE M. HSA WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THIS HAS PUSHED OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM TO THE BREAKING POINT AN
ESTIMATED SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE
EXPERIENCE A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER IN ANY GIVEN YEAR IT
ONLY. THE DAHLE TO. ANALYSTS
ARE MEANT THE RULES UNDERSTAND
WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE EVERY DAY ARE
NURSES THERAPISTS SOCIAL
WORKERS AND OTHERS SEE
FIRSTHAND THE CHALLENGES THE
PEOPLE WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS FACE IN GETTING THE
TREATMENT THEY DESERVE. PART OF
THE LOCAL TO USE THIS IS NOT
HAVE ENOUGH PSYCHIATRIST ANY
CURRENT OR FUTURE DEMAND IN A
LARGE PORTION OF THOSE
CURRENTLY PRACTICING OR NEARING
RETIREMENT. THAT ACT FINE WITH
THE GROWING POPULATION MEANS
PEOPLE WHO NEED PSYCHIATRIC
THIS HAVE INCREDIBLY HARD TIME
FINDING THE RIGHT PROFESSIONAL
TO CARE FOR THEM. IN NINETEEN
THE CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE HELP
FOR THE COMMISSION RECOMMENDED
THE STATE K. TWENTY TWO POINT
9% HI RESIDENTS GRAHAM. AT
WHERE THE LOOKUP. THIS SPECIAL
POURTANT. DATA THAT THE LOWER
WHERE A PSYCH. RECEIVES
TRAINING IS MOST LIKELY WHERE
THEY SETTLE INTO PERMANENT
PRACTICE. WE THINK THAT
ALLOCATION WILL GO AWAY TO
SIMPLY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
PSYCHIATRISTS WE HAVE HERE IN
THE STATE. OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
THOUGHTS FROM MARCH BOND.
PROPOSAL NO OKAY LA. FINANCE NO
ALL RIGHT OKAY I DID HAVE A
ACTUALLY QUESTION AND IT'S TO
RELATED TO A SOMETHING A
PROPOSAL WE'RE GONNA HERE
SHORTLY BUT SINCE YOUR BALL
THEM BOTH I THINK- HOSPICE SO
YOU HAVE THIS PROPOSAL FOR
SCHEMATIC RESIDENCIES AND THEN
THERE'S GONNA BE LATER REQUESTS
BUT YOU'RE DOING WITH. FINGER
IN SOME WAYS BUT I MEAN THEY
ARE OVERLAP OKAY SALUTE LEAD
THIS IS REALLY IDENTICAL TO ONE
HALF OF THAT PROPOSAL OKAY WE
WERE BOTH WORKING IN THIS YOU
IN. WE DIDN'T GET CORN OKAY
TIME ALL RIGHT BUT WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER OKAY NICE
RIGHT OKAY THAT THAT'S HELPFUL
TO KNOW OKAY AND- IN TERMS OF
THE- OF. GIVEN THE ENDING SO
HOW MAY BE SHOWS LIKE I TO.
WITH FROM THIS PROGRAM WITH A
FREE SO FUNDED- BY ONE HAS TO
MINCE IT'S AROUND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY IS WHAT WE THINK- AS WAS.
EARLIER THIS THESE GRANTS WOULD
FUND HA PART OF A RESIDENCIES-
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCIES ARE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER AND THEREFORE
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN PRIMARY
CARE. BUT WE THINK THAT THIS
AMOUNT COULD. FIND ABOUT THAT
MANY BUT IT DEPENDS ON OUT WHAT
LITTLE. THE GREAT SPORT
PROVIDED. THE OTHER THING THAT
WE- HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH YOUR-
FIRST WE HOPE TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRISTS BUT
ALSO ENCOURAGES SOME HOSPITALS
IN TEACHING HEALTH CENTERS TO
MAYBE START NEW PROGRAMS IF
THAT THE CASE. THE NAME MIGHT
BE YOU'RE FREE THOSE HELP IS
STILL TO HELP THEM GET A NEW
PROGRAM OFF THE GROUND. THE TO
THE TWENTY TWO POINT TWO IS
THAT A- FOR YEARS THAT A ONE
TIME AND WE'RE ASKING FOR A ONE
TIME WENT OKAY. SO THIS IS MY
RESIDENCY PROGRAM DIRECTOR HAD
ON SO- SO YOU EVER PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCIES FOR YEARS. IS IT'S
ONE HI HE BOWS HIS WAY. THEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ADDING
SOME ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO THAT
ONE THAT CLASS FOR ONE YEAR.
WHICH IS A PROGRAM RIGHT YEAH
SO AND THAT IS GONNA APPLY TO
ALL ACTUALLY. SINCE PROPOSALS.
YOU GET. READ THE REVIEW TO
EXPAND. HAVE ALL YOU DEMOS IS
THE SHOW HAVE ENOUGH TRAINING
SITES FOR THE PRO AND YOU'RE
DOING THAT OFFER A- YEAR RIGHT
NAY SAYING THE NEXT YEAR MY
RESIDENTS ONLY HAVE THE CLASS
OF WEBER TWO THOUSAND AND THE
SOMETHING IS GOING TO BE.
PEOPLE SAID OF THREE PEOPLE
FROM. THREE FIVE TO THREE THREE
SO. WELL I IS SO. REALIZE THAT
YOUR SOFT DEALING YOU I WAS IN
THE PROCESS ONE TIME. BUT
THINKING OF WILLIAM EFFECTIVE
USE OF A FUNDS WE GIVE. AND
THERE IS THAT TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE USE IT IN A WAY
BECAUSE IN A WAY. IT'S HARD TO
REALLY EXPECT TRAP RESIDENCY
PRO RIGHT AS THE THAT.
TRAININGS AT. YOU YOU NEED
ACTION MAKE MORE OF US IN THE-
GRADE BECAUSE YOU THIS REALLY.
YOU HI IT'S A- OF THE CLINICAL
VOLUME THE VARIETY DIFFERENT
CASE BECAUSE WHEN THEY COME OUT
THEY HAVE TO HAVE HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE SO- SO YEAH. ALL
THESE INSURANCE IN ORDER TO.
BUILD YOUR CITY AND TO DO THAT
JUST FOR ONE. CLASS EIGHT. THIS
IS A LOT WORK. AND I'M AND I'M
A CONCERNED AT THE RED THE
WHIMS OF CELLS AND GO. IS THAT
IT'S NOT GONNA BE WORKS THAT.
PUT ALL THAT THEY CAN BE A HOW
FAST THE MOVE THE CAN I PUT ALL
THAT TOGETHER A QUICK. RIGHT I
CAN'T MATCH. ADDITION RESIDENTS
UNLESS UNTIL I HAVE APPROVAL TO
DO THAT SO. YEAH AND WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT SHOULD SHOULD WE
BE ABLE TO GET THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WE CAN. BUILD ON
WHAT THE WHAT. GRANT WILL FUND.
AT LEAST BUILDING AND THAT. ON
THAT I YOU I MEAN WE MAY BE
COMING BACK. TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND ASKING FOR MORE BUT BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S DIFFICULT.
PARTICULARLY THE HOSPITAL OR
HEALTH FACILITIES LOOKING AT
STARTING A NEW PROGRAM. THEY
NEED TO KNOW THEY'VE GOT SO
PREDICTABLE YEAH LOUIS ESTARá
HOLE IN THE START A WHOLE
PROGRAM FOR FUNDING WITH ONLY
ONE CLASS AND A HALF SO WE DO
SO I THINK WE- WHICH IS A REAL.
IN OUR PROCESS IT'S EASIER TO
ASK FOR A- I AM. GONNA MAKE
EFFECTIVE THE MONEY REALLY EVEN
IF IT'S LIKE ONE TIME THAT
STRETCHED OUT OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS OF. THOSE SB SEARCH OVER
ONE CLASS FOR YEARS READY
MULTIPLE CLASSES THEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIVE SIX SEVEN.
CENTER THAT OKAY THANK YOU. NOW
SEE BY UP HERE LATER OKAY NEXT
TO PROPOSAL IS AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE SO
ISSHIN REGARDING IF THIS
PRACTICE CLINICIAN CAN IN
TRAINING TO IMPROVE ACCESS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES RIGHT.
WELCOME IF THE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF WHERE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPTION IS BECAUSE YOU TODAY
MY NAME IS BETH NON OWSKI
DIRECTOR OF GOT CALIFORNIA FOR
MAKING PROCESS. I HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE MORE THAN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED ME HEALTH
CENTERS THE PROVIDE COMFORT TO
QUALITY CARE TO SIT TWO MILLION
COPIES ONE IN SIX CONFERENCE IN
FACT- I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT TO
PRESENT THREE PROPOSALS WHICH
ARE ALL COURT PONENS THAT MAKE
ABOUT FREE HEALTH CARE WORK
FIRST AND OURS DIGITAL. THIRTY
TWO IT ABSOLUTE. SO START WITH
THAT FIRST ONE. THE FIRST THING
REQUEST FOR NEW FUNDING FOR
ADVANCED PRACTICE CLINICIANS
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. AS YOU
MAY BE WHERE CALIFORNIA CENTERS
ARE COMMITTED TO USING A CARE
TEAM APPROACH TO GUARANTEE TIME
ACCESS TO CARE. CALL CENTERS.
THE VALUE BENCH PRESSES
CONDITIONS IN PARTICULAR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PHYSICIAN
ASSISTED AS PART OF THAT CARE
TEAM. AND AS PART OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION AS WE KNOW
YOU'RE A PART OF THAT
COMMISSION EFFORT- WAS TO
REALLY INCREASE THE TRAINING OF
THE- PRACTICE. FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OF CSU AND UC CAMPUSES
TO BOTH EXPAND ESTABLISHED
NURSE PRACTITIONER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS COMMITTED TO PRIMARY
CARE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- WE ARE REQUEST
TODAY THIRTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION. TWENTY ONE MIN FOR
EXPANSION AND SIXTEEN MILLION
ESTABLISHMENT TO BE COMMITTED
TO THE SONG BROWN HEALTH CARE
WORK FOR TRAINING PROGRAM. THEN
TO YOU. INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PROCESS TO BURST TO ELIGIBLE US
YOU SEE AND CSU. I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS PROPOSAL DOES
GO OE STEP FURTHER THAN THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS A BY
SUGGESTING THAT POST GRADUATE
FELLOWSHIP OPPORTUNITY. FOR
BOTH NURSES AND PHYSICIANS AND-
ALSO BE FUNDED BY THE STATE TO
SUPPORT THE STATE ABILITY AND
GROWTH OF PROGRAMS. IN THE
FELLOWSHIP FACE A CURRENTLY
THERE ARE NO STATE IN IN POST
GRADUATE FELLOWSHIPS I WILL NOT
THESE POST'S GOT TO FILL START
OPTIONAL PROGRAM. OUR RESIDENCY
LIKE GRAMS WROTE POPPY THE CAN
BE AND ACROSS STATE TO THERE
ARE TWENTY. I DO POSTSCRIPT
TRAINING THIS PRACTICE PERSON
POSITION. I WILL SOME PROGRAM
HAVE LAW PERSON. AGAIN I'VE
KNOWN THERE ARE NO FUNDS AT
THIS TIME TO HELP ESTABLISH
EXPAND THESE PROGRAMS AND FOR
THIS REASON IN ADDITION TO THE
THIRTY SEVEN SORRY THIS IS A
SEVEN POINT EIGHT. FOR THE UC
AND CSU PROCESS ALL DRESSED
ELEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
PEOPLE SIDE IN PARTICULAR FOR
THESE OPPORTUNITY. FOR IS FIRST
THE SITE BROWN. TRAINING%
PROGRAM SO I'LL PAUSE HERE SO
WE CAN TAKE SOME COME TO
FEEDBACK FROM YOU OKAY THE
ASPEN ANY OPINIONS RIGHT LA-
FINANCE OKAY AND THE- AND THE
SO IT'S- IT'S- ONE TIME. BUT
WE'RE STARTING NEW PROGRAMS SO
ANYWAY I GUESS FIRST QUESTIONS
HOW AG BUT THIS INVESTMENT HOW
HOW MANY NEW PROGRAMS AND HOW
MANY- HOW MANY. ADDITIONAL
PROFESSIONALS ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT TRAINING AND- BECAUSE OF
THIS OUR PER YEAR SURE
ABSOLUTELY NOT APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION YOU'RE ASKING HERE IN
THE QUESTION- THAT US ELASTIC
CORD AS WELL AND BLOOD
KNOWLEDGE THAT SIMILAR TO THE
PHYSICIAN PRESENT THE SPACE AND
THE COMMITMENT ISN'T TO BE
MAKING. YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT
THAT HAVE LONG TERM FUNDING
OKAY ABILITY FOR THE GRAHAM IS
THE PRINCE OF AND CERTAIN LATE
JUST REFLECTING ON THE CA
EFFORT. THEY LATER OF AND IF TO
YEAR OF MAINTENANCE TO A WIDE
ACTION FIRST AND- MONDAY IS
OVER. FOR THE PROGRAMS. FIRST
ARE TODAY. I WILL PLEDGE THESE
ARE YOUR RECOMMEND. BANDS OF
THE- NEED. BUT IF. TWO OF. THIS
TRIP CERTAIN. HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT A LAW
TERM. YOU COULD LOW LIKE
SPECIFICALLY IT RELATES TO YOU
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO MANY.
OUR SLOTS COULD SEE AT THE UC
OR CSU CAMPUSES FOR TO
INFRASTRUCTURE- I WILL HAVE TO
KNOWLEDGE A PATH TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT IT WAS SOME
QUESTIONS WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
WHEN THINKING ABOUT THAT. IS OF
COURSE TO DO CAUGHT BETWEEN THE
IN THE CSU SYSTEM PRO. THEY'RE
NOT CHOOSE IT IS SIMPLY BUILD
PROGRAM THEY HAVE TODAY. IS
WHETHER NOT THEY ARE
CONSIDERING BUILDING A
COMPLETELY NEW PROGRAM FROM
SCRATCH ON CAMPUS IS NOT HAVE
ONE TODAY. TO ONE OF KNOWLEDGE
THAT WELCOME SPEAKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND WITH OUR PARTNERS
AND I SPENT L. ELLIE ON DO YOU
HAVE TO TALK MORE ABOUT HOW
THAT COULD LOOK. AND WELL I'M
P. FOR SAID. YOU SHOULD WAIT
BUT AS WELL AS THE- BE A BIT
FORCED. I'M FROM THE MEN OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF HER NURSE
PRACTITIONER OR PER PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT FELLOWSHIP SPOT TO DO
ONE OF KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT'S A
SPECIFICALLY IN THE CASE OF A
PROGRAM THAT EXIST HEY IS
LOOKING TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
SLOT THE TOP ROUGH ESTIMATE
FROM LOOKING OUR MEMBERSHIP.
FIGURE IT BUT HOW. IF YOU'RE-
AT A UNDER THAT MIGHT BE
LOOKING TO START AN AND PIERRE
P. A POSTGRADUATE FELLOWSHIP
FOR THE FIRST TIME. THE DOLLAR
FIGURES ARE CLOSER TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER SLOT- ALSO PAGE
OUT SURVEYING DOES NOT. OPERATE
OR TAKE TO COUNT OTHER
INSTITUTIONS THAT MIGHT CHOOSE
TO STOP TO FELLOWSHIP ON WILL
RECOGNIZE WE KNOW OF. CASES THE
STATE BE A HAVE A STAFF. CAPS
AND OF COURSE BE ANOTHER COMES
IN IN THIS IS A NOT. WOULD LOOK
FOR THEM. SO I THINK IT'S- OVER.
ANY OTHER AMOUNT. HOW HOW MANY
WITH A ARE THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
ESPECIALLY IN IF IN E.
POSTGRADUATE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM- IS THE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT OR NURSE PRACTITIONER
ALLOW ALLOW- BILL THROUGH THE
SUPERVISING- CLINICIAN WELL- SO
SPACE HERE TO THIS POST BUT IT
FELT IT WAS OF WHAT IN SOME
WAYS MAKES IT TO. INDIVIDUAL
ALL I'M SAYING. AND OF BABE. IN
THEIR INSTITUTIONS- BUT
ACCORDING TO THE LICENSING AND
RULES OF PRACTICE THAT EXIST
TODAY WHAT WE'RE SIMPLY DOING
WITH THESE HEALTH CENTER
PROGRESSIVE BUT THE OF THE
CLASS AND IT WILL BE THAT THE
ARE BILL THAT. US TECH WIDE
MORE THAN. FOUR OF HIS
RESIDENCY AREN'T BECAUSE THESE
ARE DOLLARS TO HELL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CREATE THE
PROGRAMMING SUPPORT AROUND
THESE COHORTS OF N. B. A.'S.
RACKED UP ONCE THEY'RE THOSE
DAY ONE CAN BE BILLING FOR THE
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE TO
PATIENTS ALL RIGHT. SO JUST
MAKE NOTE THAT. THE US ON
COURSE THE DIFFERENCE A LEVEL
OF TRAINING BETWEEN POSITIONS
AND- THESE OTHER TEACHERS TO
CORRECT. YES THAT THAT WE DON'T
EVEN ALLOW. EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE
GONE THROUGH MEDICAL SCHOOL
WHICH IS MORE THAN THE OTHER
FOLKS A GUN TRAINING WE STILL
DEMANDING TRAINING BEFORE WE
ALLOW THEM TO INDEPENDENTLY
PRACTICE. OKAY THANK ALL RIGHT-
OKAY SO WHEN WE MOVE ON TO YOUR
NEXT TO PROPOSAL WHICH DEBT
RELIEF FOR PRIMARY CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS I
TINK WE ALSO HAVE. AND OF.
HAPPY TO GET STARTED OKAY
ACTUALLY. GREAT SO- IN TERMS OF
ART SECOND PROPOSAL THIS IS
AROUND THE LOAN FORGIVENESS THE
SPACE- HAS NOTED ALSO BUILDS ON
THE OF THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORK FIRST GEN WE LOOK
HERE IN FACT TO REFLECT TO
INTEREST LIKE HIM COMMISSION
WERE BOTH THE- IN THIS. LINE
CREATION OF A MERGING
CALIFORNIA HEALTH LEADER
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM THERE'S A
BRAND NEW PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE
ESTABLISHED. THE REQUEST IN
TOTAL IS FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS BOTH TO
ESTABLISH THIS NEW PROGRAM AS
WELL AS TO BUILD ON THE CURRENT
LOAN FORGIVENESS
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THE FOLKS
WOULD LIKE A WALK. AT THE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF HAVE
SEVEN MILLION WILL GET BROKE
DOWN. SO HER OF THOSE
INTERESTED ONE TIME FUNDING
REQUEST IN THE DEBT REDUCTION
SPACE. AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING TO
USE ABOUT FORTY MILLION OF
THESE DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH LEADER
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM TO ENABLE
MORE CALIFORNIANS PURSUE
DEGREES AND HEALTH PROFESSIONS
AND PRACTICE. COMMUNITY IS.
DEFINITELY WERE SOLICITING.
ROUGHLY THIRTY MILLION BE PUT
TOWARDS ME INVESTMENTS TO
GUARANTEE THE HIGHER END OF
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS TO PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY THIS. AT AN AGE ALL
ABLE TO BE FUNDED OUR TEAM
USING TO WE RECEIVE FROM OUR
PARTNERS OFSHE THAT AND HEALTH
PROFESSION EDUCATION
FOUNDATION. DENTAL FIGHT AT
THEIR QUITE A FEW LAW REPAIR
PROGRAMS TODAY. AND HAVE ARE.
ELIGIBLE OKAY. THEY DO HAVE A-
BALLARD. AND FOR IT OF INTEREST
TO US MOVE WE CALL OUR AND
MATERIALS THAT WERE FOR YOU BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IS THE
INTEREST IN SEEING ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS PUT TOWARDS THE STEPHEN
THOMPSON POSITION CORNER
PAYMENT PROGRAM. THE LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSE WHEN A PAIR
PROGRAM THE ADVANCED PRACTICE
HEALTH CARE A LOT OF OUR
PROGRAM AND LASTLY THE LICENSE.
HEALTH SERVICE PROVIDER
EDUCATION LITTLE PAYMENT
PROGRAM YOU CAN SEE HERE AND
JUST REALLY LOOKING ACROSS THE
FULL SPECTRUM OF HEALTH
PROVIDERS PRIMARY CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. A DAY I WILL
NOT INCLUDED IN THE PROPOSAL
THE FUNDING FOR THE STATE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM. WHICH SERVES
A WIDE VARIETY OF PROFESSIONALS
THAT ARE WORKING TODAY IT
DOESN'T IT HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE AREA. LAPSLEY ALL THAT
THE IS A DOLLAR FOR YOU ALSO
INCLUDES. ANSWER FRICTION WITH
HEALTH CARE- THAT ADDITION IS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE BOB BACK UP
PLANNED PARENTHOOD FLEETS OF
CALIFORNIA. SO ALL THERE AND
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
VIEW. TOO EARLY OKAY. HE COMES
FROM A SHOT TERRY HELLO FINANCE
ALL RIGHT OKAY. AND EGGS SO
WELL- SO IN TERMS OF THE- SO
THE IN TERMS OF THE INITIAL
COHORTS- FOR THE EMERGING SO
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PIECES HERE- TO ASSIST COVER
TUITION 410% LOSSES ARE DOING
NOW. I MEAN. WHAT THREE KNOW
THIS TELLS LATER SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT. BECAUSE HE GETS
OUT A LITTLE BIT AND AGAIN
WELCOME AFTER TALK ABOUT DESIGN
FURTHER WITH BOTH COMMITTEE-
AND OUR PARTNERS AT AJ BED. OUT
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HEY THAT
THE COMMITTEE. THIS IS THEIR
LOOK AT A VERY WIDE SPECTRUM.
PROFESSIONS AND SO LATE THIS
BREAD OF THE OF. STUDENTS YOU
SEE INTERESTED IN THIS QUESTION
OPPORTUNITY WILL LIKELY IMPACT
AND HOW MUCH IT ENDS COULD
RECEIVE. UP AND THAT. SIMPLY
FACT WE- DIFFERENT. PROGRAMS
BALK SIGNIFICANTLY AMOUNTS OF
MONEY DEPENDING ON THE FIELD
AND SO I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD WANT OF
COURSE WORK THE DETAILS WITH.
ALLEGE WITH OTHER THURSDAY AND
WITH ADMINISTRATION AND
THINKING THROUGH AS WE THINK
ABOUT WATCHING THIS BUT THEY IS
THERE OUGHT CERTAIN SET OF
HEALTH CENTER ONE OF TARGET
INITIALLY AND WITH THAT WASN'T.
GETTING OUR THINKING OUR NAY
SCOTT WOULD BE. AGAIN I THINK.
THE DIFFERENCE. ON THE- OKAY SO
YOU IT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL TO.
QUALITY A LITTLE BETTER WHAT SO
WE HAVE A DOLLAR AND BUT
EXACTLY WHAT WE GET OUT OF THAT
DOLLAR AMOUNT SO OKAY AGAIN THE
10% VISION I WILL NOT JUST OVER
TEN YEARS OF INVEST. THE VISION
OKAY INDIAN THEM. TO GET A ONE
TIME. ALL RIGHT. SO WITH ALL
CHALLENGES THAT COMES FOR
ESPECIALLY HEALTH PROFESSIONS
TRAINING WHICH IS EXTENDED OVER
TIME. OKAY ALL RIGHT WE GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO THE
PRIMARY CAREGIVER HEALTH
RESIDENTS INVESTMENT. GREAT
THANK YOU. SO AGAIN I'LL SPEAK
TO MY FINAL PROPOSAL TODAY
WHICH THAT SPEAK TO THE PRIMARY
CARE AND PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY
PROGRAM SPACE- AS YOU ARE WELL
AWARE- THE COMMISSION DID SPEAK
AS WELL TO NOT ONLY A MINUTE
INVESTMENTS THAT HAPPENED TO
DATE AND SAFER GEN THAT EVEN
MORE INVESTMENT OR NEED IT AS
YOU HEARD FROM MICHAEL PARTNER
AT THE COFFEEHOUSE ASSOCIATION
EARLIER WE- NEEDED BOTH THE
PRIME MAKE. RED SPACE. EARLIER
TWENTY TWO POINT TWO MILLION
FOR PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY THOSE
FUNDS TO BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY GRANT
PROGRAMS REFERENCED EARLIER AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT CHANNEL TWENTY
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
INVEST TO MOVE TOWARD TOUCH PAD
FOR NEW PRIME RESIDENCY FOR
MEN'S UP. ON HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAM AND
I WANT TO MAYBE JUST A
KNOWLEDGE AND TACKLE SOME WAYS
THE COMMENT YOU MADE EARLIER IN
TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT- JUST
THE DOLLAR- THAT GO TOWARDS-
THE PRESENCE HE PROGRAMS- AS
NOTED IN THE COMMENTS EARLIER.
THANKS IT HAS DIRECTLY. TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PER SLOT I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE AS- SONG BROWN IS
INVOLVED IN RECENT YEARS WITH
THE THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WE HAVE SEEN IN
DIFFERENT DOLLAR FIGURES GOING
TOWARDS. BOTH EXPANDED SLOT
EXISTING PROGRAM VERSUS BRED
PROGRAMS AGAIN RCOGNIZE THE
FINANCIAL- INVESTORS EITHER BY
THE TO SAN AND CERTAINLY
WELCOME THE CONVERSATIONS ALL
OF YOU IN TERMS OF. WHAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO GET. A FIX UP ALL
THIS IS BAD BUT- CERTAINLY I
JUST EXPANSION. WE DON'T HAVE A
STRONG. PLAYING WE ARE AWARE OF
INTEREST FOR NEW PROGRAMS THE
TEACHING HEALTH CENTER SPACE
WHERE AGAIN WE SEE COULD YOU TO
STRUGGLE IN FEDERAL FUNDING-
AND ALSO IN THE BROADER JUST A
WHOLE SYSTEM SPACE WHERE HEALTH
CENTERS ONE OF THE PARTNERS. TO
HOSPITALS AND OTHER PLAYERS
INSTANT WHEN THE START
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS BUT DON'T
HAVE THE FINANCIAL STABILITY
THEY KNOW THEY NEED. TO THAT
INITIATIVE. PLEASE READ THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL AND THE ONLY
THING I WOULD LIKE TO ADD- TO
MY EARLIER COMMENTS FOR. HAVING
SPECIFIC. I CRIED THREE FIRST
OF ALL WOULD BE- THAT IS THAT
WOULD BE NEW- AND I THINK IT
WOULD WOULD- NOT NECESSARILY.
LAST JUST ONE YEAR THERE ARE
ABOUT TWENTY TWO HOSPITALS
SOMEONE TEACHING HEALTH CENTER
THAT TRAIN PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENTS IF THEY KNEW. THE
SPECIAL FUND FORWARD GEN
PSYCHIATRY GME I THINK THEY
MIGHT BE ENCOURAGED TO. FUND
ONE OR TWO ADDITIONAL AND THEN
A YEAR LATER ON OR TWO A DAY
AND ALL EIGHT GRANTED ONLY DO
THIS FOR A FEW YEARS WITH.
TWENTY MILLION BUT THANK YOU IT
WOULD BE YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ACTUALLY GET THERE AGAIN THE
ESSENTIALS WITH SO WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS REGARDING
RESIDENCY TRAINING POST
GRADUATE FELLOWSHIP TRAININGS
THAT CENTER- I MEAN YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THESE THROUGH
SONG BROWN AND THE THOMSON AND
OTHER TYPE PROGRAMS- THING ONE
TIME. BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE IN
DECISIONS UP A THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST BY MEANS IS IN TERMS
FOR THE TECH A ASSISTANCE POINT
OF VIEW. WE DO DECIDE TO SAY
DOES DECIDE WE CAN AGREEMENT TO
DEFY IN THE THINGS I MEAN HOW
YOU SEE. LUCIFER THE WAVE
STRUCK THE FUNDING FROM YOUR-
WITH WITH HAVING SUPPORTED BUSY
TRAINING PROGRAMS. COMMENT ON
THAT. I SAID WITH THE PSYCH
RESIDENCY PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO STAND UP WE HAVE
HEARD CONCERNS FROM THE-
TRAINING AND COMMUNITY IS A
REPUBLIC IN ONE TIME FUNDING
THAT WE EVEN HAVE FOR WHAT-
THAT SAID THE PROGRAMS HAVE
ALSO INDICATED THAT THEY
CERTAINLY WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN TYING OUT DOWN GIVE ONE
TIME FUND. AT THIS POINT HARD
FOR TO THE EARLY THE JURY A
SUCH ACROSS THE BORDER. IF YOU.
WERE TO TAKE AN- SOUTH OF
EXACTLY HOW THEY'LL FIT
TOGETHER BY I HADN'T. THIS
PRESENT HANS. FOR RIGHT OKAY TO
STIR OF YOUR HELLO. WE DID THE
RELEASE OF A NOW LAW YEAR WORK
FOR PRO CHEN WE DID THAT THE
THAT FUNNY PROVIDED BY A LIMóN
ON A PROVIDE A LIMITED TERM
BASE TO ALLOW ALLEGES TO RE OF
WORK FORCES AND SO FORTH NOT
MISS AS A YEAR BUT TO ME FLEX
IN IN YOU KNOW ASSESSING HOW
WITH THE WORK FORCES WHEN WIN
FOR ME IN THIS IN THIS. AND
THEN WE DID ALSO NO THAT
SPECIALLY IN SO FAR AS THIS
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE USED TO
STEP NEW PROGRAMS THAT THAT
MEDICARE TAKE UP SO OF THE ON
GOING LOSS OF. BEING THOSE
OPERATIONS GOING ON ON AN
ONGOING BASIS S RICH SIR IT'S
AND IF I BAND COULD GET UP
BROWN. THANK YOU I THINK THE
MOTHER THE BALANCE BUDGET ACT
OF FORGOT WHICH- IS THE ONE.
AND IT MAKES CHALLENGE FOR
MEDICARE TO PAY IT UP IF CAP
THE NUMBER OF VISITS SO YEAH
EXTINCTION. YEAH EXCEPT FOR AT
THE NEW THE NEW RIGHT THAT
DON'T HAVE. THAT'S WHY WE THINK
WANT FUNDING BE USED FOR THIS.
PURPOSE YEAH I SO THE TV A
BASICALLY A OTHER PROGRAMS
BECAUSE- AND SOME STE QUOTE GET
AVAILABLE SO YOU PROGRAM IT
MIGHT BE A TO BUT- THAT BUT THE-
THAT. NOT TERRIBLY CALM FOR.
THAT DID YOU THIS IS IN NINE
NINETY. YEAH I THINK EIGHT OR
NINETY. IT'S LATE AT. SO YEAH
HOUSE MAKE ANOTHER DISTINCT
WHICH IS AND RELEASED THE
TEACHING CENTER FOR AND FOR.
THE RECOGNIZING THEIR HOUSE ON
ARE SERVING UP. MEDI CAL AND
INJURED. WELCOME THAT
DISCUSSION YEAH WE CAN AT THE
WILL LEAVE WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION TO. ALL RIGHT SO
ALL RIGHT OKAY. THANKS VERY
MUCH OKAY WE FINALLY HAVE THE-
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE EXPANSION AND WE
HAVE. THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES HERE THE. WELCOME. SO
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY TESTIFYING YET THREE
MINUTES TOTAL OKAY THE FIGURE
THAT OUT. OF SAYS- DONATED
BECAUSE WERE POPULAR COULD GO.
WE WANT TO RESPECT YOUR TIME
LIMIT SO- I WILL PROVIDE THE
TESTIMONY AND THEN I HAVE FOLKS
FROM THE CO SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS HERE FOR- ANY
QUESTIONS OR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
SEC AFTERNOON AT GERMANTOWN AND
US SENATORS- I'M WE UNDER THE
CAR BE THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNT LOOKING AB HOW
THEY- AHA. PERCENT A ACROSS
WHICH PROVIDE HEALTH SUBSTANCE
DISORDERS WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
LETTER IN SUPPORT OF OUR
REQUEST TO EXPAND THE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER WORKFORCE BY
ALLOCATING FOUR POINT SEVEN IN
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO THE
ADMINISTRATOR TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY OFSHE BUT
TWENTY SIX TENS OF SIGNED ON IN
SOME. AN IMPORTANT FOCUS TODAY
AND I. THE FOCUS ON THE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE THERE'S ALSO
A GROWING CRISIS AS IT PERTAINS
TO THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORK
FOURTH THOUGH 8% OF
CALIFORNIANS MET THE CRITERIA
FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER IN
THE PAST YEAR ONLY ONE IN TEN.
TREATMENT THEN SEVEN HUNDRED OF
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS WHO HOLD A
CALIFORNIA LICENSE MAINTAIN AN
ADDICTION SPECIALTY
CERTIFICATION. THE TWENTY
TWENTY NATIONAL CONTROL DRUG
STRATEGY REPORT INDICATES THAT
QUOTE BUILDING THE ADDICTION
TREATMENT WORKFORCE IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT WAYS TO
ADDRESS GAPS AND TREATMENT. SO
THIS PROPOSAL THANKS TO A COMP.
THREE ONE ONE I PROVIDING
TUITION REIMBURSEMENT AND TEST
WAIVERS. FUNDING THE LANGUAGE
TRANSLATION OF EXAMINATIONS IN
ORDER TO SUPPORTER
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE
APPLICANT POPULATION AND THREE
CREATING A SIDE WORK FORCE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO EXAMINE THE
BREATH OF THE WORK FOR SHORTAGE
AND IDENTIFY BARRIERS FOR ENTRY.
SO WE WERE OFF YOU THE ADMIN IN
A THOUGHT WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WERE WITH ANY OTHER ELEMENT.
DOORS AS A PROPOSAL MOVES TO
THE SPOT THANK YOU. THE YOU.
BEGIN THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS I JUST WANT TO
PAINT A PICTURE OF THE UNMET
DEMAND TO- SHOW THE URGENCY OF
THIS ISSUE ALTHOUGH WE ARE
DEALING WITH THE COPA DO A TO
MAKE WE ARE ALSO IN THE MIDST
OF. BUT AMERICAN INCREASE. I
WANT. TO MAKE ON THE HORIZON WE
HAVE AN INCREASE SOCIETAL
ACCEPTANCE OF TRIMMING WHICH IS
DRIVING MORE PEOPLE TO GO INTO
TREATMENT. WE HAVE PROP SIXTY
FOUR FUNDING COMING AT UPWARDS
OF A EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS EVENTUALLY WHICH IS
DEDICATED TO. TREATMENT OF
YOUTH WE HAVE TREATMENT
EXPANSION IN JAILS AND- BOB.
FOR FURTHER TO AND FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
IN SCHOOLS. WE HAVE THE CAL AIM
INTEGRATION PROGRAM WHICH CALLS
FOR MORE SUBSISTENCE. DISORDER
PROVIDE ME SPREAD THROUGH A-
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICS. WE HAVE
A- THE GOVERNOR'S PLANS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE
THE MEASURE YOU PASSED LAST
YEAR TO PUT A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CANCER IN EVERY. ROOM
AND THE STATE WHICH DON'T HAVE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WHERE MOST
INDUSTRIES DURING THE NIGHT
COMING DOWN TERM WAS CHAU
UPLOAD A NEED FOR EMPLOYEES.
IT'S OPPOSITE ADDICTION
TREATMENT AS THE ME IS ON THE
VERGE OF SLOW. OUR NUMBERS ARE
GO MUCH HIGHER PEOPLE'S UNMET
NEEDS MEANT SHOW UP WHEN
THEY'RE UNEMPLOYED SO WITH ALL
OF THE THINGS IN MARIN AND KEEP.
WE TO SEEDOLLARS. CATEGORY.
DID YOU. GET HI WORKFORCE THAT
MANY FOR CAT MA E. L. L. A PRO
AND ANGELES COUNTY SO THE ONLY
THING I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
SAY IS THAT THERE'S AN EXTREME
WORKFORCE PROBLEM IN LOS
ANGELES AND THERE ARE NO FUNDS
FOR CALIFORNIA ANYWHERE FOR
WORK FOR SHORTAGE FOR.
COUNSELORS WE MAY OF THE
CALIFORNIA OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES WE ARE ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND JURORS APPROACH
FULLER. THANK YOU THANK YOU. US
VIED ANY DOCTOR OPINIONS ARE
EIGHT. AVAIL FINANCE BILL OKAY.
RIGHT THAT CERTAINLY. HILL
KINDS OF THE- LACK OF FUNDING
FOR TRAINING IN AND SHORTAGES
IN THE AREA SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR PRESENTATIONS- AND-
NO SMALL- HOLDING ALL THE ITEMS
OPENS UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ARE WITH THAT THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
ISSUES REDUCE IT TO- THAT.
PLEASE COME TO THE MIKE.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF I GET
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN AM JDS
HERE ON BEHALF OF SCA YOU
CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON TWO THINGS FIRST ON
THE PRESENTATION OF AWESOME
HEAD WITH REGARDS TO THE HEALTH
CARE. PAYMENTS DATABASE AS THE
IDEA IT HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
WE DO SUPPORT ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDED TENS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT FORWARD BY THE COMMITTEE
ALTHOUGH WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU KNOW DOUBLES ARE IN THE
DETAILS AND WE LOOK VERY MUCH
FOR TO. ONLY THE BUDGET CUTS
STATE AS WELL AS THE SHINS
AROUND. NG IT FINALLY. STATE
I'D YOU MEANT TO BE ARE THE
SECOND THING I LIKE TO READ SO
ON IS THE BCP PAPA FOR SB TO
FORTY TWO WE WERE THE COAST OF
THE BILL AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
THEIR SHIP ON ISSUE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELCOME HI ADDRESS
MIGUEL ON A PLANE HERE IN
PHILLY TO CALIFORNIA- JUST WANT
TO MENTION DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT OPPORTUNITY THAT WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO BE WORKING
WITH THEPRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION ON WORKFORCE.
PLEASE THAT PERTAINS TO THE
ADVANCED PRACTICE CLINICIANS-
AND THEIR DEBT IF AS YOU KNOW
THE PLAN HER HEALTH CENTERS AND
OTHER COMMUNITY CENTERS ARE A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SAFETY NET
WE HAVE. MORE THAN 86% OF ALL
PATIENTS AND THEIR- FUNDED BY
PUBLIC ROOMS. GIVE MY- AND- TAX
AND EVERY WOMAN. AND SO. YOU
KNOW. WITH THAT WE ALSO HEAR
FROM THE AFFILIATES THAT THEY
HAVE PROBLEMS AND RULE URBAN
SUBURBAN ENVIRONMENTS A LAKE
WITH RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
DUE TO THE TIGHT JOB MARKET-
AND SOME OTHER FACTORS OF. THE
SAFETY NETWORK PLACES SO- WE'RE
YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY HOPING
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME- SOME
SHORT TERM FUNDING ON ON THIS
TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S-
YOU KNOW ADEQUATE STAFFING OF
THESE- IMPORTANT CLINICIANS
WITHIN THE SAFETY NOT. AT ALL A
KEY HEALTH CENTERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS WELCOME. AND
ASKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE TO SUPPORT
VOICE SUPPORT FOR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM THE ONLY WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT PROVIDE
FUNDING AND SUPPORT FOR PRIMARY
CARE FAMILY PHYSICIAN LOOKS
LIKE ONE US LOT OF SONG BROWN
CREATE SIX HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
PATIENT VISITS PER YEAR JUST IN
THE TRAINING TIME SO IT SEEMS
THAT THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TO BE HAVING PER SE ABOUT
GETTING. A TIME WITH RIGHT. CAN
YOU COMPETITIONS ON THIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU WELCOME KELLY
BEING OVER HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
I APPRECIATE THE TEARS
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE EXISTING
JAMIE RIGHT AND SEES LOTS AND
ALSO LOOK PAYMENT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE ANY NEW- BEING. BE A
SERVICE DEPARTMENT LIKE OTHER
LOAN REPAYMENT SERVICE-
REQUIREMENTS AT SO I WOULD SAY
THAT ON THE DMB RESIN BUT G.
CLOAK. I CAN MENTION TECH THAT
WILL. OF I'M WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE COME THINK YOU. THANK YOU
WELCOME. LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER LAW AND- WE TO SUPPORT
THE ALL PAYER CLAIMED. AS WELL
AS ISSUE THREE WE SUPPORTED THE
LEGISLATION SB THREE FOUR THREE
IN SUPPORT THE BEAST THANKS
THANK YOU. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON RENTAL COMING HERE
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS WE
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTHCARE DATA DISCLOSURE THE-
THREE FORTY THREE AND ALSO
ISSUE FOR ON HOW. CAN YOU BE
BETTER. REPORTING FOR EIGHTY
FOR ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS FROM
MOSCOW ON THE H. B. D.
CERTAINLY HELP ACCESS HAD BEEN
A PART OF THE HEALTHCARE.
PAYMENT IN DATA. THIS ABOUT
THREE PER THAT JUST CAME OUT
EXCITED TO GET TO WORK ON THE
AS- AN IMPLEMENT THE DATA. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CRUCIALLY
NEED THAT WILL ALSO. OUT OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WILL FUNCTION
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- SO WITH.
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ACTUALLY-
THEY DID MENTION SOMETHING I
DON'T THINK OF WE SIR DIDN'T
REALLY TOUCH ON ON THE OVERVIEW
BUT I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT
IS THE OPERATOR. CLAIMS
DATABASE. I THINK THAT THE
THINGS WE CRITICAL FOR US IS WE
ONLY HEARD FROM AFFORDABILITY
WILLIAM HEARING FROM OTHER
FOLKS AS WELL BUT- THAT. THE
AVAILABLE COLLECTING AND MAKING
THAT DATA AVAILABLE IS GONNA BE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO DO
THE KIND OF WORK THAT WE
WANTED. TO THE FOR. USE THE
DRESS YEAH. YOU KNOW I. TO USE
THE- AND COPS ITSELF SO. ONE
SURE THAT WE OF LOST THAT OVER
LIKE YOU DOING KIND OF THING
BUT IT IS A I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING IT'S A HARD WITH HER
FROM THAT'S THE STAKEHOLDERS
BUT- FOR ME PERSONALLY AS WELL
AND BE SURE OF WE POINT THAT
OUT AND APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THAT WAS AT THE- OF. THE
LIMITED. AS QUICKLY. AS
POSSIBLE AND FULLY IS. WE
SHOULD THAT OKAY WELL WITH THE
I THINK THE SO MUCH BEING HERE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO THE
DEMAND IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH. CARE YOU.
WELCOME OFFERS DO INTRODUCTIONS
AROUND THE TABLE FOR EVERYONE.
I GET AFTERNOON MERRY WATANABE
ANOTHER ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT MANAGED
HEALTHCARE HE JENNY PHILLIPS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE THANK YOU
PRIME WILL CELIO BUT IN THE END
ARE ALMOST FINANCE ARE
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN- WITH THE OVERVIEW
AND SAID JUST MAKE NOTE THAT-
SAYS. THE THAT DON'T SERVE HIT
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE THINGS
THE STATE EVEN DONE ARE THINGS
THAT USED TO STATING THAT
YOU'LL BE DETAINED X. HERE ARE-
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS YOU
CAN DO ANY EXERCISE. TRY TO
KEEP THIS THAT WERE UNDER.
ABOUT OUR REPORTS ARE BE PEAS
SO I'M TO JUST PROVIDE A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF OUR DEPARTMENT'S
MISSION IN OUR BUDGET- OUR
MISSION IS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
HEALTHCARE RIGHTS INSURANCE
ABLE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
WE LICENSE AND REGULATE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN HEALTH PLANS. THAT
PROVIDE HEALTH COVERAGE TO MORE
THAN TWENTY SIX MILLION
CONSUMERS WE REGULATE MORE NINE
SIX FOR THE COMMERCIALAND
GOVERNMENT HEALTH PLAN
ENROLLMENT IN THE STATE- OF THE
DEBATE. TOTAL PER. SCHOOL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET IS NINETY
THREE POINTS. IN AND OF. AND
THE OPERATOR POSITION. THAT IT
FOODS ARE FOR BE. WHICH OUT
ABOUT THREE SIX MILLION AND
EIGHT AND A HALF POSITIONS. BUT
APARTMENT ESPECIALLY FUNDED BY
ASSESSMENTS ON HEALTH PLANS AND
RECEIVES NO GENERAL FUND ME- IN
TERMS OF NEW PROJECTS WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY NEW PROGRAMS ARE
PROJECTS UP I KNOW THE- NUMBER
OF HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS WILL
BE ON GOING FOR TH DEPARTMENT-
I'D BE HAPPY TO GO THROUGH EACH
OF OUR PROGRAM AREAS BUT I
THINK YOU HAVE A SUMMARY ALL.
I'D LIKE A GOOD. RECORD ABOUT
OUR- PARTS. OKAY YES WHAT GO
AND DO THAT OKAY SO TART
STARTING WITH OUR TIMELY ACCESS
REPORT FOR MEASUREMENT YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- I'D LIKE TO
JUST NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TAKES TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
VERY SERIOUSLY WORK BETTER TO
HOLDING HEALTH PLANS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE TIMELY
ACCESS TO POINT WAIT TIME AND
NETWORK ADEQUACY STANDARDS
CONTAINED IN THE KNOX KEEN ACT.
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR WE
RELEASED OUR TIMLY ACCESS
REPORT FOR MEASURE YOUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
KEY FINDINGS FROM THE REPORT
WHICH INCLUDED THE PERCENTAGE
OF ALL SURVEYED PROVIDERS WHAT
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE WITHIN
WAIT TIMES STANDARD FOR BOTH OF
AN HONOR TO APPOINTMENTS FROM
89% 260% FOR LARGER POINT THE
PERSON PAUL SURVEYED HAD
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE WITHIN
THE STANDARDS RANGED FROM 94%
271% AND FOR URGENT
APPOINTMENTS THAT PERSONS OF
ALL SURVEYED PROVIDERS TO HAVE
APPOINTMENTS AVAILABLE IN THE
STANDARDS RANGE FROM 83% 257%
IN REGARD. TO OUR BUT HEALTH
PLAN THE PERCENTAGE OF ALL THE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE APPOINTMENTS
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE WAIT TIME
STANDARDS FOR BOTH URGENT AND
NON URGENT RANGED FROM 80% TO
SEVENTY THREE PERCENT. FOR NON
URGENT APPOINTMENTS THE
PERCENTAGE OF PROVIDERS THAT
MET THE STANDARD WORK OP RANGE
FROM 90% TO EIGHTY TWO PERCENT.
AND THEN FOR URGENT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THE
PERCENTAGE OF ALL SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT APPOINTMENTS OF
IT WITHIN WAIT. UNDER RANGE
470% TO SIXTY 4% AND LATER THIS
YEAR PROBABLY THE NEXT MONTH OR
TWO WE WILL BE PROMULGATING A
REGULATION TO ESTABLISH A RATE
OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS. THAT ALL
HEALTH PLANS MUST MEET ONCE THE
REGULATIONS ADOPTED THE D. MHC
WILL HAVE A STANDARD TO WHICH
HEALTH PLANS WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS WE WERE ABLE TO COMPARE
HEALTH PLAN PERFORMED ACROSS
THE PLAN AS WELL AS INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH PLAN PERFORMANCE YEAR
OVER YEAR. THE FOLLOWING SURVEY
BUT THE METHODOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS WERE INCLUDED IN
OUR REGULATE. I JUST OF THE
COUPONS. UP TO REDUCE PER BURKE
HEALTH PLAN USE SINGLE. EIGHT
PROVIDER SURVEYS ON BEHALF OF.
MANY OF ON SO WE CAN REDUCE.
ALSO WERE IN CURBING HEALTH TO
USE A DE MATH OTHER THAN PHONE
CALLS TO OBTAIN APPOINTMENT
AVAILABILITY INFORMATION. AGAIN
TRYING TO REDUCE THE BURDEN ON
PROVIDERS ARE ANSWERED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS- WE'RE ALSO
ENCOURAGING COORDINATION
EFFORTS BY HEALTH PLANS TO
ADVISE PROVIDERS REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESPONDING TO
THESE SURVEYS WE NEED TO GET A
GOOD RESPONSE TO ASSESS
AVAILABILITY ALL. ALLOW FOR
SURE SOME VISIT. RIGHT PRIVATE
CARE PROVIDER SAM AND AGAIN-
THE PROPOSED REGULATION WILL
ALSO INCLUDE A RATE OF
COMPLAINTS STANDARD THAT WILL
BE APPLIED TO EACH HEALTH
PLAN'S NETWORK- THIS IS A
DISTINCTION FROM HOW WE
CURRENTLY REPORTS THE DATA
WE'RE REPORTING NOT AFTER
AGGREGATE LEVEL. SO MEASURE IN
THE RATE OF COMPLAINTS AT THE
NETWORK LEVEL WILL ALLOW US TO-
REALLY MEASURE ENROLLEES ACCESS
TO THE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
BASED ON THE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
AVAILABLE SO THAT ALL NETWORKS
MOST HEALTH PLANS ALREADY
SUBMITTED THIS WAY. AND FOR
SYSTEM SEE THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO LOOK AT HOW WE CURRENTLY
COLLECT AT FOUR I KNOW NETWORK
IN THAT PROCESS WE EVALUATE THE
NUMBERS TYPES AND LOCATIONS OF
PROVIDERS IN A SPECIFIC
NETWORK- THIS WILL ALSO ALLOW
US. SPECIFIC FEED TO THE HEALTH
PLANS WERE WHICH PROVIDER TYPE
THEN A NAP IN WHICH SIR. AS NOT
THE TIMELY ARE STANDARDS AND IT
WILL ALLOW US TO TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION WHEN PLANTS
ARE NOT MEETING THE RATE
FINANCING. REQUIRE DIVAC SPLIT
IN. AND TESTING SHOP PLEASE.
OVER THE PAST BUT FEW YEARS
WE'VE WORKED WITH INCLUDING OUT
THE HEALTH PLAN AND PRO. TO DO
US METHODOLOGY AND RATE OF CA.
THE DEBATE SEE WHAT MOVIE FORM
REGULATION PROCESS IN THE
SPRING AND STAKEHOLDERS WILL
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON THE PROPOSED RIGHT
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW
OF THE LATEST REPORT AND
ACTIONS CAN MOVE B SIX REPORT
IS SEVENTEEN TO GO FINISH
EVERYTHING IN WE'LL ASK SOUNDS
GOOD OKAY. OF SO SB SEVENTEEN-
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN GOV BROWN
I'M SIGNED S. SEVENTY LAW WITH
THE GOOD INCREASING TRAIN THE
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW SCRIPT
AND RIGHT OR IMPACT THE OKAY.
AS SEVENTY REQUIRES HELP BY
RATED XIN WITH THE DIEM TO A
REPORT SPECIFIC DATA RELATED TO
COST COVERED. DRUGS THE BILL
ALL REQUIRES A DAMAGE TO
PREPARE AN ANNUAL. I'M RIGHT
DATA AT THE IMPACT PER DRUG
COSTS AND HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS.
ANNUALLY COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS MUST REPORT THE TWENTY
FIVE MOST FREQUENTLY PRESCRIBED
DRUGS THE TWENTY FIVE MOST
COSTLY DRUGS BY TOTAL ANNUAL
SPENDING AND THE TWENTY FIVE
DRUGS WITH THE HIGHEST. IN YEAR
IN TOTAL IN. THEN BY CHORUS
GENERIC BRAND SPECIALTY DROPS.
HEALTH PLAN ALSO REPORTED IT.
ROTH AFTER COSTS AND HELP
PREMIUMS. TO DATE THE DAY THE
RELEASED RE THAT SOME.
INFORMATION WITH THEM RECENT
BEING RELEASED IN JANUARY AGAIN
OF THE SHARE. THE DMA SEES
REPORT FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORTING YOU PUT INFORMATION
FOR TWENTY SIX HEALTH PLANS.
THEY COVER APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
POINT THREE MILLION CALIFORNIA.
IN DEVELOPING THE REPORT THE
DMA TO CONSIDER THE TOTAL
VOLUME OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
PRESCRIBED AND THE TOTAL COST
BY HEALTH PLANS THESE DRUGS. ON
BOTH AN APT SPENING LEVEL PER
MEMBER PER MY- THEY SAID. I'M
ALL. BUT THE IN THIS REPORT
NODDING COSTS FOR PRESS DRUG
ADMINISTERED IN A HOSPITAL OR A
DOCTOR'S OFFICE OR OTHERWISE
PAID FOR THROUGH A CAPITATED
ARRANGEMENT. SO THIS ONLY
INCLUDES COSTS FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS DISPENSED AT A RETAIL OR
MAIL PHARMACY. THE INFORMATION
WE'VE COLLECTED SO FAR SHOWS
THE IMPACT OF PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COSTS AND PREMIUMS IS
SIGNIFICANT. IN THE DEER MEAT
SEES MOST RECENT REPORT HEALTH
PLANS REPORTED PAY NEARLY NINE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THIS REPRESENTED AN
INCREASE OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WHILE THE PERCENTAGE OF HEALTH
PLAN PREMIUM THAT WENT TOWARDS
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS WENT DOWN
SLIGHTLY FROM TWELVE POINT 9%
AND TWENTY. TWELVE POINT 77%
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. LANCE XIN
BROKAW INCREASED BY FOUR POINT
7% AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN- IN
COMPARISON MEDICAL EXPENSES
ONLY INCREASE BY TWO POINT 7%
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OVERALL
TOTAL HEALTH PLAN PREMIUMS
INCREASED SIX POINT 2% FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WHILE SPECIALTY DRUGS
ACCOUNT FOR LESS THAN 2% OF ALL
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS DISPENSED
THEY COUNT FOR OVER HALF OF
TOTAL ANNUAL SPENDING ON
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. AT THE SAME
TIME GENERIC DRUGS ACCOUNTED
487% OF ALL PRESCRIBED DRUGS.
AND ALL THE PRESIDENT A LITTLE
OVER 22% OF TOTAL IN SPENDING
NUMBER XIN DRUGS. AND BRICK
NAMES PARKS WHICH ACCOUNTED FOR
ELEVEN POINT FOUR. NO
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. A COUPLE OF
JUST KEY FINDINGS FROM THE
REPORT THAT ALL ADD- REBATES
FROM DRUG DRUG MANUFACTURERS
TOTALED OVERAL A LITTLE OVER
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. UP FROM
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO MILLION IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- THIS IS ABOUT ELEVEN
POINT 7% OF THE NINE POINT ONE
BILLION SPENT ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. FOR THE TWENTY FIVE MOST
FREQUENTLY PRESCRIBED DRUGS
ENROLLEES PAID THREE PER THREE
POINT 1% OF THE COST OF
SPECIALTY DRUGS. TWELVE POINT
8% OF THE COST TO BRAND NAME
DRUGS AND FIFTY FIVE POINT 7%
OF THE COST OF GENERICS. THE
HEALTH PLANS PAID THE REST. THE
TWENTY FIVE MOST FREQUENTLY
PRESCRIBED DRUGS REPRESENTED
FORTY EIGHT POINT 2% OF ALL
DRUG. DRUGS PRESCRIBED AND
APPROXIMATELY FORTY THREE POINT
2% OF TOTAL AND SPENT IN.
ANOTHER BOTH SEVEN PER TOTAL.
IN THE SPENT ON FOR. DRUGS THE
FIVE MOST COST DRUGS ACCOUNTED
FOR SIX POINT PER. I WOULD NOTE
THAT SB SEVEN. IMPOSE SEPARATE
REQUIREMENTS ON HEALTH PLANS
THAT FALL RATES IN THE LARGE
GROUP MARKET INCLUDING
REQUIREMENTS TO FILE
INFORMATIONAL PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COSTS- IT'S NOT IN OUR SB
SEVENTEEN REPORT BUT WE DID
INCLUDE INFORMATION OUR PUBLIC
MEETING. THAT WE HAD IT ON
LARGE GROUP RATES AND WE JUST
HAD THAT MEETING LAST WEEK IN
SAN FRANCISCO- AND THAT
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. SO THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW BEST BE SEVEN TO
REPORT I BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OR MOVE ON TO THE B.
C. PEAS. OKAY WELL IT'S- SO
COMES MILLION. REVIEW AND RIGHT
FINANCE RIGHT. SO I DID HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT- REPORTS OF
FIRST OF ALL ON THE TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS- I KNOW THIS
IS. STUDIES BEEN ONE THAT'S
BEEN FRAUGHT WITH CHALLENGES.
BECAUSE I FIRST HEARD THIS OF
BASICALLY. THE SAID WELL WE
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE ANY DATA.
RIGHT AND SO AND THEN THERE'S
ALWAYS THIS YEAR OLD BY WELL
COUPLE YEAR LAG ALL RIGHT- SO
IN REGARDS TO FIRST OF ALL THE
DATA COLLECTION- AND THE- AND
THE VALIDITY OF THE DATA- SO
CLEARLY WE YOU KNOW THE TRUST
MANY OF THOSE ISSUES AND YOU
TALKED ABOUT ACTUALLYTRY TO
EXPAND THE WAYS OF COLLECTING
IT TO TRY TO MINIMIZE- BY. YOUR
RESPONSE BRITAIN HAS WE GET
MORE. AFTER I PRACTICE AND THEY
ASK YOU THESE QUESTIONS YOU
LOOK AT A GO I DON'T KNOW. TEAR
GAS UP OF PRACTICE MANAGER
BECAUSE YOU'RE WHAT IT TAKES
ALL THE PHONE CALLS I'M JUST
TOO BUSY SEEING PATIENTS. KEEP
TRACK OF THAT. SO IN TERMS OF
THE. YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DATA REPORTED SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THERE WERE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME INDIVIDUAL
CARRIES IT IT HAVE AN ACCURACY-
BUT OBVIOUSLY IT PROVES BILLION
TERMS OF LIKE DATA COLLECTION
MOVING FORWARD FOR. WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO SO YOU TO TALK ABOUT
DIFFERENT WAYS TRYING TO
COLLECT THE DATA THE DAY TIGER
DE DO YOU FEEL LIKE- WHERE WE
WAS TRYING TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY THAT THEY THAT WORK
LIKE DATING SO YOU DO MENTION
SOME OF THE THINGS AND GET. THE
WORKING. THIS IS A AREA THAT I
THINK WE A LOT OF FOCUS ON OFF
OF THE DAY THAT WAS REAP INTO
FIFTEEN WE COULD EVEN CREATE
PORTRAY WE SEE A GOOD AMOUNT OF
TIME HANDS ON THAT I WHAT KEY
FACTORS THAT WE APPLY.
VALIDATION THIS IS PART NEXT.
VALIDATION VENDOR THE REVIEWS
THAT THERE. WITH THE MATH AT
ALL AND RE. THAT BUT THEY'VE
SUBMITTED WE'VE ALSO PUT IN
SOME. KIND OF- FILTERS ON OUR
SUBMISSION PROCESS THAT WILL
PICK UP SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THE PLANTS CAN TRY TO SEARCH
THEIR DATA TEST THAT TO SO THE
NUMBER THINGS. ON THE RUN AND
OUR TO. THE DAY THAT WE GET IT.
IS CORRECT I THINK PROVIDER
FOR. AND PROVIDE BURDEN
CONTINUES TO A BIGOT. WE SEE
MORE CONSOLIDATION IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF CARS THAT ARE
DOING THESE CALLS FOR THE PLANS.
THANK YOU WE'VE GOT DIRECTORIES
TIMELY OX A NUMBER OF OTHER
THINGS AND SO- I THINK WERE
PROVIDED TO CAN BE CONFUSING
THEY MAY THINK WELL I JUST
ANSWER THE SURVEY BUT YOU MAY
PRINT VENDOR A- CALL. OKAY
THERE'S- REALLY. MAYES BANNERS
IS THERE ANYTHING ABOUT RYING
TO CONSOLIDATE SOME OF THAT SO
THAT INSTEAD OF WRITER BEING
CALLED BY THREE DIFFERENT
VENDORS STAY BY THE DATA AND
NOW ALL THE ALL THE DEATHROW
THEY'RE NOT DO YOU DO NOT SAID
THAT- WELL WHOOSH I'LL SEE.
IT'S NOT A FUNCTION THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD TAKE ON WE
HAVE ENCOURAGE THE INDUSTRY TO
ABOUT A CONSOLIDATED APPROACH-
THIS ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE
HAD IN TWENTY. AS WE ARE THAT
APPROACH THE- GIVE US AT THE-
NEED THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
FOR THE DAY TO THE CO SEND AND
COMES OUT IN THE MIDDLE
DEPARTMENT AS THEIR DATA THAT
IT'S ACCURATE- BUT I DO. AN
AREA. BUT WE'VE ALL FLEXIBILITY
TO DO THINGS LIKE SEND AN
EMAIL- HAVE A PORTAL- ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE HAD
IS THE PRACTICE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS ARE NOT. LEVEL
SOPHISTICATION BERRIES- BUT
WE'VE ALLOWED SOME FLEXIBILITY
THAT AT THAT ADVANCES IN THE
TECH ADVANCES AND WE HAVE MORE
DATA AVAILABLE THAT COULD BE
LEVERAGED TO COMPLETE JUST
MAKING PHONE CALLS. SO THIS IS
REPORTED. DATE WE JUST FINISHED
TWENTY NINETEEN. IS THE TWENTY
THREE THINK THE DATA TWENTY
NINETEEN IS BETTER DATA WE GOT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I HOPE SO MARCH
THIRTY FIRST AS A SUBMISSION
DEADLINE AS LONG AS IT'S ON A
SUNDAY- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
YEARS IS INSIST GOT- WE MADE.
BUT ALL DONE. THE PLAN
HIGHLIGHTED WHERE THE THIS ARMS
AGAIN I OUR HOPE AND EXPECT IS
THE DATA WILL TO BETTER OKAY.
AND THEN. SO YOU MENTIONED
DOING RIG SON THE ACTUAL RATE
OF COMPLIANCE- IF YOU PUT OUT
ANY PRELIMINARY RATE OR
SOMETHING I MEAN WHAT RATES ARE
WE LOOKING AT. SURE TO DRAFT-
AND THAT WE SHOULD- IS A RED
COMPLAINTS A 70% FOR URGENT AN
HONOR GENTE THAT IS NOT IS NOT.
THE RIGHT IT'S COMING THE
PERCENT OF THE NUMBER THAT'S
BEEN. OKAY ALL RIGHT AS IT 70%
IS A HIGH. IT IS A MIA'S IS
ABLE I MEAN I GUESS WE WE'VE
MAY HAVE PEOPLE HERE WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE BILL'S THAT
WERE PASSED WHEN. PUSH THE
EIGHT. I THINK THE WORST OF
THAT STANDARD IS BEING
SOMETHING ASPIRATIONAL I THINK
THE OTHER THING YOU KNOW THAT
AS A MINIMUM PERFORMANCE
STANDARD AND NOW WE'RE SAYING.
THE TIME YOU HAVE TO MEET THE
MINIMUM FORM INSTEAD I REALIZE
THIS. SPEC BY KILL THE TOP IS
THE FIRST. 9% IN THE BOTTOM 67%
AND SO RIGHT NOW THEORETICALLY
AT LEAST ACCORDING TO THE GRAPH
I HAVE TO GIVE YOU SAID 70% IS
ONLY THREE PLANS BELOW THAT-
BUT USE DO YOU THINK ABOUT IT
SAID OF ALL 70% OF TOP OF THE-
THAT. AT QUITE THREE IT'S
THAT'S A LOT THAT'S SO IN THE
AT THE SAME TIME WE TURN AROUND
AND I MEAN I I'VE BEEN ON THE
FLOOR NAY SAID ALL WE HAVE
TIMELY STANDARD SO WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NETWORK ADEQUACY. EXCEPT
ME TO SET ASIDE. SO I'VE MET IT
DOES BEG THE QUESTION A LITTLE
BIT TO ME I MEAN I APPRECIATE
YOU SEE WITH ME AND THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE HAPPENING BUT
IT. AND I GUESS I CAN ASK THE
FOLKS TO SPOT WHO SPONSORED THE
BILL THAT CENTER HERNANDEZ
PASSIVELY THINKING THAT THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A STRETCH
GOAL WHEN THEY PUT THOSE
NUMBERS IN OUR THAT THE MINIMUM
PERFORMANCE THEY WERE HOPING.
WE NOW A LITTLE BIT ACOSTA NEXT
I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS THE
TIMELY ACCESS DINNERS.
GUARANTEE THAT YOU WILL GET AN
APPOINTMENT WITH PROJECT.
WRITER SO EAGER TO REPEAT A
TRUSTED AND THE YOU KNOW WORLD
RENOWNED CARDIOLOGIST- IT'S-
THAT WORK HAS TO HAVE THE
COUPON. TO MEET FAMILY ACCESS
RIGHT. ONE OF THE CRITICAL
PIECES OF THIS THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT STE STICKS MANY. AS WE
TRYING. BASED THE REAL ALL
APPROACH. TO PULL AMPLE OF THE
NETWORK. TO PUT TO. THE TO THE
ACT THE STATE. BOB SO OF THE
CITY IS. BEST UP. WERE SOME
SAMPLE TO DO ABILITY OF THE
SAYS ONE. OF AN INTERESTED
APPROACH IF YOU WERE TO REPEAT
THAT IN THREE ATTEMPTS YOU
WOULD MEET THE STANDARD SO
AGAIN I THINK THERE'S THIS
UNDERSTANDING FOR ITS THREE
HUNDRED PER TO HAVE WRITERS AT.
THE ONE FROM THE VACATION THERE
IN PART TIME THE WHAT SAYS OF.
AVAILABILITY ON THAT AT THE
TIME TO MEET THE ARE STANDARDS
SO FROM A STATISTICAL APPROACH
70% SEEMS TO BE KIND OF THE
APPROACH FOR IF YOU WERE TO
MAKE KIND OF REAP. PROCESS BUT
OR TO. STAND OF THE OTHER PIECE
I WANT TO POINT OUT IS THE
NUMBERS IS A CLEARLY HE SAID SO
YOU'RE SAYING AS SEVENTY
PERCENT- YOUR THEN YOU'RE
SAYING THAT. BASICALLY IF YOU
MADE THREE ATTEMPTS YOU WOULD
GET SOMEONE WITHIN THE- THREE
TAPS SO YOU HAVE TO GO THIS
PROVIDER CAN GET ME AND FIND
THAT PROVIDER THAN WORK AND
AFTER SECURE YET ME AT. BY THE
TIME WE GET TO THE THIRD
PROVIDER ASKED THE THIRD.
AROUND AND BILL WILL YOU GET ME
AND THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME
THAT. PLEASE BASICALLY YOU ARE
COUNTING ON A CHAIN OF THREE
EFFORTS. TO GET YOU IN NO TIME
FRAME OF THE OF THE OF. THE I
GUESS OF THE STATE GREAT THE
**** SPEAKING YES HOWEVER IN
PRACTICE WHAT WE KNOW IS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU MAY CALL AND SAY I
WANT TO MAKE IT A POINT WITH
DOCTOR OWNS AND THEY WILL SAY
WELL DOESN'T APPOINT. WEEKS
FOR. SO WHAT. DO YOU TODAY CAN
SEE YOU IN A WEEK. AND SO I
THINK FROM THE CONSUMER
EXPERIENCE DEEPER AND- DOES IT
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THEY
WOULD MAY BE ABLE TO CONNECT
YOU WITH SOMEONE SO IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN THAT YOU. ARE
MAKING THE DISH TIMES. THE
OTHER SIDE JUST WANNA HIGH.
TALK TO THE NUMBERS THAT ARE IN
THE REPORT. SO WHAT'S IN THE
REPORT IS CURRENTLY AT THE
AGGREGATE LEVEL AND AGAIN WE
ARE MOVING TO A NETWORK LEVEL.
AND AGAIN WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ASSESS. AN INDIVIDUAL HONORABLY
YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO STATE.
THAT WERE OR- THE HMO THE P.
NOT WORK AND SO WHERE WE WILL
BE UP I IN THIS RATE OF A CUP.
SO THAT THE WORK. OF LET US. IN
ON. WHERE GAP ARE WHERE THE- SO
I JUST WANT TO CAUTION A LITTLE
BIT THAT WHILE 70% IS THE RATE
OF COMPLIANCE THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING. IT'S A LITTLE. IN
ORDER IS COMPARISON TO WHAT'S
IN HERE AND SO I THINK WE MAY
SEE MORE VARIATION WHEN WE
APPLIED AT THE NETWORK LEVEL.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL- BUT THEY
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ESPECIALLY THE CHANCE THREE SO
I CAN IMAGINE THAT YOU KNOW HOW
YOU COUNTING THIS LIKE. A I
CALL PRACTICE OF NORMAL GROUPS.
WELL THERE SPECIALTY INTERNET.
THEY SAID WELL DOCTOR SO AND SO
ISN'T IN BUTWE HAVE THIS OTHER
DOCTOR WHO HAS AN APPOINTMENT.%
AND I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD
UNDERSTAND LIKE YOU KNOW I GET
THAT SOMEONE CAPTION NEVER
CENTER AND SO WE GOT SOMEONE IN
THAT'S CHAIN OF TO. DO GOING.
MEANS PRACTICE WELL WE DON'T
HAVE ANY KIDS IN TIME NOW GO
CALL SOMEONE ELSE. BECAUSE YEAH
MAYBE THREE TWO I KEPT AS A
CHAIN OF DO WELL THE PERSON BUT
IS THERE BUT- HAVE SOMEONE ELSE.
YEAH THEN OKAY YOU KNOW I DID
GET MY PERSON BUT AT LEAST I'M
GETTING TAKE CARE OF THE CHAIN
OF THREE IS A LITTLE BIT MORE I
MEAN THERE'S A BIG THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT A THRESHOLD OF ANY
LOOK AT FROM THE THIRD OF AND-
IN BECAUSE- PLEASE THAT'S THE
ONE CALL. ALL RIGHT. THE
DOCUMENT. YOU CHANGING PROVIDER.
THAT SECOND IS THE SECOND CALL
OKAY NAGA FINE NOT JUST THAT
PRACTICE I GOT FIND SOME OTHER
PRACTICE. COULD NOT WHATEVER.
THEIR PARENTS TENNESSEE. THAT'S
NOW SO. THAT MY USUAL GROUP. WE
HAVE A GROUPS HERE SO. I HATED.
STILL LOW WARY ABOUT THE 70% IN
THE RIGHT STANDARD BUT I'M SURE
YOU'LL GET YOUR STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO MOVE TO SEE WHAT HOW
THIS PLAYS OUT ALSO. HI. KATE I
DON'T EVEN MENTION BY NO MEAN
PROBABILITY SO AGAIN WE'RE
TALKING A LOT OF A STATISTICAL
APPROACHES WE- WE NEED A SOUND
SUGGESTS A **** APPROACH TO BE
ABLE TAKE ENFORCEMENT. AND I
WOULD JUST READ. THIS IS ONE
METRIC THEIR USED TO OBSESS AT
ADEQUACY OF THE NETWORK WE HAVE
OUR- ADEQUACY WE HAVE OUR- THE
SAME PROCESS AGAIN. THE PERSON.
THE THRESHOLD. WE WILL PLEASE
FOR THE IS QUICK. ULTIMATELY IS
TO HAVE A CAR ACTION PLAN TO
CORRECT THE- IN THE NETWORK
QUICKLY WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
TWO YEARS FOR THE- RIVER. GET A
WOULD A LOT. HOLD IT WHAT DO
YOU AREAS AS SO WHICH NOW ARE
AND SO AGAIN WE WILL HAVE A
VERY ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
IS YOU KNOW TERRIBLE MAKING IN.
I'M JUST. SOME OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSION WITH
YOU OKAY SO WE ARE FIGURE OUT
THAT HOW THIS THIS A PHYSICAL
AND HELP TRAINS TO WHAT THE
TRANSLATE INTO REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE FOR. SEEKING TO GET
IT WHAT DOES THAT REALLY RISEN
INTO SO I GET THE STATISTICAL.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE- THAT
THE- WALLS ON TIMELY ACCESS
BEEN PASSED MANY MANY MANY
YEARS AGO- SO IT'S NOT THIS IS
SOMETHING IS BRAND NEW. I KNOW
I KNOW. TALK AFTER YEAR WELL I
THINK I THINK THERE IS A DESIRE
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
DO THIS LAW AND YEAH YEAH I
KNOW YOU WORKING TO DO THAT
WITHOUT SOME DATA ISSUES THAT.
ALSO I ALSO THINK NEED TO BE.
IS THEN IN HOW WE PRESENT THEY
ALSOHAVE THIS PEOPLE OF USE
THIS LAW IN THIS AND THE
STANDARD WHICH BY DOESN'T EXIST
YET YOU'RE STILL GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS THAT THEY THAT
THEREFORE WE DON'T HAVE. A
PROBLEM IS IN THE- AIR RIGHT
AND SO WE ARE WE- AT THE- IT.
NETWORK TRAFFIC. DO MORE
ALREADY. AND I'M NOT SURE TO
THAT'S TRUE. RIGHT AND SO I
HOPE THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
BE REALLY CLEAR WITH PEOPLE
THAT HE SAID THIS IS NOT THE
END ALL BE ALL- BUT ALSO IS.
ASIANS AT THE ON THE CLAIM THAT
YOU'VE- DOING SOMETHING I'M NOT
SAYING AND A LOT OF WORK TO DO
THIS. BUT DON'T WE- THAT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT. DEAL WEAVE
SO OFTEN THAT WE HAVE THE
BACKSTOPS TO THE NETWORK
ACTUALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OUT OF
NETWORK STATIONS SUPER. CALL AS
MEDICAL BILLS WILL EARLY
SURPRISE BECAUSE THERE'S FOR
THE PATIENT. THE PLAN MAY NOT
BE SO SURPRISING THEY DON'T
HAVE THE CONTRACT RIGHT THE
DOCTORS ARE HOSTILE MAY NOT BE
SURPRISED HE NEVER GOT A
CONTRACT ANOTHER OUT OF NETWORK
OUT OF CONTRACT. FACILITY
PROVIDER BUT- DE. NETWORK MAY
NOT BEEN DESIGN A NO THAT'S
PARTLY TRYING TO GET AT ME NOW
BEEN THIS MAY HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED IN A WAY THAT CAUSED
THAT TO HAPPEN EIGHT AND SO YOU
ALSO WE HAVE THE STANDARD SO
AFTER WELL MAYBE NOT WE LOOK AT
THAT SO RIGHT. OKAY PARTS OF
THE- ON THE PRESCRIPTION
APPRECIATE THAT NOW- YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU'VE HAD THE
TERMS OF THE- DRUG REBATES OF
PRODUCTS AND ONE POINT ONE
BILLION- SAYS HERE JUST SINCE
ELEVEN POINT SEVEN THE NINE
POINT ONE BILLION SO THAT SO
IT'S A REAL DEBATE THAT THAT
TIME IS A DRUG. TEST BECAUSE
DEBATE. YOU FOR. SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW Z. THE POCKETING IT
ARE SPENDING ON SOMETHING ELSE
SO SOME JUST READ RECONCILE IS
IT NINE POINT ONE MINUS THE ONE
POINT ONE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
SPENDING ON DRUGS OR IS IT SHE
WAS VERY NINE POINT BILLION ON
DRUGS BECAUSE THE REBATE ITSELF.
IT'S NOT I MEAN IT'S REBATES I
MEAN THAT THAT'S NOT THE DRUGS
COSTS THERE SPEND RATE IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO SOMETHING
ELSE I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT INTERPRET THAT. RIGHT YEAH
SO ACTUALLY HAD THE SAME
QUESTION- BEFORE I CAME HERE
AND SO. YES IT IS THAT IT WILL
THE ONE MILLION WOULD BE
SUBTRACTED FROM THAT NINE.
START THE NOT. TO KNOW NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY BILLION
WOULD BE SUBTRACTED FROM NOT.
ONLY DO IT IN THAT WAY TOO THE
IN THEM BECAUSE HE BATES ARE
OUT. I AM. OVER YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PERIODS OF TIME AND
THERE AND MAYBE NOT OR IN THE-
NEAR AS THE SO EIGHT EIGHT.
TOLL. THAT WAY. YES YOUR RIGHT
BE THOUGHT TO FROM THE TOTAL OF
BUT BECAUSE THE COST THERE'S
OUT WE DO KNOW IT THE YEAR THAT
THEY'RE SPREAD WE REPORTED OUT
THAT WAY OKAY SO I THINK I
THINK WE HAVE A FULL THEN IN
TURN- WE ALWAYS SAY BECAUSE
THAT'S- THAT'S LIKE 10% RIGHT.
ELEVEN POINT SEVENTY OLYMPIC 7%
SO THAT MEANS THE ACTUAL SPEND
THE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ISN'T IS
SHOULD BE ELEVEN POINT 7% LESS
BECAUSE I MEANYEAH YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE IT'S COMING
DIFFERENT YEAR ETCETERA BUT THE
BUT THE SO THE NODES DATE THE
GIVEN THE WAY WERE DESCRIBING
IT WERE CUT OVER REPORTING THE
PMR SPENDING ON PRESCRIPTION.
THE YES NUMBER SEVEN HE'S
REBATE WHICH DOESN ACTUALLY GO
TO PAY FOR DRUGS IS GOING FOR
SOMETHING ELSE I MEAN WHETHER
IT'S POCKET SOMEONE'S. BEING
GREEN BAY SOME OTHER THING.
IT'S NOT BEING SPENT SEVEN DID
AT A REALIZE IT'S COMING OFF A
DIFFERENT TIMES IT'S AT AROUND
BUT I MEAN JUST AGAIN FOR.
ACTORS IN TRANSPARENCY I THINK
WE ARE. A REBATE IS NOT THE
SPEND ON PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
THAT ARE ARE ON MEDICATION I
ASSUME THIS PRESCRIPTION RIGHT
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WILL TAKE
THAT BACK FOR FUTURE REPORT
OKAY YOU RIGHT YEAH SO. OKAY SO
I MEAN THERE. AND THEN US SO
ANYWAY WHAT WE WILL BE HEADING
DELVING MORE INTO THIS SAID AT
AT A POLICY HEARING SO IF THAT
BY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
INSIGHTS THIS PROVIDES US. WERE
LOOKING INTO. SING THAT. NOT
FIND IT REALLY INTERESTING THAT.
THAT OF THE TWENTY FIVE MOST
RECENTLY PAID THE PRESCRIBED.
DRUGS THEY ACTUALLY REPRESENT.
THEM SO. WELL UNDER HALF 43% OF
THE TOTAL SPEND SO. YEAH SO
IT'S- BE INTERESTING BREAK THAT
DOWN EXACT BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY
ALSO NOTE THAT MOST OF THE
SPEND DISCOURSES ON. A SPECIAL
BRAG HOW ME THERE'S A SPECIAL
IS THE GENERIC DRUGS WHICH
ACTUALLY WERE MOST PEOPLE TAKE
THE MEDICATION BUT THE FOR A
FAIRLY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE
ACTUAL. SO COSTELLO BUT MOSTLY
IT IT'S NOT THE OVERALL SPEND
ON FUTURE DOES THAT PATIENTS
ARE LOOKING AT THE LOOK IN
THEIR PARTICULAR MEDICATION SO-
ALL RIGHT RANGE THINK OF THANK
YOU RIGHT NOW THE COUNCIL'S
MOVE ON TO THE PIN NUMBER TO
INFORMATION RESOURCES ALRIGHT-
SO OUR FIRST STATUS
ADMINISTRATIVE MAY OUT AT EACH
STATE AND ARE FOR STAB. THE
THEM TO FIVE. TECH OF
INFORMATION AT. ILLEGAL ATTEMPT
THIS FRAUD AND ABUSE THE DAMAGE
TECH IN AND OF SIR MISSION SO
CAN SOME DATA IT OVER FOR
HUNDRED DEVICES INFORMATION
CYBERSECURITY THREATS OF
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY IN
FREQUENCY AND SOPHISTICATION.
THE D. C. HAS RECENTLY GONE
THROUGH INDEPENDENT ACCUSE
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MY
CONTACT WITH BUSINESS ADVANTAGE
SALTINE THE SECURITY ASSESSMENT
CONCLUDED THAT THE TEAM MIGHT
SEE HAD NO SABER SI TECHNOLOGY
IN PLACE 40% OF CATEGORIES AS-
AND 12% OF EXISTING TECH. THE
FALL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN DMX
SUPPORT CREATED NATIONAL EVER
SECURE REVIEW OFF BY THE CENTER
FOR IN. SECURITY THE DAMAGE THE
SCORED BELOW THE RECOMMENDED
MINIMUM MATURITY LEVEL AND
BELOW AVERAGE IN COMPARISON TO
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL
DEPARTMENTS AND THEN AND LAST
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY%
DEPARTMENT CYBER NOT DEFENSE.
TO THE BOULDER POLICE. IN A
FIGHT WHY VULNERABILITY IN SOFT
TECHNICAL CONFIGURATIONS IN THE
MAINTENANCE OF MAINTENANCE OF
OUR TECHNICAL SYSTEMS. MS THIS
PROPOSAL AIMS PRESS THE
ASSESSMENT MEANS LEGISLATIVE
BERMAN STATE. WERE REQUESTING
TO PERMANENT AS AN EXPONENT
TORTILLA OUT OF THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOURTH PURPOSE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. STATE OR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ONE TWO TWENTY THREE
AND THREE HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND ON GOING FROM
THE MANAGED CARE FUND. OKAY
HAPPY IT'S A QUESTION I TELL
YOU LET'S FINANCE. RIGHT I
ESTIMATE- THAT. LITTLE SCARY TO
THINK THAT THE INMATES SEE
GIVEN THE KIND OF DATA YOU HAVE
TO. LET THEM KNOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH THESE OLDER LEASES. AT
THEM. SO WE HOPE TO DO MORE ALL
RIGHT. OKAY LET'S ISSUE THIRTY
THREE. IF YOU. THIRTY ONE. THE
LAW TO HELP. ENSURE OUR A PULL
IN THE INTO AND SMALL GROUP
MARKETS TO SUBMIT RATE
INFORMATION TO THE DAMAGE SEE
PRIOR TO ANY RATE CHANGE. THERE
ARE NO PROVISIONS IN CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO
SUBMIT LARGE RUBRIC KILEY. SUIT
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
RATE IN THIS IS AND RESTORE
JUSTICE. BEGINNING IN JULY. HE
SAID ON REQUIRED THE HELP OFF A
CON PAUL IN THE LAW GROUP
MARKET TO FILE RATE INFORMATION
WITH THE DAMAGE THE ANNUALLY
AND AT LEAST A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS BEFORE IMPLEMENTING A RATE
CHANGE UNLIKE OUR REVIEW AND
VIGILANT SMALL GROUP MARKET AB
SO THIRTY ONE DOES NOT REQUIRE
US TO REVIEW EVERY SPECIFIC
CAUGHT. OLDER EIGHT LARGE GROUP
MARKET STATE THE BILL PRICES US
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
METHODOLOGY BACK SHINS YOU THE
BILL GREAT DOUBLE OR JUSTIFIED
IN ADDITIONS JULY THIS YEAR
HEALTH PLANS FOR TO SPEAK IN
THE RITUALS A GROUP LARA MARKET
WILL BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT.
TRAFFIC IN FOR IT. IT'S THE-
AND THAT STARTING JULY OF NEXT
PACIFIC CONTRACT HOLDERS MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA CAN SEEK MH SO
REVIEW OF A HEALTH PLANS FOR
RAY BEFORE HEALTH PLAN CAN MOVE
FORWARD INCREASED TO THAT'S FOR
THEIR INDIVIDUAL CONTRACT. IT
MADE SEIZE REQUEST I'VE
POSITIONS AND MILLION SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TWO MILLION SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ANNUALLY THAT THEY'RE AFTER
FROM THE MANAGED CARE FUND.
HELLO. FINANCE ALL RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU THAT'S- MOVE ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOR HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
SO HEALTH AB SOME FORTY FOUR AB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR EXPANDS THE U.
TELEHEALTH BY ESTABLISHING
PAYMENT PARITY BETWEEN
TELEHEALTH AN IN PERSON CARE
SERVICES AB SPEND FORTY FOUR
RECOGNIZES THE PRACTICE OF TEL
HELP AS A LEGITIMATE MEANS BY
WHICH THE ROLE IN THE HEALTH
CARE HIS PAPER. IN CONTACT WITH
THE PER AB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
BARS DEBATE TO REVIEW THE- IN
IN. REQUIRES REQUIRE AND HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN CONTRACTS AND
DOCUMENTS REVIEW PLAN RECORDS
REGARDING PAYMENTS FOR
TELEHEALTH SERVICES. AND TO
REVIEW A SAMPLE TELL HEALTH
CLAIMS DURING OUR FINANCIAL
EXAMINATION PROCESS WE'RE
REQUESTING ONE AND A HALF
POSITIONS THREE THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THREE PERRANCE THE
NINETY. FARE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AN ON GOING FROM THE
MANAGED CARE FUND. HELLO ONCE.
RIGHT MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE HEALTH PLANS AND
HEALTH INSURANCE THIRD PARTY
PAYMENTS EIGHTY TO NINETY AB
TWO NINETY ESTABLISHES VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIRD PARTY
ENTITIES THAT PAY HEALTH
COVERAGE PREMIUMS ON BEHALF OF
AN ENROLLEE PUT AN END TO DO
YOU HAVE A FINANCIAL INTEREST
AT STAKE FOR THE THIRD PARTY OR
DISSOCIATED PROVIDER THIS BILL
ALSO REMOVES FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR THIRD PARTIES TO
PROVIDE PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
UNRELATED ALL MAKING EVERY AT
HER TO ALLOW ONE TO CAN RECEIPT.
THIRTY PARTY ASSISTANCE OR FIND
A WHAT COVERAGE. NOT JUST
RESOLUTION. BY OCTOBER FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THROUGH
WHICH PROVIDERS AND HEALTH
PLANS CAN SEEK EVERY BURKE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE OTHER THAN
THE DEFAULT RATE WHICH IS THE
MEDICARE RATE. IN ADDITION THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST RESOURCES TO
PROMULGATE RATE REGULATIONS
RECEIVE PLAN DATA REGARDING
COST SAVINGS AND REVIEW. HEALTH
PLAN EVIDENCE OF COVERAGE
DOCUMENT THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TO VERIFY PLAN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. THE DAY MAKES IS
REQUESTING TO YOUR THE TERM
EXPONENTIAL AUTHORITY OF ONE
MILLION ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND AND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE. MAY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FUND TO JUST ADDRESS THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD. OKAY LU.
HI YES SO ON THIS ITEM WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL BUT WE WOULD JUST FLAG
FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT AB TWO
NINETY WAS ENJOYING
PRELIMINARILY- AND CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED AND- THAT INJECTION
IS LIFTED- SO THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY THAT. YOU MAY NOT
NEED ALL THESE FUNDS BUT WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL AT A POINT
WHEN IT IS LIFTED ON THEIR
STEPS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE NOW-
THE PROPOSAL IS LIMITED TERM SO
AND THAT IS ONE WAY TO ADDRESS
THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND THAT
JUST ONE OF LIKE THAT THANK YOU
FINANCE. YEAH THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LOSS OF BLOOD
LEGISLATURE EMPLOYMENTS- ARE
CARRIED THROUGH THE WHEN I MAKE
SURE THEY WERE PREPARED- WE DID
DO IT TIME LIMITED THAT WE CAN
RE US US. OKAY THE YOU. KNOW
VERY QUESTION WHICH IS THAT-
THAT THEY THINK WE'RE STILL
STUCK IN COURT BUT THEN AGAIN-
I THINK ONCE IT GETS OUT OF
COURT ONE BE SURE WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT IS. IS
THERE SOMETHING IN THE ENGLISH
THAT REFLECTS THAT ARE. ON THE.
THERE IS NOT ANY PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL BUT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER DOING IS CRAFTING SOME
SORT OF- REPORTING REQUIREMENT
OR MAKING- CERTAIN COMPONENTS
OF THE OF THE FUNDING- CONTENT
ON CERTAIN EVENTS TAKING PLACE
BUT- THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
INDICATED THAT THERE ARE STEPS
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
YOU FOR WE COME THAT I'M IN
ORDER TO PREPARE ITS THAT
SOMETHING LET'S. THE NEXT
HEARING DATES ON THIS WILL BE
SOMETIME THIS SUMMER SO WE'LL
HAVE  BETTER PICTURE- FOR US
THERE IS EXISTING WORKLOAD WE
NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY TO GET
SOME OF THESE TEMPLATE SET UP
GETTING CONSULTING PLACE TO
ADVISE US- AND- THE- CRITICAL
PIECES. ESTABLISHED IN THE
INDEPENDENT DISPUTE RESOLUTION
PROCESS AND SO THERE ARE SOME
ACTIVITIES THAT WE WOULD NEED
TO CONTINUE TO DO BUT WILL HAVE
SOME SOME CLARITY THIS SUMMER.
SO WE CAN DO Và RATIO WORK
BEFORE AND OKAY AND IT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL I'M I'M GONNA
WILL PREVAIL CORD WE SHOULD DO
THAT I'D- SO. BUT OKAY. ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD. OKAY THAT'S-
THERE NO STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS.
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ITEMS AROUND THE APARTMENT H.
HEALTHCARE WELCOME. HI HI GOOD
AFTERNOON AND GDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SCA YOU CALIFORNIA.
JUST WANNA SHARE OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE VCP PROPOSALS UNDER.
ISSUE THREE FOUR A. B. SEVEN
THIRTY ONE AND ALSO IF FIVE
FOUR BEAT NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON WENT AWAY WITH STERN
SAID ON ONE PA REGARDING ACCESS
WE DO A THAT THE DATA IS
GETTING BETTER AS ARE THE
REPORTS OF WOULD NOTE THAT THE
HEALTH PLAN OF SAD JOAQUIN AS
WELL AS THE CURRENT SYSTEM AT
THE TOP OF THE- WHERE OUR
LEAGUE THE KIDS. DOT ISSUES
INTER OF EATING THOSE TYPE
ACCESS STANDARD I WHEN WORKING
WITH THAT IN CAN I ADDITION AND
I PARTS TO THE. ON AT
COMPLIANCE RAY WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT THAT THERE WILL BE A
SEPARATE COMPLY RATE FOR BOTH
URGENT AND NON URGENT BUT
SIMILAR TO THE CHAIRED. SEVENTY
PER TO. AND WOULD RECOMMEND.
81% OF AND FINALLY IN WITH TO
THE COMPLAIN BEING BY. IT'S
UNCLEAR AS TO WHETHER THAT. BY
GREW PROVIDER GROUP OUR- LEGAL
AID I. HAVE X. CONCERN WITH.
ALLEN WROTE HAVING CHALLENGE. I
ACCESS SEE. PROVIDE IN THEIR
HEALTH BUT IN A DIFFERENT GROUP
THAN THE AND SO WE WENT
pTHREE. I WON'T BE IF BY NETWORK
MEAN THAT GROUPS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ON ISSUE THREE
SUPPORT THE I LEGISLATION SAW
SUPPORT THE CITY'S OKAY THANK
YOU FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON RUN
HERE BEHALF OF HOW ACCESS QUE
WE CERTAINLY ISSUE THREE OH
LARGE GROUP MARKET RATE RIVER
AND ALL IF YOU KNOW FIVE ON A
TWO NINE. ALSO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSE ON AS
SEVEN IN THE FORWARD TO BRING A
WEEK THE INTO BECAUSE- WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO DESCRIPTION DRUG
POLICY. IT SHOULD ONLY BE UP
COMMERCE UNTIMELY I IT'S BEEN A-
COMING. THIS HEALTHCARE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. RIGHT AT THAT MOMENT THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. IT OKAY- SO NEXT
UP IS GOING TO BE THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- I EIGHT. GOING
TO ASK FOR A TWO MINUTE BREAK
AND I KNOW THAT C. PH ALSO HAS
SOMETHING COMING UP SHORTLY AS
WELL SO WE WANT TO GET YOU GUYS
GOING SO IF YOU WANT TO COME UP
SIT DOWN OR WHATEVER WILL. WILL
BE DOING ACTUALLY AND- FIVE
MINUTES OR SO. OKAY THIS.
OKAY
LET'S GET STARTED AGAIN I THINK
WE ALL ARE BEING TIED UP WITH
THE SAME THING ALL RIGHT- SO
WELCOME AND FOR THE RECORD TO-
FIRST OF ALL LET'S HAVE A ONE
INTRODUCED THE CELLS- AROUND
THE- SO. I'M JAMES WHAT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU. SONNY
ANGEL CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH YOU. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SORRY TO
OF. SEASON FINALE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH YES BRENDA
NEWNESS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OKAY L. L. SONYA
PARTICULARLY- FINANCE CHECKS
WILL FINANCE OKAY THANK YOU SO
WHAT WE START WITH THE CLOVER
YOU IN SO I GUESS SAID THESE OF
THE STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH TELL
THE ACTING. NO IT ALL
PARTICULARLY DURING THESE YES
SO GOOD AFTERNOON SHE AND
MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR SONYA ANGEL
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND PUBLIC HEALTH SIR-
IT'S CERTAINLY AN HONOR TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH MISSION IS
TO EQUITABLY ADVANCE THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE. COMMUNITIES AND WHEN
WE SPEAK OF HEALTH IT'S NOT
JUST THE ABSENCE OF DISEASE AN
INJURED HEALTH IS ALSO AN
OVERALL STATE OF PHYSICAL.
MENTAL SOCIAL WELL BEING. AS
SUCH THE ATTAINMENT OF THE
POPULATIONS OPTIMAL HEALTH IS
AN ACHIEVEMENT THAT ESTABLISHES
A SOCIETY'S COULD PASS FOR
SUCCESS. BUT BEFORE ENGINE TO
THE OVERALL HEALTH OF OUR STATE
LET ME FIRST ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT I KNOW HAS BEEN ON THE
PHONE FOR FRONT OF ALL OF OUR
MINDS AND IN PARTICULAR IN THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR ACTIONS AT THE
STATE HEALTH. DEPARTMENT NOVEL
FROM ABOUT ALSO KNOWN AS- THE
FORMULA ALONG WITH THE OTHER
STATES IN THE NATION HAD IS NOW
ENTERING A PERIOD OF COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION OF THE DISEASE.
COMMUNITY AND MISSION OCCURS
WHEN THERE ARE CASES CONFIRMED-
OF COKE NINETEEN THAT ARE NOT
TRACEABLE TO A TRAVEL HISTORY
TO IMPACT IS FROM AN IMPACTED
REGION AND IT'S NOT TRACEABLE
TO KNOWN CASES. COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION IS NOT UNEXPECTED
AND WE'VE BEEN PREPARED FOR
THIS TO COME FOR SOMETIME. ON
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST FIRST CASE
IN CALIFORNIA WAS IDENTIFIED IN
ORANGE COUNTY. I IT IT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN CASES WERE
IDENTIFIED IN ORANGE AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES THE FIRST
COMMUNITY ACQUIRED CASE WAS
IDENTIFIED ONE MONTH LATER
FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD AND
SOLANO COUNTY. CURRENTLY
CALIPHS HAS ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT CONFIRM TO CODE
SEVENTY FOUR IS OUR- ON. XIN
WELL HAD HOPES THE KELL COULD
BE SPARED THERE HAS ALSO BEEN
THREE DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
COVERT NINETEEN FOR DEATH
EXCUSE ME JUST AS WITH
INFECTIOUS DISEASE DOES NOT ALL
AREAS COMMUNITIES ARE PEOPLE
ARE FULLY AFFECTED STAY AND
COUNTY. OKAY HE WAS ASSESSING
THIS. AND WE'RE PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO THE COMMUNITIES
AS THE SITUATION CHANGES. WE'VE
ACTIVATED THE MEDICAL HEALTH
AND COORDINATION MEDICAL AND
HEALTH COORDINATION CENTER AND
THE STATE'S OPERATIONS CENTER
IS ACTIVATED AT A LEVEL ONE. WE
ARE BRINGING A WHOLE GOVERNMENT
RESPONSE TO THIS COORDINATING
RESPONSE EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY TO
SUPPORT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND THE CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT AS WELL
AS THE- BY PROVIDING AT
INFORMATION. GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS
AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT. JUST
TODAY WE'VE ANNOUNCED A
GATHERING SHOULD BE POSTPONED
OR CANCELED ACROSS THE STATE
FOR AT LEAST THE REMAINDER OF
THE MONTH TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SLOW THE RATE OF
TRANSMISSION OF COVERED
NINETEEN NINETEEN. AND THEIR
SPECIFICS ON THE TYPES OF
GATHERING SO SHOULD BE CLOSED.
BASED ON WHERE WE ARE IN THE
PRO OF THE SEVEN MAKE IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WE IMPLEMENT
SOCIAL THING THIS TO. A IS
SEVEN POURTANT. PENSION TO SLOW
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE. I'D NOW
LIKE TO GO INTO SPEAKING MORE
GENERALLY ABOUT THE STATE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- OVER THE PAST
ONE HUNDRED YEARS PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTION HAS CONTRIBUTED REDUCING
BY MORE THAN HALF THE RATE OF
THAT'S ALL GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA
LIFE EXPECTANCY IS NOW AT ITS
HIGHEST LEVEL IT IS EVER BEEN
SEVENTY NINE POINT FIVE YEARS
FROM THEN. FOUR POINT FOUR FOR
WOMEN COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
WERE ONCE THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH BUT CHRONIC CONDITIONS
ARE NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR NINE IN
TEN DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA OVER
ALL CHRONIC DISEASES AS WELL
INTENTIONAL AND UNINTENTIONAL
INJURIES ARE ALSO THE LEADING
CAUSES OF BENDABLE DESK DEBT
BEFORE AGE SIXTY FIVE. BOTH
RATES OF MERRY HEART DISEASE
AND LUNG CANCER HAS DECLINED
STEADILY AND SUBSTANTIALLY
OVERLAP A RECENT DECADES BUT
GOOD HEALTH IS A BIG IN FOR OUR-
CONTINUE TAKES. THIS HIGH EARLY
DEATH DUE TO CAN. MANY
DISPARITIES IN INEQUITIES IN
HEALTH OUTCOMES EXISTING
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE HEALTH
CONDITIONS OCCUR MORE
FREQUENTLY IN EARLIER AND WITH
GREATER SEVERITY AMONG
POPULATIONS OF COLOR AND THOSE
EXPERIENCING LOWER
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS. BLACKS
ARE TWO TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
DIE EARLY FROM CORONARY HEART
DISEASE THAN WHITES. OTHER
STRIKING EXAMPLE SEEN WHAT
HEARING HEALTH OUTCOMES AMONG
BLACK AND WHITE. IN CALIFORNIA.
AT THE AGE ADJUSTED ALL BECAUSE
DEATH DEATH RATE IN THIRTY IS
30% HIGHER FOR BLACKS AND
WHITES. THESE DIFFERENCES
BECOME EVEN MORE PRONOUNCED
YOUNGEST AGE GROUPS. DEATH
RATES FOR CHILDREN AGES FIVE TO
FOUR OR TO TIMES I AMONG AND
FOR CHILDREN AGE ZERO FOR THEIR
TWO POINT SIX TIMES HIGHER.
ADDRESSING HEALTH INEQUITIES
SUCH AS THESE IS NOT ONLY
CENTRAL TO IMPROVING
POPULATION. IT'S A SENSUAL.
WHAT IT TELLS ME IS UNIQUE AND
CORE FUNCTIONS AS POPULATION
SURVEILLANCE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
USES OUR TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
AND DATA ANALYSIS. LABORATORY
TESTING AND SCIENTIFIC PRACTICE
TO IDENTIFY AND MONITOR ISSUES
THAT AFFECT HEALTH. PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS ARE
IDENTIFYING ARE EXPERTS AT
IDENTIFYING ROOT CAUSES AND
UNDERSTANDING INTERSECTIONS
ACROSS ISSUES WERE INFORMED BY
DATA COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE
EVIDENCE AND EVALUATION MOST
IMPORTANTLY PUBLIC HEALTH IS AT
ITS TO SELL UP AND FIRST. TO
STRATEGIES. KING WHAT ARE MANY
THERE ISN'T HELP PART TO ACT
AND IMPROVE THE OF ALL. HOW THE
PRODUCT ONCE Q. X. WHEN
IMPORTANT INTERSECTION IS
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH IN
THE END IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
LIVING LONGER IT'S ABOUT LIVING
WELL. THROUGH SURVEILLANCE AND
MAPPING WE CAN BE THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
COMMUNITY ASSETS INFLUENCE
HEALTH AND THAT HEALTH OUTCOMES
OF VERY BY GEOGRAPHY. AS A
PHYSICIAN I KNOW THAT WHEN I
TELL MY PAY WHEN I TELL MY
PATIENTS TO EAT MORE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES. IN MANY
NEIGHBORHOODS THERE MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH GROCERY STORES CLOSE BY
OR FRUITS AND VEGETABLES MAY BE
EXPENSIVE. FOR THOSE ON A
LIMITED BUDGET CAN THE CHOICE
EAT MORE THAN. MIGHT IN
CHOOSING NOT TO BUY MEDICATIONS.
BUT HOW IT IS TO MAKEHEALTHY
CHOICES. BUT YOU CAN'T MAKE
HEALTHY CHOICES IF. OF HEALTHY
CHOICES HEALTH IS ORPHALI
SHAPED BY OUR COMMUNITIES
CONDITIONS. TEAMING UP PUBLIC
IN MEDICAL SYSTEM RESOURCES CAN
BE A SYNERGISTIC WAITED MAKE
OUR ASSETS GO FURTHER THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUAL HEALTH AND
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGIES CAN
EXTEND THESE BENEFITS BROADLY
ACROSS ELATION. IN CALIFORNIA
DECREASES IN PART DISEASE AND
LUNG CANCER AS WELL AS OTHER
NOTEWORTHY TO REDUCTIONS IN IN
CONDITIONS SUCH AS CHRONIC OF.
PULMONARY DISEASE HEPATITIS C.
HEPATITIS B. AND H. I. V. HAVE
BEEN INFLUENCED BY PUBLIC
HEALTH THINK NICKEL STEMS
WORKING TOGETHER. KNOWN AS THE
CROSS THE LIFESPAN VERY DEATHS
UNDER PERSONS ARE DOMINATED BY
HIGHLY BY PREVENTABLE IN THE
RELATED CONDITIONSSUCH AS DRUG
ASSOCIATED DEATHS ROAD INJURIES
SUICIDE AND ASIDE. DOZEN AGING
POPULATIONS ARE DOMINATED BY
CHRONIC DISEASES INCLUDING
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND CANCER
THERE IS MUCH WE CAN DO TO
SUPPORT HEALTHY AGING NOW AND
EVERYONE BUT OUR BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSURE HEALTHY
AGING EVERYONE IS TO START WHEN
PETE ARE YOUNG. IMPACT OF CHILD
AND COMMUNITY ADVERSITY TOXIC
STRESS AND CUMULATIVE TRAUMA IS
A ROOT CAUSE OF SOME OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
CHALLENGES FACING CALIFORNIA.
ADVERSE COULD EXPERIENCE
OTHERWISE ACES CAN HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES THROUGH ALTERED AND ALL
PEOPLE MORE PHONE TO AND-
HERE'S THE CAN FOR HELP OUT.
EXT THREE FIVE. HERE DAHLE
REPORTED A ONE OR MORE IT IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IS A STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH
PARTNER WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF
DR NADINE KERIS CALIFORNIA'S
FOR SURGEON GENERAL IN
ADDRESSING EARLY CHILDHOOD WELL
BEING AS A KEEPRITE RT. PUBLIC
HEALTH SUPPORT BY WORKING DRAFT
PREVENT COMMUNITY TRAUMA AND
FOSTER RESILIENCE TO STRENGTHEN
THE HELP THE COMMUNITIES AND TO
PREVENT ACES FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FIRST PLACE. WE CONSIDER
THE LANDSCAPE ISSUES FACING
PUBLIC HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA WE
WILL CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN
CORE PUBLIC HEALTH CAPACITY
THIS INCLUDES CONTINUING WORK
TO ADDRESS LEADING RISK FACTORS
FOR PREVENTABLE DEATH LIKE
TOBACCO AND HYPERTENSION.
STOPPING VAPING IN USE AND
REINFORCING INFECTIOUS DISEASE
CONTROL THROUGH VACCINATION
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH WE KNOW
THESE ARE WINNABLE. WE WILL
ALSO MAINTAIN OUR IN IS TO
MOBILIZE AND RESPOND TO POP UP
EMERGING HE'S AROUND. TO BUYERS
SEVERAL KEY CHALLENGES THAT KEY
ISSUES CHALLENGING CALIFORNIA
WHERE PUBLIC HEALTH CANNOT
STAND ASIDE BECAUSE WE HAVE TOO
MUCH TO LOSE BY DOING SO AND SO
MUCH TO GAIN BY LEANING IN.
THIS INCLUDES ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SUPPORT IN THE
HEALTH OF INDIVIDUALS WITH A
HISTORY ON MET HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH IT'S HOMELESSNESS. STOPS
USE CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVED I
LOOK FORWARD TO JOIN YOU IN THE
FUTURE TO DISCUSS TODAY DETAILS
OF THESE THE IMPLANTS. FOR ALL
OF THESE AREAS AND MORE BE
EXPLORING WAYS TO. OUR
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT LEAVING ANYONE
BEHIND. BECAUSE IT WHILE WHAT
WE MEASURE MATTERS WHAT WE
DON'T MEASURE ALSO MATTERS
THERE ARE KEY POPULATIONS WHICH
OUR CURRENT STANDARD POPULATION
SURVEYS AND DATA SYSTEMS DOT
CAPTOR WELL. SOMETIMES BECAUSE
WE ARE ASKING KEY QUESTIONS BUT
SOMETIMES IT'S BECAUSE SERVICE
AND DATA TOOLS THEMSELVES ARE
DESIGNED IN A WAY THAT WERE.
ADDRESSED ENGAGE OUR RELATIONS
TO FULLY. UNDER IN THE RURAL.
LGBT PERSONS JUSTICE INVOLVED
POPULATIONS AND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
JUST A FEW KEY EXAMPLES WELL WE
ARE TAKING STEPS TO ADDRESS
THOSE GAPS IMPROVING OUR DATA
SYSTEMS TO REFLECT ALL POP. IS
A PRIORITY WITHOUT THAT
UNDERSTANDING THE DESIGN AND
REFINEMENT OF OUR INTERVENTIONS
TO MAXIMIZE IMPACT CANNOT BE
FULLY REALIZED. THEY HAVE
PROVIDED A BROAD OVERVIEW OF
WHAT OUR DATA IS TELLING US
WE'RE LIVING LONGER AND MAKING
GREAT PROGRESS STILL
UNACCEPTABLE AND ON JUST
INEQUITIES EXIST FOR MOST OF
THE CAUSES OF POOR HEALTH AND
EARLY DEATH WE KNOW WHAT TO DO.
A SOLUTIONS EXIST OUR EXPERTISE
IN SURVEILLANCE GIVES US THE
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY THE
POPULATIONS UNDERSTAND WHICH
POPULATIONS ARE MOST EFFECTIVE
MEASURE. IN IMPLEMENTING XIN I
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS IN THE FUTURE.
REST OF WHICH WILL BE ON FUN.
SOME OF THOSE INTERVENTIONS CAN
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
STATE'S HEALTH. I'LL CLOSE BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WHILE WE
COMBINE DATA AND DESCRIBE
DISEASE ND HEALTH IN
AGGREGATE. EVERY DATA POINT
REPRESENTS A PERSON. A MOTHER A
FATHER A CHILD OR A NEIGHBOR
AND MAYBE EVEN ONE OF YOU. ARE
CHARGING PUBLIC TO LIFT UP THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE THE TOTALITY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. IT'S AN HONOR
FOR ALLOF US TO BE A PART OF
THAT MISSION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ADDRESS THESE PLAQUES PUBLIC.
ISSUES THANK YOU- ANY COMMENTS
ON THE FARM OVERALL FROM. OHIO
FINANCE OKAY ADDED AT ANY
ADDITIONAL PRESENTATIONS IN
TERMS THE OVERVIEW. SIDE FROM
THE- ART. SO FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR ANGEL FOR-
PRESENTING THE- STATUS IT'S
PUBLIC HEALTH. I THINK IT'S A
GOOD REMINDERS EVEN AS WE ARE
DEALING WITH THIS CURRENT
CRISIS A CORONA VIRUS. THREE
SHOULD. ONE OF. TO ACTUALLY
MUCH OF THE REAL WORK IS AN ON
GOING TO WORK IT'S NOT A CRISIS
TYPE SITUATION- WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED FOR THEM I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THIS I'VE HAD
PREVIOUS HEARINGS IS. WE CAN
ALMOST ON ON EVERY YEAR HAVING
AN OUTBREAK OF SOMETHING. RIGHT
SO ON THE CONTAGIOUS DISEASE
SIDE THAT THAT SHOULD NOT BE A
SURPRISE OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENT
SCALES. LAST YEAR WAS MEASLES-
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND WE HAD
CERTAINLY- SOME OF CASES WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME OUTBREAK WE
HAD TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN PEOPLE
SHOWED UP- YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
TO DEAL WITH. THE VIRUS EACH
ONE AND. ONE YEAH ON THE NIGHT
WE- AND BUT BAD SU YEARS AT
CETERA- BUT WE CAN ALWAYS YOU
KNOW THE BILL AND EVER REALLY
MADE IT HERE BUT WE GOT PRETTY
EXCITED ABOUT IT. THE SO WE
THERE'S ALWAYS STUFF GOING ON
BUT THEN. ALSO IN ADDITION WE
HAVE THE OUR ON GOING CONTRACTS
THESE LIKE STDS WE SELL BY A
CITY RATES. THE **** REAL HE
ACTUALLY. BE I'LL PUT HIM.
PEOPLE PEOPLE IN. RULES OF THE
CRACK RIGHT THE A RATE TODAY
AND HEART DISEASE AND OTHER
OTHER TYPES OF CONDITIONS AS
WELL AND OF COURSE- SAFETY
ISSUES RIGHT HOW DO WE SURE
ROSE SAY AND ARE COMMITTEES ARE
SAFE. GUN BY AND SUIT AND HOW
TIED RIGHT THE WENT TO THE OF A
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE BILL TO
WE'VE TREATED AND PORT SO THESE
ARE ALL VERY PIECES. THE
QUESTION IS NO SO. ONE SO RIGHT
NOW KERN AND ANA YOU GONNA HAVE
TO RUN OFF TO SPEAKERS ABOUT
CRISIS. SO WHAT TO WHAT THE-
ARE P. BEING. FROM THE ON WORK
IN TRYING DISEASE AND OTHER
THINGS TO ADDRESS CORONA VIRUS-
AT AT THE STATE LEVEL. SELVES
ATTENDS RESERVE SCRAMBLING AND
DINO YOU YOURSELF AS THE
DIRECTORS HAVE. SPENT ABOUT TOP.
BOB CAPACITY OF OUR DEPARTMENT
AND IN ALL. MAY MAKE SUCH A
LITTLE BIT TO OF A COUNTY THE
BECAUSE ARE FROM LINES AND IN
THIS THING IS WHY A DUTY I'M
LIKE I SAID WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY FOR CORONAVIRUS BUT IS
THAT DO WE HAVE HOUSE SEARCH
PASS THE- AND- ALSO. WHEN THESE
THINGS ARE WE ALWAYS POINT AWAY
FROM THE STATE. THE THINGS
THEY'RE DOING THAT ARE ALSO BE
LESS BUT YOU IMPORTANT. YEAH
THANK THAT'S A VERY IN QUESTION
A IT'S THREE IT SPEAKS TO THE
CORE OF PREPAREDNESS IN ITS-
ALL OF ITS SPEC. SO WHILE. WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T KNOW THE
TIMING OF SOMETHING LIKE A
COVERT NINETEEN WE HAVE BEEN
PLANNING FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS FOR OVER A DECADE- WE HAVE
PREPAREDNESS PLAN. FOR PANDEMIC
BUT WE ARE PREPARED IS PLANS
FOR ALMOST THE SITUATION THAT
THAT WHAT ANTICIPATE OUT
HAPPENING IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT INCLUDES ALSO CONSIDER HOW
WE SHOULD. USE EXISTING STAFF
THAT ARE BE DESIGNATED TO WORK
ON THIS. BUT THINK ABOUT HELP
OTHERS. THROUGHOUT OUR
DEPARTMENT. WITH THEIR REALLY
KEY KNOWLEDGE THAT'S VITAL AND
DETECT TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
TO BE SPECIFIC. TYPE OF
EMERGING. SO WE ARE ACTIVATED
IT LEVEL. IS IN ALL OF. ONE IT
ONE. THIS PAST WEEK NEW NEWSOME
HAD I TOP OF ALL OF THE TOP OF
AGENCY OUR AGENTS HAS A IT TO
THINK VERY ABOUT HOW ALL OF OUR-
THE ARE NEEDED COULD BE TO
PROPERLY TO RESPOND TO THIS
STAFFING AS WE THINK ABOUT WE
NOTHING WE SHOULD MOVE INTO
RESPOND AS WELL. AS ME. JUST AS
A AND THEN ZERO AS YOU MAY TO
MAKE SURE THE THOSE OR ACTIVITY
CONTINUE TO GO FORWARD SO AT
THIS TIME I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
NUMBER FOR YOU CERTAINLY WE ARE
WE KEEPING VERY CLOSE I
COMMENCE OF THAT. AND IS ALSO
IN ALL THE CHANGING YOUR LOOK
UP AND SO WE HAVE STAFF THAT
ARE BALANCING BOTH THE- OTHER
THE EMERGED. BONDS BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT EL CORE
ACTIVITIES CONTINUES THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN REMAIN SAFE AND
PROTECTED. SO I HOPE I CAN TRY
TO DO I REALIZE IT'S ALWAYS
DIFFICULT THE MISS OF A CRISIS
AND I HAD ASKED YOU SOME YOU
PREDECESSORS ON CRISIS HAPPEN
BEFORE. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO QUALITY EIGHT. THE TIME
AND COST- NOW. IT'S CHALLENGING
BECAUSE YOU'RE TO CRISIS REASON
YOU GOT PEOPLE PULLED AWAY IS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SOMETHING
URGENT TO DO AND NOW YOU'RE
TELLING THEM ALL BY THE WAY
NEED TO LOG STUFF. BUT WE DO
YOU KNOW DOES THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WE DO NEED TO. TRY
TO CAPTURE THAT IN SOME WAY AND
SO IT'S HARDENING THIS TO THE
CRISIS WE SHOULD BE PLANNING
FOR THAT. AND IF YOU TALK ABOUT
DATA SO I WAS AT THE TIME OF
THE- PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT
BUT THIS IS JUST A MEATY. SO I
OWES THAT BECAUSE YOU TO BE
ABLE TO SEE. THE BUT OR IN YOUR
RESEARCH. OWN BASIS PEOPLE GET
ALL THE WAY. YEAH THIS IS. SO
WE CAN BE. THE WHAT TO DO ALSO
COMMUNICATE FAIRS YOUR FIGHTING
THE MONEY LIKE THIS WHY WE'RE
VALLEY THE MONEY WAY WE ARE
BECAUSE WHEN THE COME IN YOUR
CALLING US AND SAYING I DO YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE YOU DOING KEEP US
pWHAT WE'RE DOING IN THIS IS
MUCH THIS IS WHAT IT TOOK FOR
US TO IT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. YEAH AND I'LL
TURN. IN JUST A MOMENT BUT I
JUST REALLY WANT TO ASK WHAT IN
IMPORTANT. IT HAS THE BILL. THE
CRACKS IS. THE SUM BEING A PRO
FIND. SO WE DON'T SEE IT AS
SOMETHING YOU JUST LOOK BACK AT
AFTER IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE WE
SEE IT AS PART OF A CORK
REGULAR ACTIVITY OF ANY
RESPONSE TO. SEE THINGS. DATE
TERMS OF RECALL IN. WE DON'T
SEE THAT. EXTRACT WE SEE THAT
IT IS A KEY RESPONSE. TO KEEP
OUR A. R. ARE. SOLVENT WHEN IT
COMES TO EMERGENCIES TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR RESOURCES
ARE BEING USE RESPONSIBLE.
ALTERNATE SUSAN TO DISAGREE
ABOUT HOW OF SOME OF THOSE
DETAILS ARE RECORDED. USE MAKE
ONE QUICK OF BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO RUN SO
JUST. BECAUSE I OF COURSE THE
MEN IN THIS TO YOUR
PREDECESSORS BEFORE. BUT I WILL
pTHIS VERY MOMENT BUT I'VE
ALWAYS. THE SOMEONE IS AN
ADVOCATE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT SOMETIMES AFTER HIS BUDGET
SUB CHAIR. I THINK WHAT DO YOU
NEED FROM US. TO PREPARE I GET
IT YOU KNOW THIS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL YOU ALL
HAVE THE INTERNAL PROCESS BUT I
MEAN REALLY WHAT IS THE
CAPACITY WE NEED WORKING WITH
THE HEALTH THEY'LL COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICERS. WHAT WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BE READY I KNOW
THERE WAS SOME REPORT THAT WAS
DONE QUITE AWHILE AGO IT'S
GETTING. OLD NOW. I WOULD
REALLY LIKE. ME BEING. AND
COMING UP WITH OF ABOUT WHAT
THE RESOURCE REALLY NEED TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY READY FOR
OUTBREAKS BUT ALSO WHILE STILL
DOING THE ON GOING WORK SO I'M
GONNA TO EIGHT SESAME PROCESSES
TO INPUT THIS AND THIS IS YOUR
FIRST YEAR AS A DIRECTOR OF
THAT THAT CHALLENGE BEFORE YOU
TO WITH THE PUBLIC AS A LEADER
TO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY
TO DO THAT SO YOU CAN HELP ME
AND MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE EMAIL I
THINK THOSE OF COURSE INFORMS
HIS OFFICE I MEAN WHAT WHAT WE
NEED REAL DO. BEST TEAM
POSSIBLE AT TO FORD THE OTHER
THING OUT ALSO JUST MAKE NOTE
IS THAT IT'S ALWAYS COMMENTED
THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
BUDGET. THAT THIS IS THE
GENERAL FUND THIS IS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND SO- YOU
KNOW THIS IS A REMINDER THAT
MOST OF OUR THE PAR PUBLIC
HEALTH IS FUNDED THROUGH EITHER
SPECIAL FUNDS OR- THE- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND UNFORTUNATELY
HE- WILL. THE CONGRESS HAS
TRIED SUSTAIN FUNDING AND
AGENCIES LIKE THE CD. THEY
HAVE. CUT BACK. AND FUNDS THAT
ACTUALLY THEN GET ALLOCATED TO
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FOR PREPARED AS WE
NEED TO CHANGE THAT. YEAH I
THINK IN WE- BROUGHT UP. HELLO
COULD I USE MORE SORE. I WILL
TO- REASSURE YOU THAT WE ARE
DOING VERY WELL AND WITH
RESPECT TO THIS RESPONSE- WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC AND WE AE THE THAT
WE ARE REASSURED THAT RESOURCES
ARE NOT THE ISSUE HERE I THINK
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FEEL
REASSURED THAT. WE'RE NOT
HOLDING BACK ON ACTION WE
SHOULD BE DOING BECAUSE OF SOME
QUITE KIND OF RESOURCE
CONSTRAINED THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
THE CASE WE BILL. IN RESPONSE
AT THE WELL IT IS GOVERNOR HAS.
HAS THAT MANY TO TODAY ONE
AGAIN IN HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
AS WELL AS THE MOST IMPORTANT
IS ABOUT OF THE- RECENT. NEEDS
TO BE. IN PARTICULAR THAT RIGHT
TO A COURT NOVEL ISN'T COVERED
EIGHTEEN RIGHT. I'M AT BUT ALL
GET. YOUR INDICATION THAT IT ON
BOARD AND LOOK FOR THE FUTURE
DISCUSS AROUND THE TH OKAY AND
I DO TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WE CERTAINLY
DIDN'T KNOW AND I HAVE WOULD
NINE. COMING FOR THE TIME AND-
THE MANY YEARS STOP. WE'VE THE
STATE PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL.
LOW GOVERNMENT. C. BUT THERE'S
BUT THIS INOW IS THE GOV
NEWSOME'S LEADERSHIP THERE AND
I KNOW YOU SORRY I THOUGHT
OFFER ME ANSWER THE YOU ANSWER
YOU THERE ARE OVER JUST GOING
TO ADD THAT WE HAVE BEEN READ
TO STYLE AND YOUR THAT'S THINGS
ARE GETTING DONE BECAUSE WE
REALLY READ TING UP STAFF WE
ALSO GOT A BRING BACK STEP CALL
FOR SOME. AND THEN. I'M GET AN-
ACCESS TO. STAY IN. STAFF AND
SO. THINGS LIKE POP INFORMATION
AND THROUGH CALLAWAY ASSETS.
BEEN A ALL HANDS ON DECK FOR
SPOT. OF THE WHOLE MINISTER.
HAS ASKED WHAT WE NEED AND
THEY'RE HELPING US WITH ANY.
ANY OF THOSE RESOURCE NEEDS.
AND JUST SO YOU KNOW DE DC JUST
CAME OUT. OF MENTAL FUNDS IN
THE AMOUNT OF NINE HUNDRED.
MILLION THE APRIL DOLLAR PART.
OF THE STATE OF. WILL RECEIVE
FORTY ONE POINT NINE MILLION.
AND LAW ANGELES WILL DIRECTLY
RECEIVE THE POINT TWO MILLION-
THESE FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR A
LOT. OF IT OF ACTIVE. I'M
BUDGET TESTING AND SORT. SOME
CASE CATION OUR MOM DATA MANAGE
AND ALL OTHER PIECES THAT GO
WITH US AND I THINK AS THIS
CONTINUES WE CERTAINLY MAY
AFFECT HAVE BIGGER NEEDS MORE
STAFF AND MORE RESOURCES AND
THAT'S THE UP AT THE LOCAL AS
WELL BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT I'M FIRST- HER HUSBAND UP
TIME EVEN WITH YOU AND FIVE.
IT'S HARD TO KEEP THE STAFF AND
THIS IS A STAFF AND TENS OF
RESPONSE OKAY ON ALL STOP THEIR
UNLESS THERE'S QUESTION. AND
ARE TRACKING THE CALL OF US AND
WILLBE ABLE TO CATCH HIM ALL
RIGHT WHEN CRISIS IS OVER WE
CAN ANALYZE THE DATA. BUT ME
NO. OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY FOR
WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
AND THE DOCTOR YOU PRY NEED TO
RUN. TO IT IS A PAID. EITHER
MEDIA PRESS COVERAGE OR
SOMETHING WITH YES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE FOR YOU OKAY THANK I
WILL I WILL GO ALL RIGHT TO
CARRY ON AND COVERED NINETEEN
OKAY VERY GOOD. OKAY SO- WE'RE
NOW GOING TO DRESS SAID WE CAN
GET UPDATE ON CORONA VIRUS
UPDATE FROM FROM- WE HAVE A
PANEL- SO THAT IF THE REST OF
THE PHARMACY WAS PARTICIPATE
SHE MOVED TO THE SIDES HERE-
AND WE DID HEAR FROM THE
DIRECTOR ABOUT- FROM THE-
APARTMENT. ABOUT IN HER REMARKS
SO WELL WE HAVE HERE- AND TERMS
OF PREVENTION RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES- WE HAVE KEPT THE
BURKE FROM THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AMANDA WILLARD- FROM THE
PRIMARY CARE CALIFORNIA CARE
ASSOCIATION KAMALA COIL
PRESENCIA WITH CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALIZATION JACKIE BENDER-
VICE VERSA POLICY FROM
CALIFORNIA SAYS HE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
EIGHTY BLOOM BURKE- AND- JASON
BUT THEN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES. WELCOME AND SO- SHE
SHE USED- PRESENTING TO US
ABOUT- SOME OF THE YEAR
PREVENTION RESEARCH ACTIVITIES
AND- AND CERTAINLY ANY THE
CHALLENGES YOU'RE FACING AS
WELL AS WERE REALLY IN THE
MISTS OF THIS CRISIS RIGHT NOW
AND MOVE FORWARD SO- ASK IF YOU
CAN TRY TO KEEP YOUR REMARKS TO
THREE MINUTE OR LESS- AND THEN
WILL. ONLY HAVE A OF DISCUSSION
AFTERWARDS SO WE GO AHEAD START
WITH THE CAT TO BERGEN DEAR
MEMBERS ARE IN THE VERY FRONT
LINES SO THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN
CATCH VERY WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
SIXTY ONE PHYSICIAN HEALTH
OFFICERS. IN CALIFORNIA FIFTY
EIGHT TONY'S THE CITIES OF
BERKELEY LONG BEACH IN PASADENA
WHO HAVE THEIR OWN HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- YOU ASKED HOW WE
ARE WORKING CITY PH AND THE
ANSWER IS WE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THEM AND WE- IN
PHONE. EARLY IN THE MORNING ON
THE WAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
GUIDANCE THAT THERE IS DOING
AND THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB OF
KEEPING US INFORMED OF THEIR
ACTIVITIES IN THE LATEST-
SCIENTIFIC ADVANCES. AND THEN
YOU ALSO ASKED WHAT DO WE NEED
AND I HAVE A LIST FOR YOU I
HAVE A LIST OF IMMEDIATE NEEDS
LONG TERM THE MOST THEM.
IMMEDIATE ARE. RELATED TO
TESTING THE BIGGEST TIME
CONSUMPTION WE HAVE A LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS RIGHT NOW IS
PEOPLE CALLING WANTING TO BE
TESTED. BECAUSE THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
APPROVE ALL TEST BECAUSE THIS
THE- CAN. A PUBLIC HEALTH LABS
IS VERY LIMITED. AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABS AND THEN PRIVATE
LABS ARE COMING ON BOARD BUT
THAT STILL LIMITED AND SO ALL
TEST NEED TO BE APPROVED BY THE
LOCAL DEPARTMENT. WE NEED
MESSAGING FROM. HER IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH TO OUTPATIENT
FACILITIES. GIVING TELLING THEM
WHO IS THE PRIORITY FOR TESTING
SO THAT THEY'RE NOT CALLING THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT EVERY.
I AM AND WE ALSO IN THE LONG
RUN IN THE SHORT RUN NEED MORE
TESTING CAPACITY MORE LABS
BETTER EQUIPMENT MORE TASK. AND
IF ALTERNATE CARE SITES ARE SET
UP AS YOU DISCUSSED EARLIER- CD
PAGE NEEDS TO STOP THOSE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS CAN'T STAFF
THOSE- WE DESK WE NEED A STATE
WHAT ALL CENTER. THERE ARE SO
MANY CALLS TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT IT'S REALLY
HARD TO FILTER OUT WHO NEEDS
GENUINE LOCAL GUIDANCE ABOUT A
LOCAL EVENT VERSES JUST CALLING
ABOUT GENERAL HEALTH ADVICE WHO
IS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HAS
EXACT. ABOUT KOFI. I'M AND
FINALLY A STAFFING
JURISDICTIONS STILL IN THE
CONTAINMENT PHASE NEED MORE
STAFF FOR CONTACT TRACING FOR
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE
ORDERS. AND WE JUST DISCOVERED
THIS MORNING THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
TASKED WITH- QUARANTINING. OR
FOLLOWING UP ON SELF QUARANTINE
FOR THE TRAVELERS RETURNING
FROM EUROPE AND THAT'S IN. HUGE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE- THAT LOCAL
DIFFERENT CAST CONTACTING. AND
ARE NAY AND STAFFING THE NEEDS
ARE FACILITIES ISOLATE IN
QUARANTINE OF PEOPLE WITHOUT
HOUSING- WHETHER THEY'RE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESTRICTED FROM TRAVELING HOME.
M. WE NEED CITY. YOU ISSUING
GUIDANCE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH PUNISHING GUIDANCE AND WE
SPECIFICALLY RIGHT NOW NEED
GUIDANCE ON JAILS AND CASINOS.
AND WE NEED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT I HEARD EARLIER THAT
AND SAID THEY HAD RECEIVED NO
REQUESTS FROM LOCALS BUT WE
NEED. THAT ARE ONGOING AT JUST
GENERAL MEANS- WE NEED
CONTINUING FUNDING FOR
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR WE REQUESTED. LANE DOLLARS
AN ON GOING FUNDING FOR EXACTLY
THAT PURPOSE ABOUT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING. AND WE CAN'T HIRE
STAFF WITH ONE TIME THE AND IS
OUR GREATEST. WE WORK FOR BEING
AND- HAS THIS FOR TO. PEOPLE
THOSE PEOPLE NEED TRAIN. AND WE
NEED UP HIGH. FOR FUTURE HEALTH
WORKERS INCLUDING LOAN
FORGIVENESS AND LOWER
CERTIFICATION FEES FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES INCENTIVES FOR
ALL. OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND- WE
NEED FOR PUBLIC LABORATORIES IN
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS ELEVEN
LOCAL PUBLIC CATHOLIC HEALTH
LABS OF CLIPS IN THIS. AND THAT
MAKES SENSE. ASSISTANCE SAVE-
INFECTED TO SAVE RESOURCES BUT
AT A TIME LIKE THIS YOU CAN
REALLY SEE THAT WE COULD TWO
HUNDRED AS FOR ME IF WE HAD
MORE LET. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND HAVE IT ANSWERED
QUESTIONS WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU BUT SWELLED THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
THE WHOLE CENTER RESPONSE-
EXPERIENCE TO DATE MY NAME IS
AMANDA AND I'M THE SENIOR
PROGRAM COORDINATOR AT THE
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION AND-
HER NET. PARTS I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF MORE THAN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS THAT WE WRITE
COMPREHENSIVE HIGH QUALITY CARE
TO SEVEN POINT TWO. MILLION
PEOPLE THAT'S SIX CALIFORNIA.
AT THIS TIME I WILL TAKE A FEW
MINUTES TO PROVIDE GREATER. ON
HOW HEALTH CENTERS IN IMPACT
CODE NINETEEN OUTBREAK IN THE
KEY ROLE THEY PLAY DURING A
PUBLIC HEALTH. AGENCY HOW
CENTERS ON THE FRONT LINES
DURING PUBLIC AGENCIES LIKE THE
KOBE NINETEEN OUTBREAK. MINUTE
TO CARING FOR THEIR PATIENTS
AND BEING A RESOURCE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHILE ALSO
MAINTAINING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THEIR STAFF. DURING A
PUBLIC EMERGENCIES. BY TRIAGE
TREATMENT FOR OLD AND WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. WELL
CENTERS ARE COMMITTED TO FULLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE COPA
NINETEEN RESPONSE THEY ARE IN
NEED OF ADDITIONAL RESPONSES TO
INCREASE. OUR CAPACITY. THE
MATCH STARTED SO PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT FOR HEALTH. LIMIT
THEIR ABILITY TO SAFELY TRIAGE
PATIENTS SUSPECTED OF KOBE
NINETEEN- OTHER CHALLENGE
HEALTH CENTERS ARE FACING IS
THE ABILITY TO UTILIZE
ALTERNATIVE QUE. MODEL JUST
VISIT WHICH ARE KEY TO
MITIGATING KOBE NINETEEN
EXPOSURE AS IT LIMITS THE SPOT
OTHER THAN OUR PATIENTS STAFF
THE JUDGE IN UNITY. EIGHT
GUARANTEES. AND IT IS ANY TEST
IT. UNLIKE OTHER PROVIDERS AND
THE COMMERCIALLY AND HEALTH
CENTERS KERN BILL FOR TELEPHONE
VISITS. SINCE THE FIRST
COMMUNITY CASE OF EIGHTEEN WAS
IDENTIFIED HEALTH CENTERS BEGAN
MORE TELEPHONIC TREE URGING
HEARING FROM PAGE FEARFUL OF
DISEASE EXPOSURE HEALTH
CENTERS. HEALTH CENTERS ARE
MEETING THIS NEED WHEN POSSIBLE
BUT THEY'RE DOING SO I
FINANCIAL RISK INSTITUTION.
INTERESTING JUST. IN RESPONSE
TO A VERY DIFFERENT DISASTER AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR WAS
INTRODUCED AND CHAMPION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
THIS BILL WANTED ALLOWS HEALTH
RISKS TO BILL FOR TELEPHONIC
VISITS DURING AN EMERGENCY
DISASTER. WELL THE BILL SIGNED
INTO LAW THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES STATES
THAT LACK OF PRESIDENTIAL
ACTIONS TO DECLARE AN EMERGENCY
IMPEDES THEIR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT. OUR STATION IS NOW
MOBILE USING MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S CAN. LOCATION TO
TAKE ACTION TO. EXPLORATION FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN SUPPORT
DH CS. ASIAN COMMENTING
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
ADDITIONALLY WE CALL ON YOU TO
CONSIDER ANY ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS LIKE TAKE
TO GUARANTEED HEALTH CENTERS
ARE FINANCIALLY SUPPORTED IN
THEIR DECISION TO USE HELP TELL
UP DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- SAID. TODAY THANK
YOU. WHAT KAMALA COIL ESERVER
THE. THANK YOU CARMEL COYLY
SERVES THE PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- I AM NOT OFTEN
HERE WHICH IS WHY I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO USE THE BUTTON AND
THAT'S HOW IN. THE STATE IS TO.
AT HEARING ON COMMEND THE WORK
THE- WELL THEY HAVE BEEN JUST
TERRIFIC AND WE ARE BY NO MEANS
ANY. IT'S HERE ARE NOW MORE
THAN EVER ANY THAT THEY AND THE
DOCTOR SONYA AGE HAS JUST UP SO
OF PARTNER A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME. CODE VIRUS OF COURSE YES
IT'S A- AND CREATING CHALLENGE.
THROUGHOUT THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM WITH HOSPITALS VERY MUCH
AT THE POINTY END OF THAT.
NURSES DOCTORS HOSPITALS DEEPLY
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THIS IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DESCRIBE THE LEVEL
OF ON GOING CONVERSATION
COMMUNICATION AND- BY MINUTE
HOUR BY OUR DAY TO DAY JUST TWO
THINGS. IF WE REALLY NEED NOW
THE FIRST IMPORTANT DECISIONS
TO BE MADE BY THE STATE AND WE
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS RIGHT HEY.
AND WE NEED TO CHANGE. CHANGE
WE'VE GOT TO WORK EVEN QUICKLY.
EVERYONE IS FLAT OUT- BUT WE
THERE IS A SENSE OF URGENCY
THAT IF WE DON'T ACT QUICKLY-
THIS FOR. WELCOME THE HELP
SYSTEM- QUICKLY. AND GOAL AND
THAT IS IN PATIENTS AND WORK IF.
POURTANT CHANGES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED MOST RECENTLY OF THE
FIRST QUARTER HELLO. THERE IS
NOT BE ACQUIRED WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY. AS A DANGER FOR HOW
WE ADDRESS BECAUSE WE NEED TO.
VERY AND HE CHALLENGE VERY
CLOSE. FOR A CONTAINMENT
STRATEGY. REALLY TO STOP THIS
THE VIRUS MEDICATIONS AND THAT
IS TO LIMIT IMPACT OF THE VICE
AND ARE. BECAUSE WE HAVE
FEDERAL. BIDEN SAID OKAY. GOT
IN. ON TOP OF THAT. DECISIONS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE NOW FIRST
OF ALL WE NEED TO MOVE FROM
AIRBORNE TWO DROPLETS
PRECAUTIONS I CAN'T UNDERSCORE
HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS WE'VE GOT
A FOLLOW THE SCIENCE WE'VE GOT
TO FOLLOW THE FACT. CENTERS
THESE CONTROL OF IT'S CLEAR. TO
BE IN THEIR GUIDANCE WE SHOULD
I BE FALL XING TEN STATE IN
THEIR MOVE TO ADOPT HEALTH
ORGANIZATION GUIDANCE ON THIS
MATTER IT WILL ALLOW US TO
ALLOCATE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
IN THAT. OCCURS FOR AT RISK AND
WITH IT WE WILL. LICENSE
STRETCH ARE LIMITED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT SECOND HE
TO ALLOW HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO THE COVE
IT VIRUS ARE CALLED THE
POSITIVE PATIENT WHO ARE NOT
SICK. CAN YOU WORK THIS
CRITICALLY IN. A ONE
ORGANIZATION AS YOU KNOW HAS
HAD TO FURLOUGH HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR WORKERS FOR ONE
PATIENT GOOD NEWS IS THEY'RE
ALL BACK HEALTHY. HAVE FOR
ALLOWING BETWEEN IN A HUNDRED
WORKERS ARE PAID. WE'VE GOT A
CHANGE THAT OR WE WILL HAVE THE
HEALTH CARE. WE NEED ONLY TO
THE CODE BY. THE CAP. IN
HOSPITAL IS THAT SOME NEED ON
IMMEDIATELY THIRD WE NEED TO
SHIFT LEAVE EIGHT ROB RATHER
THAN A COUNTY BY COUNTY
STRATEGY THE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
DOING A GREAT JOB I'LL BUT THEY
ARE DIFFERENT WE HAVE HOSPITAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT'S ALL TO. WE
FRIENDS OF ROUTE WE- DO UNIFIED
THAT. FINALLY TIME TO INTO THE
STRATEGIC NATIONAL STOCKPILE WE
ARE ON THE EDGE OF A
AVAILABILITY OF WHAT WE NEED
AND WHILE MOST PEOPLE ARE
FOCUSED RIGHT NOW ON MAC THAT
IS REAL. THEY SHE ARE WE ARE
REALLY REAL WAY AT THE END
EIGHT ASKING ORGANIZATIONS AND
ARE CARE WORKERS AND THEIR
SAFETY TO LIVE ON THE EDGE IS
NOT WHERE WE WANT TO BE RIGHT
NOW SO- THAT'S THE IMPORTANT
CHANGE. SHOULD WORK MORE QUICK.
UPWARD AS I MENTIONED WE WILL
OVER WELL THE- SO WE THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO ENTER
INTO CONVERSATION IN A FEW
MINUTES THANK YOU. REGULAR
SPENDER. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU THE ROLE THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS ARE PLAYING
IT IS IMPORTANT RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS. JACKIE BEEN. ON
INSTITUTIONAL PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS REPRESENTING
THE TWENTY ONE COUNTY
AFFILIATED SYSTEMS AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ACADEMIC HEALTH CENTERS WE ARE
LOCATED IN FIFTEEN COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
REPRESENTING OUR EIGHTY PER. ST
LUCIAN AND WHICH TO ALL WHO
NEED. AVERAGE ROUGHLY HALF OF
OUR PATIENTS EITHER HAVE MEDI
CAL OR HAVE NO INSURANCE. WE
ALSO OPERATE SEVERAL OF PUBLIC
RESOURCES WE ARE OVER HALF OF
THE LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTERS
AND BURN CENTERS IN THE STATE
AND WE TRADE OVER HALF OF THE
NEW DOCTORS IN THE STATE. BOB
BY THE SPECIAL. CHERRY CARE
BUILDING HI SPECIALIZED
CAPACITOR TREAT INFECTIOUS
DISEASE. SO BOLD AS PUBLIC
ENTITIES AND AS HOSPITALS I
WANT TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS AND- TOUCH ON THREE
KEY UNIQUELY PUBLIC ROLES THAT
WE PLAY- AND OUR MEMBERS ARE
PLAYING AND RESPOND TO THE
VIRUS SO FIRST. I WE REALLY ARE
ON THE LINE THIS CALL IN WITH
OUR LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND WE OF THE VERY
FIRST HOSPITALS TO RECEIVE
PATIENTS EITHER THROUGH AIRPORT
REFER. THREE FLIGHTS. COULD
SUPPORTING SLIDE THAT LANDED IN
RIVER. I WE RECEIVE SOME OF THE
CASE BECAUSE OF OUR CAPACITY TO
TREAT HIGH RISK INFECTIOUS
DISEASE AND BECAUSE OF OUR LONG
HISTORY OF PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS-
WE WORK WITH AND WERE SOMETIMES.
INTO LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. SECOND A MANY
PUBLIC HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS ARE
ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
INNOVATION AND WE'RE HOPING
STATE RAPIDLY EXPAND CAPACITY
FOR TESTING- AND PREPARING FOR
THE SHARP UP TAKE A POTENTIAL
WE'RE EXPECTING A CASES. HE
ALSO- IT WORKING RUN
DIAGNOSTICS IN HOUSE. AND THIS
MEANS THAT THERE WOULD THEY
WILL BE ABLE OR ARE ALREADY
PROCESSING TEST IN LESS THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. AND THAT
THEY ARE ALSO IN FREE UP
CAPACITY ANOTHER LAPSE UCSF
UCLA AND UC SAN DIEGO ARE
ALREADY ON LINE AND WE EXPECT
UC DAVIS AND UC IRVINE. RUNNING
THE THERE'S ALSO A THE SITE
WHERE ONCE OF THE OF WORDS WERE
READY TO A VACCINE AND CLINICAL
TRIALS THAT THOSE COULD BE THE
SITES TO RUN SOME OF THOSE
CLINICAL TRIAL TESTS. AND
LASTLY WE ARE CORPS PROVIDERS
OF SOME. OF CARE TO SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. OUR
MEMBERS ARE REACHING OUT TO
LISTEN CANNONS- THEY'RE
EDUCATING ABOUT APPROPRIATE
PRECAUTIONS HAND WASHING-
TRYING TO IDENTIFY NICELY
INDIVIDUALS ARE EXPERIENCING
SYMPTOMS. TO ILLUSTRATE HOW ALL
IS MY TIE TOGETHER JUST AN
EXAMPLE IN ONE COUNTY OF HOW
THE STRUCTURE WORKS- THE COUNTY
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ITSELF IS
SERVING AS THE FIRST PLACE OF
TREATMENT FOR ANYONE WHO'S
IDENTIFIED- AND IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR CAR BUYERS
SYMPTOMS. AND THEY'RE SUPPORTED
BY THEIR COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
LABS FOR TESTING. THAT SAME
SYSTEM THERE ARE STAFF- BEGAN
QUICKLY WORKING WITH THE
MEDICAL- HEALTH JOINT
OPERATIONS CENTER. SO
ORGANIZING ALL OF THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WITHIN THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. AND THAT'S
ACTIVATED WHEN THERE'S A BE A
NEED FOR INCREASED STAFFING AND
RESPONSE AND THEN THEY ARE ALSO
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE OF THE HOUSE
TO DO A REACHED HOME A POPULAR
ONES. AND ALL OF THIS IS REALLY
JUST WROTE OUR LONG HISTORY AND
OUR COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
WELLNESS AND I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST LESSONS WE CAN WAY THUS
FAR IS THAT. I LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE NOT USE THIS
BUTTON FOR SALE BOB NAME IS
JASON BELL TO I AM NOW AMY
BLOOMBERG THAT LED. TO OF THE
CALIFORNIA. OF HOUSE FACILITY.
I AM THE TO OF RUMORED. LESSEN
RISK FOR. A CALF. ARE WE READY
ABOUT TWELVE FIFTY LONG TERM
FOR. AND SCHOOL SKILLED FOR. OR
MEDIA CARE FOR STILL FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
PEDIATRICS ACUTE FACILITIES. WE
CARRY. LONG TERM CARE FACILITY.
A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND PAY. IT SUCCEEDED POINT TWO
BILLION. I JUST WANTED TO A
STEP. TO YOUR FROM BRITAIN FIVE
RESPONSE ECHO WE FULLY SO. THE
HOSPITAL SO SUGGEST AS IT
RELATES TO AND HAVING A
STATEWIDE. SEPT MESSAGE WE TO
HAVE MULTIPLE RIVER PROVIDER
WITH. FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE DIFFERENT INDICATIONS
EVEN FROM COME THE HAVE THE
SAME RATE. AND SO IT MAKES
CONFUSE FOR THEM UNDER WHICH
ONE THE MOST. WE HAVE WORKED
FANTASTICALLY WITH PUBLIC CAL
AS WELL AS HEALTH AND HE
SERVICES THE BEEN EXTRA RICH OF
THE SET UP FOR CALL THAT WE- ON
A DAY BASIS. I'M A WILL
CONTINUE TO DO UNTIL THE CRISIS
OVER WITH SEC CALF IN RESPONSE
THIS IS CREATED A WEB WHERE WE
COLLATE THE MOST PER PARTNER
INFORMATION SO. WE REVIEW THEM
FOR FROM TWENTY PUBLIC
PARCHMENTS IN TRY TO KEEP
PRESENT I CAN TO OUR MEMBERS WE
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE. THAT WE
ARE THE MOST BUT APPROACH WE DO.
WE. THE PUBLIC PARMENTER CAL'S
ADOPTION IS THIS REQUIRE FOR.
OUR VISIT OR A HOME WITH JUST
SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE
CONSERVATIVE THAT WOULD BE OUR
SUGGEST. AS WE AT. HOW WE ARE
PRETTY THE FOLKS IN A BUILDING
THESE SOME THE THINGS THAT WERE
ASK FOLKS TO DO I. WANT TO
FOLLOW THE GUIDANCE FROM C.
WHERE WE DIFFER WERE. FOLKS
GREEN STAFF. OF FIRST SENTENCE
SHIP AND WERE REQUIRING. WERE
SICK STAY THAT WAS LESS. A
LITTLE UNCLEAR IN THE C. GUIDE
ONE OF THE THINGS IN THIS GOT
THAT WE ALSO NOT CLEAR. WHAT WE
SHOULD DO ABOUT AND HELLO.
INTER SO SHOULD WE BE LOW.
INTERNALWHAT IN THE BUILDING
THAT. OUR SUGGESTION IS WE
SHOULD CUT OUT AS- WE ARE WE'VE
LEARNED THAT THERE'S A BENEFIT
TO BRING A STATE RIGHT WRIST
FOR THESE FOLKS BECAUSE OUT
DEVELOPS PLAN FOM ONE. OFFICE
TO ANOTHER DâN CAN I MY THIS
STAFF BEEN A TO COPE AND CAN I
SEND THEM TO AND BUILDING THIS
AREA. IN THIS CASE. SAN UPS. AS
IT RELATES STAFFING AND MAKES
YOU DO. FOR US TO ACCOUNT THAT
IN ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS THIS
IS HIGH. IS NOT JUST SKILLED
NURSING BUT MOST OF KERR'S JUST
IN TIME ORDER NO PP. HAS MADE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
RESPOND THIS THE MESSAGE THAT
ARE MEMBERS ARE. IS THAT UNLESS
YOU HAVE A CO FLU OUTBREAK YOU
WON'T GET. A YOU DON'T HAVE IT
YOU. UNLESS THAT CHANGES. WE'VE
GOT FOLKS AT RISK IN OUR
BUILDING. THE OTHER THING IS
WHAT DO WE DO. IN TWO WEEKS
WHEN THIS EXPERIENCE- OR ANIMAL
WHEN THIS EXPERIENCE ARE WE
LOOKING AT YOU. SPACE AND
SKILLED. FACILITIES TO TAKE. UP
POSSIBLY. A POSSIBLE PATIENTS
THAT. NON THE MATTER MORE BUT
STILL SHOW. ALL STATIONS WITH A
HEALTH ABOUT THE ONLY WOULD
WOULD I WANT TO BE THE LAST
RESORT WE WALK. TO THINK A AN
ALTERNATE CARE SITES WERE SOME
AT THE- THAN RATHER THAN
PUTTING HIM IN THE PLACE WHERE
IT WOULD CAUSE THE MOST HARM
AND SO WE KNOW. THE MORTALITY
RATE IN THE CITY'S HIM. ARE AT
IN WASHINGTON WAS BOB OF A
NINETY IT'S PAST WAIT THAT TEST
POSITIVE SO THAT'S NOT A OUR
FOR THE FOLKS IN SKILLED
NURSING THESE ARE FOLKS OVER
EIGHTY YEARS OLD A MULTI HOW
CAN SECOND TO A OUTCOME SO. ARE
OUR SUGGESTION ARE AT AS WE GO
FOR JUST. IF DO I COME UP HERE.
SO WE HEARD A LIST OF DIFFERENT
THINGS- SO WE CAN COMMENT ON A
LOT OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP OF WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING- SO MESSAGE ON
TESTING PRIORITIES WE ARE RIGHT
NOW WITH A NUMBER OF PROVIDERS
HELD. UP WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR MORE LABORATORY
TESTING AND SO WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH COST LABS TAKE
OUR BACKLOG FROM PUBLIC HEALTH.
NOW I HAVE A BACKLOG BUT MORE
OF DEMANDING TESTING WE WOULD
MEAN- ANTICIPATE ADDITIONAL
TESTING NEEDS WE ARE LOOKING
AT. I'M ALTERNATE CARE SITES
AND EXPANSION OF HOSPITAL
CAPACITY. OF CALF. ELOQUENTLY
STATED WE DO NOT WANT TO PUT
THESE PEOPLE ANYBODY WHO
COULDN'T BE IN A HOSPITAL INTO
HELP CARE FOR THE THANK. AT
THIS RISK FOR OR DOES IT IS.
FOR THE REST WE ARE. I CALL FOR
AND WE DO THAT AS NEED ME ARE
PREPARING THE SCRIPT WE ARE
LOOK AT THE CAPACITY BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH CAPACITY TO GO STATE
WILL. NOT HAVE NOT BUT AGAIN
SYSTEM I. SERVER THE NEED TO
MOVE CONTAIN TO MEDICAID AND I
THINK THAT GUIDANCE WE DID LAST
NIGHT ON MASS GATHERING AS A
FIRST STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
AND WILL. BE PUT. ON OUR
WEBSITE. HE IS AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE YOU GOT PERMISSION TO
USE EXPIRED AND NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS THAT'S TWENTY ONE
MILLION- WE'RE SENDING THOSE
OUT WE- NINETY RESOURCE
REQUESTS AND WE FILLED THE
FIRST FIFTY FIVE OR- THE-
WILLING. TO VOTE SEVEN CARE TO
CONTINUING TO. BE OUR WE HAVE
CRAFT ARE REQUEST FOR THE
STREET NATIONAL STOCKPILE.
ABOUT A MONTH. COUPLE DAYS.
TODAY BUT THERE ARE THIS IS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE IN THE WAY
HELLO I'M TO DROP A PRECAUTION
WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT
CERTAINLY MORE AWAY REQUIRING
NEVER NEGATIVE PRESS ICE COMES
EVERYTHING BUT I'M NOT AIR
HOUSING. THERE'S GOING CARE
WERE I KNOW WASHING HAS MOVED
AWAY. LOOKING UP AS WELL TO
TAKE PEOPLE OFF OF CORN AND DO
BOTH A SYMPTOM TAX IN FAVOR TAX
OKAY AS SOON AS YOU CAN PUT
THAT IN PLACE. SEE SEE ME ABOUT
WHAT. YOU'RE FOR TO MOVE THAT
WAY. TIONS SIXTEEN TO STATEWIDE
STRATEGIES- WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT NOT EVERYBODY'S IN THE
SAME PLACE IN A STATE WHERE
SOME PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ANY KIND
IT SAYS MAYBE A COLLECTION OF
NOT TESTING BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL SEE YOU ON CAN'T. TOWARDS
ALLOW THE ALLOW LOCAL FLAG.
UNDERSTANDING THAT PEOPLE WANT
TO STATEWIDE APPROACH A MORE
THE MORE WE CAN MOVE THAT
DIRECT. I'M POLITICS. WE'VE
BEEN PLANNING FOR PAN THAT FOR
A LONG TIME WE KNOW THAT IF
THIS COP REALLY BAD WE WOULD
NEED SOMETHING EYOND WHAT WE
CAN DO IN OUR OUR SYSTEM AND SO
BEEN PLANNING FOR- DIFFERENT
TYPES OF CARE APPLE BUT
PLANNING FOR THE WORST BUT- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO OUR RELATIONS
WITH HARPER HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS RIDER ASSOCIATION.
BECAUSE THOSE ORDINARY NOW TO
KEEP PLANNING THINGS THAT. WE
ARE. PLAY COMES FROM. FINANCE
YES PLEASE. SENATE
PARTICULARLY- M. WE DID HAVE
ONE QUESTION- IS WHETHER THE
EMERGENCY FUNDING AT THE STATE
LEVEL- WHAT HOW THAT BEING. THE
TWENTY THE TWENTY MILLION YEAH
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE UP THERE'S
A TWENTY MILLION REQUESTED
WASN'T VERY MUCH SPECIFICITY
ABOUT WHAT THE- WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING USED FOR.
DON'T QUESTION THE- FACT MAYBE
MORE LATER WE ARE CONTINUING TO
LOOK AT THAT AND I THINK PART
OF IT IS UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
ON THEM LOOKING WHERE THE CAPS
ARE. THEY HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
UP SO. THE SITUATION WITH THE
TESTING RIGHT- ON THE ALSO
SURVEYS THAT WE DO HERE A
LITTLE BIT MIXED MESSAGES IN
TERMS AVAILABILITY OF TESTS
RIGHT SO I UNDERSTAND THAT CC
SENDS OUT THESE KIDS BUT THE
KIDS ARE VERY. I SAY NOT
COMPLETE THEY DON'T ALLOW OU
TO DO THE ENTIRE TEST THAT THE
KIDS COME TEN CERTAIN
COMPONENTS IN THIS RESEARCH THE
LAB RESULTS FINALLY THE OTHER
COMPONENTS AND SOME OF THOSE
OTHER COMPONENTS MAY BE
AVAILABLE TO THAT LAB OR
SOMETHING SO. THAT'S AND
HITTING. AND THEN THERE'S I
HEARD SOMETHING IS ALONG THE
LINES OF WELL WE CAN'T DO THE
TEST BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
PERMISSION EXIT OFF BEAT
CERTAIN CRITERIA. OF THE
PRESIDENT'S SAYING ANYBODY WHO
WANTS ORDER A TEST TO THE
DOCTOR ONCE OR TESTICULAR TEST.
AND THEN WE ARE LIKE- WELL
THERE'S NO QUOTE THERE'S NO
BACKLOG BUT THE SAME TIME WE
KNOW PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE SO
WE'LL JUST HEAR MY OWN
DISTRICT. WE HAVE A SYSTEM
FACILITY THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THERE WE HAVE ONE WOMAN
WHO PASSED AWAY AND I'M IN
PASSED AWAY. AND TO LIKE WELL
HOW THE PEOPLE YOU TESTING
THEY'RE GOING AND SO. THERE
ISN'T A BACKLOG BUT YET WE'RE
NOT TESTING PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
THEY WERE SHOULD TO. AND IT'S
THE- A BACK. HAVE ENOUGH SO
THERE FOR THEY DON'T. ORDER
THEM. SO THERE'S A LOT OF.
AROUND TEST AVAIL. IS THAT
CENTER- I THINK MOST PEOPLE.
ANY TELL ME ONE WRONG MOST
PEOPLE SAYING WELL WE JUST
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TEST PERIOD.
THAT PROVIDE A PROBLEM BUT IS
THAT ALSO THEREFORE CAUSING
PEOPLE TO BEHAVE IN CERTAIN
WAYS THAT. IT IS REFLECTING THE
REAL DEMAND THAT WE SHOULD BE
HAVING FOR TESTING. WHAT THE
HELL YOU THINK ABOUT SOUTH. IN
TERMS OF BEILINSON SO.
COUNTRIES THERE TURN THE CURVE.
EIGHT COMPARED TO SO WE STE
WE'RE FLYING BLIND BECAUSE THE
NUMBER TOTAL NUMBER OF TESTS
THAT WERE A BIT THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO. NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TRY DOESN'T REFLECT WHAT'S
REALLY GOING ON OUT THERE IS
THE MY RATE. NO I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT IN TERMS OF THE
SURVEILLANCE TESTING I THINK IN
TERMS OF TREATMENT DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT MUCH WE ARE
PREPARED TO GET TOUGH. CLOUT
I'M JUST CAME ONLINE THIS WEEK
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
CA BOBCORE AND THEIR
RAMPING UP THEIR CAPACITY I
THINK WE STILL WANT TO WEAR
TIES. BE TESTED AND THEN MOVED
TO THE. WE ACTUALLY HAVE OUT
THERE. BECAUSE WE DON'T. IN
WEEK WHAT YOU TELL WHEN YOU
TEST MORE YOU WILL FIND MORE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE I'M- BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY KNOW MY OWN I'D SAY
OKAY. SAYS THE ONLY DO THE TEST
TODAY. WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
DO YOU HAVE. TO DO MORE THAN
THAT I THINK IT IS A BECAUSE
THE TYPE OF TASK BUT ON A
HEALTH LAB IS MY MORE ME STAFF
AND SEVEN VERY DE THAN A LAB DO
RIGHT I HEARD IT'S THAT
OBVIOUSLY TO TERM LIMITS
STAFFING WISE BUT- BUT HERE'S-
I HEARD. TO DO WITH. BUT THE
COMPONENTS THE OUT OF WILL ALSO
THE ARE THEY HAVE TO THE KIDS
ON THE LOUNGE DO CERTAIN THE
WRITERS SAYING AS OF WEEK THEY
HAVE CAPACITY TO RUN MORE TESTS
AND BUT THEY RIGHT THERE WERE
MISSED SOME OF THE PIECES LAST
WEEK. RIGHT AND SO ARE WE
HELPING FOR SO IT'S UP TO THE
FLOORS ARE READ LIVE STEP HE
DID FROM LABS BUT THAT. WHAT DO
YOU NEED AND WHY ARE WE LIKE
BREAKING THROUGH ON ON THAT DAY
A SIR FEEL LIKE. PEOPLE WELL
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO OR WE
DON'T HAVE CERTAIN COMPONENTS
OR SOMETHING THAT WHERE WE
TRULY DOWN AND GETTING PAST
THAT ARE WE ARE JUST READ THIS
WEEK OF ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO FIND OUT. THIS IS
MISSING WHAT. I'M MANY OF THEM
HAVE DONE COMMON AND SO NOT A
OF THEY'VE BEEN BACK YOU KNOW
LIKE THEY THEY AND MANY OF MARK
TO HAVE JUST BEEN TESTING FOR
THE WEAKER THERE SPEED ADDING
OTHER REACHED EVER. ABLE TO
TEST AND BROUGHT NUMBER. THAT
WE THINK. BE HELPFUL. OKAY A AT.
GET A- SELECT IS AS THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO AND AGAIN WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD CAPACITY IN THE
PRIVATE LABS YOU KNOW YOU SEE
DEVELOP THE WAY AND OTHER WHAT
THE LOW RATE A STEP FOR SEE B.
ON THE RUN THE TEST. IT
INTERESTING THAT THREE SEIZE
RIGHT WE DO THEIR RAM UP AT
WAITING FOR APPROVALS WHAT'S
HOLDING IT UP LIKE LIKE DO IT
TODAY I MEAN IT DOES WE CAN DO
IT WHY CAN'T. YOU DO IT WHY IS
IT LIKE THANK YOU FOR DAYS FOR
THE THAT. IT'S GOING. I CAN
SPEAK TO ONE OF THE LOCAL
PUBLIC OKAY WE IS EQUIPMENT
VERY QUICK IS OUT DAY WE
HAVEN'T KEEPING AN UP THERE IS
A ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
PIECE OF A THAT CAN EAT THE
DOUBLE FAULT THE AMOUNT OF
TESTING YOU PER DAY CALLED IN
ROBOT NINE US SEVEN TWO IF WE
FOUND THE FINE WE BY THEM AND
YOU CAN BUY THEM BECAUSE THERE
NOW YOU. RIGHT BUT WOULD BE
EXACTLY RIGHT AS A PREPARATION
OKAY. AND I ADD ANOTHER
LIMITING TO THAT WE HAVE. YEAH
FOCUS THE TECH. IN ORDER TO
ATTAIN THE SPACE. RIGHT YOU
WERE FULL. SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
MORE TEST KITS THAT'S NOT GOING
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM IF WE HAVE
LIMITED PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. SO WE'RE ALREADY
SHORT WE NEED TO MOVE TO DROP
WHAT PRODUCTION SO WE CAN USE
THAT AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE. BUT THAT WILL.
QUICKLY BECOME A RATE LIMITING
FACTOR CONCERNED. DOES THE
TESTING THE RESULT WILL END UP
BACK IN HOSPITALS AND WE WILL
AGAIN BE- BACKLOGGED AS A
RESULT. OKAY SO I KNOW THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO TAP INTO THESE
VARIOUS RESERVES FOR HE QUIT
AND THREE NO I MEAN IS THERE
SUFFICIENT IN THE RISEN IN
THOSE RESERVES THAT IT IS HAVE
A BROADER QUESTION AND SOME OF
THE INTERNET RESERVES ARE. WE
FINDING WAYS. PLEASE REALIZE
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN IS ALSO BEEN
DISRUPTED. OUR THAT WE ARE
FILLING SO FAR WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FILL A RESOURCE FOR
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN AND WE'RE
FEELING THE REST OF THEM AND WE
WILL MAKE A STRATEGIC NATIONAL.
REQUEST ON THIS ALSO APPLIES.
HEY REALIZES TRIED NOT SO MUCH
THE QUESTION. ALTHOUGH PRETTY
BIG STAY I MEAN A- IT IS THE-
IS THE- SUPPLY CHAIN FOR
PRODUCING EVEN MORE I MEAN I'M
JUST THINKING LIKE EVERY PART
OF THE COUNTRY'S GONNA BE THE
MAN THE THESE. CINDER BY TEN
THE PARCEL OF THEM OUT WHERE'S
THE FIRST ADDITIONAL ONES GONNA
COME FOR. PART OF THE
CHALLENGES ME THESE THINGS ARE.
IN CHINA AND SPOTS BEEN A RATE
LIMITING STEP IN TERMS OF THE
FIVE THEIR SUPPLIES. OKAY SO
YES SO WHAT ARE YOU ONE OF THE
FOR FUTURE IS TO LOOK AT OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN FOR. RATE I MEAN
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THINGS WILL
CALM THE NEXT ONE'S PROBABLY
NOT GOING. WILL I KNOW COME
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT- MADE
THE CITY HAD A- I REALIZE. IN
OUR EFFORT. BE MORE EFFICIENT
THE MORE COST EFFECTIVE RIGHT
JUST IN TIME I MEAN THAT I GOT
IT I STUDIED ALL THAT STUFF AS
WELL AND YOU KNOW AND SO FORTH
BUT SO IN IN SPECIALLY FOR
THINGS ARE NEEDED A CRISIS IT
AS SOON AS YOU LIKE RELEASING
MONEY BECAUSE OF PILING UP
STUFF- WE'RE- HAVING STORE
STUFF. ETCETERA BUT DID NOT AND
THIS IS THE TIME WE PAY THE
PRICE FOR THAT. SO WITH THAT I
REALIZE THAT I'M GOING TO MIL
DESCRIBE SO THE WE CAN'T MIND
CLOCK BACKS NO USED SPENDING A
WHOLE LOT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE SHOULD DO THAT. WEEKS
AGO WE NEED. FOR BUT ONE THE
BOARD. IS WHAT WE GET MORE.
SOME TELL QUIT RATE DOUBT. FROM
THE FACE THEY'RE SICK THAT THAT
WILL IN THE EIGHT TIME PERIOD
THE ISSUE ME THE AND I FIVE
REST. OF THE COUNTY ISSUE OTHER
WAS ALSO A RECALL FROM CARDINAL
OF SURGICAL GOWNS THAT WAS THE
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE HOLES IN THE
SWISS CHEESE JUST LINED UP- AND
WE JUST CAN'T FORGET THAT THE
FACE SHIELDS ARE CRITICAL PIECE
OF ALL OF THIS TO. ALL RIGHT.
TWELVE TO TALK TO DC ABOUT
TELEPHONIC VISITS AND OBVIOUSLY
I KNOW WE HAVE THE MAIN REQUIRE
FEDERAL ACTION TO BUT OKAY YES
THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY VERY
VERY HELPFUL AND HEALTH CENTERS
ARE REALLY WANTING TO TRIAGE
THEIR PATIENTS OVER THE PHONE
ITS GUIDANCE THE CDC HAS
RECOMMENDED- AND THEY'RE REALLY
YOU'RE OUT THERE THAT TOOK INTO
THE HEALTH CENTER IF THEY ARE
PRETENDING SIX SO. I THE
SERVICE OVER THE PHONE. SB IT
WOULD UP ALLOW MORE SPACE IN
THE HEALTH CENTER AS WELL AND
THEY WOULD HAVE MORE ABILITY
FOR SEARCH CAPACITY FOR WHEN
AND IF AND WHEN YOU KNOW.
HOSPITALS NEED TO SEND THEIR
NON PATIENTS TO US THAT WE BE
GREAT OKAY. THEN I GUESS IN
TERMS OF. OWNERS HOMES I MEAN
THE STATE'S THE PLACE GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THIS PARTICULAR
AFFECTION MOST TERRIFYING
BECAUSE WE'RE SAID THE- I MEAN
TWENTY PERCENT. MORTALITY RATE
IN PEOPLE OVER SEVENTY- SO. AND
WE SAW THAT IN THAT NURSING
HOMES AND SO EVERY TIME I HEAR
ABOUT TWELVE THERE SO. IN
NURSING AS IT HOW MANY PEOPLE
BEEN EXPOSED SO I GUESS. YOU
TALKED ABOUT NOT PUTTING OF
COURSE. HOUSING PEOPLE BUT ALSO
I MEAN I DON'T. THREE TURNER
NURSING HOMES IN THE FORCE LIKE
EVERYONE STAY AWAY AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU SCREAM THE PEOPLE
TAKING CARE OF THEM AND SO
FORTH PEOPLE ACTUALLY DO HAVE
TO COME INTO WORK. THANK YOU
FOR WE AS SOON AS- AND-
INDUSTRY FEEL VERY STRONGLY
THAT. SINCE THE RISK IS
GREATEST TO OUR FOLKS DEREK WE
TAKE THE MOST. PREVENTIVE
MEDICATION STEPS TO PROTECT
THEM. AB WE'VE NOT BEEN TOLD
THAT THIS FOR HER WRISTS WITH.
THE DIRECTIONS WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
IS THAT- THIS POTENTIALLY COULD
BE- AB. CONTAGIOUS EVEN WITHOUT
SHOWING SYMPTOMS RIGHT WE- TO
WHAT EXTENT WE CAN PROTECT THE
PEOPLE AND THAT'S A
CONSERVATIVE STEP WE HAVE TO
TAKE THE STEPS WE CAN'T
GUARANTEE THE EVERYTHING BUT
THAT'S THE BEST CHANCE WE- GIVE
THE- CITY TO DO THAT. SO THAT
SOUNDS A BIT MORE TESTS MORE
SURVEILLANCE AT LEAST OF THIS.
OF THE STAFF WHO WORKED THERE
FOR SO YOU TRY TO CATCH PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT BE THERE MILDLY A
SYMPTOMATIC. REALLY COME IN THE
WORK. I DON'T KNOW IS THAT IS
THERE'S AS VINCENT STRATEGY
ABOUT NURSING HOMES AND
PARTICULARLY THE FACT THE OF
STAFF WE HAVE TO GO ON YOU KNOW
COME IN AND OUT I GUESS WE CAN
BAN NONESSENTIAL PERSONNEL TELL
THEM THAT THEY SHOULD MAKE
PHONE CALLS ARE LEFT UNSAID OF
COMING IN WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE
ACCESS TO WORK THERE. EVERY
THOUGHT OF. BUT ABOUT. WHAT
WHAT. WHAT'S THE PLAN IS. YEAH
WE WANT. OUR STUDENTS. SO WE
PUT OUT OF ACTION CONTROL
GUIDANCE AS- OF THINGS THAT
THEY CAN DO WITHIN THE FACILITY
AND WE CERTAINLY ARE LOOKING
OUT PROGRAM FLEXES. IN TERMS OF
SYMPTOM TAX ON THAT SON. I'M
AND EVEN RESTRICTIONS ON
VETERANS AND STAFF. I'M AND-
THE ANYBODY THAT'S EXPOSED TO
ABOUT. CO IT. PATIENT HAS BEEN
QUARANTINE THE REASON ROLES MAY
BE NO TOWARD SYMPTOMS P. VERTEX
OF THAT WERE NOT RISKING. THEM
PASSING ON THIS TRANSMITTING
THIS VIRUS THAT CAN I JUST POSE
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE I KNOW
TESTING IS NOT THE SILVER BALL
DOESN'T SOLVE EVERYTHING BUT-
IN LIKE IN THE ABSENT TESTING
WHAT WE DO IS WE- COUNTY PEOPLE
FOURTEEN DAYS. WITH TESTING WE
ACTUALLY KNOW A REPOSITORY NOT
WE DON'T NEED FOURTEEN DAYS
RIGHT WE GET AN ANSWER ON THIS
YOU MIGHT BE NEGATIVE ONE DAY
AND TWO DAYS LATER RIGHT. AS I
HAVE SAID EVEN IF YOU'RE
SYMPTOMATIC ON ONE DAY AND THEN
THREE DAYS LATER YOU'RE STILL
SYMPTOMATIC AND WE TEST YOU
AGAIN SO WE'RE A LITTLE. OUT OF
ALL SUNSET THIRTY FROM THAT AND
SO WE DO THINK WE'RE TAKING. AN
AX IN TERMS OF. I PEOPLE. CLOSE
I SWEAR PEOPLE BETTER. SECOND
COME WHY THEY'RE BEING TASK OR
WITH KIND. AND QUARANTINE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CLOSE CONTACT
UNTIL WE KNOW FOR SURE ABOUT
THEIR- BABY THEY'RE SERVED UP A
QUARANTINE PERIOD OR IF THEY'RE
VERY CLOSE CONTACT WITH TEST
BOB. AND THREE THE TESTS ARE
ANALYST'S SENSITIVITY
SPECIFICITY TODAY I MEAN TO PCR
RIGHT SO THEY WANT TO TALK TO A
JAIL TERMS A FALSE POSITIVE
FALSE NEGATIVE RATES. AND I
GUESS WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH
TESTING WERE WERE SO WORRIED
BUT LET'S START DOING A LARGE
LARGE NUMBER TESTING ANY OF THE
THING WAS A FALSE POSITIVE WHAT
MAKE FALSE NEGATIVE RATES RIGHT.
IT IS OUR PEACE HERE TESTS AT.
THE PERFORMANCE HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD- THE LIMIT OF DETECTION IS
TEN. COPIES SO THAT'S A VERY
LOW LIMITED OKAY SO WE THINK
THE SENSITIVITY IS VERY HIGH
ALREADY HAVE NOT SEEN ISSUE
WITH- WITH FALSE POSITIVE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S HELPFUL- ALL
RIGHT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT WELL- I
GUESS WILL BE A LOT OF THINGS
TO DO AND- FIGURE OUT AND THEN
HOPEFULLY WE'RE LEARNING THINGS
THAT WILL SINCE THIS IS A
BUDGET HEARING AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET AND- WHO NEEDS FOR WILL
BE IN. JUNE KNOW ONE CAN ARGUE.
BERNIE ITSELF. THE OVER THE
NEXT MONTH OR TWO BUT I DON'T
KNOW- WOULD ACTUALLY TRY TO
STRETCH IT OUT. EIGHT TWO ONE
TO STRETCH IT OUT BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT OUR HOSPITALS GET
OVERWHELMED AT ONE TIME- BUT
ALSO HOPEFULLY- WE WILL NOT
FORGET WHAT WERE FACING A IN.
THE AND THINK ABOUT ALLOCATING
SOME RESOURCES TO BEING BETTER
PREPARED NOT THEM GEN I'D SAY
THAT WE TOOK SOME STEPS NOT
THAT WE HUNDRED THIRD I MEAN
WE- PLAN WE- EXECUTING THAT
PLAN WILL PUT ADDITIONAL
SOURCES BUT I THINK WE- NOTE
BEHIND. NO THE GREAT RECESSION
HIT IT CETERA. HE THINK ABOUT
SOME INVESTMENTS WE WANT TO
MAKE TO BE SURE A RIP THIS IS
EVEN BETTER THE NEXT TIME
AROUND SO OKAY BUT FOR RIGHT
NOW WE GOT TAKE CARE OF IT WE
HAVE A FRONT OF A SO OKAY THANK
YOU- ANYTHING. MUCH. SURE SO.
TESTING PROTECT. OKAY LET'S
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
MASTER DATA MANAGEMENT
SUSTAINABILITY WE HEARD FROM
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR DATA
IS AT THE CORE OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
HAVING A DATA. HEY WELCOME. SO
I GUESS SAID WITH A FEW NEW
PEOPLE AROUND THE TABLE SO WE
SHOULD DO SOME INTRODUCTIONS
FIRST. SO RIGHT. YES LEBRON
THAT'S GOOD ON OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
AM DAY ANYMORE I AM THE ACTING
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH STATISTICS AND
INFORMATICS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THAT
RIGHT NOW I THINK WOMEN DO
PERSONS BEING HERE FOR FINANCE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD. AND PERSON DEPARTMENT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AGAINST. THANK
YOU. A CD PH REQUESTS TEN
POSITIONS AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE HEALTH
STATISTICS SPECIAL FUNDS. IN
FISCAL YEARS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ON GOING. TO INCREASE
DEPARTMENT WIDE ADVANCED
ANALYTICS AND PREDICTIVE
ANALYTICS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DECISION MAKING. TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTING MASTER DID MANAGE
PRODIGIES. FOR IMPROVED HEALTH
INFORMATION MANAGEMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF DATA DRIVEN
CAN BE INTERVENTIONS. THE
REQUESTED POSITIONS ARE
EXISTING POSITION IS BETTER
FUNDED WITH LIMITED TERM.
PROGRAM FUNDING THAT IS SENDING
THIS REQUEST IS TO CONTINUE
FUNDING THE POSITION. STATE
SPECIAL FUNDS THANK YOU. HELLO
FINANCE COMMENTS OKAY AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT- IS PART OF THE
IT IS IN THE DEPARTMENTS BEEN
REALLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO RAMP UP ITS DATA CAPACITY-
GIVEN THE FACT THAT DATA IS AT
THE CORE OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
DEAL  LOT OF DATA- SO IS THIS
THIS IS PART TIME GOING EFFORT.
YES THIS OKAY. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT HAPPEN OKAY VERY GOOD
AND IN THE STATE THE SOURCE OF
THE FUNDS IS FROM. DAN IS LIKE.
VIEW FROM FIVE OF. OTHER TYPES
OF THING THAT IS CORRECT THE
HEALTH STATISTICS PARTIAL FUND
OKAY AND- THE VOLUME OF. MONEY
THAT COMES THROUGH THE FUND IS
SUFFICIENT TO SUSTAIN THIS. AT
THIS TIME YES OKAY AT THIS TIME
YES OKAY. JUST KEEP HAVING
BABIES I GUESS RIGHT NOW. OR
PERHAPS. ALL RIGHT OKAY WELL
THERE'S A WHOLE NOTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC ISSUE WE WILL GET
INTO ABOUT THAT ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD. AND THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS THE- A DEATH
PROGRAM AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. WELCOME. RIGHT. IT
WOULD HAVE EVERYONE THE NEW
PEOPLE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
FIRST FOR THE RECORD AND ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAJOR NUMBER
ALSO THE ASSISTANT DIVISION
CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF AIDS
THANK YOU THE NUMBER TELL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD ALL
RIGHT WEN YOU GO IN BEGIN.
OKAY PERFECTS ALL PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR EIGHT OUT
NOVEMBER ESTIMATE AND THEN I AM
I. ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
A SO THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
THAT. INCLUDED EIGHT UP LOCAL
SYSTEMS FUNDING OF. FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION. WITH NO- STATE
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION. TO
REVISE CURRENT NEAR. TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET. IS FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE POINT
THREE MILLION. THIRTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION.
HE'S BEEN. PORT ONCE. 4% WHEN
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACTS THE NET DECREASE IS
PRIMARILY DUE TO A DECREASE IN
PROJECTED MEDICATION
EXPENDITURES PARTIALLY OFFSET
BY PROJECTED TO INCREASE A
PRIVATE INSURANCE MEDICAL OUT
OF POCKET EXPENDITURES AND
CHANGES IN ITS BUDGET OR DO YOU
COMPARE TO TWENTY NINETEEN BUT
THAT WITH A- PIECE OF EIGHT.
SIX NINE DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS. AND AN INCREASE OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND EIGHT
EVERYBODY FUNDS. OPPOSE EIGHT
APPLE LOCAL SYSTEM FUNDING FOR
BUDGET YEAR IS FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION.
AN INCREASE OF EIGHTEEN MILLION
OR 4% WHEN COMPARED TO THE NEXT
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET AX. THE
AND THE INCREASE IS PRIMARILY
DUE TO A D. INCREASES AND
PROJECTED INSURANCE PREMIUM AND
MEDICAL OUT OF EXPENDITURES
PARTIALLY OFFSET BY PROJECTED
DECREASE IN MEDICATION
EXPENDITURES CHANGES IN A
DOUBTS BUDGET FORTY ONE
COMPARED TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT TO DECREASE OF TWENTY ONE
POINT NINE MILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS AN INCREASE THIRTY NINE
POINT NINE. IN A FIVE. WITHOUT
ON HOW TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THANK YOU LA ONCE BY ITS-
QUESTION BUT- EVERYTHING'S
PRETTY WELL COVERED SO
OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM- SO WHEN WE GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO THE- ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS THE- EIGHT
AT A FIVE. JUST A GROSS INCOME
INFORMATION. PERFECT SO THAT A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PROPOSES AMENDMENTS TO
ALLOW FOR THE ELECTRONIC
RETRIEVAL OF IT OUT CLIENTS
MODIFIED ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME
A DATA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES EIGHT UP USE
APPLICANTS MATCH I FOR PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY AND CURRENT ALL THE
ALL THE ALLOW IT TO BE PROVIDED
JUST A GROSS INCOME DOES NOT
INCLUDE SOLD IN TO CALCULATE
FIND ADDRESS ACROSS. WELL AFTER
B. IMATION NECESSARY TO A
PROVIDE BY ADDRESS GROSS INCOME
AT THE BE CENTS TAX DATA ONLY
FOR THE EIGHT HOUR APPLICANT
THESE PROPOSED CHANGES WOULD
STREAMLINED DATA COLLECTION
ELIMINATE ST OF BIRTH. AND
ELIMINATE CONFLICTS IN CURRENT
LAW. THANK YOU WILLIAM FINANCE
OKAY ALL THIS ONLY GOOD THINGS
TO DO. ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON
THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX THE
PROCTER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SO
THIS IS OUR SECOND TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL. A PUBLIC HEALTH IS
PROPOSING AN AMENDMENT TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE TO ALLOW
THE PROPER SYSTEMS PROGRAM TO
PAY FOR AN INITIAL THIRTY DAY
SUPPLY OF PROP AND PET
MEDICATION. CURRENT STATUTE
LIMITS CALL PRESCRIPTIONS. FOR
PROP APP THAT FOR PREVENT TO
FURNISH UP TO FOURTEEN DAYS A
PREP AND PET MEDICATION FOR AN
INITIAL DISPENSE. AND ALSO UP
TO TWENTY EIGHT DAYS A PATH FOR
MEDICATION OR MEDICATIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
UNTIL RECENTLY PROVIDED WAS THE
ONLY FDA APPROVED MEDICATION
FOR PROP AND IT'S A COMPONENT
AND THE FIRST LINE- RECOMMENDED
TAP REGIMENS. GILEAD SCIENCES
IS CURRENTLY THE ONLY
MANUFACTURER PROVIDED AND ONLY
PACKAGES FOR BONTA IN BOTTLES
CONTAINING THIRTY TABLETS. THE
FDA'S EXPECTATIONS IS THAT
DRUGS ARE REPACKAGING
ACCORDANCE WITH THE- HANDLING
AND STORAGE INSTRUCTIONS
PROVIDED AN FDA APPROVED
LABELING. THE PACKAGE INSERT
FOR TREVAN I DID BY THE DRUG
MANUFACTURER SPECIFICALLY
INSTRUCTS DISPENSABLE IN THE
ORIGINAL CONTAINER. BUT ONLY
MEANT TO MANY HAS BEEN REACHING
OUT AND SENDING LETTERS TO RE
PACKAGERS EXPLICITLY
INSTRUCTING THEM- TO STOP-
REPACKAGING BOTTLES OF
TOMATOES. AND TO THAT AND RE
PACKAGERS ARE RESISTANT TO
VIOLATING THESE INSTRUCTIONS IN
MOST OF SEIZE REPACKAGING OF
THE MEDICATION. PLEASE BARRIERS
TO PROP UP AS AN ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT PROVISION AS
PERMITTED BY LAW. THE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN UNABLE TO- PREPPING
PART FOURTEEN DAY PRE PACKAGED
DOSES IT DOSAGES AND IS UNABLE
TO CONTRACT THE PHARMACIES TO
BREAK UP EXISTING BOTTLES.
HELLO FINANCE SO. SO BASICALLY
THIS IS GOING TO COST FEE
REBATE FUND BETWEEN EIGHTEEN
AND THIRTY THOUSAND ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION. BECAUSE THE
MANUFACTURER OF THE DRUGS IS
UNWILLING TO PACKAGE IT IN A
WILL PAY THAT I MEAN I COULD I
COULD YOU KNOW I MEAN IS THERE
SOME PLACE WE CAN. BUT FIRST OF
ALL THE QUESTION IS THIS RIGHT-
WE PUT THOSE LIMITS. SO FROM A
TREATMENT POINTED VIEWED AS
APPROPRIATE ARE. OR IS IT THERE
IS PROVIDING EVERY THIRTY DAYS
STILL THE BETTER THING TO DO I
MEAN I GUESS SO THAT'S ASIDE
FROM WHETHER DATE IT OR NOT
WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING.
FOURTEEN DAY THIS IS OPTIMAL
WAY TO GO ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
OF HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE IS
THAT WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
THE NATIONAL DISPENSED. YOUR
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
CLIENT'S ELIGIBLE FOR THAT PROP
OUT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND SO.
BY PROVIDING THIRTY DAYS WE
ALSO GET THE ADDED BENEFIT OF.
BEING ABLE TO NOW. THE CLIENT
TO OTHER RESOURCES FOR ARGO
PLANE- PROVISION FOR A-
MEDICATION. AND SO FOR PAP.
ALLOW YOU THIRTY DAYS ACTUALLY
ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE TO YOU KNOW
INITIATE THAT ENTIRE REGIMENT
ON THE FRONT END AND THEY DON'T
HAVE TO. SCRAMBLE AND FIND
ANOTHER PAIR RESOURCES COMPLETE.
OKAY AND THEN. THAT ON PATH
RIGHT I'M TUCKER I TRAINED IN A
PRESS. YOU SAID THIS ALLOWS
IT'S TIME TO NAVIGATE THEM TO
OTHER PAY RESOURCES FOR THEIR
THERE'S NOT A GAP IN THEIR
RIGHT. SENATE REGS THOSE AS I
MEAN I GUESS. I'M DOING IT IF
THE MAIN REASON IS ACTUALLY
WE'RE TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW WE
GOTTA GET BETTER OUTCOMES
RIGHT- I HATE TO SAY THAT WE
ARE HAVING TO SPEND MORE MONEY
BECAUSE I MEAN FACTURE IS
CITED. I'M GOING. KEYGEN THE
STERN WAY FORCE YOU TO BUY MORE
THE MEDICATIONS. RIGHT I MEAN
THERE SHOULD BE SOME
CONVERSATION THEN WITH THAN AND
IN IT AND IS THAT- THAT'S THE
ONLY CAR WITH SOMEONE ELSE
COMING ON LINE WITH THE ARE NOT.
GENERIC SHIMADA IS- SCHEDULED
TO HIT THE MARKET I BELIEVE
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY- AND
I BELIEVE HAVE A
PHARMACEUTICALS IS GONNA
EXCLUSIVITY RIGHTS AND- AS THE
SOLE MANY FACTORS. FOR ABOUT A
YEAR OKAY SO I GUESS I GUESS
THE THING IS THIS RIGHT I MEAN.
THREE DAYS IS KELLY TO THEIR
OUTCOMES GOT THAT. NOTES GUNS
COST A LITTLE MORE MAY WE GET
BETTER OUTCOMES AND BUT TO SAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE SPENDING
MORE MONEY PRIMARILY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF WELL BECAUSE THE
MANUFACTURERS USES TO AND THEN
YEAH. TO GET GO **** MAYBE
EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY. THIRTY
PROVIDE. BASIC FORCED TO. GIVE
YOU KNOW SPEND MORE JUST
BECAUSE THE MANUFACTURER ONLY
WANTS TO BE A FIXTURES IN
CERTAIN PACKAGE AND I GET YOU
KNOW I GET THE RATE. IS WHY
THEY DON'T PEOPLE CAN OPEN AND
LIKE THAT NO TERMS OF. BUT THAT
THAT'S THE TO ME WOULD BE IS.
FRUSTRATING AND THAT WE SHOULD
FIGURE OUT HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA
OPENING STATEMENT TO MAKE
ACTOR. ABOUT THIS IS THAT. IF
YOU JUST SPENDING MONEY BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THEY- TAKE IT.
NUMBER MAGIC THE THIRTY. THANKS
FOR IS A IS A- NARAL OF TINA
FEY MIGHT BE WHAT PIC A THE
OKAY FOR EIGHT THIRTY RELEASE
SO JUST PICK. BUT IT ADDS THAT
MAKES IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE
AND WE'RE IN TOTAL AGREEMENT WE
DID INITIATE THE MANUFACTURER
IN DISCUSSIONS EARLY ON DURING
OUR DISCOVERY PHASE. AND FOR WE
WERE TOLD THAT DID NOT HAVE ANY
IMMEDIATE PLANS TO CHANGE
THEIR- THEIR APPLE DISPENSING.
OKAY OUR EIGHT. OKAY. YES MOVE
ON FOR THAT OKAY WELL YOU IT'S
FEDERAL OF THE WORLD MAYBE WE
CAN KEEP HAVING DISCUSSIONS.
ALL RIGHT. ISSUE SEVEN EIGHT
APP AND ROMAN SYSTEM
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
SUPPORT. SO THE EIGHT UP IN
ROMAN SYSTEM MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS AND SUPPORT BCP
REQUEST NINE POSITIONS AND FOUR
POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION FROM
THE EIGHT I APPRECIATE FINE
STARTING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO PROVIDE FOR THE
ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND SUPPORT
OPERATIONS. THAT HAPPEN ROMAN
SYSTEM THE A. S. WAS INITIALLY-DEVELOPED AS AN INTERIM
SOLUTION TO SUPPORT A DOCTORAL
BENEFITS MANAGEMENT IN MARCH OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. DUE TO THE
EMERGENCY NATURE OF IT XIN
TURKEY I WENT LIVE AS A MINIMAL
SOLUTION BILL ALL THE WITH FOR
ALL THE NECESSARY TO MAN. LG
THE INFORMATION OVER TIME. BUT
SHOULD NOMINAL. AND STATE
OPERATIONS IN JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
APPROVED A SERIES OF A US
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WOULD ALLOW
C. PH TO USE A US AS EIGHT UPS
LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR A DOCTOR
RAMAN BENEFITS MANAGEMENT THE
POWER PROCESS TO CONCLUDE IN
OCTOBER TWENTY NIGHT. SINCE THE
EIGHTY S. INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION PUBLIC HEALTH
WAS ABLE TO USE A SYSTEM TO
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE NEW
PROGRAMS. AND EXPANDED EIGHT UP
SERVICES APPROVED PREVIOUSLY BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE. THESE ENHANCEMENTS
HAVE DRASTICALLY INCREASE
REQUIREMENTS OF BOTH PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFF AND VENDORS. THE
RESOURCES PROVIDED UNDER THIS
BCP WILL BE USED TO ENSURE
SYSTEM FEATURES WORK AS
EXPECTED AND MAINTAIN THE LEVEL
DATA INTEGRITY JERRY TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE IT OUT
CLIENTS. HELLO IT'S ALL RIGHT
SO SIDE IT EXCEPT YOUR IS
ACTUALLY SO OF COURSE NOW-
STATES ESSENTIALLY PERFORMING
THIS FUNCTION PREVIOUS YOU
TRIED CONTRACTING IT OUT RIGHT
AND FORTY THAT WAS NOT VERY
SUCCESSFUL THE VENDOR DID NOT
FROM. THE IS NECESSARY- OF THE
M. CURIOUS IS TOO SO GIVEN HOW
MUCH WE WERE PLAYING TO GIVE
THE VENDOR WHO UNFORTUNATELY
DIDN'T WAS NOT ABLE TO PERFORM
THE STANDARD. AND HOW MUCH FOR
ASKING ARE WE- WE ACTUALLY
SPENDING THE SIMILAR AMOUNT OF
MONEY OR- OURS SO I MEAN WE
HAVE THIS REQUEST HERE AND I
THINK YOU WE DO IT. SO I KNOW
HOW MUCH THE RIVER ENTERED BACK
TO US FOR. BUT I WE NEED TO GO
BACK AND ACTUALLY DO THAT
COMPARISON I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE BIT LIKE COMPARING
APPLES AND ORANGES BECAUSE THE
VENDOR THE PREVIOUS VENDOR NOT
ONLY THAT THEY- MAINTAIN AN
ONLINE PORTAL BUT THEY ALSO
SERVED AS A CALL CENTER IN
PROVIDING CUSTOMER SERVICE TO
OUR CLIENTS OKAY. SO THE
CUSTOMERS AND THEIR CALL CENTER
COMPONENT WE BROUGHT IN HOUSE
AND WERE HANDLE IN THAT WOULD
STATE STAFF. AND OF. A. S.
DEVELOPMENT AND- MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS IS CONTRACTED
OUT TO ANOTHER VENDOR. OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL I THINK IT SPEAKS
TO. US OF THINGS YOU'LL SAID
WISHES CONTRACT THINGS OUT
MAYBE WE CAN DO IT AN EQUALLY
GOOD JOB FOR. THAT THANK YOU
VERY COMPETITIVE PRICE AND
HOUSE AND BABY MORE LIVELY CELL
JUSTICE AND OBSERVATION I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S AN ACCURATE ONE OR
NOT FOR IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE. WAS JUST CARRY. THAT THAT
WE'RE DOING IT. WITH THE OF
THAT EVEN THOUGH I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY THAT I'M IN COMPLETE
AGREEMENT THAT I THINK THAT BY
BRINGING IN THEY CALL THE CALL
CENTER AND MAINTAINING THAT IT.
WERE ABLE TO COME. BY THIS
INFORMATION RIGHT CONTROL
INFORMATION THAT GOES OUT AND
WERE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
INFORMATION. ON IT THANK YOU
GOOD TO KNOW THAT. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANK FOR REMOVING THANK
YOU FOR DECADES MAROON ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT MUSICIAN
MEDICAL EXEMPTION PROGRAMS. HI
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY
NAME IS IN CALCUTTA DAY I AM
THE ASSISTANT DIVISION CHIEF
FOR THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE CONTROL.
AND SO I HAVE- UNDER SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX AND SEVEN ONE FOUR-
CITY PH IS REQUIRED TO BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO HAVE
DEVELOPED A STANDARDIZED
MEDICAL EXEMPTION FORM IN THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY CARE. TO BE IS
STATEWIDE BY PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS FOR A CHILD WHOM A
PHYSICIAN DOES NOT RECOMMEND
IMMUNIZATION WERE REQUIRED TO
READ MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR ANY
SCHOOLS OR INSTITUTIONS WITH
RATES LESS THAN 9595% OR WHO DO
NOT REPORT. OR A PHYSICIAN TO
HAVE SUBMITTED FIVE OUR MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN A CALENDAR YEAR.
THE DEPARTMENT THE AUTHORITY TO
REVIEW ANY EXEMPTION. I AM VERY
TO REPORT POSITIONS THAT MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA TO THE MEDICAL
LICENSING BOARDS OF CALIFORNIA.
OUR PARENTS ARE PERMITTED TO
PEEL AN EXEMPTION REVOCATION TO
THE SET TO THE SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. THE STATUTE
OUTLINES A FRAMEWORK FOR THIS
APPEAL PROCESS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCY WILL DEVELOP THE
SPECIFIC PROCEDURES FOR THE
APPEALS. TO IMPLEMENT THESE NEW
LAWS PUBLIC HEALTH REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THREE
POINT ONE MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
ADDITIONALLY PUBLIC HEALTH IS
REQUESTING THE AUTHORITY FOR
FIFTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS.
THESE FUNDS ARE NECESSARY TO
MEET THE MANDATED WORKLOAD
RELATED TO STANDARDIZING THE
PROCESS FOR SUBMITTING AND
REVIEWING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
FROM IMMUNIZATIONS. REQUIRED
FOR ADMISSION TO SCHOOL TO
CHILD CARE OR SCHOOL. SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX AN SB SEVEN ONE
FOUR WILL REQUIRE BUILDING NEW
CAPACITY INTO INTO THE EXISTING
DATABASE. IMPLEMENT NEW PROGRAM
I JANUARY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU- LA. FINANCE
OKAY- THANK YOU I APPRECIATE-
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LEGISLATION I AUTHORED- AND- I
HOPE THAT IN THIS PROCESS WE
CAN ALSO STRENGTHENED THE- THE
MUSICIAN REGISTRY AS WELL- I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- HAVE YOU
SEE WE'RE ONLY HAVING HIGHER
ONE LAWYER. THE BILL'S GOING
THROUGH THEIR PROPOSALS FOR
LIKE THIRTY LAWYERS IN THE LIKE
WHY DO WE NEED THAT MANY I
GUESS I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION
FOR YOU THOUGH IS THAT-
CERTAINLY. I THINK THIS IS
BASED ON THE ON DISSIPATE
CASELOAD BUT LOOKING AT SOME
OTHER STATES TO LIKE THE STATE
OF WEST VIRGINIA THEY ACTUALLY.
HAVE VERY FEW MEDICAL EXEMPTION
REQUESTS SO OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER NOW WE MAY HAVE.
SAID IS THERE SO AND THAT IS A
PERMANENT POSITIONS IS THERE
ANY THOUGHT THAT ACTUALLY ONCE
WE ARE FULLY IMPLEMENTED THERE
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE A DROP IN
THAT AND MEDICAL SHOULD RIGHT.
IT'S. WE DO FEEL LIKE WE MADE
ESTIMATES THAT WERE ON THE LOOK
FOR AND TO YOU AND AT ANY TIME
MOVED TO RE EVALUATE- BASED ON
IMPLEMENTATION BUT BECAUSE THIS
IS A NEW ACTIVITY. AND WE JUST
HAD TO WITH WET- WHAT DATA WE
HAD TO MAKE OUR DECISIONS. ALL
RIGHT SO WE'LL SEE WE'LL SEE- I
THINK THAT THAT MIGHT BE THE
EXPERIENCE. WE BUT IT'S- THAT
SEE THE- WAY WILL CAN TO COME
SOMETHING WOULD PEOPLE REALIZE-
THEN THERE MAY BE A- DECREASE
IN ACTIVITY SINCE- THE- PEOPLE
GET TIRED OF PAYING FOR THE
ONES THAT. DON'T RESULT IN ANY
CHANGE IN THE STATUS SO. OKAY
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU MUCH
ALL RIGHT. SO WHAT. SENATE
SCHOOL TAKE. SEVERAL PROPOSAL
FOR AN NOW. SO WE ACTUALLY KIND
OF HAVE WELL WE HAVE A- SO WE
HAVE THE IN THE EPIDEMICS
COALITION AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
SEVERAL ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN- WHERE LAST. OKAY SO
I JUST TRY TO THINK ABOUT THAT-
DO YOU TELL THEM IS ALL IS.
THREE TOWN EACH IS A SEPARATE
PROPOSAL OR SHOULD WE JUST CLUB
THEM ALL TOGETHER AND HAVE YOU
GO ONE AFTER ANOTHER JUST ROLL
THROUGH THEM BEFORE YOU GET
COMMON THE OTHER PROBABLY MAKES
SENSE OKAY ALL RIGHT SO BECAUSE
TOTALING SINCE PLACE. OKAY AND-
SO. A USE IT THREE MINUTES- BUT
HOPEFULLY CAN DO LESS FOR
AGAINST BECAUSE WE ADAM ALL OF
THAT GETS TO BE KIND OF A LONG
PRESENTATION CELL ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO GO HEAD BEGIN. SORRY SO
WHAT WE GO HEAD START WITH THE
END OF THE EPIDEMICS COALITION
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU CREEK
PULLS FOR ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS A PELE
HEALTH- MY COLLEAGUES NAY HER
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE AND
THE EPIDEMICS COALITION. OR A
STATEWIDE COALITION OF CBS AND
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS DEDICATED TO
ENDING THE HIV HEPATITIS C. OR
EACH TV AN S. T. A. M. X. IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THE FIRST
PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE TO DEVELOP A CROSS
DEPARTMENTAL STRATEGY OR MASTER
PLAN TO AND THE CHEVY AIDS AND
STDS IN CALIFORNIA. AS YOU WELL
KNOW STATES AND CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE DEALING UP
EFFORTS TO REDUCE NEW
INFECTIONS IN AND THESE
EPIDEMICS- MOST NOTABLY IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. GOVERNOR CUOMO
LUNCH A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE
AND DATES IN NEW YORK- THE
STRATEGY HAS BEEN REMARKABLY
SUCCESSFUL- MAKES THE NEW HIV
CASES DROPPED 30% SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN- LAST YEAR THE STATE
REPORTED. THAT ON TRACT TO AND
AIDS IS AN EPIDEMIC BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR. I SENT TO. LEARN
A- THE FIFTEEN AND ALL OF HIS
REMARKABLE SUCCESS. IN THE ON.
CAN THE- IN THE COUNTRY TO GET
TO ZERO NEW. OF A- THE
OVERWHELMING SUCCESS OF THESE
INITIATIVES PROVIDE EVIDENCE
THAT A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIC
PLAN. COUPLED WITH POLITICAL
WILL AN ADEQUATE RESOURCES CAN
DRIVE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
STEMMING THE TIDE OF THESE
EPIDEMICS. YEAH CALIFORNIA
REMARKABLY HAS YET TO LAUNCH A
SIMILAR INITIATIVE AND THESE
EPIDEMICS CONTINUE TO RAGE OUT
OF CONTROL. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO RESUME ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN DEVELOPING
AGGRESSIVE STRATEGY TO ADDRESS
HIV HCV AND STDS. THIS PROPOSED
PROPOSAL PROVIDE HHS AND THE
OFFICE OF AIDS WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO BRING
TOGETHER COMMUNITY STAKE
HOLDERS AND RELEVANT STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO DEVELOP AN
EFFECTIVE STATEWIDE STRATEGY.
THIS CANNOT JUST BE INITIATIVE
WITHIN CITY PH OR THE OFFICE OF
AIDS AND EFFECTIVE MASTER PLAN
WILL WORK STRATEGIC
COORDINATION. ACROSS ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS THE SERVE PEOPLE
LIVING WITH AND AT RISK FOR
THESE CONDITIONS. MOST NOTABLY
C. PH T. H. C. S. C. C. R.
AMONG OTHERS- GREATER
COORDINATION ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS WILL PROVIDE. A
GREATER POOL OF AVAILABLE
FUNDING AND ENABLE PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES TO REACH
PATIENTS THE OTHERWISE MASS.
THIS CAN PROPOSAL IS TO
INCREASE ELDER. AND THE PROP
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FROM 5100%
TEST 6100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THANKFULLY
CALIFORNIA HAS USED REBATE
DOLLARS TO MAKE SEVERAL CLING
KRUGMAN'S TO EIGHT áP AND THE
PERSISTENCE PROGRAM. EIGHT
APPLE EXPAND CLUED AVERAGE
BASED HEALTH INSURANCE AND A
GAP POLICY. HAS BEEN EXPANDED
TO PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR YOUTH
AND INSURED INDIVIDUALS WITH
CONFIDENTIALITY CONCERNS AMONG
OTHER CHANGES AND THAT NOTABLY
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THEY IT UP
INCOME ELIGIBILITY LEVEL WAS
INCREASED FROM A FLAT CAP OF
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. 7100%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
SINCE THAT TIME HOWEVER THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
HAS CONTINUE TO RISE AND
MILLIONS OF OUR STATE RESIDENTS
STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET. AS
YOU WELL LAST LAST YEAR STATE
BUDGET INCLUDED- SOME IMPORTANT
NEW SUBSIDIES AND CALIFORNIA
AND COVER CALIFORNIA. UP TO SIX
SENATE PL- WE ARE URGING THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE AID
APPAN PROP UP ELIGIBILITY FROM
5100% 26100% F. P. L. TO ALIGN
WITH THESE NEW STATE SUBSIDIES
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA. US IN THE
RIGHT I SEE AN INCREASE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA SO. WE'LL
HAVE A RACE A NUMBER OF IT BUT
INDIVIDUAL GRAMS BUT FOR THOSE
LIMITED NUMBER OF FOLKS WILL
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE NECESSARY TO
ACCESS LIFESAVING MEDICATION
AND PREVENTION SERVICES. OKAY
AND I'LL COVER STDS CUT THE
MUSTARD WITH THE CENTRAL ACCESS
HEALTH ARE STD PREVENTION FROM
CENTER WORKS CLOSELY WITH STATE
STD PREVENTION OUR LOCAL-
COUNTY PARTNERS WELL. IT WAS
AND WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE
A COUPLE OF COMPONENTS ONE OF
THEM IS TO TAKE CURRENT.
CALIFORNIA FOR PACK GRAHAM X.
TO LOCK TO SERVE THOSE NOT A
RISK. MISSY OR NEED A OF CUT.
NOW BECAUSE THE WAY THE PROGRAM
IS STRUCTURED WE WOULD NEED TO
USE DEBT GENERAL ONLY BUT THAT
WE DO KNOW THAT WE HAVE COMING
IN THAT IF. BRAND THE PROGRAM
ACTUALLY ARE THE MET LGBT
COMMUNITY ARE NON COMMENTING
THIS THE THIS PRO TO GET S. T.
TERVIS. NOT WE KNOW WHEN WE'VE-
THE CHECK. CERTAIN MEMBERS OF
THE MANY LUSHLY TWENTY MINUTES
FROM MONEY IN TO US THESE AND
THIS BY YOU KNOW SORT OF PICK
UP AND DOLLARS LAW YEAR WE KNOW
THAT ARREST D.'S INCREASE
EXPONENTIALLY YOUR LOOK AT A
STE THIRTY YEAR HIGH WITH MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PIECES REPORTED CENTS TO
EIGHTEEN. WHICH IT. ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY I MEAN I'M SORRY
ALL OF. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO
LEVERAGE YOUR CURRENT PROGRAM.
LIES THAT PROGRAM WHICH GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS TO SIR FOLKS IN
THAT PROGRAM WE'RE ASKING FOR
ME IN THE FIRST TO INCREASE
GENERAL FUND- PUT CAN OFTEN BE
INTO THE FAMILY. DO YOU THAT
PRO. PEACE ACCESS TO STD
TREATMENT. ON THE OTHER ES DE
PROPOSAL IS A PLAY OFF OF LAST
YEAR'S WE HAVE SEVEN MILLION
CURRENTLY IN THE BUDGET FOR S.
T. D. UM TESTE TREATMENT USE
BOOKS COUNTY ARE COUNTY
PARTNERS AS WELL AS THE WITH
THOSE DAHLE. DOLLAR JUST THREE.
ENTRY TO SEE TO BE ABLE TO
ASSEMBLE AS- WILL HAVE AS GO
OUT BUT WE DO KNOW WHAT TO
DEFERRED FOR PARTNER IN C. B.
IS TO USE THOSE DOLLAR. BECAUSE
THIS POINT THE DO ARE THE SET.
MAY BE ON GOING AS IT ALLOWS
FOR THOSE COUNTY PARTNERS NAY
SECURED. HEARD ALL TODAY FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SPENDING IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO HAVE ON GOING
DOLLARS TO BE UP IN STRUCTURE.
AND PRODUCE PERSONNEL TO DO.
TESTING AND TREATMENT. WELL SO
IN THIS CASE YOU'RE ASKING FOR
CHRIS OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS
WE KNOW THAT THE ES D. ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA ENTER COUNTRY BOOKED.
FOR HIS PERJURY AND THE DISK
EATER THAN TEN BUT WHAT. DO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS IN THIS
PART OF ME TO DO TO. MAKE AT
THE WERE CAN GET THAT. A C.
WILL HAVE TO COME JUST WHAT THE
ARE BUT THINK THIS IS A PLACE
WE CAN SOMEONE. THE TEN. HOPES
PERCENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FUND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE WITH THE AND THE
EPIDEMICS COALITION FOR THAT I
HAVE A DATE HE ASKED I'M GONNA
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
WHO CAN BE HERE SO- YOU FOR.
CASE FIVE H. C. PREVENT. SAYS
PRECIADO IT THAT FUNDING-
ALTHOUGH IT IS TIME LIMITED WE
APPRECIATE THE EXTENSION TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FROM TO
ANYONE IN THE GOVERNOR'S JANET
JET. I'M WE WOULD LIKE TO STILL
REQUESTED SPENDING IT ON GOING.
AT WHERE NOW. IN FOR IT JUST
FIFTEEN MILLION SYLVESTER WE
CAME A TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND WE'RE BACK AGAIN. THE SAME
BE THAT REALLY IS WHAT THE NEED
IS BASED ON TO START SO THIS
WOULD INCLUDE HEALTH NAVIGATION
LINKAGE SIR AND LINK SERVICES
WITH A FOCUS ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
USING DRUGS. I'M THANK THERE'S
AN AT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
APPETITE ESTY AND OVER MORE
THAN HALF OF THEM ARE UNAWARE
OF THEIR STATUS LEAVE THEM BOTH.
ANSWER COMPLICATIONS EVEN DEATH
AS WELL AS THE REST FOR
TRANSMITTING TO OTHERS THE RATE
OF HCV INFECTION AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE- WHICH IS THOSE UNDER
THIRTY IS GROWING AT AN
ALARMING DRIVEN. BY THE DEBIT
IN OUR WHEN AND OTHER DRUG USE
BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN A TOTAL OF
THIRTEEN AND SIX HUNDRED THREE
EIGHT CV KEEP. REPORT ADD ON
PEOPLE IF TEAMS. ATTRACT I'M A
SIXTEEN ARE THIRTY THOUSAND.
NEARLY FORTY K. CV WHICH RANKS
CALIFORNIA AS THE FIRST AMONG
ALL STATES TO PUBLISH THEIR
SURVEILLANCE DATA SO WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS INVESTED IN
COVERING HEPATITIS C. TREATMENT
WHICH WE APPRECIATE THROUGH
MEDICARE OUR PRISONS. AND THAT
DOES ARE PRESENT AT THIS POINT
FOR OVER 95% OF PEOPLE- IT'S WE
REALLY HAVE UNDER INVESTED IT
LIKE HEALTH- PREVENTION I'M
INFRASTRUCTURE THE LAST YEAR
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
WAS THE FIRST EIGHT THE
PREVENTION FUNDING. SIXTEEN AND
NOT FUND IT IS NOT FOR THE
LEVEL OF PREVENT NAVIGATION AND
LOOK ITIS UNNECESSARY YEAH. AT
UNIVERSAL HEPATITIS C.
SCREENING- SO WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WE'LL SEE MORE- SCREENING
IN PRIMARY CARE SETTINGS BUT WE
KNOW THAT'S NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH
ESPECIALLY TO REACH DRUG POP
WE'RE CURRENTLY A MUCH LESS. I
AM. RESEARCH FROM THE AMERICAN
STUDY FOR ASSOCIATION FOR THE
STUDY OF LIVER DISEASE- STATES
THAT ADDRESSING GAPS IN
PREVENTION AND CARE AMONG USE
WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO TREAT-
ENDING THE ATV EPIDEMIC SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS REALLY AN
AND PRESS AN OPPORTUNITY TO AND
STEVE MAC OR TO AB FOR YEARS
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A CURE IN
HCV IS SO CALM. EXCITE LINK TO
THAT. M. TRUST. I'M SPOKE WERE
COMING BACK WITH THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR- REQUEST FOR
ONGOING FUNDING FOR AIDS
HEPATITIS C. I'M AND THEN I'M
BACK COVER ASK ON- HJV SO THAT
AND THE OTHER. ELECTION AGAIN
THANKS THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR ARE INVESTING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN HIV
PREVENTION LAST YEAR- WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THOSE DOLLARS ME TO
I'M GOING FUNDING AND AGAIN
WE'RE BACK WITH THE REST OF OUR
REQUEST WHICH IS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GENERAL
FUND. WHICH WOULD BE ON GOING
FOR ADDRESSING AM HIV HEALTH
AND TWENTY PARTICULARLY AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
CALIFORNIA COMMITMENT TO
REINVESTING IN ITS PREVENTION
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND
WE'RE VERYAPPRECIATIVE OF
THAT- AND- WE HAVE STARTED TO
SEE HIV CASES DECLINING AS A
RESULT OF THAT INCREASED
PREVENTION FUNDING SO- ALL THE
WORDS WERE MUCH- BEHIND NEW
YORK CORRECT PRESENTED EARLIER
WE HAVE A REST NINE CENT IN OUR
IN IN FACT TENS. ONLY THAT NOT
ALL OF US DIFFERENT. SO WHILE
CASES HAVE TO AMONG WHITES BY
OVER 20% IN THAT TIME PERIOD
THEY'VE DECREASED ONLY 4% AMONG
A LOT NEXT COMMUNITY AND
THEY'VE ACTUALLY INCREASED BY
2% AMONG AFRICAN AMERICANS- SO
THE INCREASED AND EQUITIES
REALLY UNDERSCORE HOW URGENT
THE NEED IS FOR THE IMPROVED
FOR AND ANY ENTITY TAKE
PREVENTION EFFORTS AND REALLY
THAT DATE THOSE EFFORTS TO
TARGET THE COMMUNITY. AND SO
WE'RE PROPOSING FUNDING. TO
LOCAL SECTION AND-
ORGANIZATIONS TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF PLANS BASED
AND STRENGTH BASED STRATEGIES
THAT INCLUDE BIOMEDICAL
PREVENTION STRUCTURAL SHINS
TEN. NEEDS OF THE STATE'S MOST
UNDERSERVED RESIDENTS THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNA HE WOULD I WORK WITH THE
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE AND THE EPIDEMICS
ADVOCACY COALITION. AND I'M
SPENDING ON OUR REQUEST FIVE
MILLION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE SUPPLY CLEARING HOUSE
MANAGED BY THE OFFICE OF AIDS-
ON THE SUPPLY CLEARING HOUSE
REMAIN UP. COM THE BOND START
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT
FURNISHES HARM REDUCTION
SUPPLIES TO RUN SERVICES AM.
PUTTING SERENA'S IS A LOCK
SOUND AND ALL TEST STRIPS AND
OTHER SUPPLIES FOR JACK AND
SAFE. THESE THINGS. AND THIS
THE- USED TO PROVIDE TRANS
TRANSMISSION OF HIV HEPATITIS
C. SKIN AND SOFT TISSUE
INFECTIONS AND FOR OVERDOSE
PREVENTION. SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHEN THE CLEARING HOUSE
FUND WAS DEVELOPED THERE HAVE
BEEN THIRTEEN NEW SYRINGE
SERVICES PROGRAM STARTED AND
TEN COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THIS
YEAR WE EXPECT AN ADDITIONAL
SIX PROGRAMS WITH MORE GROWTH-
EXPECTED EACH YEAR. SO A DISH
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
EXISTING SERVICES PROGRAM SEEN
AN INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR
SUPPLIES BY OVER 50% THE GROWTH
IN NEW PROGRAMS PAIRED WITH THE
INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR SUPPLIES
IN EXISTING PROGRAMS. ME THE
CURRENT BUDGET THREE PER IS A
QUICK PROGRAM TO BETWEEN ORDER
AND THE LOCKS ON OR ORDER
ENOUGH STEROLS OF SEARCHES FOR
THE PARTICIPANTS. THERE
SURRENDERS REPRESENT THE NUMBER
ONE MOST COST EFFECTIVE H. A.
B. N. H. C. B. PREVENTION TOOL
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY HARM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS PROVIDE LOW
BARRIER RESOURCES TO PEOPLE
OFTEN REFERRED TO IT'S HARD TO
REACH. MONEY INVESTED IN THESE
PROGRAMS MEANS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SAVED AND AVERTED HIV
EIGHT CB AND S. T. I. CASE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY FEWER
OVERDOSED A DEATH. WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INVESTMENT OF FIFTY MILLION AND
LAST BUT TO SUPPORT AFTER BEING
AT. THIS IS GRANT BUT THIS.
CITY HARM REDUCTION FROM FIRST.
BE ABLE TO REACH MORE
CALIFORNIA. BY CLEARING HOUSE.
SEE THE BOWL FULL OF BENEFITS
OF ALL RIGHT THANK YOU COMMENTS
FROM OHIO FINANCE ALL RIGHT OF
FREE SHEET THE PRESENTATION NAY
THINKER TRY COVER LOTS OF BASES.
SAMETIME OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THE
GOAL OF TRYINGTO ELIMINATE-
STDS SEE HIV SO VERY WELL THE
ONE AND SOMETHING WE SHOULD TRY
TO STRIVE FOR. THIS WILL
APPRECIATE PRESS. THERE ARE
ALSO TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE INTEGRATE THAT WITH OUR
OTHER EFFORTS SIZZLE AND- AND
WE CAN TRY TO DO TO- TO ELEVATE
THE DISC THE THIS BILL
CONTINUING BURDEN ON OUR SUS
YOU KNOW IT'S THE FRONT. NONE
OF US RIGHT NOW BUT THE S. BUT-
THERE AND SO WE ONLY NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THAT SO OKAY THANK
YOU THESE MUCH. HERE RIGHT-
THAT COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION HERE WITH THE
REQUEST ON THE- BURNING A CD
NAVIGATORS FOR THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENTS WELCOME. AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON SENATE MITCHELL
GIVENS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION AS YOU
KNOW WE REPRESENT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE- AND WE HAVE A JOINT
REQUESTED TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY AND IT'S FOR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE THE OTHER
INTRODUCTION. I LIBBY SANCHEZ
ON THE OF CALIFORNIA CO
REQUESTING. THE SKILLS ARE IS
FOR TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
S. T. D. NAVIGATION SIR FOR
CENTER EXT TING READ THE
COMPLEX OF STDS I WOULD
CONTINUE GET FACT THAT YOU'RE
ABLE WE CAN YOU KNOW THAT. HEAD
OF IT IS CONTENT GROW AND WE.
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS. MISSION
POTENTIALLY THE EXCHANGE OF SEX
FOR MONEY OR HOUSING AND SO
FORTH AND SO REALLY TO FROM OUR
STANDPOINT AS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE NEEDED.
ADDITIONAL SHOULD STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THE THAT PROVIDES THAT
INTO CORD. OUR REACH TO THE
INTO. AND HELPS TO PER LINKAGE
TO THE NET SERVICES OUR LOCAL.
SINCE STAFF WILL TO THIS WE
DELIVER CRITICAL FOR TO FACE
NOW. PER NATION SERVICE ALREADY
PHONE OR ON HARD REACH POP THE-
WHO HAVE STDS. AND IT ONE WE'VE
WE'VE OF OUR OUR LOCAL OUT ARE
REALLY UNDER. AT JUST AS A- DID
AN EXAM INCOME IN NINETEEN
GOING OR- TO BE DEBT. TO SO WE
WERE NEED TO BOLSTER THE READ
THE- BEST AND IS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS%
THE ISSUE WELL ALL THAT THAT WE.
NEEDS TO ADDRESS. SAYS THE HAVE
BEEN SOCIAL TO THE CLIENT
IDENTIFY THE FACT IN YEARS IN
OFFICE TO CARE AT IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO ESTABLISH A ALL TO
PAY CARE TO BE HERE A WHOLESOME
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND
SO WE REALLY DO THAT THIS IS A
HELPFUL SO THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO RE. ADD HELP TO ADDRESS THE
REASON. AND JUST. BY WAY I
WOULD JUST MENTION TO IN TERMS
OF COMPLEX. IS. BECAUSE THE
RISK OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS IS
REALLY BAD SO. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT INTENSIVE TOUCH. THANK YOU.
WE ARE NUMBER TWO IN THE NATION
FOR SEVERAL LESS AND FOR
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS THAT WHICH
IS NOT SOMETHING OF WHICH WE
SHOULD BE INCREDIBLY PROUD. AND
IT REALLY IS DIRECTLY RELATED
TO BEING FUNDED UNDER RESOURCE
UNDERSTAFFED- AS SHE MENTIONED
THESE ARE COMPLEX CASES WITH- A
POPULATION THAT OFTEN HAS
CONCURRING ISSUES- THAT
COMPLETE LEAD TO. BE INSTEAD OF
SOME AND THEN THE REAR OF
SYPHILIS SO WE ARE HOPEFULLY
OPTIMISTIC BUT BUT LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
PRIORITIZE THE HIRING OF PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS. ON IT IS THANK YOU ONE
NIGHT THANK YOU LA COMMON. ALL
RIGHT I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THE FULL FOR OF I THINK YOU
FIVE LEE- SCENE THAT I AM FIFTH
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CAPACITY OF OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND CERTAINLY THE
STD OPERATE SOMETHING. IT'S NOT
AN OUTBREAK IT'S AN IT'S JUST A
STREAMLINED OPERATE AND THE
IDEA THAT WE HAVE CHILDREN BORN
GENERAL SURPLUS- PEOPLE THINK
THAT ONE AWAY WITH LIKE.
DICKENS NOVELS AND BUILD
VICTORIAN ERA AND IT'S RIGHT
HERE AND SO WE DEFINITELY NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS WELLS.
OTHER ESTY IS AND OTHER
INFECTIONS ARE RELATED TO THAT
SO THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
AND TAKE FULL COM. PART OF THE-
FAR PUBLIC. THANK YOU CAT
DEEPER WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER
ASSIST CAL AND STRONG SO OF THE
YOU JUST HEARD BY OUR COLLEAGUE
THAT SHE EXPRESSED YOU
NAVIGATION YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
EVERY SINGLE CASE OF CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS CAN AND SHOULD BE
PREVENTED. AND ALSO SEPARATE
HAVE A AND FOR THE BOARD OF-DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION COALITION WE WANT
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
EIGHT WHICH IS THE-
IMMUNIZATION EXEMPTION PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION THINK IT THANK
YOU WELCOME KATHY MUST FOR
WANTED OF I'M SORRY SUCH AS
HEALTH COME BACK AGAIN. IT OUT
SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR THE NAVIN
PROGRAM WITH. TALES NICE ON
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA'S DOING TO
DO TESTING AND TREATMENT BUT
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY AS BEEN
DESCRIBED HERE ONE WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE A CASE OF CONTENT THAT
FLOWS IN CALIFORNIA. AND THESE
ARE THESE ARE SITUATIONS THAT
UNIQUE CASE MANAGEMENT SO WE
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELCOME A CREEK FOR A
PILATES HEALTH ALSO VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FROM
CHI TECH AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE OFFICE OF
AIDS AS WELL. THANK YOU. COME
WHAT FROM CHAU HARBORED A
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED. FROM CHECK AND FROM.
END UP. PREPPED ASSISTANCE FUND
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELCOME.
COURTNEY AMONG HER PEERS AND
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE TEA ACT ASK-
AS OTHERS HAVE SAID AND THEN
ALSO VERY THANKFUL FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE STATE OFFICE OF AIDS IN THE
FAIRLY THOUGHTFUL PROPOSALS
THEY PUT FORWARD AROUND- PREP
APPAN EIGHT APT IN SUPPORT OF
THOSE ASKS AND JUST. SHARE YOUR-
CENTER. THE DATE. PRIOR IT
THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE
INVESTMENT- I KNOW OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN STATES HAVE
TRIED TO APPROACH THE
MANUFACTURE ON THAT. AND HAVE
NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL EITHER SO I
THINK WE'RE IN GOOD COMPANY
EVEN IF THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER
WE HAWKINS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME SHALL GIVEN THE
CHECK HERE TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THE AND THE EPIDEMICS. DECEIT
THE PART OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
STRAP. THANK WELCOME. KELLY
BROOKS HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR ON THE SERRA SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPPORT ALL OF THE-
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS THAT
YOU'VE JUST HEARD IN THE
EPIDEMICS AND ON THAT- CHECK
STD ALLIGATOR THEY'VE 100%
INCREASE IN THAT THEIR CONDUCT
CASES. PARTS THE STD NAVIGATION
PROPOSAL THEY'VE HAD A FIVE
FOLD INCREASE OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND THEIR CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS CASES SEEMS TO BE A
TIME WE NEED TO BE INVESTING IN
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME. JOINT NOT SEND
TOLD ME TO. THE LARGEST WRITER
SERVICES TO THE LGBT COMMUNITY
IN THE WORLD IN THE TEST AND
TREAT ABOUT 20% OF ALL OF THIS
POSITIVE SYPHILIS CASES IN LA
COUNTY AND WE- STRONG SUPPORT.
ISSUES FOR THE SEVEN AND ALL.
PROPOSED IN ISSUE NUMBER NINE
IF YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME JERRY
NUMBER HAVE THE IS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION I. IT'S OF ALL THE
IN THE EPIDEMIC ON COALITION
PROPOSALS AS WELL AS THE CHECK
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WELCOME THE SANCHEZ AS HE YOU
CALIFORNIA ONE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THE STATION REGARDING OF
IT. RIGHT NOW. I HAVE A VERY
LONG. OF ITEMS THAT MIGHT
HEALTH NURSES ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF FIRST AND FOREMOST
BEING ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES I WILL SHARE THAT WITH
YOUR STUFF THANK THANK YOU AND
I COULD USE MORE PUBLIC THIS IS
ALL. I JUST RECOUP FELL RIGHT
SEA KNOWING ELSE AT A F. PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT THIS CONCLUDES
SORRY THE THIS YEAR THE SUB
FISCAL OF NUMBER ON AND HUMAN
SERVICES BUT THAT WOULD. THANK.